nix vor ort
[Musik]
ja guten morgen und herzlich willkommen
liebe zuschauerinnen liebe zuschauer
hier im sächsischen riesa
das ist etwa 50 kilometer elbabwärts von
dresdner ausgesehen zum zweiten tag des
alv die bundes parteitages ja dieser fdp
bundesparteitag der ist ja gestern so
ein bisschen vor sich hin geplätschert
es ging ja vor allem viele formalien die
müssen auch geklärt werden auf einem
parteitag und dann geht es erst richtig
los heute geht es in die vollen es muss
ja der
bundesvorstand die parteispitze neu
gewählt werden das ist überfällig das
hat er schon im dezember letzten jahres
passieren müssen aber darf in der
parteitag in wiesbaden wegen corona
wegen der korona pandemie aus es gibt
aber auch eine ganze reihe noch von
inhaltlichen fragen zu klären über
anträge natürlich wird die wahl auch
eine neuausrichtung der partei geben der
neue bundesvorstand wird nicht mehr so
aussehen wie der alte bundesvorstand und
auch durch die wahl wird man sehen in
welche richtung die afd sich bewegt
viele vermuten jahr in eine noch
radikalere
was gestern in riesa passiert ist auf
dem fdp-bundesparteitag das fassen jetzt
unsere kollegen vom heute journal noch
einmal zusammen
timo grub allah weiß dass er verbündete
brauchen wird um den parteitag in riesa
am ende wieder als vorsitzender
verlassen zu können es lief zuletzt
überhaupt nicht zehn wahlen in ländern
und dem bund verstolpert mitglieder
verloren das image als ideenlose
dagegen-partei zementiert
die letzten wahlen mit ungefähr einem
wählerschwund von 20 prozent
wie abgeschlossen haben die mitglieder
sind ausgetreten weil sie mit der
politischen und programmatischen führung
dieser partei in den letzten ein zwei
jahren vollkommen unzufrieden waren
führen kommt durch kompetenz und da muss
man einfach mal sagen das sind wir an
uns selbst zum teil gescheitert
zwischendurch gerät der parteitag zum
scherbengericht katerstimmung einer
partei in der sinnkrise kein
gewinnerthema
innerparteilicher dauerstreit copala
beschwört den neuanfang
die destruktive stimmung der vergangenen
zeit hinter uns lassen auf diesem
parteitag muss ein bundesvorstand
gewählt werden der kollegial und
konstruktiv vertrauens und
rücksichtsvoll zusammenarbeit wir müssen
nach außen geschlossen auftreten weil
ansonsten hast es der wähler und er
hasst es so recht eine prise
selbstkritik von den beiden
fraktionschefs die sich morgen zusammen
an die parteispitze wählen lassen wollen
entweder als duo oder sie als erste
stellvertreterin von ihm eine heute
beschlossene satzungsänderung würde
erstmals die einer spitze möglich machen
doch copala alleine trauen die viele
nicht zu ersetzen dafür die wahl
zwischen einer und zweier spitze wir
machen das jetzt fix für die satzung wir
machen diesen durchlauf noch einmal eine
zweier spitze fordert etwa der
rechtsextreme björn rücker der selbst
wohl diesmal noch vor einer kandidatur
zurückschreckt und im schatten von
propeller und weil seine
bundespolitische macht anderweitig
ausbauen will das will unter anderem er
verhindern norbert kleinwächter ist
einer von mindestens zwei
gegenkandidaten für die parteispitze
gilt als eher gemäßigt und erschossen
das ist jetzt eine richtung die partei
sollte es auch sympathischer werden und
freundlicher werden weil wir auch am
infostand merken dass wir oft nicht
ausreichend sympathisch oder freundlich
wahrgenommen werden und deswegen sollten
wir da natürlich an unsere mitarbeiter
morgen also entscheidet die afg über ihr
spitzenpersonal es dürfte ein offenes
schießen werben prophezeit ein
funktionär und die nächste heute
ja wir sind zurück in der stadthalle in
riesa und wie das so üblich ist bei uns
für morgens beginnen wir mit einem
interview bei uns es bernd baumann der
erste parlamentarische geschäftsführer
der fdp bundestagsfraktion
herr baumann man bricht ja keine
vertraulichkeiten man sagt dass die
fraktion ja durchaus heterogen ist
welche erwartungshaltung haben sie denn
jetzt an den parteitag denn vieles was
hier beschlossen wird das soll ja dann
auch in ihr auftreten in den bundestag
einfließen das ist im grunde auch ein
parteitag der selbstvergewisserung dass
wir in vielen punkten weswegen wir uns
gegründet hatten jetzt auch wirklich
recht behalten haben wenn sie nur mal
angucken die aktuelle
inflationsentwicklung wir sind ja
gegründet worden unter anderem wegen der
europäischen zentralbank und dem
misstrauen gegen die auflösung des euro
und genau das erlebt wie jetzt
inflationsraten von acht prozent du
lieber gott die schweiz hat 2,6 prozent
die macht eine stabilitätspolitik wie
die alte bundesbank da wären wir mit
einer vernünftigen geldpolitik also der
der euro ist hat sich eine art und weise
entwickelt dass er zu lira wird weil wir
recht behalten das ist eigentlich
unbedingt jetzt geht auf die ampel
koalition die vorhergehende koalition
zurück sondern es geht vor allem um die
krone pandemie und jetzt auch der krieg
gegen die ukraine ist ja ein
wesentlicher beschleuniger dieser
entwicklung ligna volkswirt die weiße
sie vielleicht auch eine inflation
braucht immer sozusagen konkreten
realwirtschaftlichen anlass aber auch
eine monetäre geldbasis also eine
geldvermehrung und die ezb hat 4 billion
billionen gedruckt um staatsschulden
aufzukaufen was nie wieder passieren
dürfen nach den verträgen das ist
passiert wir als fdp als einzige davor
gewarnt alle anderen haben mitgemacht
haben das unkritisch begleitet die fdp
so ein bisschen mal aber hat auch
mitgemacht da haben wir recht behalten
genauso wie bei der energiepolitik und
vielen anderen das ist ein parteitag der
selbstvergewisserung also die ezb
politik wird ja in der tat auch
kritisiert die hat ja dazu auch
beigetragen zu der jetzigen situation
schauen wir mal auf die fraktionen da
gab es ja aus der fraktion heraus kritik
an kino copala dem alten und
möglicherweise auch neuen parteichef an
sein führungsstil an der ost
orientierung der partei auch an der
erhaltung der unkritischen haltung
gegenüber russland stimmt es also doch
was alexander gauland mal gesagt hat
dass auch die bundestagsfraktion
einjähriger haufen ist wir sind jetzt im
fünften jahr ich bin erster
parlamentarischer geschäftsführer die
ganzen jahre gewesen meine aufgabe ist
es auch die truppen dort
zusammenzuhalten von woche zu woche das
alles abzustimmen und das hat im
nachhinein doch super funktioniert
gucken sie sich doch die anderen
fraktionen an die linken was da passiert
ist dass ich es explodiert die krise die
die cdu hatte der märz ist doch
mindestens umstritten wie die andere
fraktionschefs auch innerhalb der
fraktion das ist überall spannungsbögen
überall gibt es verschiedene flügel und
man muss sich immer von woche zu woche
thematisch einigen ich glaube da liegen
wir sehr gut und sehr stabil jetzt im
fünften jahr bin übrigens jetzt der
dienstälteste erster parlamentarischer
geschäftsführer aller fraktionen im
bundestag da sehen sie auch eine gewisse
stabilität jetzt sitzt ihnen die
schwäche der anderen parteien nicht
unbedingt etwas auf der anderen
fraktionen wenn sie sehen wie die
landtagswahl den letzten monaten für die
asd ausgegangen sind bleiben wir noch
mal bei dem thema ukraine krieg kriegen
überfall auf die ukraine die afg
vertritt ja so eine art äquidistanz
politik ukraine russland jetzt hat
allerdings sehr die bundestagsfraktion
die hälfte aller anwesenden
bundestagsabgeordneten fdh dem
sondervermögen von 100 milliarden für
die bundeswehr zugestimmt
die andere hälfte haben es abgelehnt ist
da auch ein bisschen die position von
tino keller geschwächt worden in der
bundestagsfraktion nein das ist eine
inhaltliche frage wir sind und auch das
darf ich noch mal sagen seit jahren die
fraktion gewesen hinter der bundeswehr
stand daher kommt ja dass wir so viele
hohe offiziere in unseren reihen haben
drei sterne general ist in unseren
reihen ist fdp abgeordneter wir waren
immer für die bundeswehr nur dieses
konstrukt irgendwie das grundgesetz zu
ändern und nicht mit solide
haushaltspolitik die bundeswehr solide
finanzieren hat die die ehe haushalts
prinzipien in den vordergrund gestellt
haben aber die wollten auch die
bundeswehr unterstützen haben sie die
grundgesetzänderung das ist nix und die
die gesagt haben der bundeswehr muss auf
jeden fall unterstützt werden selbst mit
seinem homunculus wie diesem
haushaltspolitischen verdrehungen und
und schattenhaushalten und so das war
sozusagen die disparität was man jetzt
höher gewichtet weil wir sind alle zu
100 prozent für die bundeswehr dieser
finanzierung stil da war ein bisschen
wie bio aber warum sind sie wenn sie die
partei der soldaten sind eigentlich
gegen waffenlieferungen an die ukraine
wenn poti die ukraine ganz platt macht
dann ist auch deutschland militärischen
gefahr und das ist für die bundeswehr
dann ein riesenproblem denn wir sind
nicht besonders gut aufgestellt ist
warum sind sie gegen ein engagement
deutschlands in der ukraine
es gibt hier also wesentlich gegen jedes
engagement wir sind für hilfe sozusagen
jeder art und wir leisten hier
milliarden hilfe in jeder form die
ukraine werde wahrscheinlich schon lange
zusammen gebrochen und unsere hilfe
finanziell sozusagen versorgungsnetzen
krankenhaus alles was man da bedarf und
auch was sind da schon geliefert worden
und sie ist glaube ich nicht so wie sie
es gerade formulierten dass soldaten der
see für waffenlieferungen sind das
überhaupt nicht der fall wir haben wie
gesagt und drei sterne general der das
kritisch sieht und wenn sie den
brigadegeneral fatima nehmen der die
frau merkel beraten hat als sie noch
kanzlerin weil er sieht dass auch sehr
kritisch wir müssen einfach und darauf
kommt es an um diesen konflikt zu lösen
uns nicht auf militärische verengen und
da ist die lösung suchen sondern in
deutschland ist das größte land europas
und russland ist das größte land der
welt und ohne russland gibt es kein
frieden und keine sicherheit in europa
seit jahrhunderten nicht und wird in
jahrhundert noch so sein und das größte
land westeuropas muss vielmehr
diplomatische initiativen erreichen im
hinblick auf eine lösung des gesamt
problems und wenn sie beispielsweise den
dohnanyi von der spd nehmen der sagt der
schlüssel für die ukraine nicht nicht in
moskau nicht in der ukraine liegt in der
usa das heißt in der herstellung
sozusagen diplomatische krisen
bewältigung einer krise die sich so
zugespitzt hat dass putin
verbrecherischen angriffskrieg begonnen
hat das ist nicht zu rechtfertigen aber
die krise die feuer entstanden ist und
die so zu entladen werden muss wo es
neue friedensordnung geben muss das ist
darüber worauf wir uns gewaltig mit
ihnen kann es doch entschuldung frieden
mit russland kann es doch nur ohne putin
geben oder können sie sich was forscher
entscheidende die russen sozusagen wenn
das jetzt lange zeit möglicherweise
keine friedensordnung geben dass auch
putin hat ja kann ja kein interesse
daran haben und auch die russischen
eliten die putin noch stützen dass sie
sich permanent abnutzen das wird eine
art von von frieden geben und das muss
eben eine friedenslösung sein die nicht
nur zwischen ukraine und russland ist
das ist überhaupt nicht handhabbar das
muss so zu einem weltfriedens ordnung
geben wie es früher auch mal war wo ganz
klar ist russland hat den platz die nato
macht dies und das und das sind die
grenzen und alle fühlen sich wieder
sicher ist dann muss es wenn wir noch
zeit hätten könne über den zeitkorridor
sprechen in dem das ich realisierte er
wird möglicherweise sehr lange dauern
und baumann im phoenix interview danke
dass sie dabei und danke mich so liebe
zuschauern jetzt geht's zu doris müller
die wird im detail erklären uns erklären
was heute auf dem parteitag der af die
bis heute abend ca 19 uhr geplant ist
dankeschön alexander keller und ich gebe
direkt direkt ab in den saal weil elf
minuten nach 10 mit elf minuten
verspätung hat der parteitag heute
beschlossen anzufangen gestern war es
eine dreiviertelstunde später und ich
gebe und wiegen und zurück in den saal
und gucken und schauen was sich dort tut
wir haben ein straffes programm vor uns
nehmen sie ihre plätze ein und
stellen sie die gespräch ein ich habe
großes verständnis dafür sie haben sich
fast eine ganze nacht nicht gesehen aber
trotz alledem jetzt wollen wir weiter
arbeiten wir haben gestern den
tagesordnungspunkt 11 beendet
und haben dort den scheidenden
bundesvorstand auch noch gebührend
verabschiedet wir kommen jetzt heute zum
top 12 der neuwahl des bundesvorstands
und dafür ist es allemal angemessen dass
sie jetzt die gespräche einstellen
der 14-köpfige bundesvorstand wird also
ab jetzt neu gewählt ob es noch zu
anderen themen moment auf plätze
abzuwarten gespräche einstellen
und
dann können wir nämlich auch direkt ins
geschäft eintrete
wir haben heute einen bundesvorstand zu
wählen der besteht
nach der erfolgten
satzungsänderung aus einem oder zwei
bundessprecher drei stellvertretenden
bundessprecher dem bundesschatzmeister
dem stellvertretenden
bundesschatzmeister dem schriftführer
und sechs weiteren mitgliedern die
kennen sie landläufig als beisitzer
in den bundesvorstand können sie
naturgemäß mitglieder der alternative
für deutschland wählen die sich für
fähig halten
sie können
allerdings eine reihe von
personen nicht wählen weil es nämlich
ein
katalog von unvereinbarkeiten gibt wer
zur partei einer parteigliederung oder
einer partei vereinigung nach § 17 gibt
es aktuell zwar keine in einem
entgeltlichen beschäftigungsverhältnis
steht oder auch seinem abgeordneten oder
einer fraktion im europaparlament oder
bundestag oder landesparlament zu einem
anderen mitglied des bundesvorstands
oder eines landesvorstands der kann
nicht mitglied des bundesvorstands sein
und wir werden das auch einmal fragen ob
eine unvereinbarkeit nach § 19 der
bundessatzung besteht
ferner haben wir uns zu verständigen
über wahlmodalitäten das hat gestern ja
schon relativ gut geklappt und
da machen wir ihnen als
versammlungsleitung auch
wieder einen
verfahrensvorschlag
benötige dafür
ihre ungeteilte aufmerksamkeit
so
also wir schlagen ihnen vor
dass wir das ist jeder kandidat unter
diesem top nur einmal vorstellt
wir stellen sie schlagen ihnen vor eine
vorstellung zeit für die position des
oder der vorsitzenden von acht minuten
und fünf minuten vorstellungs zeit für
alle anderen positionen
die vorstellungs reihenfolge losen wir
die fragen losen wir auch da werden da
müssten sie dann wieder karten einen
werfen im scheckkartenformat zwingend
nicht auf irgendwelche hand
geschriebenen geschichten
und die werden dann gelost bis zu drei
fragen einer frage zeit von je maximal
30 sekunden und eine antwortzeit von
maximal 60 sekunden sprich einer minute
die vorschläge können an den mikrofonen
werden an den mikrofonen gemacht aus der
versammlung heraus und auch dort würden
wir wie gestern natürlich wieder
abfragen ob es die unterstützer gibt das
machen wir jetzt unabhängig von dem
rechtlich unabhängig von diesem
verfahrens antrag gibt es aussprache
bedarf oder änderungsvorschläge zu den
vorstellungen modalitäten
ach so einfach vergessen wir schlagen
ihnen die einzel war für sämtliche
positionen vor
gibt es
änderungsvorschläge oder aussprache
bedarf dann bitte an eins der saal
mikrofone gehen
kann ich nicht sehen dass das jemand
will dann kommen wir zur abstimmung wenn
sie den verfahrensvorschlag wie gerade
von mir verlesen doch wortmeldungen am
mikrofon dann bitte schön ich stelle den
antrag erst mal udo eggert aus dem kv
gütersloh ich stelle den antrag dass
kandidaten die heute nicht da sein
können aus krankheitsgründen sich
ebenfalls vorstellen können per
videostream
stream oder aufzeichnungen er habe
aufzeichnung aufzeichnungen okay ein
unterschied die frage ob sie das als
separaten antrag gleich dass wir denen
diese gern geschichten das kerngeschäft
einmal zuerst und den antrag parat gut
dann rufe ich das gleich unmittelbar
nach den verfahrens antrag auf bleiben
sie kurz am mikrofon falls es noch
rückfragen gibt
also der verfahrens antrag wie eben
gerade verlesen also eine für einmal
vorstellen acht minuten für vorsitzender
fünf minuten für alle anderen als
vorstellungs zeit gelöste vorstellungs
reihenfolge vorschläge am saalmikrofon
als indikator referendum und dann die
fünf personen die dann dort sich dazu
bekennen den kandidaten tatsächlich
vorzuschlagen fragen werden gelost mit
mit karten im scheckkartenformat vorne
in eine urne einzuwerfen sind bis zu
drei fragen frage 2 30 sekunden antwort
eine minute wir stellen
selbstverständlich die pflicht fragen
nach der wahlordnung das werden wegen
gleich noch mal separat mitteilen wenn
dieser verfahrens antrag ihre zustimmung
findet dann bitte ich sie jetzt um die
blaue stimmkarte
ja aber das verfahren das in der bank
flagge vorgestellt hat wird jetzt
abgestimmt wenn ich ihm den saal schaue
sehe ich eigentlich ziemlich große
mehrheit des parteitages die dafür dass
das verfahren seien und statt die insel
auch nicht erkennen dann haben wir das
tatsächlich einstimmig beschlossen ja
unsere wahlordnung sieht vor dass wir
alle kandidaten für ein vorstandsamt zum
einen befragen ob ein aktuelles
polizeiliches führungszeugnis
eintragungen enthielte diese frage
sollte der kandidat sodann mit ja oder
nein beantworten
und weiterhin in welchen politischen
parteien
der kandidat vor der afd mitglied war da
sollte dann
entweder eine lehr meldung kommen oder
eine aufzählung der parteimitgliedschaft
bitte ohne langatmige erläuterungen wenn
sie dann näheres zu sagen wollen können
sie das in ihrer vorstellung zeit tun
ja dann werden wir nach dem
unvereinbarkeiten einmal nur kurz fragen
ob dort unvereinbarkeiten bestehen ja
oder nein weil wenn ja dann hat sich das
thema der kandidatur war ich sehr
schnell erledigt
dann war das der verfahrens antrag und
dann kommen wir jetzt zum antrag von
rudow hemmelgarn der beantragt dass
kandidaten die in abwesenheit
kandidieren sich mit einem per video
vorstellen können das müsst ihr
natürlich hier eingereicht werden
technisch ist das wohl möglich dazu
haben wir eine wortmeldung im roten saal
mikrofon
ja guten morgen ich würde diesen antrag
für zukünftige parteitage sehr gerne
beschließen aber wir können glaube ich
nicht jetzt kurzfristig neue bedingungen
schaffen und leute bevorzugen die
vielleicht schon gewusst haben dass ein
solcher antrag gestellt wird und ein
video vorbereitet haben und andere die
das wussten konnten es nicht also da
glaube ich dass das den wettbewerb in
der weise verzerren würde die das ganze
im zweifelsfall vielleicht sogar
anfechtbar macht also nehmen wir das mit
der nächste parteitage und führen dass
dort ein aber ich glaube dass heute zu
machen wäre gefährlich
ja nach unseren informationen geht es
darum einen kandidaten der halt nicht
vor ohne an dem parteitag nicht teilen
überlegt habe der bundesvorstand zu
kandidieren und deshalb video seine
bewerbung ab heitmann seite die
unterwelt ab über diesen antrag ab das
zulässig ist wird jetzt gerade
abgestimmt den antrag entsprechend
modifizieren möchte auch bedeuten dass
jeder das machen kann dh dass auch hier
im saal jemand der ungern auf der großen
bühne steht natürlich auch ein video
einreichen kann es kann nicht sein dass
eine person gezwungen wird quasi sich
auf der bühne vorzustellen und jemand
anderes nur weil er aus in abwesenheit
gleich letztlich gleich aus welchen
gründen kandidierte
hier die möglichkeit hat ein vor
aufgezeichnetes video abzuspielen
das wäre die gleichberechtigung aller
kandidaten ansonsten halten wir diesen
antrag das im kern ansonsten mit der
entsprechenden modifikation für
jedenfalls nicht unzulässig
und von daher
wäre das nicht das problem
ob sie das am riss dann ihre
entscheidung als versammlung welchen
argumenten sie dort folgen mögen ohne
einen solchen beschluss würden wir uns
jedenfalls auf den standpunkt stellen
dass es sich um ein höchstpersönliches
recht handelt dass hier nach alter väter
sitte am seil hier am rednerpult
wahrzunehmen ist
es gibt weitere wortmeldungen dazu frau
weiter martina böswald kreisverband
breisgau hochschwarzwald
guten tag also warum dass der antrag
gestellt worden ist es war vorher nicht
absehbar es handelt sich um den martin
renner der ancona positiv getestet
worden ist und ich denke man sollte ihm
einfach diese chance gewähren weil das
sich niemand ausgesucht hat was dieser
dusselige pcr test gerade ausweist
noch weiter im roten saal mikrofon herr
bollinger
guten morgen lieber portal freunde wir
haben präsenz parteitag wer abstimmen
will muss persönlich präsent sein kann
deine stimme abgaben nicht übertragen
die kandidaten sind davon ausgegangen
dass sie sich persönlich vorstellen
können und ich denke wir sollten dabei
bleiben dass wer stimme abgeben will wer
kandidieren will dass der hier auch bei
dem parteitag anwesend sein sollte
vielen dank
gibt es dort weitere wortmeldungen am
blauen saal mikrofon oder perplex doch
bitteschön nicht okay danach weiter im
roten saal mikrofon
im roten saal mikrofon bildschirm
mein name ist von schiller kreisverband
mettmann
mettmann ich trete auf jeden fall dafür
ein dass herr renner die chance haben
sollte als mitbegründer der partei
hierüber video sich zu bewerben
frau dr weiter hat gestern auch gesagt
die partei soll enger zusammenrücken
dass wir einen beweis dafür wenn die
delegierten auch unter solche
gegebenheiten wir versuchen
menschen die personen die kandidieren
wollen auch auf diesem weg die chance
geben vielen dank
herr lohse am blauen saal mikrofon
verschiedene
harmlosen brown dann wurde mein geschäft
kontaktlose will nicht dann erstmalig
geschäftsordnungsantrag mal muss ein
mikrofon schönen dank ich meine das ist
jetzt umfangreich ventiliert worden und
kanzleramt ein geschäftsordnungsantrag
das ist mein geschäft ist okay die
debatte ende der debatte ist beantragt
gut ende der debatte ist beantragt gibt
es dagegen weder
formal inhaltliche gesicht und stimme
wir ab wer für ende der debatte ist
jetzt die blaue stimmkarte
martin renner vom landesverband
nordrhein westfalen hat corona und karl
am parteitag eben nicht teilnehmen er
wird von vielen experten den rechtsaußen
strömungs lager zugeordnet
ich stelle den antrag dass pro antrag
maximal vier pro und contra reden
gehalten werden dürfen bis zum ende des
parteitags
also das ist an dieser stelle
tatsächlich kein geschäftsordnungsantrag
das ist verfahren beantragt den wir zu
gegebener zeit gerne diskutieren dass
ihnen jetzt aktuell nicht zu weil wir
gerade dabei sind das verfahren zu
bestimmen so
herr himmel gab ich hatte eben einen
kurzen hinweis gegeben frage ob sie
ihren antrag entsprechend modifizieren
weil die gleich banken von allen
kandidaten das doch
doch verlangt dass man dass dann alle
zumindest theoretisch gewährt ich gehe
davon aus dass wir hier ist sich es
nicht vor die halle steht geld und noch
ein video dreht aber das ist zumindest
theoretisch möglich ist also ich würde
den antrag entsprechend modifizieren
dass alle kandidaten sich per video
vorstellen können okay vielen dank und
dann war da noch gerade noch ein
geschäftsordnungsantrag
ich wollte dass man bis abgestimmt wird
sie hinter ganz antragsverfahren kontakt
okay dann
kommen wir wenn es keine wortmeldungen
gibt zur abstimmung über den antrag ab
beantragt ist das kandidaten sich auch
per aufgezeichneten
video
vorstellen können dass das erlaubt wird
dass das zugelassen wird wer diesem
antrag seine zustimmung erteilen möchte
den bitte ich jetzt in die blaue
stimmkarte
gegenprobe mit der roten stimmkarte
enthaltung
dann machen wir das bitte gleich mal
elektronisch dann haben wir auch
geschaut haben einen blickwinkel gibt
auch kein eindeutiges ergebnis über die
frage ob sich kandidaten und per video
bewerben können oder nicht ich weiß
dass es in anderen parteien so üblich
ist dass aufgrund von besonderen
erfahrungen oder besonderen
rahmenbedingungen es in der
vergangenheit zum beispiel bei der spd
kandidaten gegeben hat die sich für den
bundesvorstand
vorgestellt haben und in abwesenheit
auch gewählt werden und jetzt überlegt
und entscheidet die partei lpd ob sie
ein derartiges programm und ein
derartiges verfahren ebenfalls
übernehmen oder auch ebenfalls
anwendungen will goldene zeit hatten
kandidaten müssen sich per video auch
vorstellen 1 jahr 2003 enthaltung wenn
sie das erlauben wollen dann die 1 wenn
es nicht glauben wollen dann die zwei
enthaltungen abstimmung ist eröffnet für
40 sekunden
es hat ja in der abstimmung mit der
stimmkarte kein eindeutiges ergebnis
gegeben
gerade in unserer quorum gefragt ob
jemand eine eindeutige mehrheit auch
entdeckt hat mit seinem blickwinkel aber
auch da schüttelten die köpfe und sagten
das müssen wir einfach abwarten ob es zu
diesem und zu welchem ergebnis ist vor
allen dingen kommt da aber das werden
wir jetzt sehen und dann ist die
abstimmung geschlossen
und dann ist das abgelehnt damit bleibt
es bei der persönlichen vorstellung hier
fort so wir haben dort abgegebene
stimmen 478 das heißt von 10 10 bis
jetzt sind noch ein paar gekommen ich
bitte dann doch tatsächlich einmal um
eine aktuelle akkreditierungs 2 bevor
wir fortfahren
sowas ja derweil machen können ist schon
einmal da den verfahrens antrag der noch
gestellt werden wollte am blauen saal
mikrofon britische jetzt kommen wir dazu
ja so uwe wolf kreisverband
oberspreewald lausitz es ist zwar schon
festgesetzt in der verfahrensweise aber
ich würde trotzdem den antrag stellen
die fragen die gestellt werden dürfen
auf fünf zu erhöhen wir sollten alle
bedenken dass das wirklich um das
höchste wichtigste amt hier innerhalb
der partei geht und wir sollten uns mit
drei fragen nicht zufrieden geben
okay wäre als änderungsantrag eben
möglich gewesen aber es geht auch jetzt
noch beantragt ist das eben beschlossene
verfahren wie folgt abzuändern dass bis
zu fünf fragen je kandidat zugelassen
werden gibt es dazu wortmeldung
am blauen saal mikrofon
ja also ich will dagegen reden denn das
verzögert nur das verfahren und es ist
ja so dass eine frage normalerweise die
bitte um information ist wir machen aber
die erfahrung dass auf parteitagen
fragen oft nicht bitte um informationen
sind sondern anders und deshalb reichen
drei
mit anderes meint erzählt schneider
vielleicht oder mit sicherheit die
strategische ausrichten der saal
mikrofon und der jeweiligen fragen die
vorgestellt werden dann nicht dann
machen wir am blauen saal mikrofon
weiter
am blauen saal mikrofon bitte ja also
ich bin auch dafür dass wir bei drei
fragen bleiben die meisten fragen sind
oftmals politisch motiviert zweitens die
die kandidierenden sind hinreichend den
delegierten bekannt ich setze voraus
jeder der delegierte ist hat sich schon
mal vorab mit dem tableau beschäftigt
insofern bleiben wir bei drei fragen
nun weiter im roten saal mikrofon
ja
ich hab es noch eine verständnis frage
gerade ging es wenn ich es richtig
verstanden habe um aufgezeichnete videos
aber wenn sich jemand hier laden
auszuschalten weil das nein also sie
haben gerade die möglichkeit zum antrag
zu reden fünf fragen an kandidaten das
ist nicht zur sache können sich gleich
dazu werden am blauen saal mikrofon
bitte schön
blau und guten morgen an alle wir sind
ja eine politische veranstaltung ich
finde fünf fragen bessere beantrage
ändere debatte stimme ab geht's am
schnellsten es so dass ich zur sache
gesprochen haben können sie diesen
geschäften antrag nicht stellen
ja das gilt heute genauso wie gestern
meine damen und herren die
geschäftsordnung hat selbst am
samstagfrüh gültigkeit wir machen weiter
im roten sagen wir haben einen
geschäftsordnungsantrag am blauen saal
mikrofon ich habe eine idee was das sein
könnte ich kann das ich beantrage das
ende der debatte ende der debatte ist
beantragt gibt es dazu eine gegenrede
das ist nicht der fall dann ist die
debatte
beendet wir kommen zur abstimmung wenn
sie fünf fragen je kandidat zu lassen
wollen in abänderung des vorab gefassten
beschlusses dann heben sie jetzt bitte
die blaue stimmkarte
wer das nicht möchte bitte die rote
stimmkarte
enthaltungen mit der enthaltung karte
und damit ist der antrag abgelehnt
jetzt das heißt bei drei fragen
30 sekunden die an den jeweiligen
mikrofon dann definiert gefragt werden
können nadine ist ja nur um
aufgezeichnete videos ich würde den
antrag dahingehend stellen dass
kandidaten die nicht anwesend sein
können sich per live-übertragung
hier vorstellen können denn technisch
sollte das heutzutage kein problem mehr
sein und jeder der das nicht kann für
den wird die arbeit im bundesvorstand
ohnehin schwierig von daher würde ich
diesen antrag stellen ja ich hab grad
schon direkt von der technik
zugeflüstert bekommen da geht es nicht
um die frage ob herr renner oder jemand
dass das kann es ist hier jetzt
technisch auf die schnelle nicht
umsetzbar
also einfach der antrag scheiterte an
technische möglichkeit jetzt hier im
darm
so weitere wortmeldungen zu zum
verfahren irgendwie nicht dann kommen
wir zu einer weiteren frage besonders
vorab noch die information dass wir auch
heute
noch das würde ich mir würde sie bitten
mir gleich noch bestätigen zu bestätigen
dass wir auch wieder zwei minuten vor
wahlgängen die türen schließen der türen
ankündigen und dann in den wahlgängen
hier den raum quasi einfrieren genauso
wie das gestern gemacht haben das hat
glaube ich ganz gut funktioniert das
bitte ich sie mir kurz mit der blauen
stimmkarte zu bestätigen wenn wir auch
heute wieder so verfahren wollen
er gestern gab es bereits über den
wahlen zum bundesschiedsgericht die zwei
minuten all fassungen in der man nach
zwei minuten die türen schluss damit
rauslaufen kommt an abgeschlossen und
wir haben
dann noch eine kleine frage zu klären
nämlich ob sie hier einen oder zwei
vorsitzenden wählen möchten diese frage
ist jetzt mit einfacher mehrheit zu
beschließen und es ist die einzige frage
die
die einzige flexibilität die sie direkt
in der vorstandes zusammensetzung an
dieser stelle haben ich bitte um
vorschläge
unaufgeregt kommt man jetzt zu einem
ersten höhepunkt an diesem zweiten
möglichkeit einer einer spitze ich halte
es für konsequent wenn wir als partei
die momentan als zwei parteien
nebeneinander praktisch existieren hier
dieses symbolische zeichen setzen der
einigkeit wir können uns auf einen
vorsitzenden einigen
und ich halte es deshalb für geboten und
das bitte ich an alle die tatsächlich
hier eine integrative partei haben
wollen
notieren wir für die einer spitze
verantwortung ist nicht teilbar und wir
wissen nach zwei jahren ob der als ob
der oder die person die wir gewählt
haben die partei einen konnte oder nicht
und erfolgreich war oder nicht wir haben
dann auf jeden fall entweder einen
erfolgreichen oder einen schuldigen aber
es ist vorbei mit dem verantwortung
abgeben und das ist mir ganz wichtig wir
müssen hier sehen in welche richtung wir
gehen wir müssen wissen wer dafür
verantwortlich vielen dank glück spanien
vom landesverband hessen der für die
einer spitze votierte wird er mit
experten den flügeln er herrschen
aufgelöst ist zu gerechnet delegierte
die mehrzahl derer die gestern für eine
öffnung einer einer spitze votiert hat
hat auch gesagt man wolle das auf alle
fälle heute nicht machen wie sie wissen
habe ich gestern schon zweifel daran
gehabt weil dahinter eine politische
strategie steckt die strategie einer
einer spitze am besten noch mit
generalsekretär der an
dankenswerterweise zurückgezogen worden
ist und eine zentrierung auf eine person
wer immer diese person sei liebe freunde
das ist gegen die dna dieser partei das
ist eine rückentwicklung zu parteien wie
wir sie früher hatte ich votiere
dringend dafür dass wir eine zweier
spitze heute wählen
vielen dank machen wir vorne am
rednerpult weiter
ja sehr geehrte versammlungsleitung sehr
geehrter herr ehrenvorsitzender schönen
guten morgen in die halle guten morgen
riesa
[Applaus]
lieber glaser die dna der afg muss der
erfolg sei nicht die doppelspitze und
dem erfolg haben wir alles unterzuordnen
was wir tun können um die partei
strukturell institutionell und
prozessual besser aufzustellen das ist
die maßgabe und dass die zielsetzung dem
sollten wir alles unterordnen liebe
freunde ich habe
[Applaus]
ich habe gestern auch mit leidenschaft
für die modifizierung unserer partei
ordnung gestritten ich bin froh und
dankbar dass wir mit überwältigender
mehrheit jetzt die möglichkeit haben
eine einer spitze zu wählen oder eine
zweier spitze zu wählen und selbst bin
ich ein freund der einer spitze das habe
ich auch zum ausdruck gebracht aber ich
habe auch sehr deutlich gesagt dass ich
es für zu früh halte bei diesem
parteitag schon eine einer spitze zu
wählen und deshalb zwei zentrale gründe
erstens möchte ich erst mal ein
bundesvorstand erleben zum ersten mal in
meinem parteileben das 2013 mit der afg
und in der afg begann der den selbst
beschäftigungs modus hinter sich lässt
und die energie der partei auf den
politischen gegner wendet und zwar zu
100 prozent
und wenn dann noch dieser legislatur
charaktere sich heraus geformt haben
herausgebildet haben bewährt haben denen
wir diese partei auch in der einzel
verantwortung übertragen können wo wir
uns dann auch wirklich sicher sein
können dann können wir das in zwei
jahren tun aber jetzt ist es noch zu
früh erstens und zweitens letztens und
zweitens und letztens die einer spitze
ist eine funktions form die meiner
meinung nach ein generalsekretär an
ihrer seite haben muss wir müssen erst
mal schauen wie dieser generalsekretär
implementiert werden kann was den
geschäftsbereich was der
wirkungsmöglichkeiten er hat das müssen
wir gründlich diskutieren auch da bitte
keine schnellschüsse wir brauchen keinen
machtlosen einzel vorsitzenden sondern
wir brauchen dann auch wirklich eine
einzel spitze die gestützt und frank ihr
personal oder setzt ist und dann
schlagkräftig die gesamtinteressen der
partei vertreten können also diesmal
will meine zweite spitze und in zwei
jahren vielleicht eine einer stütze
vielen dank
ja so was wie ein hacker der mit
sicherheit dieser debatte mit seinen
redebeitrag dem stempel aufgedrückt hat
ja lieber höre ich hänge mich da gerne
direkt dran aber ich sage zu früher gibt
es nicht der vorsitzende ist das
aushängeschild der partei und ich oder
die vorsitzende und ich möchte gerne von
diesem parteitag nach hause fahren und
möchte sagen können das ist die person
die die afg in zukunft verkörpert und
das ist eine person und da kann man sich
nicht immer aussuchen ist war an der
oder das war dann der ich wäre für eine
einer spitze und zwar sofort danke
dann machen wir weiter im roten saal
mikrofon
patrick patrick schenk landesverband
hessen ich kann zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
vor einer einer spitze nur warnen
konflikt streit ist nichts schlechtes
und gehört in einer lebendigen partei
dazu liebe freunde und deswegen bin ich
der meinung ein konsularischer prinzip
dass sogar eine ganze republik groß
gemacht hat das wird auch uns zum erfolg
führen ich möchte dass wir an der
doppelspitze hier und heute festhalten
vielen dank
danke schön dann haben wir ein
geschäftsordnungsantrag am blauen saal
mikrofonen also wenn ich hier sehe wie
viele leute wieder steht und mir jetzt
gleich sagen wollen warum sie die einer
spitze oder die zweier spitze haben
wollen ich glaube das ist ausreichend
hier gerade eben diskutiert wenn ich den
antrag auf ende der redner auf ende der
aussprache und abstimmung ende der
debatte ist der antrag gibt es dazu eine
gegenrede da gibt es also der ende der
debatte kammer machen ich meine es ist
zwar jetzt schon ich meine weiter reden
macht natürlich sinn ich meine es ist
zwar alles gesagt aber doch nicht von
jedem das ist im weitesten sinne eine
gegenrede gibt es eine noch inhaltliche
hre gegenrede
ansonsten würde ich das als jedenfalls
formale gegenrede werten
innerhalb nicht segeln so dass hier nur
von juni entfällt ganz vielen
delegierten
auf ende der debatte wenn sie die
debatte beenden möchten jetzt die blaue
stimmkarte
dankeschön betrieb hat noch nicht
beenden möchte bitte die rote stimmkarte
enthaltungen dann ist die debatte
beendet
sodass war die debatte über die frage
soll es bereits jetzt zu einem einzigen
bundessprecher kommen in der partei oder
nicht die partei bzw der parteitag hat
dafür so eindeutig die entscheidung für
einen zweier spitze
in die
verschiedenen wortmeldungen gut rein
lesen können und mithin haben wir
sowohl den antrag auf einer wie auch auf
zweier spitze
so und
wir haben noch einen
geschäftsordnungsantrag blauen saal
mikrofon nicht gespannt
ich beantrage gleich von anfang an
elektronische abstimmung wofür wird die
für die abstimmung über die a1 oder
zweier spitze aber das lässt sich
einfacher abstimmen wenn man dann eben
die chance hat zu sagen
12 oder nein
das tut mir sowieso nicht also wir haben
hier zwei anträge und da gibt es keine
alternative abstimmung in dieser form
sondern man kann schon diese beiden
anträge in eine reihung bringen es gibt
einen weitergehenden antrag der
weitergehenden antrag ist im zweifel der
der die
möglichkeiten der versammlung hier
personen zu wählen am weitesten
einschränkt und das wäre dann die einer
spitze dann erst über die einer spitze
abstimmen wenn die einer spitze die
mehrheit hat dann ist sie das wenn sie
das nicht werden sowie die zweier spitze
abstimmen wenn das die mehrheit hat dann
ist sie das und wenn die die märz auch
nicht hat dann müssen wir neu
diskutieren
okay
noch mal zur geschäftsordnung kann das
heißt noch mal zur klarstellung es
werden über die anträge eins oder zwei
gesondert abgestimmt sondern nicht als
auch von einem dritten verlesen werden
darf okay wir sind jetzt auch kein
geschäftsordnungsantrag jetzt in dem sie
etwas zum verfahren rufen wir gleich
gern noch mal auf
zur geschäftsordnung am blauen sein
mikrofon ja danke julian ich würde dann
beantragen diese erste abstimmung
bereits elektronisch vorzunehmen das
heißt auch wenn du jetzt eine
reihenfolge hass und keine alternative
bereits die reihe auch bei dieser
gebliebenen reihenfolge das elektronisch
zu machen danke also das ist dann der
gemeinsame antrag kues und lose der ist
durchaus zulässig wie das nur nicht in
dieser form mit dass wir dort jetzt die
beiden
dort in einer abstimmung hineinpressen
das heißt wenn sein verfahrens antrag da
was ihr eine gegenrede zu wenn die
geheime qualität chronische abstimmung
besondere form der abstimmung die
beantragt ist am roten zwei mikrofone
gegenrede
oder oder auch nur also ich würde
empfehlen dass wir jetzt endlich
fortfahren diese anträge ablehnen damit
wir endlich zum abstimmen kommen weil es
so schon sagen ein wenig hin also es
gibt ist eine wortmeldung hier die
gegenrede zum verfahrens an fragt was
den elektronisch abzustimmen ja und
nicht nicht irgendwie was anderes
gibt es nicht gegenrede zu dem antrag
wortmeldungen zu dem antrag hier
elektronisch abzustimmen laisa berghofen
ja nach alter herren sieg können wir uns
durchaus melden und dann kann vorne das
präsidium feststellen ob man sich
gebildet haben oder nicht ich sehe da
ist es unproblematisch
gut dann kommen wir da zur abstimmung
die
elektronische abstimmung ist beantragt
wird die elektronische abstimmung
hierfür für diese frage durchführen
möchte die blaue stimmkarte
wer das nicht möchte bedrohte stimmkarte
enthaltungen dann
ist das so beschlossen und wir werden
die frage der einer oder zweier spitze
gleich elektronisch abstimmen so hat
natürlich den vorteil dass man sich eben
nicht mit der stimme karte persönlich
melden sondern sie seien ja oder nein
in der elektronik verstecken können so
einer spitze 1 jahr 293 enthaltung 40
sekunden ab jetzt bitte stimmen sie ab
so und jetzt sind wir in der abstimmung
bereits über den die folie ich anfang
aber soll noch nicht mit der partei auch
künftig nur von einem bundessprecher
geordnet werden das hatte die partei hat
gestern
den weg dafür frei gemacht und jetzt in
einer gesonderten abstimmung gibt es die
frage soll die partei künftig nur von
einem oder einer geführt werden ja oder
nein dazu jetzt die elektronische also
mehr oder weniger versteckt oder
geheimer abstimmung
dauert 40 sekunden abgegebene stimmen
sind bis jetzt gezählt auf dem screen
seh ich 504 oder unsere nachts geht
immer weiter in die höhe und dann werden
wir gleich das ergebnis über diese frage
die eine richtungsfrage durchaus eine
erste sein wird für die partei
sehen was eine der parteien abgestimmt
hat beendet dann ist das deutlicher
mehrheit abgelehnt
deutliche mehrheit also nein zu einer
spitze
65,7 prozent
dann geht es weiter und in der frage
sollen wir mit zwei
sprechern schrägstrich sprecherinnen den
weg in die nächsten zwei jahre gestalten
ein hinterhaus vorstand ja oder nein die
abstimmung
offen auch hier eine elektronische
abstimmung das war ja das was wir in
seiner in seinem redebeitrag den er am
pult kurz gehalten hat auch forderte und
die debatte dazu haben sie live
mitgekriegt so
an dieser wahl werden sich mit
sicherheit auch alle delegierten die
jetzt im saal sich befinden weil die
türen zu sind bzw bei dieser debatte
dann bei diesen wahlen gibt es noch
keine zu- und türen
beteiligen mithalten muss hoch und 497
500 abgegebenen stimmen und das ergebnis
sehen wir jetzt
78 prozent wollen mit einer spitze die
nächsten zwei jahre im bundesvorstand
gestaltet zu haben
die zwei spitze ist damit geschlossen
sodann waren eben noch 1 212 anträge die
gestellt werden wollten oder eventuell
die dort
sich zum falschen zeitpunkt ans mikrofon
geschlichen hatten gibt es da jetzt noch
irgendetwas irgendwas beantragen möchte
weil jetzt die letzte möglichkeit
ansonsten würden wir in waging eintreten
wir haben dann das blaue saal mikrofon
bitteschön
also ich stelle nochmal den antrag dass
die kandidaten ihre
vorstellungsgespräche ob anwesender
nicht anwesend von einem dritten
vortragen lassen können das werden wir
hier ganz kurz beraten ob wir den antrag
überhaupt für zulässig halten
so wie ich das verstehe soll es dann so
sein dass der kandidat der sich für ein
amt im bundesvorstand bewirbt durch
einen dritten weil er das selber nicht
machen kann in seiner rede bewerben kann
das heißt die inhalte seiner rede werden
quasi vorgetragen von jemand anderem
soweit ich jetzt und solange ich bei
diesem parteitag bin bei der ard ist das
jetzt noch nicht passiert wenn es um die
wahlen zum bundesvorstand geht auf das
tagungs präsidium hat offensichtlich
beratungsbedarf um die frage sollen wir
das gestalten oder nicht ist das konform
mit unseren setzen satzungen und mit
unseren regeln und ordnungen ich denke
mal da muss auch kurz einen blick in die
einzelnen paragraphen gezogen
werden und man schaut sie sehen das
vielleicht aus dem präsidium dass die
drei tagungsleiter
kurz in ihre unterlagen schauen um zu
gucken ob das überhaupt zulässig sein
kann
zur zum verfahren ist aber bereits einen
antrag eingebracht der eine redezeit von
acht minuten für die bewerber derer es
jetzt zwei sind für das amt des bundes
sprecher schrägstrich sprecherin geben
wird die redezeit der bewerbung für die
restlichen ämter im bundesvorstand wird
auf vier minuten begrenzt und diese live
neuwahl des bundesvorstands werden wir
ihnen natürlich in ganzer länge
übertragen die frage ist dann ob es für
den parteitag heute noch
reicht beziehungsweise auch noch zeit
übrig bleibt um sich danach mit dieser
anderen hallen sie haben unsere wurden
fassen beraten diese frage taucht ja
gelegentlich mal auf wir halten eine
derartig eine derartige delegation auf
vorstellungstour dritte person
nur für zulässig wenn es eine satzung
rechtliche grundlage dafür gebe ohne
satz uns rechtliche grundlage und auch
bei der ausprägung unserer wahlordnung
an einzelnen stellen ist das aus unserer
sicht nicht zulässig
deshalb werden wir diesen antrag nicht
zur abstimmung stellen
dann haben wir einen
geschäftsordnungsantrag am blauen saal
mikrofon
ja also besteht dann die möglichkeit die
satzung in diesem punkt zu ändern also
ich stelle ja fest dass die
das ist keine geschäftsordnung am
fraglichen schulz sie können gerne
rettungs anträge stellen die frist
beträgt drei wochen
und mit drei wochen vor dem parteitag
und entsprechenden sondern rückt unter
berücksichtigung der sonstigen antrags
voraussetzungen kann das gestellt werden
ad hoc selbstverständlich nicht
so weitere anträge verfahren zum
verfahren der gleichen sehe ich nicht
dann
[Musik]
ja dann würde ich doch tatsächlich gerne
einmal die aktuelle anzahl der
akkreditierten mitglieder noch einmal
haben auch noch einmal vor dem was an
und wir haben zwischenzeitlich einmal im
roten saal mikrofon bitteschön ja ich
hätte noch eine frage wo ist der
unterschied dass sie die
abstimmen lassen über eine video video
vortrag und keinen persönlichen vortrag
der hier gemacht wird wo sind da die
unterschiede in der satzung dass die
eine abstimmung zulässig war vorhin und
diesmal nicht können sie das kurz
erklären
ja sehr einfach auch eine vorstellung
per video ist es immer noch der kandidat
selber und nicht ein nicht der beste
redner den der kandidat finden konnte um
es mal deutlich zu sagen das also ist
die frage ist es persönlich oder ist es
ein dritter der sich vorstellt
üblicherweise wie gesagt nach und seine
produktion ist es hier ein persönliches
ein persönliches recht des kandidaten ja
ganz deutlich wird wenn sie in den
bereichen öffentlicher wahlen schauen wo
der kandidat die gelegenheit hat sich
und sein programm oder die gelegenheit
haben muss sich und sein programm vor in
ausreichender zeit vorzustellen insofern
ist das der entscheidende unterschied
dass in auch bei einer videoübertragung
oder einer live-schalte ist immer noch
der kandidat selbst ist der dort
auftritt so weitere fragen wollte unter
gleichen sehe ich nicht dann haben wir
den verfahrens teil abgeschlossen wir
haben um 10 uhr 52
532 akkreditierte mitglieder in der
versammlung und ich rufe dann jetzt auf
die kandidatenliste für den erst zu
wählenden
bundessprecher ich bitte um vorschläge
oder kandidaturen wir haben einen
vorschlag hier vorne frau weiter
alles weil die jetzt wahrscheinlich den
ersten kandidaten
aufrufen holz oder vorstände ich möchte
gerne herrn tino copala als erster
bundessprecher vorschlagen vielen dank
[Applaus]
dann frage ich an dieser stelle auch
gleich nach den fünf unterstützern bitte
haben wir dann haben wir einen nächsten
vorschlag am blauen saal mikrofon herr
braun
jürgen braun ist mein name delegierter
aus baden württemberg ich schlage den
stellvertretenden
fraktionsvorsitzenden der afg im
deutschen bundestag norbert kleinwächter
vor
[Applaus]
zwei menschen unter den journalisten
jetzt nicht so überraschend sind dass
diese beiden sich zur wahl stellen oder
und das wird noch formal geprüft ob sie
die wahl die kandidatur annehmen
der muss noch einen hoch rutschen dort
gibt es weitere vorschläge oder
kandidaturen
das kann ich aktuell nicht erkennen
letzter aufruf für vorschläge und
kandidaturen
dann frage ich jetzt zuerst einmal die
beiden vorgeschlagenen ob sie überhaupt
zur verfügung stehen herr krupp
steht zur verfügung her kleinwächter
ja
dann haben wir hier zwei kandidaten und
und ich darf sie bitten mir mit der
blauen stimmkarte das schließen der
kandidatenliste zu bestätigen
wäre die noch nicht schließen möchte mit
die rote stimmkarte
enthaltungen dann ist die kandidaten
liste geschlossen wir haben zwei
kandidaten
und werden jetzt eine münze werfen
so dann haben wir hier einmal die zahl
für kuba und den adler für herrn
kleinwächter damit wird die reihenfolge
wer zuerst der spricht und sich
vorstellt wo entschieden er hält zuerst
die gelegenheit zur vorstellung und
danach herr pofalla
und dann darf ich einen kleinen richter
bereits nach vorne
norbert kleinwächter
36 jahre
stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender seiner partei
hat sich hier zur wahl gestellt er gilt
als der vertreter des
gemäßigten flügels
oder der gemäßigten strömungen in der
partei
und tritt gegen kinogruppe lahn
[Applaus]
guten morgen herr kleinwächter guten
morgen ich darf ihnen zuerst die drei
pflicht fragen stellen erste frage gibt
es unvereinbarkeiten nach § 19 der
bundessatzung nein enthielt ein
aktuelles polizeiliches führungszeugnis
eintragungen nein und in welchen
politischen parteien waren sie vor der
afg in der wsg 2005 2007 zu frühen
studienzeiten vielen dank dann haben sie
jetzt bis zu acht minuten zeit für ihre
vorstellung bitte schön viel leben dank
herr flack liebe delegierte adler passt
gut wir stehen alle gemeinsam ein für
die bundesrepublikanischen werte liebe
delegierte vielen dank dass ihr heute
alle gekommen seid dass ihr euch die
zeit genommen habt und die kosten auf
euch ich grüße auch alle mitglieder die
heute nicht da sein können und ich grüße
auch insbesondere die mitglieder aus
berlin und im saarland ich bin sehr
enttäuscht dass wir es als partei nicht
schaffen das alle landesverbände ich
hier auf dieser vertreterversammlung
eine vertretung haben und ich muss das
hier wirklich zum ausdruck bringen das
ist leider ein symbol für den zustand
unserer partei liebe freunde
[Applaus]
deutschland retten wir nicht indem wir
das andere lager bekämpfen deutschland
retten wir indem wir den politischen
gegner bekämpfen und dafür trete ich an
liebe freunde wir haben uns gegründet
und deutschland zu retten in diesem
moment
wissen ein fünftel der deutschen nicht
wie sie mit dem geld was sie im monat
zur verfügung haben jetzt noch durch den
rest des monats kommen sollen
die regierung weiß nicht ob wir im
winter noch genügend gas für heizen und
produktion haben karl lauterbach plant
mal wieder unsere freiheitsrechte zu
beschränken wegen eines virus die
europäische union will uns die
souveränität und die demokratie
verwehren und jeden tag bekommen
hunderte merkel migranten als dank für
ihre illegale einwanderung die deutsche
staatsbürgerschaft deutschland braucht
uns liebe freunde und deutschland
braucht uns jetzt denn wir
wir haben den mut zur wahrheit von
anfang an auch sorgen gehabt wir haben
von anfang an gesagt dass dieser euro
uns alle arm machen wird wir haben von
anfang an gesagt dass die sanktionen
gegen putin uns mehr schaden werden als
ihm auch wenn er ein aggressor ist wir
haben von anfang an die freiheit unserer
bürger verteidigt in der korona politik
unsere grundrechte die dürfen nicht
geopfert werden für ein virus auf grund
der anweisung eines gesundheitsministers
eine regierung oder einer eu kommission
deutschland braucht uns jetzt liebe
freunde
[Applaus]
und dr gauland ich habe immer dieses
wort fünfjährigen haufen auch so
empfunden und sehr geschätzt
aber wir haben keine zeit mehr für den
jährigen haufen wir haben keine zeit
mehr wir brauchen professionalisierung
wir brauchen einigkeit wir brauchen
disziplin und wir brauchen klare
leitlinien bei voller basisdemokratie
und dafür trete ich an
wir haben keine zeit für den gehring
haufen als abgeordneter und ich danke
euch dass ich diese wertvolle aufgabe
für euch erfüllen darf sehe ich wie
schnell die regierung ihre projekte
voran treibt
die wollen das ganz ganz schnell
und deswegen sage ich ganz deutlich wir
müssen nicht nur die parlamentarischen
mandate wahrnehmen wir müssen auch immer
dabei unsere partei und unser
politisches vorfeld stärken ich als
abgeordnete haben wir gedacht was kann
ich vor allem tun und habe dann einen
social media kanal aufgebaut sehr viele
videos gemacht man youtube kanal ist der
vierte meist geklickte aller afd mdbs
und die leute haben insgesamt über 47
jahre meine videos geguckt dass es elf
jahre länger als ich am leben bin und
vor der bundestagswahl in der woche
davor habe ich ein live fernsehen
gestartet fünf tage zwölf stunden durch
gesendet mit einem kleinen team es hat
geklappt es hat funktioniert es ging und
keiner kann mir sagen dass wir mit
unseren 30.000 mitgliedern das nicht
hinkriegen eine medienplattform
aufzubauen weil linear fernsehen oder
radio oder podcast zu machen
publikationen zu machen und unser wort
unsere themen unsere werte an den wähler
zu bringen das müssen wir gemeinsam
erreichen man muss es halt organisieren
[Applaus]
und ich habe unsere bewegung ein haus
gebaut
ich habe 45 minuten von hier in
falkenberg elster in ddr kulturhaus
gekauft komplett saniert modernisiert da
ist ein großer veranstaltungssaal drin
die fraktionen kann dort tragen wir
können politische veranstaltungen machen
die partei bekommt diesen saal umsonst
liebe freunde ich bin kein lager hengst
ich bin kein fäden spinner deswegen
meine politische karriere immer
irgendwie auch am seidenen faden aber
wisst ihr ich bin immer davon überzeugt
wer politisch handelt der kann auch
leisten und diejenigen die am wenigsten
produktiv tun sind meistens diejenigen
die die meisten intrigen spinnen
lieber timo
ich danke dir für die geleistete arbeit
als partei- und fraktionsvorsitzender
und ich bin
ich weiß dass es eine unglaublich
schwere aufgabe ist in der man fehler
machen muss und das weiß ich auch wenn
ich hier antrete
ich bin aber hier an diesem pult heute
weil ich der überzeugung bin dass wir
unglaublich große aufgaben vor uns haben
wir haben eine verantwortung für unser
land und wir müssen aus dem tief indem
wir sind dringend raus kommen mit einer
neuen politischen kommunikation mit
einem neuen stil mit einem neuen wind
dass die wähler da draußen auch sehen
ahadi afd da tut sich was positives für
uns in unserem sinne und ich glaube wir
kommen am besten gemeinsam voran wir
schaffen die einigkeit am allerbesten
wenn der eine mit voller kraft die
fraktion auf vordermann bringt als
fraktionsvorsitzender unter anderem mit
voller kraft die partei organisiert
leitet und nach vorne bringt als
parteivorsitzender wir müssen dann auch
zusammenarbeiten das ist doch klar aber
diese zusammenarbeit aus fraktion und
partei die bringt die einheit die wir
letztendlich brauchen und dafür trete
ich an
liebe freunde ich bewerbe mich hier als
bundessprecher und ich finde diesen
titel sehr passend denn als
bundessprecher müssen wir tatsächlich
sprechen kommunizieren unsere inhalte
nach draußen darstellen und das will ich
tun liebe freunde ich will zu euch in
die verbände kommen euch dort
unterstützen dass es eine
selbstverständlichkeit aber ich
verspreche euch ich werde da sein in
berlin ich werde unsere eigenen medien
füttern ich werde die öffentlichkeit
auch über die etablierten medien ja wir
dürfen sie nicht verpassen auch über die
etablierten medien informieren über
unsere politik ich werde alles tun damit
das was wir sagen was wir denken wie wir
fühlen wie wir argumentieren beim wähler
in deutschland ankommt der erkennt die
afd das ist die bürgerliche partei in
deutschland liberal und konservativ wir
vertreten eigentlich die mehrheit der
bevölkerung in unserem land sie weiß es
nur nicht und wir müssen sie darüber
informieren liebe freunde
und wenn das deutlich genug passiert
dann ist das auch der wichtigste beitrag
zur einigkeit über wertekodex usw die
man auch braucht hinweg aber wenn ganz
klar ist wenn der bundessprecher ganz
klar kommuniziert erst die demokratische
meinung einholt und dann die politischen
leitlinien immer klar darstellt und sagt
hierfür stehen wir so argumentieren wir
und das ist unsere haltung zu diesem und
jenem thema was alle mitglieder wissen
dies nach außen tragen können dann gibt
es auch nicht diese aus scherereien die
wir oft gesehen haben dann gibt es einen
großen beitrag zur einigkeit in unserer
partei und das müssen wir leisten
einigkeit disziplin klarheit dafür trete
ich an vielen dank
[Applaus]
viel applaus für die rede
von den ersten kandidaten für das amt
des sprechers norbert klein richter
sie haben jetzt die gelegenheit dem
kandidaten bis zu drei fragen zu stellen
ich schaue schon mal wenn schon fragen
eingeworfen wer noch eine frage anmelden
möchte bitte jetzt schnell
schnell nach vorne
also nicht laufen nicht wehtun
die fragen werden dann eingeworfen und
werden ausgelost das hatte ja ich
verhindern im verfahren das die frage
gestellt hatte
so
wurde der parteitag mit diesem verfahren
dass sie selber ja abgestimmt haben
behaftet
die erste frage kommt von
kathrin otto
die zweite frage kommt von hans-thomas
tillschneider
und die dritte frage von karl schwarz
so für
30 sekunden
kathrin otto
die anderen herr till schneider und herr
schwarz müssen sich auch schon mal an
sein mikrofon einfinden frau otto wo
haben wir sie
katrin auto gehört dem landesverband
brandenburg und ein mikrofon 34 32
sekunden bildschirm
herr kleinwächter als vorsitzender
sollte man unsere partei einen sie haben
einen erfolgen erfolgreichen landes und
fraktionsvorsitzenden mit kinderporno
edathy verglichen
bezeichnet man so öffentlich
parteikollegen
für eine minute klein möchte nein so
bezeichneten parteikollegen nicht und
das habe ich auch nicht gemacht ich habe
kritisiert dass der parteikollege und
ist übrigens habe ich sehr bald gelöscht
an einer sehr ungeeigneten stelle eine
öffentliche äußerung getätigt hat die
mit niemandem auch abgesprochen war und
ich muss an dieser stelle sehr klar
stellen das ist ein großes problem
unserer öffentlichkeitsarbeit das
einzige einzelne leute immer ein
sendungsbewusstsein entwickeln dann wenn
es überhaupt nicht passt
[Applaus]
unsere haltung muss sein wir sprechen
uns ab in leitlinien programm und
strategie und zur strategie gehört auch
manchmal dazu dass man miteinander
abspricht wann man etwas sagt wann man
etwas veröffentlicht und wann man etwas
tut und der vorabend einer wahl wo wir
dann letztendlich aus dem landtag
geflogen sind der war wahrlich nicht der
richtige zeitpunkt für die für die
äußerung sie damals getätigt wurde
vielen dank
dann kommt die nächste frage von herrn
tillschneider ebenfalls am blauen saal
mikrofon für bis zu 30 sekunden
bitteschön
ja herr kleinwächter im bundestag wurde
ein antrag abgestimmt zu unterstützung
der ukraine ein antrag der altparteien
der auch die lieferung schwerer waffen
nicht ausschließt 66 abgeordnete afd
haben dagegen gestimmt vier dafür drei
haben sich enthalten und sieben haben
nicht abgestimmt sie haben nicht
abgestimmt ich frage sie jetzt haben sie
einfach nur ihre pflichten als
bundestagsmitglied vernachlässigt oder
haben sie sich nicht getraut mit ja zu
stimmen
kein richter
ich habe meine pflichten als
bundestagsabgeordneter genau zu diesem
zeitpunkt wahrgenommen in der
parlamentarischen versammlung des
europarats in die ich nämlich entsandt
bin war in der zeit sich zu woche und
dort gab es eine resolution
waffenlieferungen an russlands zu
befürworten den die sanktionen zu
befürworten und sogar noch die
europäische union aufzufordern noch mehr
zu tun und ich hab dann abgewogen wo ist
meine stimme wichtiger in der
parlamentarischen versammlung des
europarats oder in berlin und ich bin an
dieser stelle in die parlamentarische
versammlung des europarats gefahren ich
habe dort eine rede gehalten die kann
jeder nach gucken unter youtube frieden
statt waffen und habe mich eindeutig
gegen waffenlieferungen in die ukraine
durch deutschland auf europäischer
der ausgesprochen ich bitte um
verzeihung dass sich aufgrund dieser
internationalen verpflichtungen nicht
immer in berlin bin aber dort was
straßburg tatsächlich mal wichtiger wie
wir wissen spielt viel musik auf der
europäischen ebene ob wir das wollen
oder nicht
vielen dank und die
dritte und letzte frage kommt von herrn
schwarz ebenfalls am blauen sein
mikrofon für bis zu 30 sekunden schön
herr kleinwächter sie haben 2021 die
aufstellungsversammlung im wahlkreis 65
unserer afd zur bundestagswahl
angefochten entspricht das ihrer
vorstellung von erfolgreicher arbeit für
unsere afd
na ja wir haben eine
schiedsgerichtsbarkeit
und die kann man jeder als mitglied
anrufen wenn irgendwo eine
rechtsstreitigkeit existiert ja dafür
haben wir schiedsgericht und ich finde
es gut das ist die schiedsgerichte gibt
und ich glaube dass wir tatsächlich auch
diese innere rechtsprechung in unserer
partei auch nochmals stärken müssen und
an dieser stelle auch mein herzlicher
dank an all die schiedsrichter die auf
landes und bundesebene
aktenordner abarbeiten ich weiß das ist
sehr sehr viel mir wäre es lieber wir
bräuchten die schiedsgerichte nicht in
diesem umfang beanspruchen deswegen habe
ich auch in meiner agenda geschrieben
wir brauchen einen wertekodex das von
anfang an klar ist dass man zum beispiel
keine aufstellungsversammlung in der
diesel versuchten werkstatt eines
kandidaten abhält das gehört dazu das
gehört dazu
aber es wäre gut wenn wir diese regel
von anfang an fest schreiben und dann
wissen wir woran wir sind dann können
wir die schiedsgerichte entlasten aber
wichtige fälle müssen vor die
schiedsgerichte da stehe ich ganz dafür
ein vielen herzlichen dank für all eure
aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
ja vielen dank herr kleinwächter das von
drei fragen drei antworten damit sind
sie mit dank entlassen und als nächstes
darf fässern also die fragen die an
norbert klein richter gestellt wurden
drei kritische fragen den er sich
stellen möchte
bevor wir bevor wir hier anfangen
[Musik]
bevor wir anfangen wenn sie eben eine
karte eingeworfen haben gerne bei
gelegenheit auch wieder abholen sonst
haben wir nachher eine größere sammlung
guten tag herr kubala auch am see zuerst
die drei pflicht fragen im ohr kann
besteht eine unvereinbarkeit nach § 19
und der bundessatzung night enthielt ein
aktuelles polizeiliches führungszeugnis
eintragungen das fliegt bei ihnen vor
können sie drauf schauen als trend hält
keiner eintragung und waren sie vor der
ard mit welchen politischen parteien
waren sie vor traf die mitglied ich war
nur in der jugendorganisation der cdu in
der jungen union zwei jahre von 1990 bis
vielen dank dann haben sie jetzt bis zu
acht minuten zeit für ihre vorstellung
vielen dank ja liebe landsleute liebe
parteifreunde unsere partei feiert in
den nächsten jahr ihren zehnten
geburtstag gemeinsam haben wir viel
erreicht wir sind die einzig wahre
oppositionskraft in deutschland wir sind
keine und darauf lege ich wert und das
wollen wir auch nicht wir sind keine
zweite fdp und wir sind auch keine zwei
der cdu oder spd
und wir wollen wir wollen cdu und fdp
überflüssig machen wir sind die erste
und die letzte alternative
und das sind wir unter den gegenwärtigen
bedingungen eben nur als opposition ja
klar vernehmbar und furchtlos wir machen
nicht mit bei impfpflicht krieg und
offenen grenzen und wenn wir einmal
regieren dann wären wir als
regierungspartei ebenso unverwechselbar
sein wir machen politik für deutschland
dieses jahr dieses jahr haben wir im
deutschen bundestag die korona endlich
gestoppt das haben wir zusammen mit den
tausenden von familien mit
hunderttausenden von bürgern erreicht
die gegen die freiheitliche corona
politik auf die straße gegangen ist ging
die freiheitsfeindliche corona politik
auf die straße gegangen sind und das
haben wir zusammen mit den bürgern auf
der straße erreicht wir sind die partei
die mit den bürgern auf der straße eine
stimme gibt das ist unsere auftrag und
das werden wir auch in zukunft tun und
damit haben wir geschichte geschrieben
und die wahrheit ist aber auch wir sind
noch weit davon entfernt unsere politik
für deutschland zum wohl aller bürger
umzusetzen aber das ist nicht unsere
schuld die altparteien haben sich nicht
auf unseren patriotischen kurs zubewegt
cdu chef friedrich merz hat sogar eine
brandmauer wie er sagt zur alternative
für deutschland errichtet das muss man
sich mal vorstellen ein politiker in
deutschland redet wieder von mauern er
bedroht die cdu-mitglieder mit
ausschluss wenn sie zum wohl
deutschlands mit uns zusammenarbeiten
und deshalb sage ich märz ist kein
patriot er will den weltkrieg und er
will die impfpflicht märz ist ein grüner
wolf im schwarzen schaf welt
liebe freunde die bedrohung werden
größer und nicht kleiner die illegale
massenzuwanderung geht ungebremst weiter
und die teuerung zieht den bürgern das
geld aus der tasche mindestens zwei euro
für den sprit drei euro für ein stück
butter zehn euro für ein kilo brot und
ich rede hier von grundnahrungsmitteln
liebe freunde und was tut unserer
bundeswirtschaftsminister weg um die
folgen der installation abzumildern er
fordert die bürger auf duschköpfe
auszutauschen und die heizung
herunterzudrehen und jetzt will er ihnen
auch noch per gesetz die energie
drosseln das ist keine
verantwortungsvolle
regierungspolitik sondern dass es
autoritär und abgehoben
die inflation ist hausgemacht jetzt so
hoch wie seit 50 jahren nicht mehr und
die bundesregierung trägt die
hauptverantwortung dafür und das müssen
wir auch klar machen und nicht nur das
der krieg ist zurück in europa er hätte
durch diplomatie verhindert werden
können er hätte durch diplomatie längst
beendet werden müssen aber anstatt aber
[Applaus]
anstatt sich für ein ende des krieges
einzusetzen liefert die bundesregierung
schwere waffen ins kriegsgebiet und
verhängt sanktionen die am ende die
eigenen bürger schaden aber den krieg
keine sekunde verkürzen wir wollen diese
außenpolitik nicht die die grünen
beschönigend als werte geleitet nennen
wir fordern eine interessengeleitete
außenpolitik für deutschland wir
vertreten die interessen deutschlands
und das ist unser alleinstellungsmerkmal
[Applaus]
ich bin seit 2009 10 bundessprecher der
alternative für deutschland wo auch
immer ich konnte dort habe ich unsere
politischen positionen im sinne der
basis bestimmen lassen sie ist das
fundament
unserer partei stellen sie sich vor wir
hätten bei corona auf die regierungs
freunde in unseren reihen gehörten und
hätten lockdown und impfpflicht
gefordert gegen alle freiheit und gegen
die interessen unserer bürger dann
würden wir als lügner und opportunisten
dastehen wie die fdp heute
und noch dazu
und noch dazu mit leeren händen und
jetzt im ukraine kriegt ist es wieder
das selbe ich vertrete nicht nur die
position von timo grub aller ich
vertrete die position unserer partei auf
ihrer klausurtagung
auf ihrer klausurtagung hat unsere
bundestagsfraktion ein gutes und
ausgewogenes positionspapier beschlossen
und darin steht klare verurteilung des
russischen angriffs aber
keine waffenlieferung und keine
sanktionen und natürlich habe ich auch
die position der landesverbände
abgefragt das stimmungsbild unter den
landessprecher war eindeutig alle bis
auf einen schlossen sich unsere position
an ich habe die position für einen
bundesfachausschuss 1 abgefragt und
diese bekräftigte die eckpunkte der
übrigen gremien und daraufhin folgte
dann mein mitglieder rundschreiben an
die parteibasis deshalb kann ich sagen
ich bin der bundessprecher der basis und
ich bin nicht angegriffen werde dann nur
deshalb wenn ich angegriffen dann nur
deshalb weil die basis zum schweigen
gebracht werden soll aber das werde ich
nicht zulassen liebe freunde
[Applaus]
eine alternative für deutschland sollten
basisdemokratie und disziplin kein
widerspruch sein entscheidungen werden
gemeinsam erarbeitet doch jedoch von
denen schlussendlich getroffen und
verantwortet die dafür basisdemokratisch
ins amt gewählt wurden gelebte
hierarchien sind wichtig um gemeinsam
erarbeitete beschlüsse auch umsetzen zu
können der bundesvorstand übernimmt
dabei genau diese aufgabe als
exekutivorgan muss er die beschlüsse der
basis umsetzen der vergangenheit haben
manche vorstandsmitglieder dem
bundesvorstand allerdings für
flügelkämpfe missbraucht die folge war
streit streit und wieder streit aber die
wähler liebe freunde gehen ihre stimme
keiner partei die ein bild der
zerstrittenheit abgibt im vorfeld dieses
parteitages
im vorfeld dieses parteitages hat diese
kleine gruppe von politikern sogar
parallel strukturen aufgebaut sie
verschickten über einen eigenen
pressesprecher eigene pressemitteilung
und veranstalteten eigene
pressekonferenzen oder hintergrund
gespräche in denen sie die partei und
fraktionsführung schlecht machten mit
denen sie die partei und
fraktionsführung beschädigen wollten und
dieses verhalten macht genau das kaputt
was wir in mühevoller arbeit im
parlament oder auch am infostand ihr
alle aufbauen liebe freunde
liebe freunde
es geht hier nicht um mich sondern es
geht in diesem moment auch um diejenigen
die für uns an der basis die vielen
ehrenamtlichen die arbeit leisten und
die werden beschädigt ihr alle werdet
mit so etwas beschädigt und deshalb muss
ich ganz lang bereiten wir diesen dingen
hier und heute ein ende das muss ein
ende haben
[Applaus]
meine damen und herren helfen sie
deshalb und mir uns allen auch den
gewählten neuen bundesvorstand mit diese
ziele zu erreichen für unsere partei für
deutschland hier um steht ist hier sind
die partei die für deutschland und für
freiheit kämpft und dafür bitte ich um
ihre stimme vielen dank
[Applaus]
ebenfalls viel applaus für
die bewerbungsrede
des
amtierenden im gespräch keynote dollar
der sich mit dieser rede für weitere
zwei jahre in dieser art gehört
sie haben dann auch hier die möglichkeit
fragen zu stellen das sind schon ein
paar karten eingeworfen worden
ist noch jemand unterwegs der eine frage
anmelden möchte dann bitte jetzt
irgendwo
bemerkbar machen ja wohl da ist noch
jemand unterwegs 20
wenn ihnen die frage nicht erst bei
minute 57 an der rede kommt dürfen sie
auch schon während der redezeit reise
durch den saal gehen und die
karten einwerfen das gilt für den
verbleibenden tag
sie sehen hier wie die mitglieder
zu dem kleinen eimer gehen die karten
dann hinein werfen mit den fragen
logischerweise sind es mit sicherheit
mehr mehr mehr vielmehr frage so weiter
dran als die 3d erlaubt sind die drei
fragensteller und die rein fußwegen
[Musik]
die erste frage kommt von
lars heisel
die
zweite frage kommt von
oliver munz und
die dritte frage von silvio wolff
für 30 sekunden erste reise dann helmut
stamm herr wolf
und wir haben herrn reise am roten saal
mikrofon bitte sehr
ich lasse mein name kreisverband
ramsauer aus baden württemberg hatte was
sie sagten eben wenn ich angegriffen
werden dann bei dem basis angegriffen
werden soll das klingt so ein bisschen
nach die partei das bin ich der staat
das bin ich haben sie nicht verstanden
dass wir eben aus guten gründen eine
doppelspitze beschlossen haben und eine
doppelspitze beschlossen haben eben weil
wir keine alternativlosen und
allmächtigen einzel sprecher haben
wollen vielen dank
zur antwort herr kummer lassen für eine
minute ja wenn sie bei einer rede genau
zugehört hätten und da habe ich ja auch
davon gesprochen und das ist natürlich
auch ein punkt von hierarchien die auch
respektiert und akzeptiert werden müssen
wenn wir heute auf diesem
bundesparteitag einen bundesvorstand
wählen werden dann haben diese personen
natürlich auch einen gewissen
vertrauensvorschuss
aber diesen vertrauensvorschuss muss man
diesen personen geben und wenn einzelne
parteimitglieder öffentlich über die
presse genau diese personen beschädigen
angreifen dann schaden sie nicht nur der
person wissen sie ich kann damit gut ab
ganz ehrlich ich habe ganz andere dinge
im einmal lebt in meinem leben erlebt
als person
hinterrücks getroffenen pressemitteilung
die mich vielleicht schaden aber sie
schaden unserer sache sie schauen
unseren wählern und die schaden vor
allem denjenigen die an den
wahlkampfständen
die schaden vor allem denjenigen die an
den wahlkampfständen diese unangenehmen
fragen beantworten müssen das müssen
diejenigen die den schaden verursacht
haben nämlich nicht vielen dank
[Applaus]
die nächste frage für bis zu 30 sekunden
von herrn mythos bitteschön
kristalle ja erstmal oliver molitor
stellvertretender bezirksvorsitzender
von oberbayern
europa ich habe ihre rede mit interesse
verfolgt was wir aber hier völlig
gefehlt hat ist die perspektive was
anders laufen soll die frage ist sie
ganz konkret nach den letzten verlorenen
wollen die wir haben die ein erster
linie unter ihrer führung als
bundesvorstand zu verantworten ist mal
ganz klar was wollen sie in zukunft
anders machen da wir hier wieder besser
dastehen
vielen dank zur antwort
ja das danke für die frage dass sie
genau darauf eingehen kann das ist genau
das was natürlich aus als nächster
bundesvorstand auch vorantreibt und nach
was uns natürlich auch ein bisschen
sorge gemacht hat und wir werden im
nächsten bundesvorstand als allererstes
auch die niedersachsen war vorbereiten
müssen die nächste ist aber was wir
brauchen ist die unterstützung aller
kreis und landesverbänden auch um sich
gegenseitig zu unterstützen und wir
haben es erlebt in schleswig holstein da
wurden sogar wahl und unterstützungs
anfang abgelehnt ich denke das darf
nicht sein wir müssen uns gegenseitig
unterstützen gerade dort in der fläche
wo wir im schwächer sind
[Applaus]
und darf ja und darf dafür bin ich immer
eingetreten ich bin immer dorthin
gereist wo ich angefragt wenn ich es
möglich machen konnte ich unterstütze wo
ich kann und wir sollten das auch in
zukunft viel mehr forcieren dass die
kreisverbände enger zusammenarbeiten das
ist partnerschaften und da gibt es ja
einige schon gründet partnerschaften
auch zwischen ost und west dann verträgt
man unter den fallenden versteht man
sich auch besser das ist wichtig und das
sollten wir auch in zukunft machen
vielen dank
und die dritte frage kommt von herrn
wolf am blauen saal mikrofon für bis zu
30 sekunden britische ja so wolf
kreisverband oberspreewald-lausitz wer
norbert kleinwächter wählt macht sich
entweder mit schuldig oder
ist ungesund
meine frage ist
meine frage ist ist es normal dass ein
norbert kleinwächter permanent lügen
verbreitet über parteimitglieder dieser
öffentlich luft lässt die lüge stehen
und entscheidet sich privat
und als zweites wer 350 mitglieder
wissentlich
die redezeit ist vorbei die fragezeit
sie haben formal gesehen eine frage
gestellt und her grob aller kann diese
jetzt beantworten ja ich gehe jetzt mal
auf die person überhaupt nicht einig die
auf die frage ob in dem sinne nicht
direkt ein das ist die entscheidung der
mitglieder aber lassen sie mich
vielleicht noch einen ganz kurzen
schlusssatz sagen damit habe ich ja die
gelegenheit dafür ich möchte ihnen
vielleicht noch mal aus meiner historie
auch aus meiner verwurzelung einiges
sagen und zwar wissen sie ich bin 15
jahre selbstständiger malermeister
gewesen ich habe ein unternehmen
aufgebaut habe zehn mitarbeiter gehabt
und ich hätte es eigentlich nicht nötig
gab ich sags mal so offen
verantwortung überhaupt in einer
politischen partei zu leisten und zu
machen aber mir liegt deutschland wir
liegen meine kinder und vielleicht auch
mal meine enkelkinder am herzen und
deshalb mache ich das hier für sie als
ehrenamt und ich möchte dazu beitragen
und ich will
und ich möchte dazu ich möchte dazu auch
in zukunft beitragen ich bitte um ihr
vertrauen geben sie mir die chance mit
einem guten geeinten bundesvorstand die
vergangenheit hinter uns zu lassen heute
muss es einen aufbruch geben liebe
freunde vielen dank
[Applaus]
vielen dank herr
vielen dank herr kubala das waren drei
fragen beantworten
damit sind auch sie mit dank entlassen
wir müssen uns hier einmal kurz beraten
ja soweit die fragen die an herrn
pofalla gestellt wurden wobei einer der
fragen sich nicht mit ihm und seiner
politischen arbeit
beschäftigte sondern eher mit seinem
gegenkandidaten oder mit dem zweiten
kandidaten norbert kleinwächter ich
denke mal es geht jetzt darum wie darauf
reagiert werden soll
tagungspräsident steckt gerade mal
wieder die köpfe zusammen um zu
überlegen wie das sein soll ob es
einfach geschehen wurde und ob man dazu
in irgendeiner art und weise noch
stellung nimmt aber ich denke mal dass
das
in kurzer zeit hier weitergeht
der kandidat steht noch ein arbeit
kleinwächter in einem saal mikrofon und
hat sicherlich noch das bedürfnis sich
zu äußern
müssen wir abwarten was jetzt passiert
ob die frage noch zugelassen wird oder
seine einlassung
beiden reicht ja eine einfache mehrheit
der delegierten hier im saal die
berechtigt sind an dieser wahl
teilzunehmen
dann hören wir mal was der
versammlungsleiter
uns weiter über die wahl so meine ferne
wir sind hier gerade
zeuge doch etwas unschön vorfalls
geworden herr wolf ich rücke sie für im
namen des präsidiums für die
diffamierung und für die benutzung des
wortes lügner
über an kandidaten
und
mit der maßgabe dies ausschließlich zur
richtigstellung
der erhobenen vorwurf zu machen erteile
ich ein kleinwächter für 15 sekunden das
wort am blauen saal mikrofon
ausschließlich dazu ich bitte sie im
gesamten tag wenn sie fragen stellen
bleiben sie fair dass wir sind die
alternative für deutschland und als
alternative deutschland sind wir besser
als das
so herr kleinwächter 15 sekunden
vielen dank liebe präsidium diese
darstellung dort war fakten widrig lasst
uns alle zur einigkeit beitragen und
solchen hass lassen vielen dank
so vielen dank
[Applaus]
meine damen und herren in zwei minuten
treten wir dann wahlgang ein dann werden
die türen geschlossen die zeit läuft
ja in diesen zeiten können die
delegierten rein oder raus können sich
entscheiden ob sie an der wahl
teilnehmen wollen oder nicht das quorum
haben wir ja gesehen ist mit 500 über
500 delegierten ja gut gefüllt 600
delegierte sind maximal
zulässig für diesen parteitag der ja ein
delegierter parteitag ist wir werden
später noch im verlauf des parteitags
sehen dass es anträge gibt den nächsten
parteitag als mitgliederpartei tag zu
organisieren das wäre dann in der tat
eine
übersichtliche mängel von
mitgliedern die dann dazu kommen können
weil
dieses so ist dass jedes mitglied in dem
nächsten parteitag dann teilnehmen hier
könnte mal mitzuteilen
es wird elektronisch dann abgestimmt
dieses verfahren
so sicher zu machen und auch ein
bisschen damit zu verstecken die eigene
stimme zu verstecken so um 11 uhr
34 sind akkreditiert
stimmberechtigte teilnehmer
wie jetzt wenn sie alle im saal sind und
dann sagst dass du türen zu sehen
abstimmen können das ist bedauerlich ich
hoffe den geht es einem gut
so noch 20 sekunden dann werden die
türen geschlossen
die beiden kandidaten norbert
kleinwächter und tino keller bewerben
sich für das amt des ersten gerne los
schoss gleich jemand angestellt und
danach geht es dann direkt weiter zur
wahl des zweiten bundes sprechers der
quasi der co-vorsitzende ist die partei
hatte ja für
sich entschieden zu beginn des
parteitages am 2 sprecher für die
nächsten zwei jahre zu benennen aller
stimmen sie können mit der 3 gegen beide
kandidaten votieren und sich mit vier
der stimme enthalten
die abstimmung ist geöffnet eine minute
zeit ab jetzt 1 für kleinwächter 24
kubala
39 zu beiden vier enthaltung
die abstimmung läuft beide kandidaten
beides männer der eine 36 der andere 47
beide schon seit einiger zeit in der afg
und in mehreren funktionen tätig die
jetzt in einer kampfkandidatur um das
amt des bundes sprechers sich bewerben
und darum kämpfen und der parteitag ist
jetzt in der abstimmung mit der frage
wem geben sie die mehrheit
dem
waren im amt befindlichen bundessprecher
tino keller oder seinem herausforderer
norbert kleinwächter stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender der afg im
bundestag
fünf sekunden
321 nun wirklich ein ergebnis
einzublenden
[Applaus]
53,45 prozent für teenager der
gegenkandidaten aber kleinwächter
36,31 prozent
[Musik]
für weitere zwei jahre im amt ist
gestern beschloss wiedergewählt worden
nur 50 haben mit nein votiert bei einer
enthaltung ich stelle fest dass der
kandidat kubaner mit
53,4 5 prozent die erforderliche
einfache mehrheit
erreicht hat und herr kubaner ich frage
sie ob sie die wahl auch annehmen
herzlichen glückwunsch im namen des
gesamten präsidiums auf eine gute
amtszeit
so in anbetracht des medialen der
medialen aufmerksamkeit hier vorne haben
wir uns hier verständigt wir
unterbrechen den parteitag für sieben
minuten bis 11 uhr 45 dann mögen sich
aber die traube von gratulanten und
medienvertretern vorne auch wieder
aufgelöst haben in sieben minuten fahren
wir fort
ja damit ist der hund bitte das ergebnis
nochmal einblenden kann technik
unterbrochen die wahl zum ersten
bundessprecher ist erfolgt
53,4 prozent
für tino gruppe den amtsinhaber den
alten und neuen
bundessprecher für den unterlegenen
norbert kleinwächter stimmten
36,31 prozent ich wiederhole noch mal
natürlich wird jetzt erstmal
wollen alle natürlich erstmal die ersten
bilder des neuen und alten bundes
sprechers haben natürlich kann man auch
dieses
erste ergebnis werten
53,45 prozent für kinogruppe
kann man durchaus
analysieren und ich denke mal dass es
bevor es dann zur wahl des zweiten
bundessprecher es kommt dass wir dann
eine kurze analyse tätigen können
um die reden die die beiden gehalten
haben ihre bewerbungsreden um die fragen
die sich im anschluss daran gedacht
haben und um die intervention die dann
passiert ist
das war das erste mal auf diesem
parteitag dass es sozusagen zur
persönlichen
ausfällen oder beziehungsweise zu
persönlichen bemerkungen gekommen ist
das wurde aber dann vom präsidium gerügt
also wir haben zeit um eine erste
analyse dieses wahlergebnisses zu
tätigen damit gebe ich ab zu alexander
keller
ja wir schauen uns jetzt dieses erste
ergebnis der wahl hier auf dem
fdp-bundesparteitag genauer an mit uns
auch heute professor wolfgang schröder
universität kassel und
wissenschaftszentrum berlin herr
schröder das ergebnis 53 zu 36 haben
sich auch relativ viele enthalten
beziehungen gesagt haben keinen von
beiden das man etwa zehn prozent das ist
ja auch relativ viel wieso ergebnis zu
bewerten überrascht sie das überrascht
sie das nicht auch der abstand zwischen
den beiden
ausstellungen ergebnis ist relativ
überraschungsfrei man muss natürlich
sagen für einen vorsitzenden ist ein
ergebnis mit knapp über 50 prozent keine
gute basis um führungsstärke und die
gewissheit zu haben dass man wirklich
von der organisation von der partei
getragen wird der wettstreit der hier in
den reden ausgeführt wurde war für die
verhältnisse der afg relativ fair
gewesen was die inhalte angeht beide
kandidaten sind jetzt wechselseitig
nicht ausdrücklich aufeinander
eindreschen gegangen sondern haben
versucht jeweils ihre stärken
herauszukehren bzw
versucht zu erklären worum sie in der
vergangenheit nicht so stark sein
konnten wie das wünschenswert wäre wenn
es kampfkandidaturen gibt auch in
anderen parteien dann ist es da ergebnis
natürlich viel knapper als wenn es nur
einen kandidaten eine kandidatin gibt
insofern ist das schon ein
vertrauensbeweis für kino palaver muss
hat schon klar sagen dass coop aller der
kandidat des flügels ist der flügel ist
hier die mobilisierung stärkste gruppe
insofern ist das ergebnis den bisherigen
kräfte verhältnissen entsprechend die
rede von kleinwächter war jetzt auch
nicht so überragend dass er im bereich
der unentschlossenen zusätzliche starke
punkte machen konnte er hat im
vordergrund gestellt die einigkeit der
partei und die kommunikations schwäche
des bisher amtierenden sprechers und des
neuen sprechers und damit ein angebot
unterbreitet was aber dann am ende nicht
an obwohl also rhetorisch war klein
richter aber tino keller überlegen auch
deutlich überlegen deutlich überlegen
aber es war eben nicht so dass der saal
wirklich getobt hat dass der saal den
eindruck hatte also hier ist wirklich
eine überwölbende
alternative die uns eine bessere zukunft
verspricht aber dahinter stehen
natürlich die klar fest gewonnenen
kräfteverhältnis zwischen dem eher
gemäßigten flügel und dem radikalen
flügel es gab noch eine interessante ein
besonderes ereignis im laufe des
wahlkampfs das darf ja an die das ist
eine spezialität der afg an die rednern
die kandidaten dürfen drei fragen
gestellt werden möglichst kritische an
die kandidaten das war mal kleinwächter
auch so zunächst mal bei tino keller
auch der letzte redner silvio wolff aus
brandenburg der hat allerdings dann
massiv norbert kleinwächter noch einmal
beschuldigt der bei einer
war listenaufstellung so wie ich das
mitbekommen habe dass er da mit falschen
karten gespielt hat obwohl latino copala
oben auf dem rednerpult stand
wie ist das eigentlich zu werden hat das
einen einfluss gehabt kleinwechter
dürfte es sich ja nur noch 15 sekunden
danach rechtfertigen auch dieser zeit
unterschied ist ja sehr auffällig
gewesen kilo copala hat ja dann diese
frage die gar nicht ihm galt dafür
genutzt nochmal an die wähler zu
appellieren wie ist dieser vorgang
insgesamt zu bewerten das ist ein klares
foul weil es gibt ja hier im reglement
das reglement heißt fragen an den
jeweiligen kandidaten hier wurde die
chance genutzt um dem kandidaten der
zunächst gesprochen hatte ein
kleinwächter zu beschädigen und gerade
wenn das am ende ist bleibt das ja auch
stehen und ist für kleinwächter nicht
mehr zu neutralisieren also insofern war
das ein klares foul nachteil man muss
auch sehen es ist auch ein nachteil wenn
zwei kandidaten sprechen und der zweite
kandidat ist natürlich wenn eine gute
rede hält besser im gedächtnis als der
erste insofern ist auch zu fragen wie
diese reihenfolge zustande kommen ob die
ausgelost worden ist oder ob die einfach
so gesetzt wurde weil wenn sie gesetzt
werden wenn sie gesetzt sein sollte ist
es auf jeden fall ein nachteil für
kleinwächter gut ist ja wohl aus einer
kiste gezogen worden als los in dieser
reihenfolge gut das war dann
möglicherweise pech für kleinwächter was
macht das was gibt das für ein image für
die afg wenn so etwas passiert
naja es zeigt deutlich dass sind
unverträglichkeiten die in der fairness
nicht vorgesehen sind und das ist eine
kampfsituation wo also mit allen mitteln
hier vorgegangen wird wir müssen hier
unterbrechen denn der wahlsieger thilo
köhler spricht glaube durch müller hat
mehr informationen
ja danke alexander keller wie es scheint
möchte tino keller sich nach seiner
wieder erstarkten wahl an die
delegierten wenden
so jetzt darf ich zum einen alle
delegierten bitten ihre plätze wieder
einzunehmen und auch die presse bitten
hier vorne die die sicht auf die bühne
wieder frei zu geben und von uns in
richtung
versammlung dass wir fortfahren können
wir fahren nicht fort bevor wir hier
nicht wieder ordnungsgemäß arbeiten
können
der frisch gewählte bundessprecher tina
propeller oder wiedergewählter
bundessprecher tino köhler wartet bis
sich
in seinem gesichtsfeld die medien erst
mal ein stück fährt wieder nach den
ganzen bildern zurückgezogen haben und
wird sich dann wahrscheinlich in einer
kurzen rede
an die delegierten wenden
so
meine damen und herren bei denen sie
ihre plätze wieder einen wir fahren mit
dem parteitag fort und eröffnet die
kandidaten
das wird dann wahrscheinlich die der
vorschlag von kinogruppe
die kandidat neueste film des zweiten
gesprächen sein und das amt des
sprechers ich bitte um vorschläge für
einen weiteren bundessprecher ein erster
vorschlag kommt hier vorne vom
rednerpult hair group ag
schlage dr alice weidl vor
vielen dank
dann frage ich hier ob es auch
mindestens fünf unterstützer gibt bitte
einmal haben ja wohl das ist der fall
gibt es weitere vorschläge vorschläge
für einen weiteren bundessprecher am
blauen saal mikrofon herr mackowski
trieben ist bildschirm dankeschön ich
schlage herrn jörg spaniel vor doktor
der spanier ist vorgeschlagen gibt es
auch hier fünf mindestens fünf
unterstützer bitte einmal den arm heben
das stehe nicht für den wahlgang zur
verfügung der fall
spanien erklärte nicht zur verfügung zu
stehen da kann man gleich wieder
gestrichen werden dort
dann am roten saal mikrofon
ja ich schlage
nikolausfest vor
dr nikolausfest des vorgeschlagenen gibt
es hier 5 unterstützer
einmal
einmal die hand deutlich zeigen ja wohl
haben wir vielen dank und dann frage ich
ob es weitere vorschläge für einen
zweiten bundessprecher gibt
das scheint nicht der fall zu sein dann
frage ich die vorgeschlagenen erst
einmal ab wie eben auch frau doktor
weide stehen sie zur verfügung
steht zur verfügung herr doktor fest
stehen sie zur verfügung
steht ebenfalls zur verfügung
ich sehe keine weiteren vorschläge dann
darf ich sie bitten die schließung der
kandidatenliste zu
vorzunehmen und zwar indem sie jetzt die
blaue stimmkarte heben
eine stimmkarte zum schließen der
kandidatenliste
dankeschön gegen stimmenenthaltung dann
ist die kandidaten liste geschlossen
so und ich habe hier wieder eine münze
haben wir eine magd irgendwo nicht es
ist ein euro münze es tut mir leid
und ich werde jetzt die vorstellungs
reihenfolge auslosen doktor
doktor schlossfest adler
die münze die entscheidet wer zuerst
erhalten kann die wahl hat alles seidel
gewonnen also sie wird die erste sein
die jetzt in acht minuten aber auch für
die ihren bewerbungsreden
halten auflösen
alles beide fraktionsvorsitzende der fdp
bereits im bundestag
zusammen auch mit tino keller guten
tagen auch beide jetzt in der halle
haben wir drei pflicht fragen liegen
unvereinbarkeiten nach § 19 vor
enthielt ein aktuelles polizeiliches
führungszeugnis eintragungen auch nicht
und in welchen politischen parteien
waren sie vor der afd mitglied in keiner
dann haben sie jetzt bis zu acht minuten
zeit für ihre vorstellungen und herren
bitte lassen sie ruhe im saal ein kern
frau beide sie haben das wort
liebe freunde ich
bin froh und stolz
heute hier auf dem parteitag stehen
und in so viele bekannte gesichter
blicken zu dürfen
ich möchte uns allen noch weitere gute
und fruchtbringende debatten und
entscheidungen wünschen
viel wurde im vorfeld dieses parteitages
durch die medien geschrieben die afd in
schwerer krise kfd auf dem absteigenden
ast
vor wenigen tagen erklärte ein
ehemaliger bundessprecher die afg sei
ein
auslaufmodell
ihr habt es vielleicht mitverfolgt jörg
meuten hat vor einer woche in einer groß
angekündigten pressekonferenz seinen
beitritt zur katholischen mini partei
zentrum erklärt
er hat dafür extra einen kostspieligen
saal in der bundespressekonferenz in
berlin gebucht und tatsächlich hätte für
dieses trauerspiel ein beichtstuhl in
einer friedhofskapelle
aufgereiht
[Applaus]
und nein
die afd
ist kein auslaufmodell die afg ist die
partei der zukunft liebe freunde
die afd
ist das notwendige korrektiv in der
verkrusteten parteienlandschaft und ohne
uns steht das land vor einer bitteren
zukunft außer frage steht wir haben
schon einmal komfortablere zeiten erlebt
aber
wer von uns hat denn wirklich gedacht
dass es bei einem projekt wie der afg
keine zwischen schläge geben würde dass
wir ungehindert von sieg zu sieg
marschieren werden können dass die
etablierten parteien tatenlos ihrem
machtverlust zu sehen
es war völlig klar
das imperium schlägt zurück und darauf
werden wir reagieren
denn wir sind nicht angetreten
um es möglichst komfortabel und bequem
zu haben
wir sind angetreten um
dieses land zu verändern für unsere
kinder für unsere enkel
was aber ist zu tun erstens wir müssen
wieder lernen zu kämpfen
lassen wir uns nicht von jedem
rückschlag leicht nach unten ziehen
halten wir uns doch an unseren zielen
unseren idealen fest und man sollte sich
stets reflektieren dass es völlig klar
aber nicht jede inhaltliche und
personelle position muss permanent in
frage gestellt werden uns hat in der
vergangenheit die gradlinigkeit stark
gemacht
zweitens wir müssen unsere erfolge
besser verkaufen zeigen wir was wir was
die afg geleistet hat ich habe es
gestern schon erwähnt die afd war dafür
verantwortlich die impfpflicht im
deutschen bundestag zu verhindern dass
waren wir
[Applaus]
und wir werden jeden weiteren versuch
verhindern zur einführung einer
allgemeinen impfpflicht und ich muss
noch eins sagen wir werden es euch auch
durch bringen dass die einrichtungs
bezogene impfpflicht fällt auch die
pflege bezogene endlich für
pflegepersonal muss fallen man tritt den
menschen nicht in den rücken die für
andere da sind wenn sie in not sind so
geht man nicht mit menschen um
wir haben die themen innere sicherheit
migration und gescheiterte integration
in die öffentlichkeit gebracht das waren
wir das war keine andere partei
und das wird uns auch in naher zukunft
wir wissen alle es kommt eine weitere
krise auf und zu
inflation teuerung energie energiekrise
all das sind themen die jetzt schon
verstärkt im raum stehen eine
inflationsrate von zehn prozent ist noch
gar nichts sie werden noch mehr sehen
was glauben wir eigentlich was in diesem
land los sein wird und da sind wir die
einzige problemlösungs partei liebe
freunde und darauf müssen wir uns
fokussieren
drittens
wir müssen unser land in den vordergrund
stellen nicht die eigenen
befindlichkeiten
ich habe es gestern auch schon
angesprochen hören wir doch auf mit den
haltlosen anschuldigungen in der
öffentlichkeit
hören wir auf die medien mit internen
scharmützeln zu füttern man muss nicht
in jede kamera ein sprechen die vorher
aufgestellt wird hören wir einfach auch
damit
[Applaus]
sie hätten
das schaffen wir nur mit einigkeit
einigkeit und geschlossenheit
nur wenn wir inneren zusammenhalt leben
mit einer offenen und kultivierte ich
betone kultivierten diskussions und
debattenkultur wird uns nach außen die
einheit gelingen nur so und ich kann nur
eins ins gedächtnis rufen nichts hasst
der wähler mehr als eine partei die mit
sich beschäftigt ist das muss abgestellt
werden
und das alles schaffen wir nur mit
geduld
fähigkeit disziplin und einen langen
atem
nicht jeder nackenschlag ist ein
knockout
dann heißt es die deckung nach oben zu
nehmen sich berappeln und dann umso
stärker zurückzukehren
und das schaffen wir nur mit einer
führung die sich einig ist eine
mannschaft die eingespielt ist die es
schafft die basis und den wähler ernst
und mitzunehmen und für diesen kurs
liebe freunde stehe ich und für diesen
kurs bitte ich um euer vertrauen ich
bedanke mich
[Applaus]
viel applaus für die amtierende zweite
bundessprecherin alles weiter wie sich
mit dieser rede bei den delegierten für
eine zweite amtszeit auf den zweiten
sprecher kosten
lang gewirkt
sie haben auch jetzt hier die
möglichkeit der kandidatin bis zu drei
fragen zu stellen wenn sie eine frage
anmelden möchten bitte hier vorne die
karte einwerfen ist noch irgendjemand
unterwegs dann bitte bemerkbar machen ja
wohl vorne gesehen
12 unterwegs
muss mich korrigieren natürlich ist sie
noch nicht amtierende bundessprecherin
sondern sie ist amtierende
fraktionsvorsitzende
so noch irgendjemanden auf anfrage
anmelden möchte kann ich nicht sehen
dann darf ich bitten mir die
hunde hier zu bringen sie klingt wohl
gefühlt und wir losen dann jetzt die
drei fragesteller aus die erste frage
kommt von eugen feser die
zweite von frank lied zurück
und die dritte frage kann stellen
markus connell frohnmeyer
so zuerst herzi leser
am blauen saal mikrofon für jetzt zu 30
sekunden
ja mein name in theresa vom kreisverband
ulm frau bereit wir haben sie ja schon
in baden württemberg sind jetzt zwei
zweieinhalb jahren als vorsitzende sie
haben diesen landesverband
total an die wand gefahren in baden
württemberg sieht absolut katastrophal
aus welche garantien geben sie uns dass
das gleiche nicht die nächsten zwei
jahre im bundesvorstand passiert
vielen dank zur antwort bis zu einem
mittel verwenden
lieber eugen wir waren irgendwann mal
beim duo weil wir uns schon jahrelang
kennen ich kenne dich und wenn dein
kreisverband den landesvorstand nicht
über die gebühr hinaus beschäftigen
würde war du ihn nicht führen kannst
hätte man noch ressourcen für was
anderes
[Applaus]
die nächste frage kommt von frank
die wahrheit sagen von frank wieczorek
blauen saal mikrofon ebenfalls
bitteschön für bis zu 30 sekunden
die wir alle wissen wie widersprüche in
unserem land die spitzen sich in einem
enormen tempo zu und meine frage ist
also wie sehen sie die chancen dass wir
vielleicht doch irgendwo in deutschland
ein konservatives lager bilden können
und die afg in regierungsverantwortung
kommen
vielen dank vielen dank für die frage
ich glaube dass wir zuallererst in den
ostdeutschen bundesländern in die
regierungsverantwortung kommen werden
das halte ich im übrigen auch für
unausweichlich
[Applaus]
sie haben jetzt auch völlig richtig
gesagt die zustände in diesem land
werden sich mit zu einer rasanten
geschwindigkeit zuspitzen da wird man
gar nicht mehr hinterherkommen die krise
und die teuerung die inflation die
enteignung der sparer
das alles kommt ihr auf die menschen zu
und ich bin fest davon überzeugt
dass in naher zukunft der wähler dann
doch einmal die richtigen konsequenzen
zieht und diese parteien die dafür
verantwortlich sind abstraft und dafür
die afg stärker macht bin fest davon
überzeugt dass wir davon profitieren
werden denn so geht es nicht weiter die
anderen parteien machen nicht politik
für die menschen in diesem land das ist
die afg das sind wir
[Applaus]
vielen dank und die dritte und letzte
frage kommt von markus frohnmeyer im
roten saal mikrofon für bis zu 30
sekunden
ließ eine schwierige frage höchste
inflation strompreise explodieren alles
läuft in deutschland schlecht aber die
grünen und andere parteien lägen noch
immer zu was hat das mit wohlfühlen zu
tun jeder weiß ja die berbalk ist ein
bisschen dumm aber man fühlt sich quasi
mit den grünen wohl was können wir das
afg besser machen
wir als afd müssen endlich wieder lernen
klare kante zu zeigen wir müssen als
oppositionspartei wahrgenommen werden
und dazu reicht kein kuschelkurs das ist
absolut abzulehnen und was die cdu mit
den grünen macht ist ein absolut
unwürdiges beispiel
unwürdiges beispiel wie man ein land ein
industrieland wie deutschland so
gnadenlos gegen die wand fahren kann
dieses industrieland wird ja gerade
abgewickelt und ich bin fest davon
überzeugt dass die arbeitnehmer heute
und die arbeitslosen morgen genau wissen
wem sie das zu verdanken haben das ist
völlig unseriöse politik die in
deutschland gemacht wie das muss man mal
ganz klar sagen
vielen dank das waren drei fragen drei
antworten damit ist die kandidatin mit
dank entlassen und als nächste celtic
länger zur vorstellung doktor
nikolausfest den ich dann auf die bühne
bitte
ja ein ex journalist und seit 2009 10
mitglied des europäischen parlamentes
er ist seit
2016 afd mitglied
[Musik]
guten tag herr doktor fest auch an sie
zuerst die drei pflicht fragen wir
stehen unvereinbarkeiten nach § 19
unserer bundessatzung
enthielte ein aktuelles polizeiliches
führungszeugnis eintragungen nein und in
welchen politischen parteien waren sie
vor der ard in keiner dann haben sie
jetzt bis zu acht minuten zeit für ihre
vorstellungen bitteschön vielen dank
liebe freunde auch liebe vorteil
mitglieder an den monitoren wir alle
sind uns glaube ich einig programmatisch
sind wir exzellent aufgestellt vor dem
euro und einer weichwährung haben wir
immer gewarnt jetzt ist die inflation da
und zwar krachend wir haben immer davor
gewarnt dass der ausstieg aus atom gas
und kohle zur gleichen zeit die
energiesicherheit von deutschland massiv
gefährden würde jetzt ist die energie
krise da wir haben immer gesagt dass die
bundeswehr massiv unterfinanziert sei
nun sehen dass sogar die grünen ein die
sozialisten und die beiden merkel
parteien die dies wesentlich zu
verantworten haben und auch und auch in
der kurve krise haben wir einen
exzellenten kurs gesteuert erst als wir
nicht wussten wie gefährlich corona
wirklich ist haben wir sofort gesagt
grenzen dicht machen erst mal gucken was
kommt da dann als klar war dass vor
allem die älteren
bevölkerungsgruppen gefährdet sind haben
wir gesagt schutz von variablen gruppen
aber ansonsten kein lockdown auch dies
war exzellent es war goldrichtig und
programmatisch haben wir keine fehler
gemacht aber und das ist sie müssen
nicht klatschen denn jetzt kommt das
große aber aber dennoch werden wir nicht
gehört wir werden nicht zur kenntnis
genommen woran liegt das
wer sich vor der buchung wahl mal
den pott an tat in die sozialen medien
zu schauen der wusste warum eine kabale
auf und das niveau putin ist hingegen
transatlantik übel landen gegen
neu-trainer zelt pinkler gegen
jogginghose ein dauerndes gehacke und
gehetze und wenn ich sage vor den wochen
der rufe oder in den wochen vor der wahl
da muss ich leider sagen das stimmt
nicht ganz eigentlich herrscht dieser
zustand immer tag für tag woche für
woche monat für monat jahr für jahr
liebe freunde wir geben jedes jahr viel
geld für parteitage aus bundesparteitage
landesparteitage und dann wählen wir in
einem buchstäblich erschöpfenden
verfahren die person die wir für
geeignet halten diese partei
voranzubringen und in die zukunft zu
führen und damit auch deutschland zu
helfen aber schon am nächsten tag am
nächsten tag der gleiche dauerbeschuss
das gleiche kesseltreiben nun gegen die
gerade erst gewählten warum warum tun
wir uns eigentlich diese ganzen
landesparteitage an wenn für
offensichtlich einen teil der mitglieder
schon von vornherein feststeht ja was
für leute hier gewählt wurden alle durch
alle unfähig alle machtgeil alle korrupt
und das ist das wichtigste glaubt
eigentlich irgendjemand hier in diesem
raum damit der hände hoch dass uns das
eine einzige stimme bringt das der
wähler eine so innerlich zerrissene
partei wählt glaubt dass hier wirklich
irgendjemand ich muss sagen ich glaube
ist leider nicht und wenn wir uns auf
die mitglieder und vor allem auch die
auch die wähler entwicklung wenn wir die
anschauen dann muss man sagen
auch viele wenden sich ab viele sind
frustriert viele sind entmutigt
gerade freunde gerade in den zeiten von
krieg gerade in den zeiten einer die
wirtschaftlich immer schwieriger werden
gerade in den zeiten von inflation
ist harmonie gefragt und die müssen wir
auch leben auch im eigenen interesse die
leute wählen uns nicht wenn wir uns so
präsentieren wie wir gerade sind
harmonie ist elementar wichtig gerade
auch für uns wie kommen wir da hin wie
schaffen wir mehr harmonie wir müssen
endlich lernen wieder vernünftig zu
schreiben nicht alles ist eine frage von
paradies oder hölle von sieg oder
niederlage ich gebe ihnen beispiele die
angst vor krone zu sich an korrelation
zu infizieren und sich impfen zu lassen
und sich daher impfen zu lassen ja sie
ist berechtigt man kann sich impfen
lassen ja ok man kann auch sozial
patriotisch denken aber man kann auch
der auffassung seien dass mehr
eigenverantwortung besser ist und man
kann gegen waffenlieferungen an die
ukraine sein auch wenn ich das
persönlich für nicht richtig konsistent
halte solange wir dem hauptfinanzier des
terrorismus saudi arabien weiterhin
schwere waffen liefern aber ja ich gebe
es zu es kann sein dass
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine das
kriegsrisiko erhöhen aber man kann
genauso auf der anderen seite sagen dass
apps mend möglicherweise putin dazu
bringen wird den krieg noch auszuweiten
keiner hat eine kleine hat eine
kristallkugel und keiner kann es wissen
und jetzt die große frage an euch alle
warum verlegen wir uns dann öffentlich
über eine solche frage in den sozialen
medien
ich verstehe es nicht
[Applaus]
unsere schreibkultur ist freundlich
gesagt stark verbesserungsfähig
genau das will ich erreichen und dafür
will ich im buch beispiele setzen außer
außerhalb haben wir genug gegner im
inneren müssen wir sie nicht mehr suchen
eben sagte ellis walde er wesentlich zu
dieser geschlossenheit gehört auch dass
man nicht in jede kamera ein quatsch das
stimmt ja und ich möchte daran erinnern
dass wir hier offensichtlich ein
umdenken haben denn wir wissen alle als
es vor einigen also vor zwei jahren
ungefähr eine entscheidung im
bundesvorstand gab haben leider einige
mitglieder in jede kamera quatsch und
die mehrheitsentscheidung des vorstands
massiv kritisiert auch das hat zur
zerrissenheit der partei
beigetragen aber es ist gut wenn jetzt
fehler eingesehen werden daran können
wir arbeiten
liebe freunde im berliner
landesvorstand habe ich gezeigt wie man
harmonie
herbeiführt ich kalt da unter meinen
kollegen als der sanfte diktator die
liberale diktator und das heißt bei
allen meinungen sehr liberal und sehr
sanft der lange debatten aber wenn es
dazu kam oder wenn es um geschlossenheit
und disziplin und vor allem um
mindeststandards der diskussionskultur
ging war ich sehr sehr bestimmt das war
sehr erfolgreich wir haben es sogar
geschafft den andauernden streit aus der
fraktion im abgeordnetenhaus aus der aus
dem landesvorstand rauszuhalten und dann
muss man auch sagen hatte ich noch zwei
sachen eingeführt nämlich einmal es gab
bei mir keine enthaltung enthaltung gab
es nur wenn man selbst oder unheilbare
familienmitglieder betroffen waren sonst
grundsätzlich nicht vorstellen sind dazu
da zu entscheiden nicht sich zu
enthalten und zweitens
und zweitens gab es galt bei mir die
stimmt die stimmt verhinderung ob wegen
zusammenbrechen der telefonleitung wegen
abwesenheit oder welcher gründen auch
immer geld bei mir als klares nein mit
korrekturmöglichkeit das führte zu einer
hohen disziplin und auch zur
geschlossenheit liebe freunde vorstände
sind gewählt um zu entscheiden sind
nicht gewählt um sich zu enthalten oder
sich wegzuducken führung heißt klarheit
heißt entscheidung und ich will ganz
klar sagen führung heißt nicht 35
entscheiden so 33 entscheiden so sechs
entscheiden oben sechs entscheiden unten
das ist nicht führung das ist chaos wer
soll uns für sowas wählen liebe freunde
ich
kann wie ich kann für uns und ich will
auch führen dafür brauche ich ihre
stimme für eine bessere streitkultur für
einen gelassen den umgang mit
unterschiedlichen positionen festival
ein altes darum höhere wertschätzung der
kollegen für mehr geschlossenheit und
disziplin für ein zusammenführen der
partei für eine harmonie und vor allem
für deutschland für unser heimatort über
die zeit
[Applaus]
meine und herren sie haben jetzt die
möglichkeit noch fragen anzumelden sind
noch fragesteller potenzielle unterwegs
einmal irgendwie erkenntlich zeigen
kann ich nicht erkennen dass jemand noch
eine karte ein werfen möchte dann darf
ich schon bin dass die ohne hier nach
vorne kommt in der zwischenzeit ein
kurzer dringlicher suchaufruf der fahrer
des jetzt tatsächlich das fazit den
amtlichen kennzeichen mol en dort 24 und
silbernen vw bus steht einer feuerwehr
einfahrt und wird dort sicherlich nicht
mehr ewig lange stehen entweder fahren
sie den wagen weg oder es übernimmt ein
dritter
und wir laufen jetzt die drei
fragesteller aus die erste frage kommt
von markus frohnmeyer die
zweite frage
von jonas dünzl
und die dritte frage von marius kühne
frohnmeyer
wahrscheinlich
im roten saal mikrofon für bis zu 30
sekunden britischer
kollege sie hatten einen verstorbenen
leider zitat dreckschwein genannt und
ich will fragen ob das das neue
bürgerlich in der afg werden soll sowas
finde ich nicht gut weil wir wissen wie
die altparteien auch uns bezeichnen und
mit uns umgehen und das darf kein stil
in unserer partei werden
so antwort für bis zu einer minute ja
vielen dank da haben sie recht ich habe
mich auch dafür sofort entschuldigt das
war ein interner chat und es war eine
reaktion auf die pressemitteilung die
nicht abgestimmte pressemitteilung eines
bundes sprechers dessen name schon
vergessen hatte ich hatte einen ordner
mit
15 oder 20 briefen mit julie ob seiner
versammlungsleitung
die war so skandalös dass sogar andere
gruppierungen also ep und so die es
nicht so gut fanden und tatsächlich als
ich dann noch die sehr lobende
pressemitteilung da sind mir da leider
die zügel durchgegangen aber ich habe
mich sofort öffentlich entschuldigt und
selbst im gespräch mit der jetzigen
präsidentin auch die sagte na ja wir
haben alle schon intern und privat über
den politischen gegner ausdrücke benutzt
die vielleicht nicht komme vor sind also
insofern es wäre auch von ihr vermessen
zu sagen dass sie da eine reine weste
hat insofern verfehlen haben sie auch
auf alle sanktionen
dank die nächste frage kommt von jonas
dünzl für bis zu 30 sekunden ebenfalls
am roten saal mikrofon
er fest ich möchte gar nicht auf ihre
unsäglichen äußerungen eingehen oder auf
ihre abstimmung zur waffenlieferung in
die ukraine was der parteilinie
widersprach ich möchte auf die frage
eingehen alice weil hat uns jetzt im
wahlkampf in zwickau unterstützt werden
eine grandiose veranstaltung mit über
200.000 teilnehmern wie selbst die
presse geschrieben hat glauben sie
ernsthaft oder hatten sie schon mal
annähernd große veranstaltungen
organisiert wo auch danach so viele
leute zu bekommen zu den fotos gemacht
haben wo sie zwei stunden danach noch
mit den bürgern gesprochen haben dass es
mich eine bürgernahe volks politiker
hatten sie das schon mal ein anfang
der dienstherr dünnste ich muss sie
korrigieren sie müssten mal gelegentlich
das partei oder die parteibeschlüsse
auch lesen es gibt in der in dem
beschluss der partei kein wort zu
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine das ist
in der bundestags im beschluss der
bundestagsfraktion so aber wenn sie hier
die partei zitieren dann liegen sie
falsch nein ich hatte noch nie so eine
veranstaltung aber ich war bisher auch
noch nicht bundesvorstand ich bin sicher
sie werden mich tatkräftig unterstützen
wenn ich dann im bundesvorstand mit
vielen dank
und die dritte frage kommt von marius
kühne am blauen saal mikrofon für bis zu
30 sekunden bitteschön schönen guten tag
herr fest marius kühne mein name und
zwar meine frage nachdem es jetzt mit
dem afd bashing fertig sind würde ich
sie gerne fragen nachdem sie auf drei
fragen ja an dem bundesparteitag in die
runde gestellt haben warum sie diese
wenn sie da oben stehen nicht sind nicht
selber beantworten das wäre doch ihre
aufgabe als bundessprecher lösungen
dafür zu haben statt dass wir in die
runde zu stellt vielleicht möchten sie
da noch mal drauf antworten
fest
entschuldigen sie was meinen sie ihnen
jetzt mit den drei fragen was
sie die fragezeit das herren war
abgelaufen die frage können wir
interpretieren wie die mögliche tut mir
leid unklare frage sie müssen schon
konkret sagen hätten von konrad konkret
sagen müssen was sie eigentlich meinen
so ist ein bisschen schwer zu antworten
gut
vielen dank das war dann die antwort des
kandidaten dann sind sie mit dank
ebenfalls entlassen und ich darf schon
ankündige werden zwei minuten in einen
wahlgang antreten werden als alle rein
kommen die an diesem wahlgang teilnehmen
möchten ja soweit also die fragen die an
die kandidaten gestellt werden konnten
kritische fragen teilweise auch fragen
die sozusagen nur stichwort gebend sind
das alles per los und per zufall
ausgelost durch einen kleinen eimer in
dem die fragen eingestellt wurden und
dann wurden die fragesteller zugelost
und ausgewählt sie haben es ja gesehen
herr flath griff in den eimer so wie
jeden samstag die losfee früher vor
etlichen jahrzehnten die zahlen im lotto
gezogen hat so hat er auch dieses mal
diese frage stelle mit hilfe der
delegierten und der mitgliedskarte
gezogen und jetzt geht es darum wer
zweiter bundessprecher wird alice weidl
amtierende fraktionsvorsitzende
der
kfd im bundestag
nikolausfest mitglied des europäischen
parlamentes seit 2009 10
beide stellen sich zur wahl zum zweiten
bundessprecher gleich werden die türen
geschlossen das wird der flug dann
sozusagen auch ankündigen dass es jetzt
losgeht mit der wahl und dann wird auch
hier elektronisch abgestimmt und man
kann verdeckt die stimme abgeben indem
man seine stimmgerät einfach nur den
bewerber wählt oder eine enthaltung auch
dieses ist bei dieser wahl
logischerweise möglich 20 sekunden zeit
gerne nach draußen auch immer weiter
geben
nehmen sie ebenso wird ihre plätze
wieder ein
haben die meisten ja schon getan
und dann können die türen langsam aber
sicher geschlossen werden zwei minuten
sind um ich bitte um mitteilung wenn die
tür geschlossen ist es gibt probleme mit
stimm geräten dann bitte direkt einmal
vorne so der technik gehen damit
wobei ich nicht weiß wie sie das jetzt
erkennen wollen was tut sich ja der akku
nicht wir haben dann auch eine
akkreditierung zahl und zwar um 12 uhr
21 sind 500 und
stimmberechtigte versammlungsteilnehmer
akkreditiert ist die tür geschlossen
ist geschlossen dann haben sie jetzt für
den zweit zu wählenden bundessprecher
die bundessprecher sind natürlich
gleichberechtigt
die folgenden wahlmöglichkeiten mit der
einst können sie votieren für doktor
alice weidl mit der nummer zwei können
sie votieren für doktor nikolausfest mit
der drei können sie gegen beide
kandidaten stimmen und mit der 4 können
sie sich der stimme enthalten für diese
abstimmung
warte ich einmal kurz gibt's hier noch
technische probleme oder hat sich dass
es geklärt
april oft wird ja ist eröffnet für eine
minute bitteschön
jetzt haben die delegierten wie beim
ersten mal bei der wahl des ersten
bundes sprechers die zeit von einer
minute in der sie ihre elektronische
stimmabgabe tätigen können
in derzeit laufen gespräche die
kandidaten sind natürlich bei einer
aufgeregt sollte es dazu kommen dass
alice weidl auch hier zur
bundessprecherin gewählt wird dann wären
beide kandidaten die bereits amtierende
fraktionsvorsitzende sind im deutschen
bundestag auch gleichzeitig
bundessprecher das heißt beide würden
jeweils beide ämter im bundestag als
chef und in der partei übernehmen
und jetzt sehen wir gleich das ergebnis
viele kameras versammeln sich um
67,2 neun prozent zinsen bild für alles
bei
20,75 prozent für nikolausfest
hinein zu beiden gesagt haben enthaltung
waren 311 stimmen und mit nein votiert
64 3 enthaltungen ich stelle fest dass
doktor alle zweifel die notwendige
einfache mehrheit erreicht ist und
erreicht hat und damit zur
bundessprecherin der afg gewählt ist
vorbei nehmen sie die wahl an
herzlichen glückwunsch
ja damit ist das neue duo die beiden
bundessprecher so die
ersten fertig dh sie sind gewählt alice
weil und tino keller die beiden die wie
gesagt auch in berlin im bundestag
auch die zügel in der hand haben haben
jetzt auch hier die zügel in der hand
und damit kommen wir dann direkt denke
ich mal weiter zu den wahlen interessant
ist ja dass vor beginn des parteitages
kinogruppe mit einem team zukunft
angetreten ist in denen er auch
bereits namen genannt hat die er gerne
dabei haben möchte in seinem neuen
bundesvorstand beziehungsweise mit denen
er sich eine zusammenarbeit vorstellen
kann dazu gehören einige mitglieder des
deutschen bundestages
eine kandidatin auf seinem team zukunft
ist damit schon gewählt nämlich alles
weil die er gerne in seinem team zukunft
gehabt hätte er wird für jedes der
mitglieder die er
favorisiert in einer einzel war auch die
kandidaten vorstellen
wollen und müssen denn wir hatten vorhin
ja mitgekriegt dass diese wahlen der
nächsten
bundesvorstandsmitglieder jeweils
einzeln gewählt werden müssen das heißt
also jeder der nächsten
kandidaten wird einzeln gewählt also es
gibt jetzt noch die nächsten wahlen der
drei stellvertreter dann ist im grunde
genommen der engere vorstand gewählt mit
fünf personen danach erfolgen die wahlen
für den bundesschatzmeister für die
beisitzer und bei allem dürfen wir den
ehrenvorsitzenden alexander gauland
natürlich nicht vergessen all diese
wahlen finden im einzel wahlverfahren
statt die bewerbungsreden
werden jetzt gekürzt das heißt die
nächsten kandidaten für die wahlen der
drei stellvertreter die sind nur vier
minuten lang die frage
wird auch wieder gestellt ist werden
drei fragen gestellt 30 sekunden auch
das bleibt gleich und
dann wird nach einer kurzen pause es mit
sicherlich war mit sicherheit
weitergehen mit der wahl der nächsten
drei stellvertreter und dabei wird denn
sein ob die kandidatenliste aus dem team
zukunft von timo grub aller sich
ebenfalls durchsetzt oder ob es zu
gegenkandidaten kommen wird interessant
wird auch sein ob beatrix von storch
noch mal antritt der auf ihre berliner
delegiertenstimmen verzichten muss
weil der berliner landesverband ja wie
gesagt nicht mit abstimmen darf das hat
der bundesvorstand in einer sitzung kurz
vor beginn des parteitages entschieden
nachdem beide schiedsgerichte landes und
bundes schiedsgericht bereits wegen
irritationen bei der liste der vergabe
für die delegierten dieses parteitages
ein
formalen fehler gemacht haben so hatte
es das landes und auch das
bundesschiedsgericht entschieden und der
bundesvorstand entschied dann dass diese
delegierten nicht dabei sein dürfen die
fehlen natürlich wenn es zu einer
kandidatin beatrix von storch für das
amt des bundesvorstandes kommen sollte
so wir sehen hier die bilder der
frischgebackenen bundessprecherin der
zweiten bundesweiten alice weil die
natürlich jetzt
von kameras umringt ist nach ihrer wahl
und sich mit sicherheit jetzt in die
arbeit mit ihrem bundessprecher tino
keller stürzen wird das neue duo ist
gewählt und es folgen jetzt gleich die
kandidaten für die wahl der drei
stellvertreter und herren minuten fahren
wir fort bitte also schon mal langsam
wieder in richtung ihrer plätze gegeben
und auch die pressevertreter wieder
vorsichtig in richtung des pressebereich
in zwei minuten fahren wir fort
wenn ich jetzt auf meine uhr schauer
dann haben wir jetzt mittag das heißt
wir haben ungefähr zweieinhalb stunden
verfolgen können wie die ersten beiden
sprecher posten besetzt wurden es werden
jetzt noch wenn ich richtig zähle wenn
der 14-köpfige bundesvorstand genauso
sich zusammensetzt dann müssen ja jetzt
noch zwölf personen gewählt werden
jeweils in einzelwahl ich denke mal das
wird sich mit sicherheit bis in den
heutigen abend reinziehen vielleicht bis
in den nachmittag in den späten denn es
ist ja immer so dass diese vorstellung
der kandidaten und sie sehen jetzt die
unterbrechungen logischerweise zeit
kosten und nach den wahlen werden dann
die beiden neuen bundessprecher ihre
reden halten und dann wird es in einem
ersten
teil zu diversen anderen themen kommen
ich hatte vorhin bereits erwähnt dass
die partei sich danach entscheiden wird
ob sie einen mitglieder parteitag beim
nächsten parteitag machen wird das heißt
jedes mitglied das media fd ist kann
diesen parteitag besuchen das bedeutet
beim letzten mitglieder parteitag 2016
in stuttgart waren es über 1200
mitglieder die da waren
ob das der parteitag so quer schreiben
wird bleibt abzuwarten es liegen mehrere
anträge für diese änderung für den
nächsten
aber es soll werden wir sehen wann ist
zu diesem programmpunkt auf der
tagesordnung kommt
die
sicherlich interessierte
traube um frau weiter bitten sich dort
langsam mal aufzulösen wir würden hier
gerne weiter arbeiten und das
funktioniert so nicht
frau weiterläuft hatte heute auch nicht
weg die können sie doch den ganzen tag
lang interview
alle andere bitte mal die plätze wieder
einnehmen wir würden gerne fortfahren
wir haben noch ein bisschen programm vor
uns
so im weiteren verlauf des parteitages
wird es auch dann zu politischen themen
kommen ob die heute noch abgehandelt
werden oder nicht das wahre ich jetzt
nicht so
vorauszusehen dass bleibt noch
abzuwarten auf der tagesordnung könnte
es noch funktionieren es kann aber auch
sein dass die partei diese debatten auf
den morgigen tag schiebt wir werden
sehen was
die zeit jetzt noch bringt für eine
erste analyse das neue duo ist da steht
uns jetzt alexander keller mit experten
zur verfügung
ja und das sind experten die wir gestern
auch schon hatten jetzt könnte das sehr
viel handfester sprechen mit ann kathrin
müller vom spiegel und alexander kissler
von der neunziger zeitpunkt ja wir haben
jetzt zwei
neue bundessprecherin bundessprecherin
einen bundessprecher das alles andere
als eine überraschung darüber haben wir
gestern schon spekuliert und das ist
sicherlich auch keine große spekulation
gewesen was zeigen denn diese beiden
wahlgänge jetzt wieder stehen zukunft
weitergeht
tatsächlich dass die entwicklung die wir
schon hatten sich fortsetzt offenbar
hoffentlich laut fdp politikern mit mehr
einigkeit also damit sind sie angetreten
dass sie weniger streiten wollen und
tatsächlich haben wir jetzt zwei
parteichefs die sich sehr gut verstehen
auch inhaltlich die sich glaube ich
nicht streiten werden wie ein propeller
und seinen leuten das getan haben
sondern die eben wenn sie streitigkeiten
haben dass hinter den kulissen ausmachen
zumindest war es bislang so und die die
partei weiter da hin schieben werden wo
sie eigentlich ja schon steht
das sind zu den gegenkandidaten zu sagen
hat man ist vor allem bei dem
gegenkandidaten von alles weitere
michael klauß fest der kandidatin ja
davon wahrscheinlich schon vorher
besprochen worden ist wirklich zu leicht
gemacht erst mal durch ein ganz
schwaches ergebnis für festen ich glaube
20,45 prozent also man hat er gedacht
dass kleine wächter schwächer
abschneidet weil
fest eigentlich intellektuell und
rhetorisch besser aufgestellt ist klein
fischer hat eine sehr starke rhetorisch
geschickte rede gehalten völlig frei
gehalten das ist mehr als ein
achtungserfolg
europa bleibe zwar noch ein paar prozent
paar stellen hinter dem komma hinter
seinen ergebnis von 20 19 also ich denke
mit kleinwächter wird zu rechnen sein er
hat wirklich aus seiner schlechten
ausgangsposition durch die späte
bekanntgabe sondern kampagne aus seiner
sicht das meiste herausgeholt man wird
es sehen wenn auch in den vorstand kommt
können bis zu 14 köpfe sein und ich kann
mir einfach nicht vorstellen dass es
hier komplett das tableau von coop aller
durchgewunken wird einige haben glaube
ich auch mit dem messer in der tasche
gewählt und man hat ja gemerkt wenn
immer darauf angesprochen wurde ist was
seine eigene schuld ist immer sofort
reflexartig habe keine schuld anderen
sind schuld also verantwortung scheu und
flucht aus der verantwortung das ging
heute nochmal gut aber ein aufbruch
steht anders aus wenn jetzt die wahl
deshalb der restlichen
bundesvorstandsmitglieder kommt wird man
da sehr darauf achten dass es in zukunft
weniger ärger im bundesvorstand geben
wird wird das aber gleichzeitig auch
bedeuten dass er in zukunft
stromlinienförmiger ist also das ist
sehr große versuch hier heute oder in
diesem wochenende dass sie eben diese
einigkeit herstellen wollen weil sie
eben selber sagen die schlechten
ergebnisse liegt nur daran wir sehen
keine probleme bei ihren inhalten sie
sehen keine probleme damit dass sie
immer die dagegen partei sind sondern
sie sagen das liegt nur daran dass uns
gestritten haben wenn wir das aufhören
dann wird es auch besser für uns laufen
weil die kriegen seien ja da aus denen
von denen sie profitieren könnten und
jetzt ist die frage ob ihnen das gelingt
das kommt dann eben dass ich auch drauf
an wer noch so in den bundesvorstand
gewählt wird aber dass die zwei an der
spitze sind und das geschafft haben dass
zumindest ein signal dass der parteitag
das ähnlich sieht wie die die das in
ihren reden gesagt
es ist ja auch die frage was wird
programmatisch auf den tisch gelegt wir
haben heute noch drei sehr wichtige oder
morgen drei sehr wichtige entscheidungen
die programmatische pflöcke einschlagen
könnten eu also nach wir noch einmal so
gefordert werden abschaffung der eu der
ukraine überhaupt keine waffen schatten
schaffen also gewissermaßen ein antrag
der beleg ist eigentlich wieder mal für
die hufeisen theorie ganz rechts und
ganz links radikal pazifismus relativ
naiv art würde ich sagen und dann
drittens natürlich gibt es diese
programmstruktur kommission noch
wichtiger wird herr rücke der sich dafür
warmluft an deren spitze gesetzt also
wenn wir diese drei entscheidungen haben
dann können wir wirklich eine präzise
aussage machen was ich nun am kurs
ändern wird momentan ist es nur ich muss
wiederholen ein mutloses weiter so er
hat sich die afg von ihren grundsätzen
verabschiedet heute jetzt sind die
beiden wichtigsten ämter in ein und
denselben vier händen als zweiter und
tino keller ja wohl an der spitze der
bundestagsfraktion als auch der partei
ja na gut er wurde immer wieder darauf
angesprochen ob alle auch von uns
journalisten sagte er schaut mal bei der
cdu läuft es doch eigentlich auch da hat
man das auch zusammen im parteivorsitz
und fraktionsvorsitz mit herrn merz hat
die das haben läuft nach vorne herr
hüppe hat auch gesagt wir sind noch
seien noch nicht reif klammer auf ich
bin noch nicht gut genug klammer zu
vielleicht in zwei jahren könnte er mich
rufen da mag es vielleicht klammer zu
man hat sich zumindest davon
verabschiedet dass man jenseits der
popularität stärker noch auf kompetenz
und professionalität sitzt man sagt die
beiden machen die verstehen sich
irgendwie lasst sie beide also beide
pferde satteln das ist ein gewisses
risiko weil natürlich intern der produkt
die kritik geratene fraktionsführung von
frau von fern hoppala und frau weiter
sehr sehr hoch ist also das können sich
auch auf schaukeln zu einem doppelten
kritikpunkte eine kurze letzte antwort
bitte herr müller die die tatsache dass
jetzt alles wie und tino copala hier in
der spitze sind was bedeutet das
eigentlich für die zukunft der partei
ist also übergangs vorsitzende
sivas übergangsvorsitzender also
tatsächlich hat man das gefühl dass
dieser parteitag und diese partei sich
darauf vorbereitet dass irgendwann
werden wir können an die macht gelangen
will und das werden wir glaube ich im
laufe des tages noch sehen wenn es um
diese struktur kommission geht die durch
bekommt und die dann auch leitet dann
ist das glaube ich der rampe für ihn gut
dass wir in den noch sehr im laufe des
tages auch mit ihnen beiden dann noch
vielen dank erstmal für dieses gespräch
und es geht zurück zu doris müller
kandidieren sie ja vielen dank alexander
keller so weit das erste fazit und die
erste analyse nach der wahl der beiden
bundessprecher es geht jetzt hier weiter
mit der vorstellung der kandidaten liste
für die wahl des ersten
stellvertretenden bundessprecher
stefan brandner war christian handl
martin renner und
haben sich zur wahl gestellt martin
renner ist ja derjenige der mit corona
nicht anwesend ist da hören wir mal wie
das verfahren jetzt hier weitergeht und
eine sekunde
stefan brandner ist einer der
wunschkandidaten von tino propeller auf
dem team zukunft wird auch dem der
flügel strömung zugeordnet ähnlich wie
heiner luhmann und
martin renner der bewegen
da niederlegt weil der wahl diese
annimmt
kandidiert damit auch und heiner lohmann
wo sind sie
ja erklärt ja dann haben wir hier vier
kandidaten da werden wir jetzt einmal
die vorstellungs reihenfolge
auslosen
vier kandidaten für die wahl des ersten
stellvertretenden
bundesvorstandes sprechers ich zähle
eins zwei drei vier männer
und eine frau
ja da wird jetzt nach geguckt wie das
mit der reihenfolge der kandidaten
bewerben nur läden ist
genau aus zuerst die gelegenheit zur
vorstellung
herr brandner danach erhält die
gelegenheit zur vorstellung
der handel
[Musik]
nicht dass der eindruck entsteht dass
könnte hier
herr renner na dann wollte ich anfang
lotto zu spielen und als viertes dann
herr lehmann
brandner hansel soll die reihenfolge
steht fest stefan brandner wird der
erste der kandidaten sein der sich in
einer vier minuten 4 minütigen rede
mit der bewerbung und das amt des ersten
stellvertretenden bundessprecher
auf die bühne stellt nachreichen möchte
ich ihnen dass der anteil der frauen in
der partei der afg ungefähr bei 17
prozent liegt
guten tag herr brannten auch an sie
zuerst die drei pflicht fragen und zwar
ob es unvereinbarkeit nach § 19 der
bundessatzung gibt nein enthielt ein
aktuelles polizeiliches führungszeugnis
eintragungen und
waren sie in welchen politischen
parteien waren sie vor der afd bei der
cdu in der csu allerdings 2010 habe ich
bereits in schlussstrich gezogen vielen
dank dann haben sie jetzt ist zu acht
minuten zeit für ihre vorstellungen
bitteschön fünf minuten weil die 8 steht
opa doch fünf wir sind dadurch
stellvertreter steht in fünf ich sehr
aufmerksam vielen dank fünf minuten zeit
für ihre vorstellungen bis zu fünf
minuten schade mir am ende dann
vielleicht selber aber sofort sagen ja
hallo riesa schon mal von vorne zu
schauen fast 600 personen hier in der
halle wie im deutschen bundestag
wertvoll ist allerdings hier ist die
stimmung freundlich viel freundlicher
und ich bin vorher kandidieren zu dürfen
und hoffen dass sich unsere partei auch
dann in den nächsten jahren ein bisschen
nach vorne bringen kann halo riesa
herzlichen glückwunsch dies sei dennoch
herzlichen glückwunsch an alle zweifel
ich kam gerade durch den pulk nicht
durch auch da denkt man habt ihr schon
zweimal jetzt eine gute wahl getroffen
ich hoffe das wird jetzt im dritten bei
dem dritten person ist zur wahl steht
nicht an dass liebe freunde wir machen
der vorstellungsrede die persönlichen
daten sind seit
einiger zeit unverändert das lebensalter
hat sich geändert inzwischen 56 jahre
alt manche sagt ich sehe wesentlich
jünger aus das kann ich jetzt schlecht
beurteilen aber ich fühle mich natürlich
wesentlich jünger ansonsten bin ich
immer noch verheiratet habe immer noch
kinder und bin immer noch männlich also
da hat sich nichts getan seit der
letzten vorstellungsrede in braunschweig
geboren
in herten in westfalen das war mal
jemals eine große bergbaustadt die
europäische in europa die größte
bergbaustadt inzwischen ist da alles
platt gemacht worden dass ich kenne
nicht mit strukturwandel aus hat eine
lehre gemacht in castrop rauxel war im
bergbau zulieferbetrieb mit 2009 gibt es
inzwischen auch nicht mehr bin dann auf
dem wunderschönen in herten und
castrop-rauxel nach bayern habe in
regensburg studiert und in memmingen und
münchen mein referendariat gemacht und
bin seit 2 seit 1996 in gera in
ostthüringen und gera ist ein guter
aufhänger liebe freunde es ist nicht
alles schlecht in der afg dieser
verstehe ich die personen nicht die sich
hier ans rednerpult stellen und unsere
partei schlecht reden wir brauchen die
afd wir brauchen eine starke und das
funktioniert auch natürlich überall
anders in gera sind wir mit abstand die
stärkste fraktion wir sind im stadtrat
von gera doppelt so stark wie die cdu
wissen die stadtrats von den vier mal so
stark wie die spd und die stadt vom
gegner gibt so gut wie keine grünen also
ist funktioniert es funktioniert
das hängt natürlich auch von den
rahmenbedingungen ab das hängt von den
rahmenbedingungen ab aber es geht und
das ist mein anspruch an den neuen
bundesvorstand lasst alle nach ihrer
fasson glücklich werden die leute vor
ort die wissen wie gehandelt werden muss
die kreisverbände müssen gestärkt werden
und die landesverbände der nächsten
bundesvorstand finger weg von partei
ordnungsmaßnahmen die an den haaren
herbeigezogen sind natürlich müssen
partei
ordnungsmaßnahmen seien aber nur dann
wenn sie erforderlich sind und nicht um
kurzfristig persönliche erfolge zu
erzielen lasst den kreisverbänden lasst
den landesverbänden ihre freiheit die
wissen vor ort am besten wie es geht und
wir haben auch nicht alle wahlen
verloren
seiten angefangen hat durchzudrehen
anfang 20 20 denn das war der punkt an
dem es bergab gegen nicht der punkt als
hätte ich nur kuba oder in den
bundesvorstand kam es war 2020 die
unsägliche spaltung debatte kalkar
ausschlussverfahren unnötige art und
weise debatten über doppelt spitzen und
kandidaturen vor der bundestagswahl
unterstützung von durchgeknallten
landespolitikern in niedersachsen hier
war ein innen übrigens ganz wichtig
angefügt also immer aufs falsche pferd
gesetzt wollten immer nur bei auf dem
weg nach seinem eigenen vorteil zu
suchen das ist schiefgegangen das hat
unsere partei geschadet und das muss
aufhören in zukunft brauchen einen
homogenen bundesvorstand ein
bundesvorstand der die partei innerlich
befriedet wir brauchen keinen
bundesvorstand der heute hier beim
bundesparteitag für ruhe sorgt nein wir
brauchen im bundesvorstand der ab montag
und da ist die nächste bundesvorstands
telco wahrscheinlich der abda hin
harmonisch und geschlossen
zusammenarbeitet der innerparteilich
befriedet der die programmatik
voranbringt der kampf indien macht
inhaltlicher art der zum angriff bläst
auf die altparteien da ist der gegner
und da ist der feind da ist der feind
denn feindlich wie mit uns umgegangen
liebe freunde bestehen ich hab gesagt
ist die sich alles schlecht bestehen
eigentlich relativ deutlich im
zweistelligen bereich bei um die zehn
prozent aber wie keine andere partei
stehen wir permanent jeden tag unter
druck von innen teilweise selbst gemacht
deshalb verstehe ich überhaupt nicht wie
man sich intern sozial legen kann wir
stehen unter druck von aussen
schlapphüte die haben ja gar nicht
gewusst heute die wir verfassungsschutz
viele grüße von mir vorne ich hoffe ihr
schreibt fleißig mit die schlapphüte
werden in jedem land auf uns gehetzt wir
werden ausspioniert werden drangsaliert
schikaniert ausgegrenzt
veranstaltungen werden blockiert als wir
stehen permanent unter druck lässt das
ist umso wichtiger dass wir geschlossen
bleiben als alternative für deutschland
unsere programmatik umsetzt und zum
schluss eigentlich würde ich die rede zu
anfang mit einem großen dichter und
denker martin luther liebe freunde aus
einem verzagten arsch fährt niemals ein
freundlicher für das heißt wenn wir wenn
wir nicht begeistert sind können wir
auch nicht begeistert also lasst uns
wichtig verzagten erste sein sondern
lasst uns fröhlich gekürzt werden wenn
ihr so wollt last schritte nach vorne
gehen und für die unser alternative für
deutschland kämpfen vielen dank vielen
dank
[Applaus]
drei fall für die rede von stefan
brandner der das amt seit 2009 10 jahren
bereits innerhalb der bundespartei
frage anmelden möchte bitte jetzt
schleunigst die vorne die karte
einwerfen ist noch jemand unterwegs mit
einer karte jawohl
so weitere
tochter anna einer kommt rat noch
so und dann kommen wir zur auslosung
ist einmal mehr
die auslösung der fragen ist analog zu
der frage und verfahren sowie werden es
drei wie bei den beiden bundes sprechern
da gibt es wieder die kiste gefüllt ist
mit sicherheit mehr tragen als die 3d
zuerst
mehr fragesteller als die für drei
fragen und die franken so gebilligt
wurden
die zweite frage
kommt von michael kaufmann
und die dritte frage von doktor
maximilian krah
dann haben wir für bis zu 30 sekunden am
blauen saal mikrofon herrn nicht direkt
verbrannt
sie haben schon viel von dem genannt was
der neue bundesvorstand besser machen
kann und ich wüsste gerne was sie an
potenzial einwerfen können in den neuen
bundesvorstand und was sie vielleicht
auch besser machen wollen als in der
turbine zeit
die frage ist die frage ist sehr gut ich
bin unglaublich in braunschweig damit
angetreten zusagen der bundesvorstand
muss und politische führungsorgan werden
der bundesvorstand darf sich nicht auf
verwaltungsaufgaben bestritten der
bundesvorstand muss unsere themen nach
vorne bringen und durch geschlossenheit
sozusagen ein gutes vorbild sein für die
partei das ist leider im letzten
bundesvorstand gescheitert ich behaupte
mal das würde wahrscheinlich jeder ist
sie tun es lag nicht ausschließlich an
mir die mehrheiten di-bundesvorstand
waren wie sie waren und die mehrheiten
waren gefährlich für die partei also wir
standen tatsächlich was den
bundesvorstand angeht ich sage es mal
ganz klar vor dem abgrund und ich möchte
jetzt
keinen schritt weiter gehen denn wenn
ich vor dem abgrund steht weil ich hier
rein ich würde gerne ein paar schritte
zurückgehen und sagen wir müssen uns die
programmatik wieder auf die fahnen
schreiben norbert kleinwächter hat es
angesprochen ist ganz wichtig dass wir
medial unterwegs sind wir werden
permanent bei jeder veranstaltung
angesprochen was ist mit den radio was
ist mit afg fernsehen ist es extrem
schwierig so etwas auf die beine zu
stellen aber ich habe mir vorgenommen im
nächsten bundesvorstand werde ich das
tatsächlich nicht mit dem halben ohr
machen sondern ich hätte mich da rein
kinder versuchen viel dass irgend sowas
in der richtung auf die wege bringen auf
die gleise gestellt wird
dankeschön die zweite frage kommt von
michael kaufmann ebenfalls am blauen
saal mikrofon für bis zu 30 sekunden
bitteschön ja lieber stefan wir sind ja
einerseits fraktionskollegen aber vor
allem sind wir auch wahlkreis nach vorn
wir haben beide unsere wahlkreise direkt
gewonnen und zwar mit den besten
ergebnissen in thüringen
wir standen teilweise zeit an zeit auf
dem podium an den info-ständen meine
frage welche schlüsse ziehst du aus
diesen erfahrungen für die arbeit im
bundesvorstand lange der film zunächst
mal stapelt eher tief das beste ergebnis
der thüringer hast du geholt 29,3
prozent ich musste mich mit 29 leider
begnügen aber ich arbeite dran michael
dass sich diese schmach in meinem
lebenslauf dass ich diese schmach tilgen
kann aber ganz wichtig ganz wichtig war
natürlich und wir haben ja auch
wahlkreis grenzen übergreifend gemacht
gemeinsam wahlkampf zu führen also wir
haben nicht gesagt mal gucken wer besser
abschneidet und um sich in den
vordergrund zu spielen sondern wir am
tatsächlich auf die gleichen personen
zurückgegriffen teilweise auf die
gleichen fahrzeuge wir haben
veranstaltungen doppelt bestückt auf
beiden seiten der wahlkreis grenzen und
in die wahlkreise rein untersagt es auch
einen eine erlebnis ist eine erfahrung
die ich gerne weitergeben würde leute
arbeitet zusammen arbeitet doch nicht
gegeneinander
gegen uns arbeiten alle ich hatte vorhin
schon die schlapphüte genannt der
öffentlich rechtliche rundfunk die
medien die anti fanden und weise die
gesamte regierung angela merkel wurde
sogar dafür verurteilt das sie gegen uns
kämpfen arbeitet zusammen und dann wird
man auch erfolgreich dankeschön
und die dritte frage kommt am roten saal
mikrofon von dr maximilian krah
stefan du hast ja gesagt die einigkeit
müssen wir jetzt herstellen das schaffen
wir und jetzt mal den blick ins stück
nach vorn wir die einigkeit haben und wo
kann die afg nach deiner meinung 20.30
stehen deine vision afg 20 30 20 30
jahren wenn ich richtig rechne dann bin
ich 64
aber wir haben noch zwei jüngere
politiker nehmen wir also ich wünsche
mir dass wir bis 20.30 eine
grundgesetzänderung hinbekommen haben
die es möglich macht eine doppelspitze
im bundeskanzleramt zu implementieren
und diese doppelspitze sitzt daniel
links neben mir ich würde das ganze
gerne
ich würde das ganze gerne parlamenten
standen auch mit leighton in
regierungsverantwortung und das muss
unser ziel sein dass wir sagen 20.30
weiß jetzt nicht wenn die
bundestagswahlen davor sind da kann sich
einiges verschieben aber
regierungsbeteiligung sind unumgänglich
und alles weil hatte schon gesagt wir
wissen die unterschiedlichen ergebnisse
im osten der republik und im westen der
republik im osten der republik holen wir
die prozente im westen der republik wie
die absoluten stimmen deshalb ist beides
extrem wichtig die prozente brauchen wir
für eine starke regierungsbeteiligung
und die stimmen brauchen wir natürlich
um im bund stark zu sein deshalb kein
ost west konflikt beide gemeinsam
marschieren und auch gemeinsam handeln
und am ende gemeinsam die ernte
einfahren
das waren die drei fragen die eher
unkritisch waren
stefan partner die gelegenheit gaben
über verschiedene themen zu reden dann
sind sie mit dank entlassen und als
nächstes die gelegenheit zur vorstellung
frank-christian handeln
frank christian hansen
mitglied der afg in berlin
der
2013 schon gründungsmitglied der afd
berlin und erster schatzmeister gewesen
ist und von oktober 2013 bis 2014 war er
bundesgeschäftsführer
der ard nein der afg
der bundessatzung
enthielt ein aktuelles polizeiliches
führungszeugnis eintragungen auch nein
und in welchen politischen parteien
waren sie vor der fdp bekannt ist 95 in
der spd als man sie noch wind konnte und
dann lange nichts mehr und dann kurz bei
den freien wählern bevor gott sei dank
unsere heftige grund den worten liebe
freunde vielen dank dann haben sie jetzt
bis zu fünf minuten zeit für ihre
vorstellung findet er lieber stefan du
hast wieder eine launige rede gehalten
du bist unsere rampensau das war
wirklich wieder großartig und schön zu
hören aber
das ist hier für diesen saal das ist für
unsere blase das ist auch wichtig und
das müssen wir auch feiern aber wir
müssen uns auch ehrlich machen und da
komme ich jetzt auf deinen schlussworten
mit luther zurück ich sage hier mit
luther ich stehe hier und ich kann nicht
anders liebe freunde warum weil wir die
ergebnisse im westen ernst nehmen müssen
und wir sind knapp unterkante und wenn
wir am besten nichts reißen bringen uns
auch die fantastischen ergebnisse im
osten nichts und ich freue mich den
reader zu sein bei unseren freunden hier
in sachsen
natürlich werden bessere zeiten kommen
das ist ganz klar aber wollen wir darauf
warten dass es besser wird wollen wir
wieder auf eine möglichst neue krise
warten auch sehr viel an kapital
schlagen können um wieder besser zu
werden kann das wirklich liebe freunde
kann dass unser anspruch sein wollen wir
auf politische äußere ereignisse warten
damit sie darauf versteht ich sage nein
wir müssen selbst aus dem
vertrauensverlust beim wähler
herauskommen und den vertrauensverlust
beim wähler müssen wir ernst nehmen da
müssen wir raus und das schaffen wir
denn der wähler ist nicht alles aber der
ohne wähler ist alles nichts auch die
schönste parteiveranstaltung die wir
heute wieder auch mit einem stefan
brandner erleben durften
den wähler zu fokussieren stärker zu
fokussieren
als die eigene blase das ist die
führungsaufgabe darum geht dass die
aufgabe an der müssen wir arbeiten von
riesa aus muss heute das signal ausgehen
liebe landsleute ja wir haben verstanden
ja wir wollen verantwortung wir müssen
verantwortung übernehmen für unser
deutschland die anderen parteien
arbeiten systematisch eine alternative
zu deutschland wir sind die einzige für
unser land und wir stehen zu deutschland
zu seiner souveränität sondern
wirtschaftlichen technischen
wirtschaftlichen industriellen
wettbewerbsfähigkeit und zu seiner
verteidigungsfähigkeit es gibt millionen
wähler die genau das auch wollen und
leute die wollen uns wählen wir stehen
da uns selbst im weg machen wir ihn
freigeben das signal wir wollen
mitspielen im politischen system wir
wollen daran arbeiten wir haben
konstruktiv mitspielen denn die wähler
erwarten dass wir mitregieren wollen und
können personas gesagt alice hat gesagt
wir sagen dass alle es reicht nicht dass
sie nur da sind und warten bis es besser
wird das bessere zeiten kommen nein
diese zeiten müssen wir selber herauf
arbeiten mit unserem muss für wahrheit
mit unseren richtigen programmen haben
auch alle gesagt und mit charme liebe
freunde wir brauchen auch eine
charmeoffensive in richtung wähler
weniger verbessert hat weniger
gehässigkeit sondern positiv mit einem
lächeln ich glaube liebe freunde das
schaffen wir und wir müssen und können
zurück zu unserer begeisterungsfähigkeit
wenn wir uns
die wir brauchen um mitspielen zu können
das ist uns ans verkaufen müssen wir
schaffen und darum dass wir uns selbst
hinarbeiten und nicht warten es
irgendwas passiert bei unserer
mannschaft ist ich traue uns das zu weiß
ich ja richtig das programm und am ende
alternativlose projekt zur rettung
unseres landes gewisse partei ist mein
mantra die partei des politischen
realismus aus der mitte der gesellschaft
dafür gerne gewählt ich bin überzeugt
dass es keine bürgerliche mehrheiten die
man mir gibt gegen uns nur mit der ft
ist das möglich und dafür stehe ich und
kann will bereits im zehnten jahr
nachweisbar als dienstältester
landesvorstand von kiel bis münchen von
essen nach görlitz in dieser partei
lasst uns mit dieser wahl mit dieser war
das betreten und in die republik rufen
wir sind zurück ins feld nein nicht am
rand des spiels chef sondern auf dem
feld am anstoßpunkt liebe freunde wir
sind nicht nur gekommen um am rand zu
stehen und zu bleiben sondern um mich zu
spielen und zu gewinnen und wir wollen
nicht nur ein gutes spiel machen wir
wollen auch ein schönes spiel machen
nicht holzen
weniger tritte sondern trippeln mit der
elegant und auch mal hässliche
wie gestern mit dem sächsischen antrag
unterhalb von teese natürlich völlig
recht mit dem kernenergie antrag nichts
anderes verträglichen berliner
landesparlaments als abgeordneter
svitzer police
klimapolitischer sprecher das ist genau
das richtige das ist unser
alleinstellungsmerkmal in der frage
gegen den klimaschutz muss der
linksfraktionen von rot rot grüne
noch mal wir müssen erkennen wir stehen
knapp unterkante aber wir werden es
schaffen wir müssen es schaffen und wenn
ich würde ich nicht hier stehen wenn ich
nicht bereit werde wählen die den
bundesvorstand konstruktiv mitzuarbeiten
denn auch hier ist klar ein
gegeneinander geht mich das haben wir
alle gelernt wir müssen gemeinsam
vorantreiben aber ich gebe auch dafür
für die partei des politischen realismus
aus der mit der gesellschaft das muss
repräsentiert sein und dazu stehe ich
als überzeugungstäter nach zehn jahren
afg und ich habe wirklich glaubt mir
alles erlebt intrigen kämpfe von hoch
hoch hoch jauchzend zu tode betrübt aber
ich bin kissel fest ich stehe hier heute
immer noch ist jedoch nicht gehen als
patriot und aufrecht wir können es wenn
wir nur wollen und lasst es uns mit
dieser meiner wahl zum ausdruck
verliehen danke handel genau das wollen
das spiel drehen für unsere für unser
heiliges deutschland
vielen dank
[Applaus]
warum haben sie jetzt die möglichkeit
bis zu drei fragen anzumelden fehlen
noch jemand eine karte
einwerfen jemand unterwegs
jetzt bemerkbar machen
damit wir sie nicht mit spazier einfach
nur einen spaziergang erhalten
wenig dass noch jemand unterwegs wäre
dann losen wir jetzt die drei
fragesteller aus
das war
die erste frage kommt von
[Musik]
sandro schaer
die zweite frage kommt von doktor
andreas geisenheim und
die dritte frage
kommt von christian blacks man schon so
genau in sein mikrofon für bis zu 30
sekunden wie schon im vorfeld vom
parteitag bzw nach der nrw wahl
gab es ja so genanntes selbsternannte
kollegen vom team vernunft die quasi
stimmungen über die presse die partei
versucht haben hinein zu transportieren
ich persönlich glaube niemand der da
dabei war es für so ein gremium
überhaupt geeignet waren sie da dabei
frage 1 und 2 warum haben sie das
gemacht
eine mütze für die antwort ja deswegen
habe ich ja gesagt ich stehe und ich
kann ich kann nicht anders weil wir
diesen realismus erkennen müssen dass
wir da tatsächlich invest am abgrund
stehen und tino keller kann nichts dafür
dass er als einzig verbliebener sprecher
da war aber er ist leer aber der
sprecher aus dem osten und das ist im
westen so verstanden worden völlig egal
was er da macht oder das ist einfach
eine schlechte akzeptanz im westen das
hat mit ihm auch gar nicht so dass die
strukturen da hab ich gesagt wir müssen
überzeugende vorstandsmitglieder haben
und sprecher die bundesweit überzeugen
können wir haben jetzt diese
doppelspitze das wird auch gelingen aber
ich glaube dieser weg über den
blätterwald zu rücken die parteien diese
diskussion zu führen ich glaube dies
wichtig man kann das kritisieren es ist
nicht immer ideal aber es geht man hin
dass wir haben heute relativ wenig
gehört von den problemen die wir haben
der partei und wir müssen das gemeinsam
schaffen die beiden sind jetzt gewählt
und ich werde vielleicht auch gewählten
gemeinsam packen wir's
vielen dank dann haben wir die zweite
frage von dr geisenheimer am roten saal
mikrofon für bis zu 30 sekunden
bildschirm heraus ich habe mich sehr
gefreut dass sie wird das thema klima
und energie im sinne unseres
grundsatzprogramms gesprochen haben
gerade aus dem berliner bereich hat man
auch andere stimmen gehört die frage ist
wenn sie neu anfangen wollen wenn sich
die partei auch im westen vorwärts
bringen wollen stehen sie zum
grundsatzprogrammen der gänse oder sagen
sie auch am grundsatzprogramm müsste
etwas geändert werden und wenn ja wann
bitte wo vielen dank ich stehe zum
grundsatzprogramm ich habe mich immer
als vertreter des zentralen kerns der
afg empfunden gegen den rand und wir
sind jetzt in der partei wir haben die
richtigen antworten in der
migrationspolitik in der islamkritik in
der politik gegen die linksfront im
klima sozialismus das ist eine
zivilreligion das ist alles unfassbar
was da auf uns zukommt da müssen wir uns
geschlossen in geschlossenheit dagegen
stellen und in berlin gibt keine andere
stimmen als die dass wir
atomforschung wiederhaben wollen auch in
der hauptstadt mit großem widerstand
gegen den senat die arbeiten daran wir
haben das im haushalt auch berüchtigt
ich stehe voll dem kurzprogramm und
hoffe dass sie das auch alle tun liebe
freundin
danke
vielen dank und die dritte frage kommt
am blauen saal mikrofon von doktor
blacks bitteschön der handel sie haben
mit ihrer machenschaften die berliner
delegierten es geschafft die welle der
delegierten zu disqualifizieren für den
heutigen parteitag sie sind in der
vergangenheit immer damit aufgefallen in
ihren facebook post und sonst so gegen
verdiente parteifreunde zu schießen sie
sind nur damit aufgefallen direkt zu
schmeißen in der öffentlichkeit warum
clowns hier heute mit ihrer kandidatur
die zeit die haben keine chance gewählt
zu werden
weil genau auch dass das problem unserer
partei ist das so war es jetzt von ihnen
kommt aber ich verstehe dass ich habe
von ihnen auch nichts anderes erwartet
der beck's danke ihnen
ich könnte noch mehr dazu sagen weil
natürlich kritik in dieser partie an
notwendig ist wir werden wir haben das
gelernt von der cdu wie alle haben doch
immer gesagt warum gibt es keinen
bosbachs warum gibt es keine leute die
dann mehr zu sagen was war was machen
sie da das ist völlig verrückt was sie
machen warum hat keiner kritisiert den
atomausstieg warum haben wir sollten
zugelassen weil alle dann sagen auch die
darf man nicht kritisieren das sind sie
nicht liebe freunde wir haben unsere
meinung und das muss man auch sagen
dürfen und das waren auch alle
mitglieder ob sie funktionieren und dann
nicht und das ist auch richtig so und
trotzdem brauchen wir die
geschlossenheit und ich stehe hier dass
ich im neuen bundesvorstand gemeinsam
mitarbeiter dieses programm zu
verwirklichen und ich sag ihr auch ich
bin das freundliche gesicht ein
freundliches gesicht dieser afd
vielen dank dass man drei fragen drei
antworten dann ist der kandidat handel
mit dank auch entlassen bevor wir
weitermachen müssen wir vorne einmal
ganz kurz in einer angelegenheit beraten
die beratungen bezieht sich mit
sicherheit auf den nächsten kandidaten
martin renner so das war die vorstellung
von frank christian hansen mitglied des
berliner abgeordnetenhauses und vom
landesverband berlin der er den
gemäßigten lager zugerechnet wird von
den experten
er bekam zum teil kritische und zum teil
eben unkritische fragen das sind die
fragen in dem man als stichwort
gerne auf dieses stichwort
antwortet und sich dann zu einem
bestimmten thema äußern kann das alles
wird von den fragestellern die dann
zugelost werden mit hilfe von
unterstützern in irgendeiner art und
weise kanalisiert per handy sie haben
vielleicht die bilder schon mal gesehen
dass manche für handy stehen mit an den
saal mikrofonen und dann werden diese
antworten eben oder die fragen
vielmehr so kanalisiert dass sie auch
gestellt werden können all das ist
parteitags strategie der verschiedenen
strömungen und der verschiedenen
interessen und jetzt geht es um den
nächsten kandidaten martin rennert der
ja wie gesagt aus krankheitsgründen
nicht anwesend sein kann und die frage
wie umgehen mit diesem kandidaten hätte
etwas zu klären das werden wir dann aber
gleich noch mitteilen also der
berner hat eine kandidatur in
abwesenheit eingereicht das kann man
sich hier nicht persönlich vorstellen
das haben sie heute früh auch
entsprechend beschlossen in den
unterlagen die er uns eingereicht hat
gibt es keine aussage zu
einem etwaigen zu etwaigen
unvereinbarkeit nach § 19 ebenfalls
keine zum führungszeugnis und auch wenn
ich es richtig sehe nicht zu
früheren partei mitgliedschaften
damit fragen stellen können sie am
abwesenden natürlich entsprechend auch
nicht
wie gesagt dass noch kurz was zu klären
wir machen dann aber vorläufig erst
immer weiter mit der vorstellung von
heinemann herr lehmann bitte kommen sie
zu bringen
der nächste kandidat für das amt des
ersten stellvertreters
als bundessprecher rainer lehmann aus
dem bremer
landesverband
kreisverband
osterholz
seit
2021 mitglied der bremischen
bürgerschaft
guten tag herr lehmann auch am sie
zuerst die drei pflicht fragen frage
nummer eins gibt es unvereinbarkeiten
nach § 19 der bundessatzung zusagen
enthielt ein aktuelles polizeiliches
führungszeugnis eintragungen und in
welchen politischen parteien waren sie
vor darf den ich war bis 2015 vor 1998
in der cdu vielen dank dann haben sie
jetzt bis zu fünf minuten zeit für ihre
vorstellungen britischen
sehr geehrte damen und herren liebe
parteifreunde mein name ist einer
lähmung
landesverband nehmen und abgeordneter in
der bremischen bürgerschaft
sowohl beruflich als auch privat
wirklich sehr gut in bremen und
niedersachsen verankert durch
vielfältige kontakte unterschiedlichsten
kreisen aber auch bundesweit gut
vernetzt
meine bewerbung für den bundesvorstand
soll sowohl den hart arbeitenden
mitgliedern aus der mittelschicht und
den arbeitern in der partei aber auch
diesen personenkreis außerhalb der
alternativen für deutschland eine stimme
verleihen dem willen und streben dieser
menschen wird von einem teil des
bisherigen vorstands nicht mehr
entsprochen
deshalb trete ich hier an um dies zu
ändern es muss außerdem erreicht werden
dass die identität der alternativen für
deutschland als einzige wirkliche
opposition in deutschland wieder klar
erkennbar wird eine cdu oder fdp 20 ist
eine klare absage zu erteilen
der durch unsere ehemalige
bundessprecher erneuten entstandene
schaden ist kurzfristig zu beheben und
die weichen müssen wieder auf den
richtigen weg gestellt werden das
bedeutet es ist platz für alle da und
mit ausgrenzung und spaltungen muss
schluss sein
ein zunehmendes ärgernis ist allerdings
dass gute leute aus schierem mandat
streep und wettbewerbs verdrängung aus
der partei gedrängt werden dabei geht es
hier nicht um die schlagzeilenträchtigen
fälle von bundes und landes
vorstandsmitglieder durch zum teil und
durchdachte maßnahmen man kann auch von
vorsatz gehen werden parteimitglieder
gerade zum austritt genötigt ein gutes
beispiel ist der versuch
die mitgliedsbeiträge nur noch und
verbindlich durch ein teil erteilung
eines sepa-lastschrift man da das
einzuziehen dies ist nicht mal auf dem
ersten blick eine gute idee wenn dieses
dem schatzmeister die arbeit erleichtern
soll viele parteimitglieder zahlen ihre
beiträge in denen sie die
mitgliedsbeitrag einem freund oder guten
bekannten zur überweisung von dessen
konto in bar geben damit sie ihre
existenz gefährden oder eine
kontaminierung ihres eigenen kontos
durch die hausbank vermeiden nicht jeder
kann oder will durch den schatzmeister
zwangsweise als fdp-mitglied geortet
werden hier wurde nicht einmal bis zum
ende gedacht
oder will man den mitgliederbestand
dadurch bewusst reduzieren klingt absurd
aber leider ist das in anderen fällen
nachgewiesen realität 1 uhr bekenntnis
der alternativen für deutschland ist die
rechtsstaatlichkeit
sowohl in der bundes partei als auch in
den landes gliederung bis zu 100 zu
manchen kreisverbänden wird von leider
viel zu vielen funktionsträgern aus
schierem machtkalkül das recht mit füßen
getreten die parteiinterne
schiedsgerichtsbarkeit muss ein
stellenwert haben und darf nicht für
eigene renkl spielereien
instrumentalisiert werden wo dies nicht
gelingt weil das antike schiedsrichter
gibt werden deren entscheidung ignoriert
und oder schiedsgerichte handlung
handlungsunfähig gemacht indem man
einzelne schiedsrichter zum rücktritt
überredet
mittlerweile wird das leider gibt es
leider keinen landesverband in der
alternativen für deutschland wo solche
geschichten unbekannt sind da gibt es
eine gehäufte zahl von fällen wo auch
vor wahlbetrug nicht zurückgeschickt
zurückgeschreckt wird fliegt das ganze
dann auf dann führt das nicht etwa
zurück schuldigen nein sie stellt nicht
einmal davor zurück diejenigen die
dieses kriminelle verhalten aufgedeckt
haben als nestbeschmutzer zu denunzieren
und deren parteiausschluss zu beantragen
dabei sind in wahrheit sie es die der
alternativen für deutschland erheblichen
schaden zugefügt haben innerparteilich
für solch ein verhalten fatal weil sich
viele rechtschaffende mitglieder von
diesen vorgängen durch parteiaustritt
distanzieren mitglieder die aus diesem
grund ausgeschieden sind benötigen eine
besondere rückkehrmöglichkeit
in einem neuen heimat verband in bremen
wurde die mitgliederzahl innerhalb von
zwei jahren halbiert sollte ich auf
welcher position noch immer in diesen
vorstand gewählt werden so werde ich
mich für das gehört der nachgeordneten
verbände einsetzen es ist ein unding
dass appell der fankreis verbänden oder
ein anderes schiedsgerichten erst gar
nicht an die mitglieder des
bundesvorstandes weitergeleitet werden
ein beispiel aus bremen seit drei jahren
wird versucht ein kreisverband zu
installieren und der landesverband lädt
nicht zu der versammlung ein
das vorstands
das vorstand ludwig das
vorstandsmitglied herr ritter hat
ähnlich wie im saarland wo er auch
zuständig es solches verhalten nicht nur
geduldet sondern die manipulation von
landesparteitagen und
aufstellungsversammlung sogar
unterstützt hier braucht der vorstand
die partei eine anlaufstelle im vorstand
die solche machenschaften in zukunft
verhindert und zur wahrung der
rechtsstaatlichkeit solche missbräuche
untersucht ohne die autonomie die
autonomie des verbandes zu beeinflussen
bei meiner kandidatur geht es darum
diese rechtsstreitigkeit
wiederherzustellen
konsequent wiederum zusätzlichen danke
wir brauchen ehrliche glaubhafte
vertreter in unserer alternativen für
deutschland mein name ist heiner luhmann
geben sie mir ihr vertrauen danke
vielen dank
meine damen und herren dann haben sie
jetzt die gelegenheit dem kandidaten bis
zu drei fragen zu stellen dafür werfen
sie die reformen noch ihre karte ein ist
noch jemand mit karte unterwegs dann
bitte jetzt deutlich bemerkbar machen
das kann ich nicht erkennen noch immer
mit karten ein dann bitte ich hier vorne
die ohne vorbeizubringen wo sind wir die
fragesteller aus
die erste frage an herrn lehmann kommt
von silvio wolff die zweite frage
von stefan schröder und
die dritte frage von andreas black herr
wolf für bis zu 30 sekunden am blauen
saal mikrofon bitte
erstmal entschuldigung für meine
gleichung vorhin meine bord entlassung
meine frage an hannah wir kennen uns ja
schon eigentlich ein paar jahren kann
man eigentlich sagen wie wichtig ist
dass auch die basis in dem vorstand zum
beispiel vertreten ist und was müsste
sich in diesem land verändern dass es
wieder voran geht
bitteschön vielen dank das größte
problem in diesem land ist die
parallelgesellschaft zwischen politiker
und volk der bürger sieht es nicht mehr
ein und die letzte legislaturperiode
oder die letzte koalition im bundestag
hat es nicht geschafft dem volk zu
vermitteln dass wir nicht diese
parallelgesellschaft sind und aus diesem
grunde muss ganz einfach gezeigt werden
dass wir anders sind und das wird nicht
geleistet durch die mandats triebe durch
das wir in der blase leben dass es
einfach den leuten um die mandate geht
aber nicht um das volk
vielen dank die nächste frage kommt von
stefan schröder ebenfalls am blauen saal
mikrofon
ist ja wenn man in vielen dank für ihre
vorstellungsrede ich bin hier in meiner
funktion des landesschatzmeisters sie
haben einen punkt angesprochen
bezüglich der
mitgliedsbeiträge ihre ausführungen
zeigen doch eigentlich nur dass wir zwei
große probleme am ersten serie problem
damit aufrecht zu gehen sagt dann zahlt
ihr dass seine mandate seine
mitgliedsbeiträge selber und zweitens
sie haben einfach nicht verstanden wie
viel arbeit es den leuten
kreisschatzmeister den
landesschatzmeister macht wilkes
beiträgt hinterherzuhängen vielen dank
wie wollen sie das machen wie wollen sie
diese umkehren des titanic und ich
beantworte vielen dank für die frage ich
gehe da mal ich gehe davon aus dass
dieser bundesvorstand und auch die
kreisverbände über ordentliche
buchführung
verfügen aber es ist ganz einfach so
dass es berufsstände auch unternehmer
gibt dies war wo das herz für uns
schlicht die es aber zum schutz ihrer
mitarbeiter nicht zulassen können dass
es herauskommt dass sie uns unterstützen
und diese dieses klientel braucht dieses
vehikel dass sie alternativ zahlen
können und auch natürlich ständen können
vielen dank das waren drei fragen drei
antworten
dritte frage an euch war etwas voreilig
hierher black den habe ich noch im roten
saal mikrofon fahren jetzt bisher zwei
fragen die dritte frage kommt von herrn
black für bis zu 30 sekunden bitte schön
herr lehmann ich bin ein zurückhaltender
mensch aber sie haben fünf minuten lang
vom blatt abgelesen und nicht ein
einziges mal hochgekocht sie kandidieren
als stellvertretender bundesvorsitzender
um eine frage die ich jetzt stellen muss
das erstens welche ämter hatten sie in
der afb bereits gehabt haben sie
vorstands erfahrung die zweite frage ist
sind sie wirklich der festen überzeugung
dass sie persönlich einen mehrwert jetzt
bieten wenn sie als stellvertretender
bundesvorsitzender explizit kandidieren
und noch einer 4 heute dass sich
kandidaten einigen vielen dank die zeit
ist um und frage ist gestellt herr will
man zur antwort auch da vielen dank für
die frage die auch sehr berechtigt es
zum einen ich bin seit 2015 in der ard
ich bin seit
2009 10 beirat gewesen weise zur gewesen
im landesvorstand bremen
sitze seit juli letzten jahres in der
bürgerschaft in bremen
die zu der anderen frage die ich auch
sehr gut finde ist das hab ich als
stellvertretender bundessprecher hier
aufgehoben bin
das entscheidet ihr ganz alleine mir war
nur wichtig dass die der inhalt meines
meine motivation zu diesem zeitpunkt
kommuniziert wird danke
vielen dank dann war das jetzt
tatsächlich drei fragen drei antworten
dann sind sie mit dank entlassen ich hab
ein zwei wichtige
informationen noch zu diesem wahlgang
auch allen weiteren zum einen hat herr
renner hier eben erklärt per fax
äquivalent zu diesem wahlgang erster
stellvertretender sprecher trete ich
nicht an er zieht seine kandidatur
hierfür zurück unterschrieben
materieller 18 6 13 9 das heißt der in
abbitte von der kandidatenliste zu
streichen die wahl die bei stattfindet
ist eine geheime wahl dass sie das
parteiengesetz zuvor mithin auf unsere
satzung auch alle damen und herren
draußen an den geräten da wird wohl
bisweilen etwas
sich darüber gewundert also das
parteiengesetz liegt geheime wahl vor
und wir hatten hier vom verfahren her
beschlossen dass dies in zwei minuten
mit geschlossenen türen passiert zeit
läuft bitte alle rein kommen die an dem
wahlgang teilnehmen möchten
wir haben noch drei kandidaten im rennen
das sind stefan brandner frank christian
hansen und heinz öhmann eine abstimmung
folie wird gleich schon mal im
hintergrund vorbereitet
sie haben noch eine minute 35 um in den
saal hinein zu kommen dann findet dieser
wahlgang statt
hier aber in den kandidaten
stefan brandner frank christian handl
und heiner luhmann geht es um drei
bewerber die sich auf das amt des ersten
stellvertreters bewerben der ja mit drei
kandidaturen ausgestattet ist das gibt
drei stellvertreter der beiden
bundessprecher die
gewählt werden und den engeren vorstand
bilden der engere vorstand hat aber nur
begrenzt die kunden
kompetenz denn es geht immer noch um den
gesamten bundesvorstand bei der afg wenn
es um grundlegende fragen geht
werden können
die wahl ist noch nicht ganz öffnen
wir haben sondern man wartet immer noch
bis in
die türen geschlossen werden
die delegierten dann mehr oder weniger
nicht mehr ausgewechselt oder sonst
irgendwas können damit die wahlen auch
wirklich geheim sind geheim mit der
elektronischen stimmabgabe ist es mit ph
auch das ist korrigiert dann haben wir
das jetzt alles korrekt und in fünf
sekunden wenn dann nicht gerade noch
jemand durch die tür bitte die tür
schließen kann geschlossen werden
wird geschlossen
bitte die plätze einzunehmen bitte kurz
einmal signal geben dass die tür
geschlossen ist es jedoch zu entfernen
und geschlossen aus ja wohl vielen dank
ist geschlossen und dann haben sie jetzt
die möglichkeit mit 1 gleich zu wählen
herrn brandner mit der nummer zwei herrn
handel mit der drei herrn lehmann mit
der vier können sie nein gegen alle
kandidaten votieren und mit der fünf
sich der stimme enthalten sie haben für
diese wahl jetzt eine minute zeit die
abstimmung ist eröffnet
er eine minute zeit damit die wahl des
ersten stellvertretenden bundessprecher
vollzogen werden kann stefan waldner
mitglied des deutschen bundestages noch
einmal erwähnt ist einmal wunschkandidat
von martin okpala
wird dem
national oder rechtskonservativen
strömungs flügel zugerechnet und
stellt sich genauso zur wahl wie die
beiden anderen reifen kandidaten ihre
stimme abgaben
und wenn ich zähle wie viel an dieser
wahl teilnehmen von den delegierten sind
wir auch und kommen wenn das zelt
verhalten jetzt sich weiter ändert auf
jeden fall über die 500 das heißt über
500 delegierte geben derzeit ihre stimme
ab für einen der drei kandidaten und
dann wird man gleich sehen wer diese
wahl gewonnen hat so noch fünf sekunden
321 und dann bitte ich das ergebnis
einzublenden
deutliche mehrheit für steuern veranda
mit
62,35 prozent
frank christian handl entfielen 19
297 stimmen auf herrn lehmann 5 stimmen
nein gegen alle 39 und zwei personen
haben sich der stimme enthalten ich
stelle fest dass da kann der renten hat
die notwendige einfache mehrheit
erreicht hat hier brannten hand nehmen
sie diese wahl auch an
herzlichen glückwunsch dann
übergebe ich an dieser stelle also und
während herr brandner die glückwünsche
seiner fraktions und parteikollegen
entgegennimmt gebe ich noch mal ab zu
alexander keller
ja wir sind jetzt ihnen wahlgängen zur
parteispitze und da sind schon einige
auffälligkeiten hier bei diesem
parteitag zu erkennen und deswegen
wollen wir das auch besprechen mit
professor wolfgang schröder wir hatten
vorher schon über die wal gruppe a gegen
kleinwächter gesprochen der einer die
bessere rede gehalten der andere hat die
wahl gewonnen
wie ist denn im vergleich dazu die wahl
zwischen alles weiterhin nikolausfest zu
bewerten das waren beide keine großen
redner war das ergebnis allerdings für
alles wesentlich deutlicher als für tino
keller was war der unterschied im
wahlgang neuer hier war eine ganz klare
hierarchie die sich schon auf dem
parteitag gestern angedeutet hat weil
hat doch eine große sympathie hier in
dieser halle und diese sympathie hat
sich auch in einem sehr beeindruckenden
wahlergebnis dann auch abgebildet oder
muss ja sehen es war ein gegenkandidat
der gegenkandidat hat durchaus auch ein
renommee er ist angetreten im vorfeld
dass er die einigung der partei
voranbringen will mit den erfahrungen
aus berlin und aus brüssel und ist aber
hier dann doch als bettvorleger gelandet
und das spiegelt die macht architektur
wider die in der vergangenheit auch die
ard geprägt hat und vor allen dingen es
ist jetzt eine situation die die afg von
anfang an nicht haben wollte dass sie
nämlich die ämter kumulation hat jetzt
haben wir das gleiche pärchen was auch
die bundestagsfraktion anführt haben wir
jetzt hier in der parteispitze und damit
ist die afg eigentlich eine komplette
alt partei was die aufstellung angeht
und die idee einer partei neuen typs ist
eigentlich gar nicht mehr erkennbar 53
prozent für die docucolor aber 67 für
alles weiter stärkt das auch alles
weiter gegenüber kino copala dieses
wahlergebnis auf jeden fall das haben
wir ja auch schon in den letzten monaten
in der fraktion gesehen wo sie im
vergleich zu den vorhergehenden
legislaturperiode wo sie als co pilotin
mit bauland die geschicke der fraktion
führt relativ ruhig relativ verhalten im
hintergrund und die neue paarung führt
dazu dass sie eigentlich die
tonangebende ist diejenige die die
autorität hat diejenige der man zutraut
die intellektualität auch zu besitzen um
die afg kommunikativ zumindest ein stück
weit besser zu vertreten als dies durch
grob aller möglich ist aber gleichzeitig
muss man auch sagen die ergebnisse hier
sind sehr erwacht war die ergebnisse
bilden die enorme
mobilisierungsfähigkeit des flügels ab
und insofern ist hier erst mal nichts
neues zu erkennen und das ist für die
partei keine gute botschaft weil sie es
mit einer enormen defensive hier
angereist und die sehnsucht der
delegierten ist dass etwas geschieht was
eine perspektive neue hart für sie
vermittelt und das nicht erkennbar
kommen wir ganz kurzen die weitere
zukunft böcke hat ja schon angekündigt
möglicherweise gibt es in zwei jahren
dann eine einer spitze kann es sein dass
wenn wir ein höcker sich für diesen
posten des alleinigen bundessprecher
dann interessiert er an alles sei die
nicht vorbei kommt also was man jetzt
feststellen kann ist das alles in
richtung höckel eupd dass er die
choreographie im griff hat dass die
personalentscheidungen in seinem sinne
sind und ob dann frau weil eine
alternative zur hypo ist das glaube ich
nicht weil man muss immer sehen weil hat
keine eigene machtbasis in der partei
seien sie lebt von der machtbasis des
flügels und von ihrer dann doch
stärkeren intellektualität
kommunikationsfähigkeit gegenüber gruppe
aber aus sich selbst heraus hat sie
weder ideen noch eine politische
strategie die diesen laden diese afd in
eine andere position bringen könnte und
das ist glaube ich das grundproblem
geht hier strategisch sehr geschickt vor
er hat diese entscheidenden anträge die
diesen kongress am ende prägen werden
initiiert und da ist jeweils ein sehr
taktisches vorgehen zum beispiel die
einer spitze hat er klar gesagt wir
brauchen wir aber nicht geht sonst so
eine art vorratsbeschluss um dann wenn
die zeit reif ist selbst möglicherweise
nach der macht zu greifen den zuschlag
einigkeit sagen sie auch eine enorme
mobilisierung des heckflügels und der
östlichen landesverbände hier in der kfd
das hat man ja jetzt auch gemerkt bei
den wahlen besonders zum ersten
stellvertretenden bundessprecher
gefälligkeits fragen an kandidaten des
koala weite weiden oder röcke flügels
und ziemlich kritische aggressive zum
teil auch herabwürdigende fragen
unterstellung fragen auch an die
kandidaten die er zu dem alten flügel
angehört haben den leuten lager was sagt
das eigentlich über die performance über
die darstellung der partei bei diesem
wahlgang aus der findet ja dieser
wahlgang findet in aller öffentlichkeit
statt wird live im fernsehen übertragen
was sagt das über die idee aus das sagt
zunächst mal dass diese
störung einer anderen politischen kultur
die sie benötigen um einigkeit zu
ermöglichen ein reines lippenbekenntnis
ist und am ende zählt immer nur der sieg
zählt dass man sich gegen den anderen
durch set und sofern hat man den
eindruck hier ist weiterhin die kultur
des faust teils im vordergrund stehen
und damit ist man natürlich nicht in der
lage vertrauen aufzubauen wir haben wir
hier doch klare machtverhältnisse die
aber am ende nicht das abbilden was die
partei als ganzes leisten muss um
bundespolitische aufmerksamkeit und
stärke zu erlangen also was man sich er
hätte hier vorstellen können ist dass
dieser dominante flügel sich überlegt
wie er die anderen auch vertrauensvoll
einbindet und diese vertrauensvolle
einbindung der anderen der kritiker die
findet nicht statt und die werden
abgestraft die werden in die ecke
gedrängt wir werden als ursache der
nicht einigkeit
herausgearbeitet und das scheint mir
nicht die grundlage zu sein um aus
diesem parteitag heraus eine neue
offensive zu entwickeln heißt die afg
wirft jetzt den ballast lucke petri
mountain endgültig ab und wird eine
partei neuen typs sie wird eine partei
alten typs der alten rechten das muss
man glaube ich klar herausarbeiten weil
das potenzial was die afg am anfang
hatte war ja eine partei neuen typs in
dem sie radikale und etwas weniger
radikale in einem club vereint und das
in wechselseitigem respekt und deshalb
auch die doppelspitze und deshalb auch
ein stück basisdemokratie und das
scheint mehr überholt zu sein weil es
geht jetzt nur noch um den puren macht
erhalten das konnte man auch sehen nach
der kritik von total braun und wolf da
hat man keinen dialog organisiert
sondern man hat die leute ausgegrenzten
hat dazu beigetragen dass sie
kapitulieren und ihr gar nicht mehr
auftreten gut bis dahin wolfgang
schröder es geht weiter beim wahlgang
liebe zuschauer und damit mit doris
müller er half vielen dank alexander
keller und ich wir gucken schauen direkt
in den saal da stellt sich peter
böhringer zur wahl als stellvertretender
zweiter unsere sprechen sich ihr
programm vorzustellen bitteschön
hallo riesa liebe freunde ihr wisst
wofür ich stehe
denn ich bearbeite seit 20 jahren die
hauptthemen der afg eben die lebenslügen
der ard euro dauer rettung
massenzuwanderung
kompetenz anmaßungen der eu schulden
sozialismus co2 waren ich kämpfe für
bürgernahe demokratie meinungsfreiheit
marktwirtschaft für den erhalt des
rechtsstaats und einer souveränen
deutschen nation und sitecore oder sogar
für das grundrecht am eigenen körper
wir wissen auch wie ich arbeite immer
inhaltlich getrieben im rahmen dieser
harten prämissen bin ich allerdings auch
pragmatiker politik ist stetiges
aushandeln des machbaren ich war als
haushaltspolitischer sprecher der
bundestagsfraktion seit fünf jahren bei
sehr vielen schwierigen anträgen in der
rolle des zentralen vermittlers mit
wenigen ausnahmen erfolgreich weil wir
frühzeitig kompromisse ausloten
ich bin seit 2005 10 sprecher des
bundesfachausschusses euro und
finanzpolitik und mitglied unserer
bundesprogramm kommission wir haben alle
leitanträge zur bundesprogramm
parteitagen 2016 17 19 21
formuliert aber ja ihr habt ihr durch
eure saarland regel noch verbessert ich
bin stolz auf diese partei das wäre bei
den altparteien undenkbar
[Applaus]
ich war vier jahre lang vorsitzende des
haushaltsausschusses des deutschen
bundestages und in dieser rolle
permanent unter medialen beschuss ich
habe alle diese rollen immer
freiheitlich konservativ und zugleich
national denken ausgefüllt das schließt
sich alles keinesfalls aus liebe
freundin
den haltungs journalisten des mainstream
ist zu unserer bekämpfung jedes mittel
recht nur eines nicht das argument
bitte wählt darum nur bewerber mit sehr
großer frustrationstoleranz
ich bearbeite unsere idealen wurzeln
publizistisch seit jahrzehnten und ich
kenne die internet szene sehr gut das
war und ist unser primäres vorfeld sehr
wichtig ist darum die alternativen
medienarbeit ich betreibe heute den
viertgrößten youtube-kanal aller
bundestagsabgeordneten und den größten
telegramm kanal aller deutschen
politiker überhaupt
wir müssen als fdp boss lügen der bund
mit elastischen republik thematisieren
wir brauchen dazu eigentlich keine insel
um fragen die uns höchstens zeigen
könnten wie wir uns verbiegen müssten um
eine derzeit verlorene grün urbane
parallelwelt als wähler zu gewinnen
diese leute werden wieder zur realität
zurück finden aber wahrscheinlich erst
bei 20 plus prozent inflation oder bei
einem blackout
unser ziel kann darum nicht die schnelle
koalitionsfähigkeit der afg sein in
einer verrückten welt wird der
eigentlich nur konservative automatisch
zum fundamentalkritik
opposition bedeutet die erkannten
missstände klar auszusprechen ich mache
das in deutlichen worten und ja frau
feser oder herhalten
das ist keine die legitimierung des
staates das ist absurd das ist die ganz
reguläre oppositionsarbeit der größten
deutschen oppositionspartei der
alternative für deutschland
manchmal werden wir gefragt wo wollt ihr
eigentlich hin was ist die vision nun
unsere vision ist ein umsteuern bei all
dem was schon gescheitert ist und der
erhalt des bewährten menschen statt
roter grüner transformations- vision wir
müssen in den wichtigen politik fragen
einfach nur kurs halten praktisch alle
großen entscheidungen der letzten 30
jahre waren falsch das umkehren dieser
fehlentwicklung ist eine starke vision
die vision der rettung eines souveränen
deutschlands und der sozialen
marktwirtschaft gegen die eu die rettung
unserer kultur des rechtsstaats der
meinungsfreiheit unseres rechts am
eigenen körper
wir brauchen den bundesvorstand mehr mut
mehr außen beschäftigung wir müssen das
vorfeld und die alternativen medien
einbinden auch wenn wir nicht alle
alternativen medialen forderungen 11
erfüllen können dafür sind sie zu
heterogen und auch nicht alle vom
parteiprogramm gedeckt und wir müssen
die partei befrieden durch sacharbeit
streiterei streitereien haben bei uns
meistens stilistische gründe und sehr
oft machttaktische das muss endlich
aufhören
und verhandelbare grenzen sind natürlich
echter rassismus echte antisemitismus
gewaltaufrufe und sozialismus es kann
nicht jeder auf jedermanns kosten leben
es ist kommt zum schluss ja okay nur wir
als afd verteidigen authentisch das wohl
verstandenen nationale interesse ich
danke darum daher für euren
vertrauensvorschuss wählt eine nato
weniger einen homogenen bundesvorstand
vielen dank
ja soweit peter böhringer der liebt es
haushaltspolitische sprecher der fdp im
bundestag
es möchten auch noch delegierte fragen
einwerfen wir warten kurz zu lange ich
weise darauf hin ist es bereits möglich
und während der rede wenn sie eine
bestimmte stelle sehr interessant finden
und die eine frage aufwirft natürlich
fragen einzuwerfen
wenn niemand sonst eine frage ein werfen
möchte losen wir jetzt
die erste frage stellt dr rainer rothfuß
die zweite frage stellt frank lee zurück
die dritte frage stellt tobias ponto
wir beginnen mit herrn doktor rothfuß
sie stehen am roten saal mikrofon
bitteschön
ja lieber peter du hast erwähnt dass die
alternativ medien sehr wichtig sind dube
spielt sie sehr gut und gekonnt aber die
frage ist für mich ganz zentral wie
schaffen wir es auch in die mainstream
medien reinzukommen denn sie haben eine
art brandmauer aufgerichtet gegen die
afd es ist letztendlich klar sie wollen
unsere meinungen raushalten aus dem
öffentlichen diskurs 0 talkshow
einladungen bei 254 politiker einladung
für alle anderen parteien zeigt ganz
klar die afb wird einfach totgeschwiegen
wie willst du dagegen vorgehen
dankeschön und die antwort ja dieses
schweigen ist das hauptproblem seit 2008
zehn so lange hatten wir uns nicht
totgeschwiegen und wenn wir das wort
bekamen und das argument geben dürften 1
waren wir in aller regel weit vorne und
am ende bei 18% und dann kam dieser
bruch der mainstream medien und
totzuschweigen das ist natürlich das
hauptproblem das habe ich bleibe dabei
wir müssen auch über die alternativen
medien das wort erheben und alles
weitere hat vorhin auch schon gesagt man
muss trotzdem nicht in jede kamera ab um
einen dreinreden auch nicht in jedem
mainstream kamera ich teile nicht die
meinung dass jeder auftritt per
definition gute presse ist trotzdem ist
es natürlich die aufgabe der sprecher
unter stellvertretenden sprecher richtig
viel zu sprechen und ich werde es immer
und immer wieder auf die sachebene
zurückführen und auf dieser ebene
punkten wir und dann ist mir das am ende
egal ob es ein mainstream oder einen
alternativen mediales mikrofon ist danke
vielen dank
die nächste frage stellt am blauen saal
mikrofon franken zurück 30 sekunden
ja herr böhringer wir sind sehr oft auch
in den vorständen unterwegs und besuchen
versuchen menschen zum wählen zu bewegen
und man hört oft sehr resignierte
meinung unter anderem ihr seid einfach
zu spät mit eurer partei gekommen ihr
könnt ihr sowieso nichts mehr trainieren
ist warten bis das ganze irgendwann
kriegt und dann habt ihr eine chance wie
stehen sie dazu
antwort es
ist ein naheliegender schluss und
liegt leicht dieser versuchung so zu
denken ich mache das ja wirklich schon
20 jahre öffentlich und ich habe dieses
argument ist es doch zu spät deutschland
ist verloren vor genau 20 jahren auch
schon gehört und sogar noch länger und
immer wieder seitdem an wer sich zurück
denkt in 2002 deutschland wäre noch
nicht verloren gewesen und wir geben ist
auch heute noch nicht verloren auch wenn
es natürlich ungleich heikler ist
inzwischen ist der euro eingeführt alles
was wir vorausgesagt haben ist noch viel
schlimmer eingetreten inzwischen ist
2015 der dammbruch mit der
massenzuwanderung passiert und ja es ist
schwieriger aber deutschland hat eine
riesige rest substanz wir müssen wenn
wir verlieren würden am ende hätten wir
eine verpflichtung vor der geschichte
und vor unseren kindern diesen kampf
durchzuführen ich bleibe auch dabei ich
habe das so lange gehört ja ich habe das
schon so oft gehört immer hieß es es ist
zu spät nein es ist noch nicht zu spät
dieses land ist zu retten und wir sind
die vorderste speerspitze bei dieser
rettung vielen dank und die letzte frage
stellt tobias ponto im roten saal
mikrofon bitteschön ja herr der ringe
speerspitze ist ein gutes thema sie
haben im bundestag gegen das
sondervermögen bundeswehr gestimmt
meinen sie wirklich dass das unsere
soldaten hier wirklich schützt die jetzt
so lange nicht material ordentlich
ausgerüstet sind ist das wirklich ihr
ernst
antwort ich bin dankbar dafür dass diese
erstens missverständnis und zweitens
minderheitenmeinung an der basis der afg
hier klar ausgesprochen wird dass sie
mir die gelegenheit geben das noch mal
zu erklären ich habe mindestens drei
videos dazu gedreht ich habe im
bundestag dazu gesprochen wir sind die
partei der bundeswehr wir haben der
bundeswehr diese 100 milliarden glasklar
versprochen es gab nicht den geringsten
dissens in der ganzen bundestagsfraktion
dazu
aber wir konnten nicht den
haushaltsvollzug
komplett aushebeln lassen über eine
grundgesetzänderung und wir ich
persönlich haben am gleichen tag der
verabschiedung im bundestag wege
aufgezeigt
160 milliarden euro einzusparen im
aktuellen haushalt und wir reden nur von
20 milliarden auf fünf jahre verteilt
werden pro jahr es wäre nicht das
geringste problem den investitionsstau
der bundeswehr der seit 20 jahren
aufgelöst aufgelaufen ist wirklich zu
beheben das habe ich ja x-mal klar
gemacht insofern danke für die frage die
bundeswehr kann sich auf uns verlassen
aber in dieser form konnten wir das auf
keinen fall durchgehen lassen vielen
dank
[Applaus]
er bringe sie sind mit dank entlassen
und dann darf ich frau steinbach auf die
bühne bitten
erika steinbach die erst vor kurzem in
die afg eingetreten ist sie hat aber die
afg bereits seit längerem unterstützt so
zb bei der bundestagswahl
guten tag frau steinbach ich muss sie
als erstes fragen ob unvereinbarkeiten
im hinblick auf ein amt im
bundesvorstand laut auf die
bundessatzung bestehen nein ich darf sie
dann des weiteren fragen ob ein
polizeiliches führungszeugnis eintragung
enthielte
wie bitte ob ein paar ob ein
polizeiliches führungszeugnis
eintragungen in die 1 und schließlich
darf ich sie noch fragen oder darum
bitten frühere parteien mitgliedschaften
anzugeben ist 2017 in der cdu alles klar
dann frau steinbach haben sie jetzt fünf
minuten zeit um sich vorzustellen
bitteschön liebe delegierte meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren nach meinem
austritt vor fünf jahren aus der cdu die
als rechtsstaatspartei
völlig versagt hat wollte ich keiner
partei mehr beitreten zwar habe es
bereits 2017 vor der bundestagswahl für
die afg geworden mit einer anzeige in
der faz und an einer großen
veranstaltung in heilbronn teilgenommen
und zwei 2018 engagiere ich mich mit
freude für die afg nahe die sirius
erasmus stiftung aber die situation in
deutschland hat mich jetzt nicht tun
lassen und so bin ich nach dem
unanständigen in farmen abgang von jörg
mal spontan in die afg eingetreten
[Applaus]
ich will einfach nicht länger tatenlos
zusehen wie unser schönes land in den
abgrund ruiniert wird weil es mich
umtreibt wie in deutschland recht und
gesetz mit füßen getreten werden und
gebrochen werden weil es mich umtreibt
wie deutschland in allen
politikbereichen in den abgrund reagiert
wird aber auch weil ich nicht mehr
ertragen kann wie mit der afd
seitens von politik und medien
umgegangen wird das alles
das alles hat mit demokratie doch nichts
aber auch gar nichts mehr zu tun das
grundsatzprogramm der fdp
studiert in seiner präambel wunderbar
mut zu deutschland freie bürger keine
untertanen hier sind liberale und
konservative
wir sind freie bürger unseres landes und
wir sind überzeugte demokraten so steht
es dort
und wir sind patrioten aber keine
nationalisten wir sind sozial aber keine
sozialisten
deutschlands lage hat sich leider nicht
verbessert ganz im gegenteil die
meinungsfreiheit
elementarer teil jedweder demokratie ist
so eingeengt und unter druck wie niemals
zuvor in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik deutschland
recht und gesetz leiden not und
millionen bürger stehen am
wirtschaftlichen abgrund
unsere partei ist also noch nötiger als
jemals zuvor in dieser situation
und eines muss man sehen die afd ist in
der geschichte der bundesrepublik
deutschland geradezu ein mirakel sie hat
etwas singuläres geschafft innerhalb
kürzester zeit war sie in allen
landtagen im bundestag im
europaparlament präsent und nie zuvor
ist das einer anderen neuen partei
gelungen
für deutschland zukunft
für deutschlands zukunft und für seine
menschen vor allen dingen für seine
menschen ist es jetzt elementar wichtig
dass unsere partei dass die afd nicht
nur stabil bleibt sondern dass sie
wächst damit sie für deutschland etwas
gutes bewirken kann und jetzt muss ich
mal sagen hin und wieder erinnert mich
die afg mit ihren neuen jahren als junge
partei in ihrem verhalten an ein
9-jähriges kind das mit den füßen auf
stampft mal porzellan zerschlägt auch
wenn es ansonsten intelligent und
wirklich vielversprechend ist das liebe
freunde das muss und das wird sich
auswachsen daran müssen wir aber
gemeinsam arbeiten und zum dringend
nötigen reifeprozess der afd müssen wir
jetzt alle ihr und ich dazu beitragen
das muss unser wille sein
die afg ist wirklich kostbar und ich
halte sie für unverzichtbar für unsere
demokratie und für deutschland
allein die ard legt den finger in die
wunden die unserem land permanent durch
falsche politik geschlagen wurden und
werden die total süß und lucy da von
außen noch von im inneren der partei
zerstören lassen es ist unsere
gemeinsame aufgabe die partei vor beiden
gefahren mit vereinten kräften zu
schützen mit heißem herzen aber kühlem
verstand
vielen dank
erika steinbach 27 jahre mdb mitglied
des deutschen bundestages für die cdu
2017 ist sie aus der partei ausgetreten
und vor kurzem im bafa ein
nachdem
auch hier die berühmte kiste der
fragesteller für die fragen die dann die
erste forderung
gestellt werden
er ist ein partner die kandidaten auf
der bühne am rednerpult
wehr gezogen wird und stellen sich dann
den fragen wären drei fragen aus dem
kreis der delegierten im saal mikrofon
sie haben 30 sekunden ja vielen dank
frau stein der frau steinbach auf dem
bundesparteitag in augsburg als die die
sie der erasmus stiftung als parteinahe
stiftung anerkannt wurde abends sie
versprochen dass sie sämtliche
strömungen der partei integrieren werden
sie haben dann herrn dr erich lehner hat
vom institut für staatspolitik aus der
stiftung ausgeschlossen oder innerhalb
der stiftung abgesägt mit der begründung
das institut für staatspolitik würde vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet jetzt will
sie eine freiheit erneut jetzt treten
sie in eine partei ein die ebenfalls
beobachtet wir uns sehen und schrieben
gleich in den bundesvorstand vielleicht
können sie diesen widerspruch mal
auflösen
antwort herr doktor lehnert ist kein
mitglied der afg und das institut für
staatspolitik ist keine organisation der
afg bitteschön ich stehe für die dinge
in der af.de nicht willst das was von
extern herbeigeredet wird
[Applaus]
die
zweite frage stellt arnulf fröhlich auch
sie haben 30 sekunden
schönen tag sie kenne ich bereits so aus
der stiftung beziehungsweise aus dem
bund vertriebenen ich kenne aber auch
ihre vorgänger es kommt nicht darauf an
dass die schöne worte machen sondern
welche fußabdrücke sie hinterlassen und
sie haben sowohl wichtige menschen aus
der stiftung herausgedrängt und sie
haben auch sozusagen die die bundes
vertriebenen abgewickelte
bedeutungslosigkeit wollen sie das auch
mit der fc thun
einen moment
so wie frau steinbach sie haben jetzt
eine minute sie frau steinbach ich muss
erst freischalten so jetzt nochmal bitte
der bund der vertriebenen ist unter
meiner leitung wie das administrations
fähig geworden und dem standen alle
türen offen die vorher verschlossen
waren
[Applaus]
vielen dank
und die letzte frage stellt herr
christian paulwitz am roten mikrofon
wenn ich das richtig sehe hervorragend
bitte ja frau steinbach vielen dank für
ihre rede die man gut gefallen hat eine
frage wie vereinbaren sie ihre tätigkeit
für die stiftung mit einem amt im
bundesvorstand wodurch partei und
stiftungen eine gewisse strukturelle
ferne haben sollten können sie dazu
etwas sagen 'bitte antwort das
selbstverständlich das lässt sich
vereinbaren und ich bilden willens beide
aufgaben getrennt voneinander zu
vereinbaren die afd die leos erasmus
stiftung ist eine parteinahe stiftung
und insofern ist es auch logisch dass
das miteinander verzahnt werden kann und
auch darauf uns hätte ich hier nicht
kandidiert
vielen dank frau steinbach sie sind mit
dank entlassen meine damen und herren
wir werden dann jetzt in zwei minuten
die türen schließen und dann zur wahl
kommen
erika steinbach ist ja
populär gewesen als präsidentin des
bundes der vertriebenen
deren sitz sie lange inne gehalten hatte
und zwar bis november 2014 von 1998 an
war sie die präsidentin des bundes der
vertriebenen und
gleichzeitig sprecherin für
menschenrechte und humanitäre hilfe der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion
in ihrer 27 jährigen geschichte als
parlamentarierin für bundespolitische
themen sie stellt sich hier zur wahl die
zwei minuten sind bereits angezählt für
die wahl des zweiten stellvertretenden
bundessprecher
der inzwischen das präsidium und das
tagungs präsidium übernommen
kollege von julian fleig hat
mit sicherheit gleich die ansage parat
die türen wieder zu schließen damit die
wahl auch wirklich geheim sein kann und
dann wird der vierte oder die der vierte
posten das ungefähr 14 köpfigen
bundesvorstandes
besetzt sein nach dieser wahl
es verbleiben noch 20 sekunden bis wir
die türen schließen
peter böhringer das mitglied des
deutschen bundestages für die afg
geschlossen ist führt ihn auf der liste
standen
folgende abstimmungs möglichkeiten 1
peter böhringer zwei erika steinbach 3
nein zu allen vier enthaltungen ich
hoffe dir den wahlgang und sie haben 40
sekunden
dass die sekunden man kann nicht ablesen
wer das heute um hier das schwimmen
gerät austauschen können die türen
bleiben man merkt wie sie sehen ist ja
die wahl geheim jetzt wird elektronisch
abgestimmt
muss immer wieder
einzelprobleme bei den elektronischen
stimmen geräten händeln und das tagungs
präsidium muss diese kleinen betrieben
und belastungen dann
final
als problem beheben
ist das nicht erforderlich das zu prüfen
dann kann das stimmen gerät einfach
ausgetauscht werden die türen bleiben
weiter geschlossen ist wird niemand rein
oder rausgelassen
die wahl läuft zwischen peter böhringer
und erika steinbach für die wahl des
zweiten stellvertretenden bundessprecher
es werden insgesamt drei
stellvertretende bundessprecher gewählt
wie wir hören soll nach dieser nächsten
wahl es zumindestens ist mit dem gerät
aus meiringen auftritt der dann ja
fünfköpfigen lange bereits dann gegen
ein gespanntes sagen wie viele frauen
dann auf diesem bild erscheinen ob es
für den berühmten titel reicht
gruppenbild mit dame oder ob es jetzt
dazu kommt dass in diesen engeren
führungszirkel auch eine zweite frau
gewählt wird
die abstimmung läuft wird mit sicherheit
gleich geschlossen und dann können wir
uns das ergebnis angucken
auch hier ist das wahlverhalten noch
hoch es sind weit über 500 delegierte
die jetzt im saal sind und ihre stimme
abgeben das gerät bleibt zurzeit bei 529
delegierten die bilder ihre wahlen
gleiten
stehen ja
3210 der wahlgang ist geschlossen
[Applaus]
um deutlich über
50 prozent für peter böhringer
55,39
42,16 eur steinberg nein zu allen hart
und 13 gesagt und zwei enthaltungen
herzlichen glückwunsch und
dann meine damen und herren fahren wir
fort mit der wahl des so damit ist auch
der zweite kandidatin auf den listen
kinogruppe durchgekommen zeit genug um
auch ein zwischenfazit auch für diese
wahl nach vier
bundesvorstand die maus amro zu ziehen
mit alexander keller
ja das heißt jetzt mit ihren stand barca
erst die zweite frau hier angetreten zu
einem wahlgang das war ja alles weitere
zur zweit bundessprecherin und jetzt
erika steinbach die allerdings die wahl
gegen peter böhringer nicht geschafft
hat wir wollen weiter reden über das was
hier am wahltag und ab zahltag natürlich
auch der des fdp bundesparteitags
passiert vorhin hat ja alles sei die bei
ihrer bewerbung zu wenig gesagt wir
müssen wieder kohle oder wir müssen
koalition nicht wider sondern wir müssen
koalitionsfähigkeit anschlussfähigkeit
regierung bilden stefan brandmann der
erste stellt der erste stellvertretende
bundessprecher hat gesagt oder
fantasiert von der ice-t im kanzleramt
nach 2030 wie ist das jetzt was ich
jetzt hier abzeichnet eine klare
dominanz des hatte krupp allerdings eine
wahrscheinlich zuspitzung auch der
politischen auseinandersetzung hilft das
der afd dabei in regierungsverantwortung
zu kommen wenn man die
personalentscheidungen die hier
getroffen worden sind zuordnen will dann
kann man durchaus das bild bemühen dass
wir es hier mit höcker festspielen zu
tun haben wo alles nach seiner
choreographie und seinem plan läuft weil
erster stellvertreter und zweiter
stellvertreter lässt sich auch mehr oder
weniger den hochgelagert zuordnen so
dass der raum für die anderen die er
eine gestaltung seine
koalitionsperspektiven echter art
beanspruchen kaum vorhanden es
zumindestens aus der perspektive des
machtzentrums dass der parteivorstand
dann irgendwann einmal bilden soll und
das ist ein punkt der wenn man die
ausgangslage nimmt zerrissenheit der
partei bemühen um einigkeit herzustellen
ist das hier nicht zu erkennen sondern
das läuft er auf einen durchmarsch der
hacker-gruppe hinaus das heißt aber in
zukunft wird es im bundesvorstand
weniger ärger geben weniger streit man
wird sich wahrscheinlich auch weniger
mit parteiausschlussverfahren überziehen
das ist ja hier auch von stefan brandner
angemahnt worden das heißt er wird
stromlinienförmiger dieser
bundesvorstand shf de wird sich klar
positionieren also der streit der die
asd ja bisher auch in der öffentlichkeit
geprägt hat den wird es weniger geben ja
das ist auch die definition von
einheiten hier unterstellt wird die
einheit wird nicht unbedingt in der
vielstimmigkeit besucht in der vielfalt
sondern eher in einem klaren portfolio
was in der lage ist durch eine bessere
steuerung zu integrieren und insofern
ist das glaube ich dem einheits
verständnis von hüppe brandner
entsprechend was hier gerade passiert
aber es bildet nicht ab die vielfalt die
die afd dann doch darstellt wenn man die
verschiedenen landesverbände sich
anschauen das auch für uns als
beobachter sehr interessant dass die
größeren landesverbände im westen die ja
auch mehr mitglieder haben und die für
das gesamtbild dann doch wichtig sind
wie nordrhein westfalen oder hessen wir
eigentlich nicht vorkommen einheit in
der vielfalt oder einheit und vielfalt
der fahrer bisher ja auch ein
markenzeichen der afg die gesagt hat wir
integrieren verschiedene strömungen geht
sie davon jetzt ab doch das muss man
abwarten auf jeden fall das führungs
tableau bildet diese einheit in vielfalt
nicht mehr so weit bis hierhin wolfgang
schröder dankeschön so und wir gehen
weiter denn jetzt kommt der dritte
stellvertreter stellvertreterin
vielleicht dieses mal der bundessprecher
alles weitere mit doris müller
dankeschön alexander keller wir sind
inzwischen in der wahl zum dritten
stellvertreter
bundessprecher als einzige kandidatin
ist marianne haardt kühne dessen
bewerbungsrede wir jetzt zu ende hören
liebe freunde als zweimalige hessische
spitzenkandidatin habe ich schon oft im
fokus der presse gestanden aber ihr
werdet nirgends auch nur ein schlechtes
wort über einen kollegen in der presse
von mir finden nirgends liebe freunde
dafür ist mir unsere afd ihre
zusammenhalt und ihr erfolg zu wichtig
wir alle haben uns der afg verschrieben
viele von uns haben ihre berufliche
existenz oder private beziehung
gefährdet wir setzen alle auf diese eine
karte in der hoffnung auf ein besseres
deutschland
und liebe freunde das lasse ich mir von
niemandem kaputt machen und deshalb sage
ich ganz klar wir wollen keine
parallelgesellschaften wir wollen keine
no go areas wir wollen keine
einwanderung in die sozialsysteme und
wir wollen keine islamisierung liebe
freunde wir
wollen nicht dass unsere bürger
diffamiert und verfolgt werden nur weil
sie ihre meinung frei äußern
wir wollen nicht das ganze
wirtschaftszweige einer absurden corona
und klimapolitik geopfert werden und vor
allem vor allem wollen wir nicht dass
deutsche zur minderheit im eigenen land
werden dass berlin so bagdad wird meine
freunde
[Applaus]
und hierfür brauchen wir eine
restriktive migrationspolitik auf der
einen und eine aktivierende
familienpolitik auf der anderen seite
die einbürgerung darf erst der krönende
abschluss einer gelungenen integration
sein nur wer unsere sprache spricht und
bewährte bejaht und unsere lebensweise
teil soll deutscher werden können aber
wenn wenn jemand das tut wenn jemand das
dudweiler unser deutschland liebt dann
freude ist er teil unserer
schicksalsgemeinschaft patrioten wie ihm
hat karin stehen uns 1000 mal mehr als
irgendwelche linken deutschland hasler
liebe freunde
die matt karim ist deutsch claudia roth
ist an sie deutsch aber damit es
überhaupt noch auch in zukunft in
deutschland gibt das wir lieben können
müssen wir migrations anreize beseitigen
wir müssen unsere staatsgrenzen wieder
schützen und natürlich müssen wir
diejenigen die kein bleiberecht haben
oder straffällig geworden sind
konsequent zurückführen es wird zeit für
relegation liebe freunde
und die zweite entscheidende front ende
die schlachtung unsere zukunft
geschlagen wird das ist die
familienpolitik wo zur familie das ist
unser motto wir machen politik für
deutschland und wer machen qualität für
deutsche und deshalb wollen wir kinder
willkommen heißen familien entlasten
bürger beschützen das ist politik für
das eigene volk
und dafür kämpfe ich aber wir werden nur
erfolgreich sein wenn wir diesen kampf
gemeinsam führen einheit ist notwendig
um attacken von außen abzuwehren und
einheit ist notwendig um selbst attacken
fahren zu können wir können muss
natürlich lebhaft innerparteilich
diskutieren konservative
nationalliberale und sozial patrioten
aber nach außen brauchen wir endlich
geschlossenheit hat in der sache klar in
der rhetorik fokussiert auf ein ziel ein
besseres deutschland das ist unsere
gemeinsame mission liebe freunde sie
müssen zum schluss kommen
[Applaus]
wir sind die einzige echte opposition
also lasst sie uns weiter jagen weil wir
deutschland nicht den deutschland kassen
überlassen dürfen weil es ganz einfach
ein wunderbares landes das es verdient
hat gerettet zu werden und weil es
unsere verdammte bürgerpflicht ist in
wohlstand und frieden an unsere kinder
weiterzugeben und für diesen kampf für
unsere heimat muss deutschland für
unsere zukunft und die zukunft unserer
kinder möchte ich dass das der beste
bundesvorstand wird den wir je hatten
und bitte euch euer vertrauen dafür
[Applaus]
gibt
gibt es fragen an die kandidaten harder
kühnel
ja da sie die einzige kandidatin ist die
für das amt des dritten
stellvertretenden bundessprecher
irmgard steht
gibt es natürlich ein gruppenbild mit
dame gleich
und jetzt die 33 fragen die auch an sie
gestellt werden
die an ein mikrofon kommen müsste
frau rest 30 sekunden
meine frage an frau der kindle ist
können sie sich vorstellen dass sie
bisher gewählten für den bundesvorstand
in zukunft vertrauensvoll
zusammenarbeiten können ja natürlich es
kann ich mir sogar sehr gut vorstellen
wir arbeiten schon seit jahren in der
fraktion sehr vertrauensvoll und
kollegial zusammen wir sind alles
spitzenkandidaten gewesen frau weigel in
baden württemberg hair group aller in
sachsen der brannten in thüringen herr
boehringer in bayern auch in diesem
wahlkampf haben wir uns bereits sehr
unterstützen ich freue mich auf eine
mögliche zusammenarbeit wenn ich denn
gewählt werde vielen dank
[Applaus]
die zweite frage stellt herr doktor maß
liebe mariana
stellte die frage hier als der sprecher
deines heimat kreisverbandes ich weiß
wie stark du dich für unsere partei und
unser land einsetzt aber trotzdem was
siehst du als deine wichtigsten aufgaben
oder die wichtigsten aufgaben in dem
neuen bundesvorstand an
man muss wir müssen natürlich endlich
aus dem defensiv modus heraus kommen und
in die offensive gehen in den
vergangenen beiden jahren hat der
bundesvorstand sich nur mit sich selber
beschäftigt das muss vorbei sein
ich glaube wir müssen erstmal zunächst
analysieren welche strukturellen und
organisatorischen
probleme ist bisher gab und dann müssen
wir natürlich ganz klar an unserem image
an der öffentlichkeitsarbeit und an der
kommunikation
arbeiten wir sind nicht nur eine partei
sondern wir sind eine gemeinschaft und
als solche sind wir jetzt verpflichtet
viel verloren gegangenes vertrauen bei
den mitgliedern und bei den wählern
zurück zu gewinnen das schaffen wir aber
nur wenn wir an einem strang ziehen es
ist klar wir sind die letzte chance für
deutschland und diesmal muss ist der
bundesvorstand rocken liebe leute vielen
dank
und die letzte frage stellt heiko schulz
am roten saal mikrofon bitteschön ja hat
sich dank der name ist haltlos holz
selber der landessprecher hessen
mariana wer kenn dich als eine
tapfere streiterin für unsere familien
für unsere kinder für die frauen in
unserem schönen heimatland wie kannst du
deine verantwortungsvolle tätigkeit im
bundestag gestalten in verbindung mit
deinem neuen mandat im in der im
vorstand des bundesvorstandes
ob es auch dann kommt ja
liebe freunde ich habe immer viel
gremienarbeit gemacht aber ich über
derzeit keine
eine tätigkeit in einem landesvorstand
auszudehnen da hab ich erheblich zeit
auch um mich um den bundesvorstand zu
kümmern und dazu beizutragen dass unsere
parteiführung künftig wirklich wie eine
mannschaft zusammen arbeitet das heißt
vertrauensvoll geschlossen und immer mit
einem ohr an der parteibasis vielen dank
vielen dank frau harder könne sie sind
mit dank entlassen meine damen und
herren wir werden dann in zwei minuten
die türen schließen und wählen
ja die berühmten zwei minuten die für
die gesamten wahlen gelten laufen jetzt
wieder
marianna h da kühle ist die letzte wahl
bei den drei stellvertretern die die
partei jetzt mit diesem wahlgang
abgeschlossen hat das heißt die ersten
fünf werden dann bereits ihre posten
entweder neu oder auch als schrägstrich
neu besetzt haben das gremium setzt sich
dann bei frau harder könne keinen
gegenkandidaten hatte und sie nur das
heißt nur aber sie braucht eine einfache
mehrheit um schlussendlich gewählt zu
werden auf dem wahlzettel oder auf dem
stimmabgabe teil des elektronischen
stimmzettels
dürfen die delegierten sie entweder
wellen oder sie dürfen sie ablehnen mit
einer 90 enthalten
damit sind dann die ersten fünf gewählt
insgesamt steht besteht der
bundesvorstand aus 13
mitgliedern inklusive des
ehrenvorsitzenden alexander gauland
diesen ehrenvorsitz hat man ihm zuliebe
ja auf einem parteitag eingerichtet und
er hat diesen punkt diese funktion auch
angenommen
wir warten jetzt auf das schließen der
türen und dann beginnt der wahlgang zu
der wahl des dritten stellvertretenden
bundessprecher in diesem fall eine frau
und wie gesagt es wird dann auf jeden
fall ein gruppenbild mit damen geben
wenn die ersten fünf gewählt sind und
dann geht es weiter mit sieben weiteren
einzel wahlen darunter fünf beisitzer
einem schriftführer und eine
bundesschatzmeister der auch noch einen
stellvertreter
bundessprecher den dritten
stellvertretenden bundessprecher den
dritten runde sprich haben wir
abgeschafft und demzufolge haben sie
folgende abstimmungsmöglichkeit 1 1
marianne harder kühne
293 enthaltung ich eröffne die
abstimmung sie haben 40 sekunden
die 40 sekunden geben mir noch mal
gelegenheit zu erwähnen dass die dass
der parteitag nach der wahl natürlich
nicht vorbei ist sondern dann geht es
mit der normalen tagesordnung weiter
nachdem die beiden bundessprecher
sicherlich ihre reden nach der wahl
halten werden und es stehen noch
politische themen auf der tagesordnung
es geht nämlich um noch die um die frage
wie hält es die afd auf ihrem parteitag
mit den waffenlieferungen
für die ukraine und wie hält die partei
ist mit europa
54 aber jetzt sind wir erstmal ob china
handel das
foto bekommen hat
deutlich und 74 64 prozent ohne
gegenkandidat ist sie gar gewährt daten
harder könne die erforderliche einfache
mehrheit erreicht hat ich davor hat er
keine fragen nehmen sie ihre wahl an
herzlichen glückwunsch
so meine damen und herren wir kommen
dann jetzt zur wahl des bundes
schatzmeisters hierfür nehme ich ihre
vorschläge an es gibt einen
geschäftsordnungsantrag
sie machen nur ein foto ach so
will ich später dann gerne sehen
sowie
die irritationen gibt es weil die halle
sehr groß ist können wir uns aus gesehen
haben wir ungefähr 30 meter bis zur
bühne da kann man schon mal das eine
oder andere bildnis interpretieren
so wunderbar und jetzt kommen wir aber
auch zur wahl des stoffes des bundes
schatzmeisters bitte bitte die
kandidaten folie einblenden und
hierfür nehme ich jetzt ihre vorschläge
an den saal mikrofon entgegen
der name und auf jeden fall neu sein
weil der bisherige bundesschatzmeister
sich nicht mehr zur wahl stellen wird
und damit ist die wahl für die
kandidatenliste eröffnet
ich schlage carsten hütter danke
wird dieser vorschlag von fünf
stimmberechtigten delegierten
unterstützt ja wird er dann machen wir
weiter am roten saal mikrofon bitteschön
aus dem aus dem landesverband
niedersachsen wird professorin
vorgeschlagen
suren wurde vorgeschlagen wird dieser
vorschlag von fünf kandidaten
unterstützt von fünf stimmberechtigten
delegierten natürlich
kassenhüter der bisherige
bundesschatzmeister ist dann doch wieder
zur wahl des neuen bundes schatzmeisters
angetreten das heißt frage ob er sein
amt an jetzt behalten wird oder nicht
und es gibt einen neuen kandidaten so
langsam der gegen ihn antreten wird
ich schlage e mail sense vor
wird dieser vorschlag von fünf
stimmberechtigten teilnehmern
unterstützt das ist der fall gibt es
weitere vorschläge
ich kann nicht erkennen dass noch jemand
einen vorschlag machen möchte dann frage
ich die bereitschaft der kandidaten zur
kandidatur ab erhöhter stehen sie zur
verfügung
herr suren stehen sie zur verfügung
frage noch mal versuchen stehen sie zur
verfügung
ich frage ein
drittes und dann auch letztes mal
versuchen stehen sie zur verfügung
dann habe ich drei mal erfolglos gefragt
ob versuchung zur verfügung steht und
keine antwort erhalten wir streichen
ihnen also wieder von der liste
und dann darf ich ein sensor fragen ob
sie zur verfügung stehen zur verfügung
wunderbar so wenn es jetzt keine
weiteren vorschläge gibt dann meine
damen und herren würde ich mit ihrer
zustimmung die kandidatenliste schließen
lassen wer ist für den schluss der
kandidatenliste
danke schön wer ist dagegen
während hält sich dann ist dies mit
großer mehrheit so beschlossen
ich darf zwischenzeitlich noch mal
darauf hinweisen wenn sie ihren
parteiausweis eingeworfen haben um eine
frage zu stellen die amerikaner und
herren während wir die vorschläge zur
wahl des bundes schatzmeisters im saal
haben gehen wir jetzt schnell rüber zu
dem berühmten foto und dem statement
dass ich ihnen angekündigt habe
also lieber
er holte ihn jemand weiß ja dass geholt
nein
[Musik]
mit er ist übrigens ist der fr brandner
gemeint der
stellvertretende bundessprecher ist für
so viel zeit haben wir nämlich nicht
genau
dankeschön
[Musik]
sein vorstand ist nicht da
holte ihn jemand
das klingt
was soll ich sagen ihre deutsches volk
und hüte freuen ich deine hand
deutschland mache ich gleich weiter wir
warten noch auf der vom brandner
hans sachs
[Musik]
dann fangen wir einfach dazu
nein gesagt
ich habe jetzt wieder hin
selbst
er konnte
ich berate
[Musik]
ja offensichtlich gibt es probleme in
der kommunikation dieser fünf
öffentliche wissen nicht bescheid
besucht wird immer noch stefan brandner
der alte und neue stellvertretende
bundessprecher die fünf wollten sich
zusammen zu einem ersten statement
während dieser neuen gruppierung stellen
da ist er jetzt haben wir ihn gefunden
so jetzt sind wir komplett
gruppenbild mit damen pressevertreter
wir fangen an genau so ist es
heute beginnt der aufbruch der afd mit
diesen bereits gewählten vorstand mit
den beiden vorsitzenden mit den beiden
stellvertretenden vorsitz nicht möchte
mich recht hat sich bei den delegierten
bedanken die uns das vertrauen gegeben
haben ich freue mich ganz besonders dass
ich mit alice weiterhin vertrauensvoll
jetzt in der sprecher position
zusammenarbeiten kann das hat mir
wirklich ein großes glücksgefühl auf
mein herz gebracht und ich freue mich
natürlich auch mit den drei
stellvertreter mit denen ja bereits
schon im bundestag zusammenarbeit hier
vertrauensvoll zusammenarbeiten das ist
unser ziel dass wir heute die
vergangenheit hinter uns lassen den
streit hinter uns lassen und geschlossen
die weiteren aufgaben für deutschland
für unser volk vorantreiben werden
ja auch von meiner seite gibt es
eigentlich den gesamten worten des
bundes spreche das team europa überhaupt
nichts hinzuzufügen
ich bedanke mich für die konzentrierte
arbeit der delegierten hier und
wünsche uns allen eine sehr sehr gute
zusammenarbeit jetzt schon mit dem
gewählten rumpf vorstand und morgen
stehen noch viele anträge auch auf der
tagesordnung die wir auch konzentriert
arbeiten werden
bilder
ja gut peter böhringer ich bin ja auch
nicht unbekannte diesem kreis und
genauso verhält es sich mit dem
gesamtgremium des bisherigen bisher
gewählten bundesvorstand ich bin sicher
es wird harmonisch vorangehen es muss
auch modisch vorangehen trotzdem werden
wir uns natürlich über inhaltliche dinge
auch einmal kontrovers auseinandersetzen
aber ich denke es wird ein bisschen
konstruktiver als bisher und im
interesse deutschlands machen wir das
was sollte vielleicht als neulinge zu
diesem gremium nicht gleich die
inhaltlichen ansagen machen deshalb
gehen wir das wort weiter
ja na da kann ich bin sehr stolz diesem
team dieser mannschaft bei zu gehören
ich denke es wird ein neuer aufbruch für
die afg werden wir arbeiten schon seit
vielen jahren kollegial zusammen
vertrauensvoll zusammen und wir sind
eine neue chance für deutschland vielen
dank noch fünf gute wahlen bisher neun
folgen ich hoffe die werden ähnlich
erfolgreich ausgehen erfolgreich für die
partei dass die partei sich endlich
darauf konzentriert was sie tun sollte
nämlich programmatik eine außen tragen
und sich nicht mit internen sachen
beschäftigen aber ich hoffe mir guten
mutes dass das jetzt der vergangenheit
zunächst mal für einige zeit angehören
wissen sie ich habe gewonnen das muss
erstmal die hauptaussage die hier
getroffen wurde von den delegierten
dafür bedanke ich mich und natürlich ist
immer die person die ganz vorne steht
die an der man sich am meisten
abarbeitet haben auch die delegierten
getan ich nehme natürlich auch das mit
demut zur kenntnis und ich werde die
nächsten zwei jahre genau daran arbeiten
dass es weitere und bessere ergebnisse
auch mit mir an der spitze gibt
nichtsdestotrotz möchte ich mich
trotzdem noch mal für dieses vertrauen
bedanken und wie dieser wie schon
eingangs gesagt hat heute beginnt der
aufbruch ich schaue nicht mehr zurück
was gewesen ist was war die ära mountain
ist mit dem heutigen tag beendet
also die ersten sachen die zu dem
aufbruch gehören ist das team was wir
uns auch zusammen ausgesucht und was wir
auch zusammen bevor gestellt haben was
bislang auch von den delegierten mit
großer mehrheit gewählt worden ist also
das gibt uns doch den rückhalt den wir
brauchen und die weiteren sache anträge
werden wer wie frau weiter schon sagte
morgen bearbeiten und ich denke auch
dort wenden uns die delegierten folge
also ich war vorher schon
fraktionsvorsitzender ich war vorher
schon parteivorsitzender ich habe die
letzten monate gut hinbekommen ich bin
ins leipziger arbeiter wie sie wissen
von früh bis spät also ich freue mich
auf die zukünftige arbeit ich bin gesund
und fit meine partnerin ist es ebenso
also von daher freuen wir uns dass und
wir werden es auch schaffen
wenn wir angetreten sind war das der
plan
[Gelächter]
trennt sich
das zu sagen
ja das habe ich ja meiner rede auch
ausgeführt im übrigen auch die anderen
redner dass wir genau diese
kommunikation die natürlich auch durch
die korona krise in deutschland
stattgefunden hat das sind im prinzip
die kommunikation nicht stattfand dass
wir uns kaum austauschen konnten dass
wir uns nicht treffen konnten und das
wird auch zwischen ost und west gleich
wohl auch zwischen nord und süd die
nächsten monate und jahre die aufgabe
sein die wir natürlich über bewältigen
müssen dass wir dort in der
kommunikation besser werden auch intern
und trotzdem lassen wir uns diese
spaltung nicht einreden nicht von der
presse einreden diese unterschiede gibt
es in allen parteien übrigen auch in der
cdu auch in der spd diese regionalen
unterschiede muss man auch ein stück
weit an erkennen ohne sofort mit dem
finger auf den anderen zu zeigen
wissen sie ich bin vor zwei jahren mit
54 prozent gewählt worden der aktuelle
cdu-vorsitzende brauchte drei wahlgänge
um überhaupt mal vorsitzender zu werden
also von daher sehe ich das jetzt nicht
so kritisch an wie gesagt ist eine
aufgabe und an der welt messen lassen
und ich möchte natürlich auch das
ergebnis in zwei jahren verbessern
wir wollten es ist endgültig vorbei
ihrer der gewesen
also geben sie mir bitte ein ton wo ich
nicht gemäßigt war von fortan haben wir
die partei der mitte die repräsentieren
wir wie wir hier stehen und ihre
präsentieren wir hier in unserer führung
der umgang mit uns selber der umgang mit
deutschland das ist unsere aufgabe ich
habe es meiner rede gesagt wir vertreten
die interessen der bürger der wähler wir
vertreten die interessen deutschlands
wir vertreten nicht die interessen
russlands genauso wenig wie amerikas
genauso wenig wie brüssel wir wollen für
unsere bürger fallen für die aufgaben
die jetzt anstehen politik betreiben
[Musik]
doch eigentlich
es gibt in jeder partei diese
unterschiedlichen haltungen und auch die
unterschiedlichen positionen wir haben
ein positionspapier verabschiedet was
mit über 90 prozent bestätigt wurde ich
habe es heute auch in meiner rede gesagt
auch die landesvorsitzenden außer ein
landesverband hat den vollumfänglich
zugestimmt also von daher gibt es diese
spaltung die sie ja bei reden wollen
auch zu dieser positionierung nicht
die erste projekt ist die konstituierung
das gehört dazu dann habe ich ein
geschäftsverteilungsplan wir schauen wir
uns in ruhe an und werden beraten werde
ich ja aufgaben auch in den zukünftigen
bundesvorstand übernimmt und ich gehe
davon aus dass sie am montag oder
dienstag stattfinden wird
fasst die stimmung besser wird weiß ich
nicht das ist
die hatte na ja also ich bin ja schon
sieben jahre im bundesvorstand
dementsprechend jahren kann ich auch
vergleiche anstellen ist heute meine
vierte bundesvorstands wahl
das ist der letzte bundesvorstand ist
mit abstand der unerfahrenste gewesen
der unpolitische
und also schlechter konnte man das alles
gar nicht mehr machen das muss ich hier
auch in aller deutlichkeit sagen
der bundesvorstand völlig anders
aufgestellt als beispielsweise der
fraktionsvorstand der bundestagsfraktion
noch komplett anders geführt wird und
wir werden das und das ist jetzt auch
eben der ganz große vorteil der
doppelspitze in der fraktion als auch in
der bundes partei werden wir natürlich
dieses erfolgsmodell auf die partei
spiegeln mit einem hervorragenden themen
wir wählen hier gerade durch mit
kompetenten leuten die haben wir uns ja
auch vorher nachdem gerade der fähigkeit
ausgesucht jeder hat seine aufgabe laut
geschäftsverteilungsplan
und was wir tun werden ist als
allererstes die strategie der partei
umstellen
und das ist das sehe ich als unsere
forderung aufgabe wie positionieren wir
uns dazu habe ich ja auch schon zweimal
gesprochen auf diesem bundesparteitag
und da sind wir uns auch einig tino
keller und ich dass das unsere unsere
größte priorität ist und ich bin da sehr
zuversichtlich dass das mit diesem team
was auch sehr erfahrene des berufs
verfahren ist vor allen dingen dass das
dann auch gelingen wird
das kann man jetzt noch gar nicht sagen
wissen sie
sie können ja selbst auf diesem
parteitag nicht sagen wer wo gewählt
wird wir haben ja eine echte
konkurrenzsituation auch wettbewerb hier
und das ist noch so weit weg sie wissen
doch eine woche kann in dieser partei
sehr lang sein
kleiner betrag
woran machen sie das fest
tenor
nein es war kein misstrauen wir haben's
ja auch gehörten einigen redebeiträgen
was ich auch richtig fahren bevor man
die überhaupt über diese einer spitze in
zukunft weiter diskutiert müssen die
strukturen noch aufgebaut werden was
eventuell mit einem generalsekretär
passiert wie kann man die befugnisse des
generalsekretärs eigentlich definieren
und das ist noch nicht geschehen von
daher wäre es auch heute zu früh gewesen
und noch mal ich freue mich mit alice
weiter vertrauensvoll hier auch als
bundesvorsitzender weiter
zusammenzuarbeiten das funktioniert in
der bundestagsfraktion wunderbar und von
daher freuen wir uns gemeinsam auf die
arbeit und wir können aktuell nicht ohne
uns
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
in dem schreiben
ja soweit die kurze pressekonferenz der
ersten fünf wenn bilder politische
botschaften senden
dann gibt es mit sicherheit politische
botschaften die durch dieses bild
gesendet werden welche das ist jetzt
aufgabe von alexander keller ja die
ja die können also nicht beide ohne
einander sagt timo grub aller über alles
weitere und umgekehrt das werden wir
jetzt in den nächsten monaten sehen was
aus diesem duo ganz an der spitze
gemeinsam mit den drei anderen
stellvertretern bundessprecher
bundessprecherin fünf personen werden
wird wir wollen mal ganz kurz aus der
halle raus schauen weil in dieser gibt
es wie bei vielen afd parteitagen auch
gegendemonstranten demonstration gegen
die afg gegen den parteitag und wir
schauen uns jetzt mal bilder an aus
riesa die noch gar nicht so alt sind wir
sehen demonstranten etwa 200 bis 300
tausend waren erwartet 200 bis 300 das
sind demonstranten die von den grünen
von attacke von der spd kommen und
anders als bei vielen anderen
demonstration gegen die parteitage ist
diese demonstration ziemlich friedlich
verlaufen so jedenfalls unsere
informationen 200 bis 300 hier wollen
vor die halle ziehen und dann noch zum
rathaus und dann wird sich auch dieser
demonstrationszug in elisa hier wieder
auflösen demonstration gegen den
parteitag der afg und gegen die politik
der afd
so jetzt sind wir wieder in der halle
zurück wie gesagt diese demonstrations-
bilder sind eine knappe stunde alt hier
demonstrationen also gegen den fdp
parteitag
in riesa professor wolfgang schröder wir
haben über die regierungsfähigkeit
gerade noch gesprochen der als die
vielleicht nehmen wir das nochmal auf
das was ich jetzt gerade entwickelt in
der afg in der führung und personen sind
auch immer inhalte sind politik
erleichtert dass das geschäft sich einer
anderen partei anzunehmen anzunähern um
eine koalition zu bilden und damit eben
auch erst dadurch in
regierungsverantwortung zu kommen also
wenn man die werdegänge und das
verhalten der handelnden personen aus
den letzten jahren als maßstab nimmt
dann gibt es wenig anhaltspunkte dafür
dass jetzt an der spitze diejenigen sind
die gestaltungs orientiert
anschlussfähigkeit herstellen wollen im
sinne von möglichen koalitionen das sagt
ja noch nichts über regierungsberater
sondern sagt er zunächst einmal nur
etwas darüber wie man sich ein ort und
wie man sich bestimmte positionen
annähert weil das was wir hier erleben
sind ja nur serie große zerrbilder die
gezeichnet werden von der lage in der
bundesrepublik und von den möglichkeiten
wie man diese zu einer besseren
bundesrepublik entwickeln könnte und da
ist wenig zu erkennen von wirklich
konkreten lösungen auf konkrete probleme
sondern das hat eher etwas
konfessionelle es etwas glaubens
orientiertes in diesem sinne ist die afg
möglicherweise er auf dem weg
eine sekte zu werden weil es ja anfangs
so war dass die fdp als partei neuen
typs versucht hat eine große bandbreite
zur bildung jetzt sind sie eher auf dem
wege ihre internen probleme dadurch zu
lösen indem sie den korridor verengen
und diese verengung und schließung des
korridors die wir erleben hat natürlich
auch ihren preis und der preis ist dass
man bestimmte positionen nicht mehr
berücksichtigen will und er in
erinnerung rufen muss man ja auch dass
die negative abgrenzung von leuten ja
nicht einfach die abgrenzung von leuten
als person ist sondern leuten hat sich
ja dann am ende doch darum bemüht die
grenze zu den rechtsextremen klarer zu
ziehen und da will man in zukunft so
sind zumindestens die signale zu
verstehen großzügiger seien weniger die
aufmerksamkeit auf diese schwierigen
position lenken sondern hier die
integration und einheit herstellen indem
man das ganze nicht mehr so wichtig
nimmt und das bedeutet natürlich dass
diese partei sich von ihrer
rechtsstaatlichkeit möglicherweise lösen
könnte wenngleich im inneren die großen
konflikte alle nur rechtsstaatlich
gelöst werden können es gibt keine
andere parteien der die schiedsgerichte
eine so große rolle spielen um überhaupt
eine befriedung der verhältnisse
herzustellen
es gibt keine andere partei in der die
großflächigen entwürfe so stark sind und
die konkreten lösungsvorschläge so
schwach und wenn man das fortschreiben
bildern ist man auf dem weg der in der
vergangenheit ja auch schon dominiert
hat fundamental position ist das reich
in dem diese partei sich verankern will
etwas stutzig hat gemacht dass jetzt
gerade auf dieser pressekonferenz timo
grub aller gesagt hat mit dem heutigen
tag sei die er am leuten endgültig zu
ende ich dachte die eigentlich schon
letztes jahr zu ende gegangen ist als er
angekündigt hat er wird nicht wieder
kandidieren und spätestens im januar als
er die partei verlassen hat kann man
sagen dass der geist von jörg leuten
hier immer noch über den parteitag
schwebt dass man dem versucht immer noch
abzuschütteln motto es ist auf jeden
fall ein wesentlicher resonanzboden den
mann zur legitimation dieses parteitages
braucht man sagt also über uns war eine
schwarze wolke die durch eine person und
ihrem narzissmus und egoismus
herbeigeführt worden ist und wir wollen
dass alles neu ordnen indem wir in
zukunft die einigkeit und
sonderinteressen der einzelnen personen
ins
nebengleis führen und damit das
hauptgleis für alle befahrbar machen und
dieses hauptgleis sondern so aussehen
wie der choreograf höcke das ganze
inszenierter das muss man sich immer
klarmachen derjenige der diesen
parteitag maßgeblich bisher break von
den anträgen von den auftritten von der
strategie von den netzwerken ist
verrückt und er ist so was wie ein
schatten dirigent ein schatten
vorsitzender in diese ganzen aufführung
und tritt gleichzeitig aber in der
offiziellen formation nicht an und das
ist natürlich auch eine besonderheit die
wir in den anderen parteien so nicht
kennen diese rolle der grauen eminenz
von gehören heute wird ihm den nutzwert
wird aus ihnen nutzen in der nächsten
zeit man vermutet ja dass er
möglicherweise in zwei jahren nach dem
amt des dann erledigten bundes sprechers
greifen wird ist das oder kann sich auch
diese diese funktion der grauen eminenz
als bumerang erweisen die kann sich
natürlich abnutzen weil irgendwann muss
man ja auch konkrete taten ermöglichen
erlebt jetzt zurzeit immer noch von der
ankündigung und anmutung ankündigung der
anmutung inszenierte hier sehr gut auch
mit den anträgen und insofern sind wir
natürlich sehr gespannt wie die debatte
läuft zudem satzungs antrag der die
parteireform dann nach vorne bringen
sollen wo er ja sich selbst eine
zentrale rolle zugeschanzt hat und wenn
diese rolle und dieser satzungs antrag
so durchkäme könnte natürlich so eine
art nebenregierung entstehen von der aus
er dann noch konzentrierter konkreter in
den aufbau und die struktur der partei
hinein wirkt und damit auch die weitere
programmatische und personelle
orientierung der partei festigen könnte
wenn es auf parteitagen immer etwas
unübersichtlich oder turbulent wurde
dann fiel ein immer das zitat von
alexander gauland einen dasein jähriger
haufen kann das sein dass dieser leere
gelaufen jetzt das jährige
verliert dass das nicht mehr so oft
passiert dass einzelne politikerinnen
und politiker auf ihr individuelles
selbstbestimmungsrecht pochen und
sozusagen auf eigene rechnung polit
machen nur der jährige haufen ist in die
jahre gekommen ist ein wenig erschöpft
und das was man hier erlebt ist
eigentlich schon eine klassische
parteitags formation wo die sich
bekämpfenden gegenüber stehenden
strukturen in der lage sind ganz gut
ihre steaks abzustecken auffallend ist
allerdings dass die west- landesverbände
die ja nun das gros der mitglieder
stellen die für den gesamterfolg
maßgeblich sind das die sich hier kaum
zu gehör melden dass sie kaum mit
eigenen initiativen vor brechen insofern
muss man sich mal stärker dafür
interessieren was denn eigentlich deren
zukunft ist von propeller selbst und
anderen ist ja bereits geäußert worden
gebrauchen den westen und da gibt es
vorstellungen von einem zwei stufen
modell das man also für den osten ein
eigenes modell hat und für den westen
aber dafür braucht man auch im westen
der artikulation fähige spitze führung
die sich dieses projektes annimmt und es
könnte sein dass mit diesem parteitag
hier erst mal so was wie eine paralyse
eingetreten ist weil der westen bekommt
hier keinen rückenwind kann es sein dass
man dann im westen resigniert innerhalb
der alv die mitgliedschaft dass man sich
ins private zurück zieht er und dass das
dann weiter die position der asd im
westen weiter schwächt also es gibt drei
möglichkeiten einmal die
rückzugsmöglichkeit die wir haben wir ja
bei frau pro tag jetzt schon erlebt die
nicht mehr kandidiert hat für den
bundesvorstand zweitens ist die option
denkbar dass man sagt man baut eine
eigene partei auf halte ich aber für
sehr unwahrscheinlich weil dafür weder
personen noch zeit da ist das dritte
wäre dass man versucht innerhalb des
eigenen landes verbandes doch ein
eigenes profil mittelfristig aufzubauen
und dann wieder neu in den wettstreit um
die führung der partei einzugreifen gut
soweit professor wolfgang schüler der
gehen schnell zu doris müller es gibt
nämlich ein ergebnis zur wahl des bundes
schatzmeisters das ist richtig danke
alexander keller und der neue und alte
bundesschatzmeister heißt carsten hütter
er ist knapp gewählt worden ist 50 82
prozent auf den herausforderer e-mails
entfielen 47
54 prozent knappe wahl für den
amtsinhaber der auch das
amt des bundes schatzmeisters in den
kommenden
donnerstag innehält und jetzt geht es um
die vorschläge zur wahl des
stellvertretenden bundesschatzmeister
der ebenfalls heute gewählt hat
ich kenne zwei drei andere max auch noch
dann
am blauen so einig wird die kandidatur
von herrn mark von drei
stimmberechtigten teilnehmern
unterstützt von fünf
unterstützt
also derzeit
sehe ich nicht fünf doch jetzt sehe ich
fünf wunderbar so dann
machen wir weiter am blauen saal
mikrofon
sie können einen vorschlag machen vielen
dank viktor hübner kreisverband lippe
nordrhein westfalen ich schlage den
herrn professor doktor harald weil vor
vielen dank
harald weil wurde vorgeschlagen
wird diese kandidatur von fünf
stimmberechtigten teilnehmern
unterstützt
ja das ist der fall wir machen weiter am
roten saal mikrofon
wir machen weiter im roten saal mikrofon
bitteschön haynsburg haus
burghaus wurde vorgeschlagen
[Musik]
gibt es fünf stimmberechtigte teilnehmer
die diesen vorschlag unterstützen
das ist der fall
der burg aus müsste dann noch auf die
liste gesetzt werden
wir machen weiter am rednerpult
schlag herrn e mail sense vor vielen
dank der sense wurde vorgeschlagen gibt
es hierfür fünf unterstützer
das ist der fall
so dann machen wir dann frage ich ob es
weitere vorschläge gibt
das kann ich nicht erkennen dann frage
ich die bereitschaft der kandidaten
ab hier zu kandidieren herr marx
steht zur verfügung herr professor weil
erklärt ja herr burg aus
das habe ich nicht gehört normal bitte
ja
und herr sense
sie stehen nicht zur verfügung dann wird
herr sense gestrichen
so dann
wenn es keine weiteren vorschläge gibt
würde ich die kandidatenliste schließen
lassen wer ist für den schluss der
kandidatenliste
danke schön wer ist dagegen enthält sich
dann ist dies mit großer mehrheit so
beschlossen dann haben wir jetzt drei
kandidaten müssen wir kurz lose
vorbereiten
einer der kandidaten sebastian marx
hatte übrigens gegenwehr tricks von
storch kandidiert als spitzenkandidat
für die bundestagswahl in berlin und er
ist auch teil auf der team zukunft
wunschliste von tino gruppe
so und während wir darauf warten dass
die
fragen wieder gestellt werden gibt es
noch
analysefähigkeiten von alexander keller
ja es gibt vor allem nachfragen und zwar
an norbert kleinwächter
stellvertretender vorsitzender der
bundestagsfraktion der afc und
gegenkandidat unterlegener gegenkandidat
gegen tino keller beim bewerb bei der
bewerbung um das amt des ersten bundes
sprechers wenn es nach dem rhetorischen
talent gegangen wäre klein richterin
hätten sie eigentlich oder wären sie
jetzt erst der bundessprecher warum
haben sie nicht gezündet jetzt darf ich
für die blumen danken nun wissen sie es
gibt natürlich eine art gewöhnung an
europa es gibt auch eine große
wertschätzung seiner person in der
partei und das hat sich natürlich in dem
ergebnis auch ausgedrückt er hat es
gewonnen meine herzlichen glückwünsche
an ihn und gratulationen und viel erfolg
vor allem für die kommenden zwei jahre
im amt ich habe da eine demokratische
alternative angeboten das war wichtig
auch für die seele der partei und das
ergebnis ist so und das ist schön wenn
sie sich jetzt das tableau anziehen das
war jetzt gerade neu gewählt worden ist
es sicher die bundessprecher und die
beiden und eben die drei stellvertreter
könnte es sein dass die position und die
position nennen die sie vertreten in der
afg gerade untergepflügt werden so würde
ich das nicht ausdrücken die partei hat
ja mehrere strömungen und versucht
natürlich auch immer zwischen diesen
strömungen zu vermitteln und das war ja
auch der ansatz den kino copala mit
seinem team das er ursprünglich
vorgestellt hatte verfolgt hat nämlich
dass er sagte ja ich nehme leute aus
unterschiedlichen strömungen auf und
dann werde ich schon irgendwie die
partei repräsentieren das wird
offensichtlich mit einer sehr knappen
aber mit einer mehrheit hier getragen
und insofern wünsche ich dem gewählten
team alles alles gute für die arbeit
eigentlich wollte die afg ja mehr
einigkeit erreichen wenn es jetzt immer
knappe mehrheiten gibt bei solchen
abstimmungen
dann ist eigentlich ja der zwiespalt und
der streit auch für die zukunft
programmiert nicht der streik sondern
die auseinandersetzung und das ringen um
die besten positionen um den besten stil
um das beste auftreten und so muss timo
copala auch sein ergebnis verstehen er
hat ja selbst ein sehr knappes ergebnis
bekommen nach vielen gesprächen die noch
geführt hatte und das muss für ihn
ansporn sein vielleicht auch noch ein
paar dinge besser zu machen wir wollen
doch alle nur das beste für die afg
erreichen wir wollen alle nur das beste
für unser land erreichen dafür müssen
wir stark werden und da müssen wir auch
parteiintern darum ringen und diese
stärker zusammen in ihrer bewerbungsrede
den finger in die wunde gelegt gesagt
die partei macht einen zerstrittenen
druck nach außen wo sehen sie denn immer
noch große defizite in der afg für die
nächste zeit ich denke dass viel mehr
kommunikation nach außen aber wie auch
nach innen zusammen hängt oftmals wissen
die mitglieder beispielsweise nicht und
die wähler erst recht nicht welche
position wir in einer frage denn konkret
tatsächlich haben und das ist ein punkt
wo ich auch tino köhler jetzt sehr
unterstützen werde das zu verbessern
damit eben diese klarheit in zukunft
ganz deutlich besteht weil wir dann auch
weniger unschärfen in der argumentation
haben timo kampala die jetzt gerade auch
bei der presseerklärung noch mal klar
gesagt das würde die stimmen dass die
partei gespalten sei aber besteht die
gefahr der abspaltung dass die die sich
jetzt hier als zu kurz gekommen fühlen
die möglicherweise mit den positionen
des neuen bundesvorstandes nicht mehr
einverstanden sind zumindestens sich ins
private zurückziehen oder vielleicht die
partei auch verlassen das werden ja
nicht die ersten die das in der afg tun
nun ja primär waren das hier
personalfragen und keine großartigen
position finden auch inhaltlich und
zeitlich tatsächlich sehr sehr nahe
bayern an das set und die afg seine
partei die verschiedene strömungen
vereint und wir brauchen auch alle in
der afd es hat keinen sinn in
irgendeiner weise auf zu stecken oder
sich zu separieren sondern wir müssen
erstmal gucken dass wir als konservative
kraft eine große stärke erreichen und
dann hat profitieren wir alle gemeinsam
davon insbesondere deutschland wenn die
alternative für deutschland eine starke
politische tragen sie sind inhaltlich
nah beisammen in der europafrage gibt es
sehr unterschiedliche meinungen der
dexxit der austritt deutschlands aus der
europäischen union der im wahlprogramm
dem bundestagswahlprogramm stand der ist
nicht von allen mitgetragen worden auch
zum thema waffenlieferung ukraine gibt
es unterschiedliche meinungen umfragen
unter den fdp wählern sagen sogar die
mehrheit sei eben für einen schärferen
kurs gegenüber putin diese liebedienerei
wie sie da so sicher dass es dann in der
inhaltlichen auseinandersetzung hier
klare signale nach außen gibt daher
wissen sie wie viele dinge sind auch
technische fragen zum beispiel haben wir
die überzeugung dass eine reform der
europäischen union von innen heraus als
er über den reform artikel nicht möglich
sein wird deswegen fordern wir eben den
austritt und gleichzeitig die neu
schaffung einer neuen europäischen
gemeinschaft eben der zusammenarbeit
souveräner europäischer nationen da
stand natürlich dann dieser begriff
dexxit im programm und da wurde viel
drauf aufgehängt aber es geht uns
prinzipiell tatsächlich darum dass wir
sagen wir wollen im endeffekt eine neue
europäische zusammenarbeit haben die
wird wahrscheinlich nur über den text
gehen und ähnliche fragen haben sie dann
auch bei den waffenlieferungen haben sie
zum beispiel bei sanktionsfrage oftmals
sind die unterschiede in der
argumentation nur im detail gelegen und
das müssen wir eben parteiintern gut aus
diskutieren und dann sehr klar nach
außen vertreten das heißt sie sehen auch
weiterhin für sich eine zukunft in der
afg selbstverständlich das ist meine
partei und ich bin stolz darauf ihr
angehören zu dürfen mitglied des
bundestages für sie sein zu dürfen und
ich wünsche wirklich den neu gewählten
team alles alles gute also die gefahr
dass sich die partei in irgendeiner
weise zerlegt die gab es ja immer im
vorfeld auch dieses bundestagswahl die
ist für sie gebannt auch wenn hier der
geist von leuten immer noch beschworen
wird der offenbar noch da ist man muss
sich ständig von ihm distanzieren obwohl
er ja schon über ein halbes jahr gar
nicht mehr mitglieder partei ist ja
sehen sie das ist natürlich das problem
wenn führungspersonen dann plötzlich
hinschmeißen und gehen und sagen ich
habe von dem laden genug das trägt
natürlich nicht zur motivation bei aber
deswegen sage ich jetzt auch mal
sozusagen als der der als erster
kandidiert hat für eine starke bewegung
in unserer partei ich möchte nicht dass
die leute gehen ich möchte dass die
leute bleiben und ich möchte dass wir
gemeinsam stark werden innerhalb dieser
alternative für deutschland weil dann
die alternative für deutschland stark
wird und damit deutschland stark wird
sie sind ein sogenannter rossi sie sind
im westen geboren aufgewachsen leben
jetzt in ostdeutschland ja von den west
landesverbänden hört man vier so gut wie
nichts auf diesem parteitag obwohl sie
ja eigentlich die mehrheit stellen der
nordrhein westfälische landesverband ist
ja der größte haben sich die
zurückgezogen warum äussern sie sich
nicht der die östlichen landesverbände
auch ihre brandenburg scheint sehr gut
organisiert zu sein 34 dynamisch vor
natürlich besonders björn höcke der von
hinten quasi dem parteitag steuer zu
erscheinen das was ist mit den
westdeutschen in der afg los da sehen
sie viele west verbände setzen auf
sacharbeit und nicht auf die show auf
dem parteitag und das ist der
unterschied warum sie zum beispiel von
west vertretern eher weniger gehört
haben aber wir hatten west kandidaten
wir hatten erika steinbach
beispielsweise wir hatten nikolausfest
die angetreten sind sind alle tödlich
verletzten sind durchgefallen aber mit
sehr guten ergebnissen zum teil wenn ich
mir erika steinbach zum beispiel angucke
während die berliner heute zugelassen
gewesen hätte sie gewonnen mit klaus
festplatte kein so gutes ergebnis
verglichen mit ihnen vor allen dingen
sie war relativ nah dran norbert
kleinwächter im phoenix-interview
bedanke mich dass sie dabei vielen
herzlichen dank betrifft so und wir
geben jetzt gleich weiter es geht mich
mit der wahl zum bundesvorstand den
ganzen tag noch weiter alles weitere
jetzt von doris müller hier fielen dank
alexander kähler genau wir sind zurzeit
in der wahl in dem wahlverfahren wahl
des stellvertretenden
bundesschatzmeister sich wenigen
nachrichten erreichen dass der
bundesschatzmeister inzwischen gewählt
worden ist carsten hütter der alte ist
auch der neue bundesschatzmeister in der
alfsee also er ist dann jetzt auch
mitglied des neuen bundesvorstandes zur
zeit werden wir die fragen an die
kandidaten für die weiteren
bundesvorstandsmitglieder gestellt und
die weiteren kandidaten für die plätze
stellen sich vor es müssen noch fünf
beisitzer gewählt werden ein bundes
schriftführer muss noch gewählt werden
all das dauert noch ein bisschen weil
die rede und die vorstellungs und die
fragezeit sich dann auch bei jeder wahl
als einzelwahl darstellt und dieses wird
dann jetzt in den folgenden minuten und
ein viertelstündchen noch passieren dass
die wahlen hier weiter fortschreiten
hier 30 c gewerbeordnung und makler
nach artikel 16 bauverordnung vor über
25 jahren erworben war da fünf jahre
zuletzt selbstständig beim vertrieb von
finanzdienstleistungen und
finanzierungen und daneben die
20-jährige praxis dass zu lehren als
einen hauptgegenstand an der fh dass man
das ist mein hintergrund dankeschön
vielen dank
die zweite frage stellt benjamin
deutsche ja herr professor weil haben
sie vielleicht noch weitere ideen wie
man neue gelder für die partei
generieren kann ich mein regelmäßige
brief waren die mitglieder mit der bitte
um spenden schön und gut aber meiner
meinung nach muster ein bisschen mehr
kommen wenn man was bewegen wollen
dankeschön ich hatte es ja schon
angesprochen das was am wenigsten
erschlossen ist und was auch irgendwie
seitens der potenziellen geber am
meisten tabuisiert ist ist ja dass wir
nennenswerte spenden von unternehmen
bekommen gerne auch und insbesondere
mittelständischen unternehmen die ja die
wahl haben entweder lassen sich weiter
von der hiesigen standard politik der
standard der mainstream parteien und
medien sozusagen die butter vom brot
nehmen gehen dafür ins ausland machen
die gewinne riesen deutschland nicht
mehr machen können im ausland oder sie
bleiben im lande und nähren sich redlich
wie man es dem mittelstand unterstellen
kann deswegen die
akquirierung von mittelständischen
unternehmen die anonym in entsprechender
stückelung an uns spenden können aber
auch die mitarbeiter die viel weniger
von irgendwelchen gewerkschaften mit
immerhin mehr 100 euro jahresbeiträgen
profitieren können als von uns die wir
die arbeitnehmer interessen vertreten
besser als die etablierten
gewerkschaften oder als von uns die wir
die unternehmensinteressen besser
vertreten als die altbekannten
lobbyisten dankes vielen dank und die
letzte frage stellt herr dorn auf ja
guten tag herr professor weise sind
kreissprecher rheinberg ich bin selber
mitglied
des kreises rheinberg ich will gar nicht
darauf an geben dass seitdem sie
kreissprecher sind mitgliederzahl
gesunken qualität der veranstaltungen
gesunken ist sie auf dem letzten
kreisparteitag als bundes kasper ich
zitiere ich mache mir nun ausdrücklich
zu eigen
bezeichnet werden ich habe eine ganz
andere frage bei den spaziergängen in
bergisch gladbach sind sie mit der
deutschlandfahne mit der banane darauf
gesehen worden die neben ihnen ihr
ratsherrn glattpark getragen hat sie
sind mein glas und micro ist ein
unbehagen ja mache ich wie verträgt sich
das mit dem anspruch einer patriotischen
partei dank die deutsche fahne und die
antwort vielen dank die persiflage fade
haben sie selbst gesagt haben ich
getragen sondern mein stellvertreter und
in dem rahmen in dem es in den protest
rahmen dienstag gab er ist auch nichts
gegen einzuwenden
darüber hinaus sind wir in unserer stadt
und in unserem verein nachdem es da zwei
jahre lang ich war zwei jahre
stellvertretender kreissprecher dann war
ich zwei jahre abwesend es ging viel es
drunter und drüber und negativ aus ich
bin dann nach vier jahren sozusagen
zurückgekehrt und habe den burgfrieden
wieder hergestellt
dankeschön
vielen dank herr professor weil sie sind
mit dank entlassen und dann hören wir
als nächstes die vorstellung von herrn
burghaus
guten tag herr burghaus ich darf sie als
erstes fragen ob eine unvereinbarkeit
mit einem amt im bundesvorstand laut auf
die bundesrats mehr besteht nein das
nicht der fall ich darf sie dann des
weiteren fragen ob ein solches
führungszeugnis eintragung enthielte das
ist auch nicht der fall und ich darf sie
dann noch darum bitten frühere parteien
mitgliedschaften an zwar in der cdu herr
borg aus dann haben sie jetzt fünf
minuten zeit um sich vorzustellen
bitteschön meine damen und herren liebe
parteifreunde
wir wählen in diesem wahlgang den das
amt des stellvertretenden
bundesschatzmeister eine position die
mit sicherheit einen finanzexperten
verlangt und ich kandidiere dafür und
ich bitte um ihre unterstützung mein
name ist haynsburg aus ich bin in
düsseldorf geboren und aufgewachsen
ich habe auch viele jahre in hessen
gelebt meine frau stammt aus cottbus so
dass sie auch enge beziehung nach
brandenburg habe nach einer
kaufmännischen betrieblichen ausbildung
habe ich betriebswirtschaft studiert und
meine so erworbenen kenntnisse in
leitenden positionen in einem der
größten chemiekonzerne der welt zunächst
in deutschland und der schweiz danach in
den usa und später auf allen weiteren
kontinent in leitenden positionen
einbringen können hauptsächlich im
finanz und it bereich meine letzte
position war die finanzdirektor der
deutschen niederlassung mit
ungefähr 6.000 mitarbeitern
durch die ereignisse im jahr 2015 die
uns allen sicher besonders in
unangenehmer erinnerung bleiben habe ich
mich entschlossen der alternative für
deutschland beizutreten ich bin heute
stellvertretender sprecher des
kreisverbands mettmann seit vier jahren
mitglied des konvents wo sich auch
vornehmlich auch mit finanzfragen
betrachtet wird und seit fünf jahren
mitglied des landesvorstands von
nordrhein-westfalen als verantwortlicher
für die finanzen als landesschatzmeister
delegierten noch mal durchfahren sind
wir ganz knapp an einem desaster und
darf es ruhig so nennen vorbeigerutscht
5,4 prozent nach 7,4 prozent in 2017
sind kein ergebnis dass man besonders
stolz sein kann wir haben rund
220.000 das ist ein drittel der stimmen
verloren gegenüber 2017 verloren und
haben sogar 10.000 stimmen an die grünen
abgegeben ein weiterer verlust von rund
36.000
wäre das ende der landtagsfraktion in
nordrhein westfalen gewesen besonders zu
erwähnen ist allerdings dass wir rund
160 stimmen gegen überzeugte gegenüber
2017 verloren haben aufgrund der
verweigerung überhaupt zur wahl zu gehen
das sicher das hat sicherlich mehrere
gründe zwischen in unserer partei aber
auch die tatsache dass wir seit ungefähr
sechs monaten in den medien überhaupt
nicht erwähnt werden nachdem wir
regelmäßig regelrecht beschimpft wurden
werden unsere vertreter einfach
ignoriert zu talkshows erfolgen keine
einladung mehr und erwähnungen unserer
afd in medien findet nur noch statt wenn
man negatives berichten kann meine damen
und herren das muss sich ändern und ich
kann nur für vielen vorrednern hier
heute zustimmen
man muss gespräche mit medien und
kommunikationsexperten einführen ich
würde mich als stellvertretender und
schatzmeister dafür einsetzen für solche
überlebensnotwendige schritte geld in
die hand ich bin kein experte auf dem
gebiet aber ich werde dafür sorgen dass
wir geld in die hand nehmen um eben
solche dinger zeitungen radiostationen
usw zu ermöglichen
der bundesvorstand hat neben den
politischen aufgaben
auch die wesentliche aufgabe die ein
funktionierendes
parteiapparates durch alle
landesverbände zu gewährleisten das
trifft ganz besonders auf die
schatzmeisterei zu
aus diesem grunde werde ich auch hier
auch keine politische rede halten
sondern einige wichtige punkte auf
listen die mir besonders am herzen
liegen und für die ich mich einsetzen
werde spenden akquise ist auch schon ein
paar mal erwähnt worden jede
eingegangene euro wird aufgestockt und
reduziert die begrenzung der staatlichen
teilfinanzierung
ganz wesentlich ist die verbesserung des
ablaufs zu erstellendes
rechenschaftsbericht und servicekosten
hütter hat ausführlich dazu berichtet
schon er hat ganz erhebliches auf den
weg gebracht mit dem pilotprojekt in
sachsen was jetzt auf weitere
landesverbände ausgedehnt wird wichtiges
aber wichtige arbeit hier von den
viertel hier von den schatzmeister in
den landesverbänden verlangen wie
bereits erwähnt ist der dritte punkt die
verbesserung unserer darstellung in den
medien so weit her zu den wichtigen
punkten wie sie mir vorschweben auf den
beiden erstgenannten habe ich dazu
entsprechende erfahrungen sowohl in der
wahlkampffinanzierung als auch durch
meine frühere partei- tätigkeit um eine
frühere berufliche beschäftigung in der
chemischen industrie meine damen und
herren es gibt viel zu tun ich bin dazu
bereit wenn sie mir vertrauen schenken
und mehrere stimme geben vielen dank
dafür schon jetzt und glückauf vielen
dank
gibt es fragen an den kandidaten
burghaus
bis dato nicht möchte noch jemand einen
anmelden
auch nicht der fall dann sind sie eher
brokers ohne fragen gleichwohl mit dank
entlassen und dann hören wir als letztes
noch die vorstellung von herrn mag
guten tag herr mag ich darf sie fragen
ob eine unvereinbarkeit mit einem amt
immer auf die bundesvorstand nach auf
die bundessatzung besteht nein das wird
nicht der fall ich darf sie fragen ob
ein polizeiliches führungszeugnis
eintragungen enthielte nein das ist
gluten rein und dann darf ich hier noch
bitten frühere patenschaften zu benennen
ich bin im jahr 1981 mit zwölf jahren
der union beigetreten und bei der union
gibt so lange geblieben bis eine
alternative gab im februar 2014 bin ich
in der auf die eingetreten vielen dank
dann haben sie herr marx jetzt fünf
minuten zeit um sich vorzustellen dass
menschen unter euch werden sich von dem
programm parteitagen kennen
genussmenschen deswegen weil sie lieber
in einem besser alle sitzen als draußen
bei diesem wetter im schwimmbad sie
werden wie von dem programm parteitagen
kennen in denen ich als mitglied der
bundesprogramm kommission und als leiter
des bundesfachausschusses 4 des familien
kapitel vorgestellt habe heute werde ich
aber nichts zur programmatischen fragen
reden weil es beim stellvertretenden
schatzmeister um fachliche qualifikation
geht ich werde also mich etwas in dieser
richtung darstellen ich habe
wirtschaftsingenieurwesen an der tu
berlin studiert und danach über 20 jahre
kaufmännischer software projekte
eingeführt in kombination mit einer
prozessoptimierung ich hatte einen
schwerpunkt im bereich rechnungswesen
habe dort also verschiedene controlling
kostenrechnung systeme eingeführt bis
hin zur flexiblen krenz plan
kostenrechnung und im bereich der
buchhaltung habe ich große konzerne auch
darin beraten die man in parallelen
jahresabschluss macht ingo s geb und ers
und hgb und bei der mehrstufigen gruppen
konsolidierung habe dort also relativ
einschlägige erfahrungen ich war zweimal
gutachterlich tätig für
wirtschaftsprüfer ich glaube aber die
relevant da für die bewerbung hier ist
der umstand dass sich bei zwei
politischen stiftungen als projektleiter
eines externen dienstleisters die
software und die buchhaltung und
abrechnungssoftware eingeführt habe und
ebenfalls bei einer bundestags partei
die software die buchhaltung eingeführt
habe
mit knapp 10.000 gliederungen ich habe
also einschlägige erfahrungen
rechnungswesen auch in der parteien
buchhaltung nicht nur in der theorie
sondern auch in der praxis
im jahr 2016 wurde ich als einer der
ersten vielleicht sogar ist der erste
auf der politiker ein exekutivamt
gewählt ich bin in berlin-reinickendorf
zum bezirk stadtrat gewählt worden die
berliner bezirke werden von dem
bürgermeister und vier bzw sie jetzt
fünf stadträten gewählt ich habe dort
eine behörde mit 220 mitarbeitern
geleitet das amt für bürgerdienste und
das ordnungsamt und habe dort ein budget
von knapp 20 millionen verantwortlich
und war als sogenannter beauftragter für
den haushalt auch für diesen betrag für
diesen betrag in haftung
vielleicht noch zwei anmerkungen ich
habe meiner ansicht nach ein ganz gutes
händchen für spenden akquise eine
spendenkampagne im rahmen der
bundestagswahl 2021 hat viermal so viel
geld eingespielt wie die parallele
spendenkampagne des landesverbandes wir
hatten dann wird anderen
spendenkampagnen zusammen zur
bundestagswahl am kreisverband ein
budget von 127.000 euro zur verfügung
das ist ganz ordentlich
vielleicht an dieser stelle noch ein
zweiter aspekt wir haben jetzt sehr
viele bewerber die mitglieder des
bundestages sind oder eines landtages
ich glaube das hat auch gute gründe dass
es so ist aber vielleicht werde es im
bundesvorstand auch ganz gut wenn ein
zwei personen darin sieht die keine
berufspolitiker sind das als anregung an
dieser stelle
liebe freunde ich habe in den fünf
jahren die ich bezirksstadtrat wahrlich
wöchentlich öffentlich geäußert war ein
fast jeder lokalzeitung enthalten
meistens wurde ich positiv bewertet
manchmal neutral selten negativ
ich habe in dieser zeit keinen einzigen
skandal produziert trotzdem würde ich es
mir niemals anmaßen zu behaupten ich sei
deshalb ein gemäßigter ich mach
ehrenamtlich auch kommunikations und
rhetorik trainings und ich bin immer
wieder überrascht wie wenig bewusstsein
dafür in unserer partei ist dass das was
man sagt und das was man kommuniziert
zwei grundverschiedene dinge sein können
und jemand der sagt ich bin gemäßigt
kommuniziert kommuniziert damit etwas
ganz anderes er kommuniziert damit dass
wir in dieser partei radikale haben und
in einer rechten partei sind radikale
immer gleich rechtsradikale liebe
freunde ich sehe ich hier in dem saal
aber keine rechtsradikalen
und ich sehe ich auch keine gemäßigten
ich sehe hier 600 patrioten die bereit
sind für ihr vaterland diffamierungen
hass und ausgrenzungen kauf zu nehmen
ich sehe hier 600 mutige frauen und
männer die auch noch standhaft und treu
sind wenn der wind des linken
zeitgeistes ihn mit aller kraft ins
gesicht peitscht liebe freunde ich bin
stolz dass ich teil dieser partei sein
kann und es wäre mir eine ehre dieser
partei im vorstand zu dienen vielen dank
[Applaus]
vielen dank herr mag gibt es fragen an
den kandidaten mag
apropos 600 ich kann ihnen noch ein
bericht der mandats berufungskommission
verkünden um 1435 waren 545 delegierte
akkreditiert
so im das hallo
sodann losen wir jetzt mit zwei karten
die erste frage stellt dr jörg
bretschneider und die zweite frage
stellt michael frisch herr bretschneider
beginnt am
roten saal mikrofon
ja lieber sebastian wir kennen uns seit
mehreren jahren als leitung leitungsteam
im bundesfachausschuss 4 und ich kenne
die stadt als in sachen arbeitern als
einen der immer fleißig und
zielorientiert ist das freut mich und
ich glaube dass du das auch in deiner
arbeit als bezirksstadtrat geleistet
hast kannst du uns bitte zu deinen
themen dort mit denen du gepunktet ast
in der kommunalpolitik etwas mehr
erzählen ja dank in der tat war es so
dass ich relativ schwieriges ressort
bekommen habe denn dem amt für
bürgerdienste war das standesamt
havariert wir hatten dort über 50
prozent krankenstand und acht wochen
wartezeiten auf stapler konnte und
geburtsurkunden war also eine sehr
schwierige situation habe aber
glücklicherweise weil ich ja eine
gewisse erfahrung in der
prozessoptimierung hab war ich in der
lage dieses problem innerhalb von drei
monaten zu lösen also noch in der in der
karenzzeit in der 100 tage
zur zeit die man hat ich habe darüber
hinaus das werden jetzt die
westdeutschen nicht wissen wie es in
berlin abläuft aber es gibt tatsächlich
keine polit terminen bürgerämtern und
ich habe in meiner amtszeit geschafft
das in meinem bezirk nicht nur die
bezirklichen termine abgearbeitet werden
sondern darüber aus 50 prozent dieser
termine noch für andere bezirke zur
verfügung gestanden gestellt werden
konnten ich habe beim ordnungsamt
angefangen verbund einsätze zu machen
der polizei wir haben dort illegale
shisha bars ausgehoben und andere
einrichtungen mit unterkünfte wo sie
müssen zum abschluss kommen insofern
glaube ich dass wir eine art die auch
politiker brauchen die eine
exekutiverfahrung haben wenn wir eines
tages an die regierung kommen sollten
vielen dank und die zweite und letzte
frage stellt herr frisch am roten saal
mikrofon
er mag wir kennen uns ja aus dem bfh 4
und ich hab da eine gute erinnerung an
eine konstruktive zusammenarbeit und ich
habe auch keine zweifel mit blick auf
ihre berufliche qualifikationen dass sie
das amt des schatzmeisters gut ausüben
würden aber es kommen natürlich im
bundesvorstand auch andere
entscheidungen auf sie tun ich habe da
eine frage die mich sehr beschäftigt
sollte im neuen bundesvorstand einen
antrag kommen andreas kalbitz wieder in
die partei aufzunehmen wie würden sie
dann abstimmen und ich würde mich sehr
freuen wenn es eine klare konkrete
antwort geben würde danke
antwort ich glaube eine klare konkrete
antwort ist schwierig wir haben hier ein
parteitag in dem sie eine einigkeit
dieser partei darstellen wollen und wir
sollten uns dementsprechend mit themen
beschäftigen die einigkeit auch
herstellen und aus meiner sicht sollte
eine so grundlegende entscheidung von
einem parteitag getroffen wird und ich
vom vorstand das heißt solange ein
parteitag für eine solche personalie
kein grünes licht gibt sollte eine
entsprechende
aufnahme zunächst einmal zurückgestellt
werden und dementsprechend
glaube ich insgesamt dass wir dass wir
uns wegen solcher dinge nicht
auseinanderdividieren lassen sollten
vielen dank herr mag sie sind mit dank
entlassen und dann meine damen und
herren kommen wir in zwei minuten zur
wahl
noch 15 sekunden anschließen wir die
türen bitte nehmen sie ihre plätze ein
fünf vier drei zwei eins null die türen
werden bitte geschlossen ist wird
niemand mehr rein oder rausgelassen
wir kommen dann jetzt zur wahl des
stellvertretenden bundesschatzmeister
sie haben folgende abstimmungs
möglichkeiten 1 professor dr altweil
zwei haynsburg aus 3 sebastian marx vier
nein zu allen oder fünf enthaltungen ich
hoffe den wahlgang sie haben 40 sekunden
ich darf zwischenzeitlich bekannt geben
dass um 15 uhr 10 548 stimmberechtigte
delegierte akkreditiert waren
so es verbleiben noch zehn sekunden
nehmen sie ihre wahlentscheidung vor
10 der wahlgang ist geschlossen
so ein moment
so ich stelle fest dass keiner der
kandidaten die erforderliche einfache
mehrheit erreicht hat wir treten daher
in einer stichwahl zwischen den beiden
stimmenstärksten
kandidaten einrichtungen wir allerdings
auch erst gemäß unseres beschlusses in
zwei minuten die stichwahl wird dann
durchgeführt zwischen herrn weil und
herrnburg haus
noch eine halbe minute ehe wir die türen
schließen
ja
und dann schließen wir jetzt bitte die
türen es wird niemand mehr rein oder
rausgelassen und wir kommen dann jetzt
zur stichwahl
bei der wahl des stellvertretenden
schatzmeister dass sie haben folgende
abstimmungs möglichkeiten 1 professor
doktor harald weil zwei haynsburg aus
drei nein zu allen vier enthaltungen
die abstimmung ist eröffnet sie haben 40
sekunden
fünf vier drei zwei eins null der
wahlgang ist geschlossen
ich stelle fest
dass der kandidat professor doktor
harald weil die erforderliche einfache
mehrheit erhalten hat ich darf sie
fragen herr professor dr weiß ob sie
ihre wahl annehmen
herzlichen glückwunsch
dann meine damen und herren kommen wir
jetzt zur wahl des schriftführers im
bundesvorstand ich nehme hier für
ich nehme hier für ihre vorschläge und
gehen es gibt bereits einen vorschlag
vom rednerpult aus frau dr
ich schlage frau geriet aus bayern vor
gibt es weitere vorschläge bzw nein ich
muss erst mal fragen ob dieser vorschlag
von fünf stimmberechtigten delegierten
unterstützt wird
das ist der fall
gibt es weitere vorschläge am roten sein
mikrofon
dennis hohloch
wird dieser vorschlag von fünf
delegierten unterstützt
das ist der fall
gibt es weitere vorschläge
am blauen sein mikrofon ich schlage
stefan kreuzer folgen
gibt es ist hierfür fünf unterstützer
das ist der fall
gibt es weitere vorschläge
ich kann nicht erkennen dass da jemand
weitere vorschläge macht dann frage ich
die bereitschaft der kandidaten zu ihrer
kandidatur ab frau wie stehen sie zur
verfügung
das habe ich nicht verstanden noch mal
bitte
ja
hat dass frau wie gesagt
also kommen sie bitte einfach den saal
mikrofon das vereinfachte ist mir auch
jetzt
frau d ja ich stehe zur verfügung vielen
dank dann dennis hohloch
stehen sie zur verfügung
ja
okay dann stefan kreuzer
steht auch zur verfügung dann losen wir
jetzt nein dann wenn es keine weiteren
vorschläge gibt darf ich sie darum
bitten dass wir die kandidatenliste
schließen
danke schön wer ist dagegen
enthält sich dann ist dies einstimmig
wenn auch mit verschwindend geringer
beteiligung so beschlossen
sodann losen wir jetzt die kandidaten
reihenfolge aus
als erstes stellt sich frau wie vor
als zweites herr kräuter
als drittes erholung ich darf dann als
erstes frau ihn nach vorne bitten
guten tag frau schrie ich muss sie als
erstes fragen ob unvereinbarkeiten mit
einem amt im bundesvorstand laut auf die
bundessatzung bestehen 1 bestehen keine
unverträglichkeiten ich darf sie dann
fragen ob ein polizeiliches
führungszeugnis eintragung enthielte
nein keine eintragungen und dann darf
ich sie bitten früher
parteimitgliedschaft anzugeben keine
frau sie haben dann jetzt fünf minuten
zeit um sich vorzustellen bitteschön ja
meine damen und herren liebe freunde
gary tui lange verheiratet mutter von
drei kindern was bringe ich mit für den
job für den ich mich bewerben ich habe
in meinem berufsleben viele interessante
stationen durchlaufen und habe dabei
führen gelernt mit meinen teams habe ich
erfolgreich neue autos entwickelt
zugekaufte firmen integriert verkrustete
führungsstrukturen verflacht und mit
innovativen produkten neue umsatz und
gewinn schieber ausgelöst
schlüssel für den erfolg sind übrigens
immer und überall die mitarbeiter
auf die partei übertragen heißt das
schlüssel für den erfolg ist die basis
ohne basis geht nichts und erfolg kann
man ohne basis schon dreimal nicht haben
und diese basis braucht immer frische
klare gute und parteiübergreifende
botschaften die sie weitergeben kann an
den info-ständen und sie sollte darauf
nicht wochenlang warten müssen sondern
sie sollte zeitig zügig informiert
werden wo der vorstand steht
das sehe ich als eine ganz wichtige
aufgabe für die zukunft aus
denn wenn wir nicht kommunizieren ein
anderer macht es nicht für uns und da
müssen wir schlüssig stimmig und
identisch seien über alle gliederungen
ich arbeite schon seit mehreren jahren
für das soziale gesicht der partei weil
ich das für sehr wichtig halte während
meiner arbeit als leiterin des
bundesfachausschusses für soziales habe
ich maßgeblich mit allem das
sozialkonzept gearbeitet das in kalkar
verabschiedet worden ist und jetzt
im bundesparlament als mitglied des
ausschusses für arbeit und soziales
setze ich diese arbeit fort
vielen dank viele fragen ja passt das
denn überhaupt sein der
wirtschaftsliberalen partei ja liebe
freunde das passt sehr gut es ist
nämlich genau dass er hatte konzept er
hat der vater des wirtschaftswunders
nach dem krieg er hat eine freiheitliche
wettbewerbsorientierte marktwirtschaft
eingeführt die einkommen zu wechseln
allen schichten ermöglicht hat weil er
gefordert hat wohlstand für alle und das
ist auch unsere forderung wohlstand für
die deutschen wohlstand für unser volk
das im moment systematisch verarmt wird
und lassen sie mich noch eines hinzu
fügen diese er hessischer blow nämlich
das zusammenspiel von freier
wettbewerbsorientierte marktwirtschaft
und innovativen unternehmertum auf der
einen seite und soziale verpflichtung
auf der anderen seite für unsere
mitbürger das sind genau es genau die
schablone die die beiden großen
strömungen unser partei harmonisch
zusammenfügt sollte also möglich sein
dass wir einen gemeinsamen
grabenweg finden
[Applaus]
ja und dann sehe ich natürlich für viele
andere das uns nicht mehr viel zeit
bleibt wenn wir der großen
transformationen die bundeskanzler
scholz ist nennt noch etwas
entgegensetzen wollen die bürger
vorabend zu sehen und uns wird mehr und
mehr in die privatsphäre hineinregiert
du willst es warm haben in seiner
wohnung wir müssen mit alles über 21
grad für zu teuer du willst fleisch
essen höchstens ein mal die woche
vielleicht später gar nicht mehr dann
auch das machen wir teurer du willst
autofahren höchstens elektrisch und auch
nur wände der einen parkplatz am
stadtrand leisten kannst und wann du das
aufladen kannst weiß keiner fragt ob
wind und sonne und so weiter und so fort
social kredite stimme das ist noch nicht
alles zukunft aber es ist eine zukunft
die bedrohlich nah vor unserer türe
steht und liebe freunde das ist ja nur
ein kleiner teil des gemacht dass uns
bevorsteht weitere teile sind das
kaputtmachen der sozialkassen durch
zügellose migration die unwägbarkeiten
dass so keine kriegs das herunter
regulieren des mittelstands die
verarmung der unteren 50 prozent unserer
bürger und ganz schlimm die
indoktrination unserer kleinen und
großen kinder von denen heute fast jeder
irgendeine allergie und weitere
körperliche und psychosoziale schäden
mit sich herumträgt liebe freunde das
alles empört uns aber wir müssen diese
empörung hinter uns lassen damit die
wähler uns akzeptiert wir müssen besser
ankommen als sympathischer werden ohne
unsere botschaften zu vergessen denn der
wähler systems akzeptieren muss und das
heißt wir müssen zuerst uns selbst
verkaufen als personen dann die ganze
partei und unsere botschaften das ist
eine alte verkäufer weisheit packen wir
es an lassen wir uns am erfolg messen
der erfolg sind weitere zusätzliche
wählerstimmen vielen dank
vielen dank frau
gibt es fragen an die kandidaten
die erste frage stellt dr einer rothfuß
die zweite frage stellt tobias ponto
die dritte frage stellt karl schwarz wir
beginnen mit herrn doktor rothfuß am
roten saal mikrofon
ja liebe gerät ich habe da ein interview
gesehen auf phoenix wo du sehr in die
zange genommen wurde ist mit ganz
üblichen frühlings die uns als afd ihm
entgegen schlagen und es wurde auch mal
wieder auf heute alles verkürzt und ich
hatte das gefühl dass du dich das sehr
gut geschlagen hast uns sehr gut dagegen
gehalten hast du immer auf die sache
gelenkt hast was kannst du uns mit geben
wie wir aus diesen negativ raming
ausbrechen können dass die medien und
ständig versuchen überzustülpen
antwort vielen dank für die frage wir
müssen natürlich versuchen dieses
narrativ umzudrehen dann liebe freunde
wir wissen am besten wir sind nicht so
wie sie uns beschreiben wir stehen auf
der guten seite und der
verfassungsschutz hat ja fast nichts
gegen uns in der hand das heißt wir
können selbstbewusst auftreten wir
schaffen das und wir sind die guten die
für dieses volk dieses land die bürger
arbeiten
vielen dank
die zweite frage stellt tobias ponto im
roten saal mikrofon
vielen dank frau ruhig gibt es in ihren
augen eine legitimation für russland für
diesen ukraine krieg
antwort antwort das ist nicht die frage
die sich mir stellt die frage ist wie
kommen wir gut aus diesem
kriegsgeschehen raus wir sind wir am
besten positioniert für uns deutsche für
unsere bürger wie verhindern wir dass
sie weiter geld deswegen verlieren und
wie verhindern wir dass weiter unrecht
geschieht
vielen dank und dann kommt die letzte
frage von karl schwarz im roten saal
mikrofon
da brauche ich bin mitglied der jungen
alternative wir sind die zukunft der
partei aber wir sind auch auf die
unterstützung der mutterpartei
angewiesen um ihr zu ohren gekommen dass
sich die fördermitgliedschaft djk bayern
gecancelt haben würden sie dies bitte
begründen
antwort also ist es mir nicht bewusst
dass ich die fördermitgliedschaft
gecancelt habe ich werde das mal
nachprüfen nein ich stehe voll hinter
der jungen alternative das ist doch
selbstverständlich sie sind unsere
zukunft dank
[Applaus]
vielen dank frau wie sie sind mit dank
entlassen und dann hören wir als
nächstes
so also hier ist auf der folie erholung
und herr kräuter aber es ist nach meiner
erinnerung andersrum ich hatte erst denn
kräuter und dann wohl auch gezogen
wenn sich irgendjemand anders erinnert
möge es ist jetzt sagen das ist so
wunderbar dann darf ich als nächstes
herrn kreuzer nach vorne bitten
guten tag herr kräuter ich darf sie dann
als erstes fragen ob unvereinbarkeiten
mit einem amt immer auf die
bundesvorstand nach auf die
bundessatzung bestehen
selbstverständlich nein ich darf sie
dann fragen ob ein polizeiliches
führungszeugnis eintragungen enthielte
auch nein und dann darf ich sie darum
bitten etwaige frühere parteien
geschafften anzugeben für mich gab es
nur eine partei und gibt es nur ich war
in keiner anderen partei außer der afd
vielen dank herr kräuter dann haben sie
jetzt fünf minuten zeit um sich
vorzustellen
vielen dank liebe freunde vor einer
woche wusste ich gar nicht dass ich
heute hier vor euch stehen werde ich
hatte eigentlich nicht vor zu
kandidieren aber wie das so ist wenn die
partei ruft wenn es landesverbände gibt
die sagen kräuter wir brauchen dich dann
kann man immer auf mich zählen da war es
jeder der mit mir zusammengearbeitet hat
entweder ein parteiorganisation privat
oder im deutschen bundestag ich bin
mitglied seit 2013 in der alternative
für deutschland und hoffe dass man meine
arbeit so betrachtet dass sich diese
partei mit geformt habe ich war der
erste kreis sprecher in nrw was ja immer
mal als zerstritten dargestellt wurde im
kreis essen noch zerstritten der mit
einem einstimmigen ergebnis
wiedergewählt wurde meine stärke ist er
an zu einen meine stärke liegt darin in
team zu arbeiten zwar führungsaufgaben
zu übernehmen sich aber in den richtigen
momenten zurückzunehmen und unter mir
ist noch nie sei es im bezirk oder in
kreis- oder sonst wo eine
organisationseinheit auseinander
geflogen
ich bin 2013 in die alternative für
deutschland eingetreten weil sich für
mut zur wahrheit stand die arbeit der
partei war nicht immer leicht aber die
richtung gegen immer nach oben gesagte
man ein medienvertreter egal was ihr
macht es gibt für euch nur eine richtung
wir wissen gar nicht mehr was wir machen
sollen ihr könnt den gröbsten unfug
machen ihr werde trotzdem gewählt jetzt
haben wir ein problem es geht nicht
immer nur nach oben ich bewerbe mich
hier zwar als schriftführer damit für
einen reinen arbeit job ich hoffe dass
sie mir den zutraut aber ich möchte auch
noch ein paar worte zur parteilos werden
ich habe intensiv im letzten jahr
wahlkampf gemacht erst im
bundestagswahlkampf dann den landtag
wahlkampf um die haben die wähler gesagt
wieso wir euch nicht wählen oder
schwierigkeit mit der fdp haben ist
einmal die zerstrittenheit und zweitens
dass man von uns nicht hören so das
stück zerstrittenheit kann ich nur sagen
die wird natürlich herbeigeschrieben von
den medien nichts desto trotz gibt es in
unserer partei immer wieder streithähne
damit muss aufhört wir müssen uns
professionalisiert und wir müssen
zusammenstehen wir sind die letzte
chance für dieses land
wenn wir zu den medien kommen man hört
von uns nichts ja das ist so erst sind
eher belächelt worden dann sind wir
bekämpft wurden dann hieß es wir stellen
sie inhaltlich und als auch das nicht
klappte weil wir einfach die richtigen
und besseren argumente hat man uns
totgeschwiegen die situation ist so ich
habe mich letztes jahr mit dem
geschäftsführer eines
meinungsforschungsinstitutes unterhalten
sagte mensch ihr habt es geschafft von
null auf zehn prozent zu kommen ihr habt
in deutschland zehn prozent stammwähler
das ist ein gigantisches erlebnis oder
aber als um als große volkspartei
wahrgenommen zu werden dafür braucht es
ein bisschen mehr dafür müssen wir mehr
stimmen haben und das sind die
protestwähler und diese protestwähler
sind uns in der letzten zeit
abhandengekommen es hieß die letzten
neun bis zehn wahlen hätten wir verloren
verloren haben wir sie nicht wir haben
für unsere verhältnisse gute ergebnisse
eingefahren nur dieser große hype ist
weg und jetzt geht nicht nur fahren auf
sicht jetzt brauchen wir strategien wir
brauchen eine taktik und da müssen uns
daran halten und die umsetzen und dafür
ist ein schlagkräftiger bundesvorstand
nötig an dem ich gerne mitarbeiten
möchte
wir sind keine establishment partei
davon sind wir noch weit entfernt und
ich hoffe dass wir dort nie hinkommen
werden wir brauchen strategien wir
müssen den shadow ben bei den sozialen
medien durchbrechen wenn ihr mich fragt
wir brauchen einen eigenen radiosender
wir brauchen einen eigenen fernsehsender
das ist inzwischen dieser partei schon
fast ein running gag geworden weil alle
sich das vorgenommen haben das zu machen
und die projekte sind dann eingeschlafen
ich sage euch mit mir im vorstand wir
dieses thema angegangen und ich werde so
lange nicht locker lassen bis wir es
umgesetzt haben
wir brauchen außerdem mehr mitmacht
politik wir brauchen ein relais system
ist es relativ einfach die algorithmen
auszutricksen indem man bürger
interessierte politisch interessierte
bürger parteimitglieder mitnimmt die
gewisse nachrichten nach einem
bestimmten system in die öffentlichkeit
tragen dieses release system müssen wir
aufbauen wir brauchen weiter ein
politisches vorfeld ist es gut dass wir
uns von einigen kritischen kräften
distanzieren wir dürfen uns aber nicht
durch die medien getrieben von allem und
jedem distanzieren wir brauchen wie
andere parteien auch ein politisches
vorfeld
menschen bürger familien väter mütter
die sich für unsere belange die
deutschen belange unseres landes
einsetzen wir brauchen aber auch den
richtigen vorstand ein vorstand der
führt der nicht zerstritten ist und vor
allem dingen der keine informationen
durch sticht man kann nicht immer einer
meinung sein aber so eine
zerstrittenheit wie in den letzten
jahren an den tag gelegt wurde so etwas
darf man nicht geben ich kommen so
langsam zum ende wir brauchen die
strategie wir brauchen keine cdu oder
fdp 2.0 da wählt der bürger lieber das
original wir müssen eine protestpartei
eine oppositionspartei bleiben und die
alternative für deutschland die zeiten
politisch stehen gut die probleme in
diesem land komme zum schluss nehmen
überhand energie unsicherheit etc warum
sollen sie mich wählen ich halte druck
aus ich habe nie schlecht über einen
kollegen geredet ich bin verschwiegen
und ich bin teamfähig mein name stefan
reuter 49 jahre aus nrw und nrw solches
berücksichtigt werden vielen dank vielen
dank
gibt es fragen an herrn kräuter
eine gibt es mehr als eine frage
das kann ich nicht erkennen und es ist
auch der ausfall von herrn genau er
genau dann können sie jetzt ihre frage
stellen bitteschön
vielen dank lieber stefan für deine rede
ich hab dich ja in berlin kennengelernt
als der umtriebigen und arbeitswilligen
mdb so wie man das eigentlich immer aus
nrw kennt deswegen ist dieser posten des
schriftführers für dich auch genau der
richtige meiner meinung nach meine frage
geht dahin hast du erfahrung als
schriftführer wir sind keine
vorkenntnisse und was qualifiziert sich
insbesondere für diesen posten vielen
dank
antwort ja hannes vielen dank dafür
warum traue ich mir zuerst mal möchte
ich an die praxis verweisen wenn der
jörg schneider in den landesgruppen
sitzungen nicht da war bin ich gefragt
worden ob ich protokollführer und mehr
ist aus meiner landesgruppe im bundestag
keine klage zu den protokollen gekommen
ich habe damals mich ehrenamtlich beim
roten kreuz engagiert habe da auch
protokolle gefertigt war in der freien
wirtschaft über jahrzehnte wo ich
aufsichtsratssitzung und
vorstandssitzungen geschäftsleitungs
runden protokolliert habe mit der
nötigen sorgfalt ich war sieben jahre
bei der deutschen bank und wenn man da
keine gründlichkeit gelernt hätte dann
wäre man da falsch am platz gewesen
vielen dank herr kräuter sie sind mit
dank entlassen und dann hören wir die
letzte kandidatenvorstellung für die
position des schriftführers
das ist dennis hohloch
ja denn ist wohl auch der letzte
kandidat für die wahl des schriftführers
der bundes schriftführer joachim kues
der derzeitige tritt nicht mehr an ich
darf und dass
der bewerber einer der bewerber für die
wahl eines neuen
die bundessatzung bestehen
ich darf sie fragen ob ein polizeiliches
führungszeugnis eintragung enthielte
nein ich darf sie darum bitten etwaige
frühere parteien mitgliedschaften
anzugeben anderthalb jahre spd in meiner
jugend alles klar dann haben sie jetzt
fünf minuten zeit um sich vorzustellen
vielen dank sehr geehrte damen und
herren liebe mitstreiter mein name ist
denn es soll auch ich bin 33 jahre alt
vater einer wunderbaren tochter und
verheiratet ich bin gebürtiger potsdamer
und war bis zu meinem einzug in den
landtag brandenburg im september 2009
zehn lehrer für die fächer geografie und
geschichte in berlin ich habe über
sieben jahre kommunalpolitische
erfahrungen gesammelt habe die
stadtfraktion in potsdam unserer
landeshauptstadt in brandenburg geführt
und habe auch dort 2018 als
oberbürgermeisterkandidat kandidiert und
wurde kürzlich erst einstimmig von
meinem kreisverband zum
kreisvorsitzenden wiedergewählt
lieber mitstreiter es ist mir eine
wirklich große ehre heute vor ihnen für
euch zu stehen diese entscheidung für
unser höchstes gremium zu kandidieren
die trifft man nicht leicht die trifft
man nicht in kürze sondern die will man
sich reiflich überlegen und das geht
natürlich nicht nur noch für denjenigen
der hier vorne steht es gilt auch für
alle anwesenden delegierten hier im saal
denn die aufgabe vor der wir stehen ist
einen bundesvorstand zu wählen der
unsere partei in einer denkbar schweren
krise übernimmt wir lernen oder wir
sehen aus den rahmen gesehen in den
letzten monaten dass wir vor allem in
den alten bundesländern immer wieder
wählerschichten nicht angesprochen haben
wählerschichten verloren haben und dort
anscheinend mit unseren mit unseren
inhalten nicht wirklich die wähler
überzeugen konnten wir lernen aber und
wir sehen aber auch dass wir eine fc in
den neuen bundesländern erleben die
trotz verlusten immer noch eine hohe
anziehungskraft kraft auf die menschen
dort hat
und
was wir trotzdem nicht wegdiskutieren
können ist wenn sich zum beispiel in
unserem afd kern land sachsen eine
vermeintliche alternative zu unserer
alternative bildet dann können wir das
als af.de nicht hinnehmen hierauf muss
der kommende bundesvorstand eine antwort
finden und ich bin der festen
überzeugung dass diese antwort nicht mit
einer verlängerung der unvereinbarkeit
vista liegen kann liebe freunde
liebe freunde wenn wir ehrlich sind dann
müssen wir auch sagen dass wir in den
letzten jahren unter unseren
möglichkeiten geblieben sind denn das
liegt nicht an unseren themen es liegt
nicht an unseren inhalten dass man uns
nicht wählt über 50 prozent der
deutschen stimmen mit unserer
migrationspolitik überein eine mehrheit
der deutschen stimmt mit unserer
familienpolitik überein wir müssen uns
also fragen woran liegt es dass wir
dieses wählerpotenzial nicht ausschöpfen
können und das liegt daran dass wir uns
nicht immer professionell verhalten
es liegt an einem nicht professionellen
auftritt nach außen es liegt daran dass
die partei im inneren zerstritten ist
und es liegt daran dass wir nicht
kampagnenfähig waren in den letzten zwei
jahren und auf krisen nicht schnell
genug reagiert haben und daraus
und daraus müssen wir für uns alle die
wir sind schlussfolgerungen ziehen denn
wir müssen professioneller werden wir
müssen auf diese krisen schneller
reagieren wir müssen kampagnenfähig
werden und diese situation in
deutschland für uns nutzen wenn wir
dieses land verändern wollen und das
sage ich hier auch als recht junger
kandidat wir müssen alles tun was uns
die anderen parteien schon lange voraus
haben wir müssen endlich unseren
nachwuchs fördern es gibt in dieser
partei keine richtige nachwuchsförderung
das muss sich ändern denn es sind genau
diese jungen leute die von anfang an ihr
leben in die waagschale werfen für
dieses land einstehen und ihre
bürgerliche existenz aufs spiel setzen
und diesen menschen müssen wir nicht
unseren respekt zollen sondern wir
müssen wirklich etwas für sie tun und
dafür werde ich mich im bundesvorstand
einsetzen liebe freunde
[Applaus]
und wir stehen hier natürlich auch vor
großen herausforderungen denn unser land
und das sehen wir alle und das haben
viele trainer vor mir auch schon erwähnt
es krankt es krankt an einem altparteien
kartell an einem start funk und einer
internationalen zivilbevölkerung mafia
die ihre links liberale agenda in alle
teile unseres staates und unserer
gesellschaft getragen hat und wir als
afd wir sind die lösungen wir müssen
diese lösung aus dieser probleme seien
und damit geht eine riesige
verantwortung einher die wir wahrnehmen
müssen und wer diese verantwortung ernst
nimmt der weiß dass es eben nicht reicht
sich als gegenentwurf zu den grünen zu
etablieren sondern der muss wissen dass
wir in diesem land auch wenn wir eine
opposition sind die machtfrage stellen
müssen wenn man uns fragt ob wir dieses
land verändern wollen ob wir die macht
wollen dann muss die antwort heißen ja
wir wollen die macht in diesem land wir
wollen sie in brandenburg wir wollen sie
in sachsen wir wollen sie in
nordrhein-westfalen und wir wollen sie
schlussendlich auch im bund liebe
freunde das muss das zeichen dieses
parteitags nach außen sein dass wir als
ard gemeinsam nach vorne gehen wir
dieses land verändern und den menschen
nur draußen die ihre hoffnung in uns
setzen diese hoffnungen auch erfüllen
und wir dieses land zum wohle unserer
kinder und auch zum wohle meiner tochter
zum besseren verändern beenden vielen
dank
soweit die bewerbungsrede und dennis
hole
dereinst ein eigenartiges
aufeinandertreffen nicht ganz ohne
körperliche
auseinandersetzung mit dem ehemaligen
parteikollegen andreas kalbitz hatte
die erste frage stellt stellt irmhild
borsdorf
die zweite frage stellt severing köhler
die dritte frage stellt dimitri schulz
frau borsdorf
sie sind zuerst dran
und ich schalte dafür dass blaue
mikrofon frei bitte finden
häufig werden dankbar wenn sie mal
richtig aussprechen könnten ich bitte um
entschuldigung frau posthof kein problem
herr hole aus die sind bildungspolitiker
in brandenburg brandburg es meines
wissens das bundesland mit den
schlechtesten schule lernergebnissen
könnten sie dazu kurz was sagen danke
antwort ja selbstverständlich sage ich
dazu gerne was das liegt daran dass die
kanzlergattin bei uns in brandenburg die
bildungsministerin stellt und wir seit
30 jahren spd-regierung haben aber das
ist etwas was wir in den bildungs
ausschlüssen und immer wieder klar und
deutlich gemacht haben was wir nicht
akzeptieren unsere kanzler gattin britta
ernst verfolgt hier einen kurs des
scheiterns wir haben es immer wieder
deutlich gemacht auch während der korona
pandemie das einzige partei die lösung
auf die bildungspolitischen probleme
unserer kinder und der zukunft hat die
ard ist auch in brandenburg und ich bin
besonders stolz dass meine
landtagsfraktion gerade bei diesem
themenfeld einen schwerpunkt setzt und
auch immer gut in der presse erwähnt
wird und ich denke dass es etwas wenn
die fdp in brandenburg gewählt wird was
der vergangenheit angehören wird
vielen dank die nächste frage stellt
severin köhler am blauen saal mikrofon
ja vielen dank denis wie kriegen wir so
wie in cottbus im westen und auch in der
ganzen bundesrepublik große mengen
menschen auf die straße in unserem sinne
antwort also es ist ja schon möglich
auch in westdeutschland also den alten
bundesländern sage ich lieber solche
masten auf die man auf die beine zu
stellen ich war einmal in göppingen hat
dort gesprochen dort stand nicht auf
circa 250 leuten eine sehr schöne
veranstaltung allerdings muss man
natürlich sagen dass die
grundvoraussetzungen bei uns in den
neuen bundesländern natürlich anders
sind und dafür muss man verständnis
haben aber das ist auch das was ich in
meiner rede gesagt haben wir sollten
hart in der sache sein wir sollten
unsere inhalte nicht verbiegen wir
müssen aber klar in dem sein was wir tun
und wir mussten professor nach außen
wirken man kann die dinge die wir sagen
die inhalte die wir meinen klar und
deutlich aussprechen ohne dass man
irgendeine ecke gestellt werden kann und
ich denke das habe ich mit meiner arbeit
im landtag brandenburg bis jetzt auch
sehr gut gezeigt
vielen dank
und dann stellt die letzte frage dimitri
schulz am roten saal mikrofon also es
erstmal danke denn ist dass du als
junger vater den mut hass und die zeit
findet für den bundesvorstand zu
kandidieren das finde ich gut die frage
ist du bist ja lehrer und wie kannst du
deine expertise
in das amt des schriftführers mitbringen
antwort ja ich habe mir die kann ich ja
schon natürlich wirklich reiflich
überlegt und auf welcher position ich
gehe jetzt lehrer bin ich natürlich des
deutschen mächtig ich kann schreiben ich
kann sogar sehr gut schreiben wenn ich
das was du selbst beurteilen darf und
bin natürlich in der lage diese
erfahrung mit einzubringen und ich denke
auch vor allem dass bildung in den
nächsten jahren ein wirklich wichtiges
thema bleiben wird und auch werden wird
wir erleben aktuell dass gerade das
thema bildung was aktuellen den ländern
angesiedelt ist immer mehr in den bund
verlagert werden soll das heißt also es
wird auch ein bundespolitisches thema
bleiben und denken sie alle dran meine
damen und herren gerade das thema koma
wird uns im herbst wieder ereilen und
auch unsere bildungsministerin hat
durchblicken lassen gegebenenfalls
wieder schulen zu schließen und ich
denke da muss die afg mit einer ganz
klaren kampagne nach vorne gehen nie
wieder schulschließungen in diesem land
vielen dank herr uhr los sie sind mit
dank entlassen meine damen und herren in
zwei minuten wählen wir dann den
schriftführer
so das ist weder die zweiminütige pause
die nach jeder wahl bewerbungsrede und
den kandidaten
vorstellungen inklusive der fragerunde
getätigt wird um die delegierten in den
saal zu bitten und dann die türe und
schließen zu lassen für die garantie
einer geheimen wahl in die dann
natürlich per automatischer oder
elektronischer stimmkarte durchgeführt
wird
drei kandidaten stehen zur auswahl für
die wahl des schriftführers
gerät hui den neu im bundestag ist und
vom landesverband bayern ist auch sie
steht als wunschkandidaten auf der liste
vom team zukunft das kino gruppe
mehr oder weniger
verlautbart hat lassen und die anderen
beiden kandidaten haben sie gerade noch
den letzten gehört und stefan reuter
ebenfalls als kandidat für die wahl des
gesehen sekunden
3210 und türen werden bitte geschlossen
wir kommen wenn die türen geschlossen
sind
das sind sie jetzt
zur wahl des schriftführers sie haben
folgende abstimmungs möglichkeiten 1
gary 22 stefan kräuter 3 dennis hohloch
vier nein zu allen fünf enthaltung ich
eröffne den wahlgang sie haben 40
sekunden
nachzureichen bleibt mir dann noch in
der abfolge dessen was hier an personal
schon entschieden worden ist der name
des bundes schriftführers
bundesschatzmeister des
stellvertretenden bundesschatzmeister
das ist harald weil er hat sich bei der
wahl durchgesetzt er ist mitglied des
bundestages und
hat diesen posten inne
bitte nehmen sie ihre wahlentscheidung
vor noch zehn sekunden
so die abstimmung läuft zehn sekunden
und jetzt wird das ergebnis eingeblendet
10 die abstimmung ist geschlossen
und ich stelle fest
dass keiner der kandidaten die
erforderliche einfache mehrheit erreicht
hat wir treten daher in eine stichwahl
mit zwischen den beiden stimmenstärksten
kandidaten ein dies sind dennis hohloch
und stephan kreutz die türen sind wieder
offen und in zwei minuten fahren wir
dann mit der stichwahl fort
ja die kandidatin aus bayern neue
bundestagsabgeordnete seit der
wahlperiode
2021 hat es also in der abfolge nicht
geschafft und zieht sich als diejenigen
mit den wenigsten stimmen dann aus der
stichwahl zurück das ist automatisch und
jetzt geht es nur noch um die frage von
den beiden restlichen kandidaten stefan
kreuzer und dennis voll auf die dann
jetzt in die stichwahl gehen und man
wird sehen welches ergebnis die partei
für die beiden aus stimmen wird
das wahl prozedere für den kompletten
neuen bundesvorstand der dann zwei jahre
lang seine arbeit tätig ist zäh aber
notwendig für jede partei die
personalentscheidungen trifft und es
bleibt abzuwarten ob dann der parteitag
sich mit den inhalten heute nach diesen
wahl marathon noch beschäftigen oder
auch nicht es geht ja noch um das thema
europa die frage wie sich die afd das
europapolitische zusammensein der
einzelnen länder vorstellt und was sie
für positionen verteidigt oder auch
erweitert festlegt und ihr verhältnis zu
waffenlieferungen das aber später jetzt
das ergebnis zur wahl des schriftführers
in der stichwahl zur stichwahl bei der
wahl des schriftführers sie haben
folgende abstimmungs möglichkeiten 1
stefan kräuter 2 dennis hohloch 3 nein
zu allen vier enthaltung ich hoffe den
wahlgang sie haben 40 sekunden
40 sekunden zeit um die stichwahl zu
entscheiden der brandenburger
landtagsabgeordnete dennis hohloch
kandidiert also für das amt des
schriftführers und
hatte sich im vorfeld allerdings
vehement gegen eine wiederaufnahme von
auftritten gegen vor dafür auch ein
halbes ausgesprochen aber das thema wird
hier auf dem parteitag überhaupt nicht
behandelt
fünf vier drei zwei eins null der wagen
ist geschlossen
und ich stelle fest
ja dann doch eine mehrheit für den es
nur noch 55 68 prozent wir sehen uns
hier eingeblendet
und darf er ist damit sowohl für uns als
erfolgreicher und durchgegangen und wird
der neue schriftführer im bundesvorstand
der fdp des bundesvorstandes die
landläufig auch beisitzer genannt werden
bis zu sechs sind zu wählen und wir
beginnen mit der wahl des ersten von
sechs beisitzern hierfür nehme ich ihre
vorschläge an den saal mikrofonen
entgegen
die sechs beisitzer
komplettieren dann den gesamten
bundesvorstand damit wird der künftige
bundesvorstand
14 köpfe so haben wir nach gezählt das
final im neuen gewand seine arbeit
aufnehmen ab montag und die restlichen
sechs werden jetzt die beisitzer gewählt
in einem einzel warf erfahrung
wenn das niemand möchte frage ich an dr
doch
am blauen saal mikrofon bitte schulden
ist frei geschaltet können loslegen
doktor christina baum
frau dr baum wurde vorgeschlagen gibt es
weitere vorträge am roten sein mikrofon
matthias vogler
vogler wurde vorgeschlagen und dann am
blauen sein mikrofon bitteschön
ich schlage jürgen braun form
gibt es
so ich hatte übrigens gerade vergessen
bei frau baum abzufragen gibt es hierfür
5 unterstützt
das ist der fall gibt es für 1 vogler
fünf unterstützer
das ist der fall und dann gibt es für
herrn braun 5 unterstützer
wunderbar dann darf herr braun auch auf
die liste
gibt es weitere vorschläge
ich kann nicht erkennen dass noch jemand
einen vorschlag machen möchte dann frage
ich die bereitschaft der kandidaten zur
kandidatur ab herr dr jungen
ich
trete an vielen dank hatte nicht in die
richtige richtung geschaut tut mir leid
frau dr baum
erklärt nein frau dr baum ist dann von
der liste zu streichen
herr vogler sie stehen auch zur
verfügung und herr braun
steht auch zur verfügung dann losen wir
nein dann darf ich jetzt sie darum
bitten dass wir die kandidatenliste
schließen wer ist für den schluss der
kandidatenliste
danke schön wäre es dagegen
wer enthält sich dann ist dies mit
großer mehrheit so beschlossen und dann
losen wir jetzt die reihenfolge der
kandidaten vorstellungen aus das dauert
einen moment
ja auch hier auf dieser liste des ersten
beisitzers findet sich ein name den kino
kubala gerne in seinem team zukunft
sehen möchte markierungen allgemeinhin
gilt er bei vielen experten als der
chefideologe in der afg hat im
bundestagswahlprogramm mitgearbeitet als
ersatzprogramm ihr der afg mitgearbeitet
und
bewirbt sich hier für den ersten weise
zahl im neuen bundesvorstand matthias
vogler und jürgen braun komplettieren
die
wahlliste matthias vogl
aus dem landesverband bayern
so
da hätte der erste kandidat einzug auf
die bühne und wird gleich guten tag herr
unvereinbarkeiten mit einem amt im
fdp-bundesvorstand nach auf die
bundessatzung besteht das ist nicht der
fall ich darf sie fragen ob ein
polizeiliches führungszeugnis
eintragungen enthielte
nein das ist nicht der fall und ich darf
sie darum bitten etwaige frühere partei
mitgliedschaften anzugeben
ja ich war mal in der cdu meine letzte
funktion in der cdu war irgendwie so
mitte der 80er ende der 80er jahre
und da können sie sich vorstellen da war
ich noch zum eg das reicht schon als
auskunft vielen dank und dann herr braun
haben sie jetzt fünf minuten zeit um
sich vorzustellen bitteschön
liebe freunde
liebe freunde der einzigen
freiheitlichen partei in deutschland
liebe freunde hier in riesa
wir haben gestern den 17 juni gehabt
den siebzehnter juni den volksaufstand
wir sind die einzige partei in
deutschland die auch heute für die
freiheit steht und gegen sozialistische
experimente gegen die ganzen neo öko
sozialistischen experimente die unser
land kaputt machen und das muss so
bleiben
ich bin jetzt mittlerweile 60 jahre alt
und
ich habe noch erlebt das ist normal war
bin ja so alt dass man männer und frauen
am aussehen unterscheiden konnte ich
habe noch erlebt dass es zwei
geschlechter gegeben hat
stellen sie sich das mal vor ich habe
noch erlebt dass die nachrichtensprecher
und
fernsehsendungen und talksendungen und
im radio
dass die nicht sich mit schluckauf
auseinandergesetzt haben und
irgendwelche
innen oder außen oder wie auch immer
vertreten haben ich habe noch erlebt ich
habe noch erlebt dass es in deutschland
freiheitlich war und dass man in diesem
land seine meinung sagen konnte wie wir
das über jahrzehnte gewohnt sind in
diesem land
ja und wir sind jetzt an dem punkt dass
diese unsere freiheit die für uns
selbstverständlich war gefährdet ist ich
bin 60 jahre alt
ich bin seit 27 jahren mit derselben
frau verheiratet darf man vielleicht
auch nicht mehr weil sich wird demnächst
wahrscheinlich auch verboten zwei
erwachsene kinder bin seit kurzem
großvater bin sehr stolz darauf und ich
sage warum ja warum tust du dir das an
jürgen
sagen andere zu mir warum tust du dir
das an papier sagt meine tochter zu mir
weil ich möchte dass meine kinder und
enkel so in freiheit leben können wie
wir das selbstverständlich über
jahrzehnte in der bundesrepublik
deutschland gewohnt waren ich will diese
bundesrepublik deutschland zurück die
wir hatten ich will dieser nicht
gefährden das ist das entscheidende
ich will
dass unsere kinder zukunft haben und
unsere kinder und auch noch die enkel
ich bin gegen die industrialisierung
gegenwind radwan gehen gender unsinn
gegen diesen ganzen sprach schimmel der
alles kaputt macht ich bin gegen den
ganzen rot grün linken wahnsinn wir sind
ja unterwegs auf dem grünen rot-grünen
linksgrünen narrenschiff utopia von dem
franz josef strauß gesprochen hat und
heute ist es so die fdp macht damit das
ist nicht mehr ein rot-grünes
narrenschiff alleine und die cdu und csu
auch hier in sachsen die möchten gerne
mit dabei sein auf diesen linksgrünen
grün-linken narrenschiff utopia als
leichtmatrosen möchten die auch anheuern
und in den bundesländern wo die union
koalition mit den grünen macht da wird
alles entsprechend vor die hunde gehen
das ist der punkt wir brauchen
eine klare eine klare ausrichtung für
den weiterhin freiheitlichen kurs dieser
partei und wer wenn ich diese
alternative für deutschland wenn nicht
wir sind in der lage unser land wieder
in eine sichere freiheitliche und
friedliche zukunft zu führen wer wenn
nicht wir und
wir haben
wir haben die große situation die große
herausforderung dass alle anderen
parteien eine gigantische lücke für uns
lassen unser vaterland ist in gefahr
wohlstand ist in gefahr
armut droht energiemangel
alles das ist zum greifen nahe und da
können wir uns nicht länger streiten
hier um die genauen ziele um personen
wir sind die alternative für deutschland
wir stehen zusammen und schauen in die
zukunft und sagen ja in niedersachsen
und in hessen im nächsten jahr ihr könnt
uns wählen wir sind und bleiben die
verlässliche alternative für deutschland
wir
und niemand sonst mein name ist jürgen
braun 60 jahre alt zwei kinder und ein
enkelkind
ich bitte um ihr vertrauen
vielen dank herr braun
gibt es fragen an den kandidaten
das ist der fall
jürgen braun vom landesverband baden
württemberg mitglied des deutschen
bundestages wird es jetzt in fragen der
delegierten stellen stocker 3 in der
länge von jeweils 30 sekunden
inhalte sind immer eine wundertüte für
denjenigen der dort oben steht dritte
frage stellte siegbert frank dröse ich
darf herrn müller ans mikrofon bitten
bitteschön eine halbe minute haben sie
hallo
herr braun sie haben sicher in der
bundestagsfraktion
vehement für waffenlieferungen und
sanktionen gegen russland eingesetzt
gegen den gegen die mehrheit der
fraktion wollen sie damit frieden
schaffen wollen sie damit unsere kinder
dass das risiko aussetzen dass wir noch
mal in einen krieg rein schlittern
antworten
ich habe nicht das stimmt so nicht ich
habe mich nicht vehement für
waffenlieferungen eingesetzt und ich
habe mich auch nicht vehement dafür
ausgesprochen wirtschaftssanktionen zu
machen wir haben uns in der fraktion mit
großer mehrheit und da habe ich
mitgewirkt wir haben uns geeinigt in der
fraktion dass wir den
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieg
verurteilen und das für
wirtschaftssanktionen ablehnen die unser
volk stärker schädigen als jeden
angreifer das ist vollkommener konsens
in der afg bundestagsfraktion bitte hier
keine legenden verbreiten und das ist
auch selbstverständlich so wird sollten
uns nicht ins eigene fleisch schneiden
nur weil die altparteien die
energiepolitik an die wand gefahren
haben dürfen wir jetzt nicht sagen ja
wir machen sanktionen egal was mit
erdgas mit erdöl in zukunft in
deutschland ist die deutsche industrie
die dort menschen in deutschland dürfen
nicht darunter leiden dass man
sanktionen macht die nicht richtig
überlegt sind völlig einverstanden
vielen dank
dann stellt die zweite frage uwe von
wangenheim
bitteschön am roten saal mikrofon hallo
jürgen
irgend ist jetzt meine meinung als
bundestagsabgeordneter gibt es nicht
eine enthaltung da gibt es in vier
jahren ein und warum hast du dich bei
der das wichtigen fragen der
waffenlieferung enthalten
antwort es
gibt auch die möglichkeit der enthaltung
es ist so uwe lieber ubs es so und es
ist einfach so dass der antrag mir nicht
gefallen hat der antrag der dargestellt
wurde deswegen konnte ich dem nicht
zustimmen aber es ist natürlich so dass
wir als partei des deutschen
nationalstaates
selbstverständlich allen völkern dieser
welt zu billigen in einem nationalstaat
in sicheren grenzen zu leben und das
gilt für die balten die esten letten
litauer genauso viel wie für die polen
das gilt aber auch für die ukraine
und deswegen bin ich natürlich als
normaler mensch der angriffskriege
ablehnt an dieser in dieser frage auf
der seite der ukraine das ist
naheliegend das ist absolut naheliegend
in dieser frage und wir können es
niemanden in deutschland niemanden in
deutschland weiß machen dass wir eine
zukunft haben als partei
wenn wir sagen wir verteidigen jeglichen
angriffskrieg dann haben wir ein problem
vielen das ist einfach so
und die letzte frage stellt herr dröse
am roten sein mikrofon vielen dank herr
vorsitzender jürgen du hast gehört die
partei will hier mehrheitlich heute
ausgehend von diesem bundesparteitag den
aufbruch wir brauchen für die zukunft
der partei mache leute die nicht nur
schön reden sondern richtig mit anfassen
du weißt du warst selber pdf in der
ersten hälfte der 19 wahlperiode im
bundestag bis nicht wiedergewählt wurden
du hast uns einen wunsch seiner frage
kommt meist wunderbar von einem newsroom
gesprochen ist nie was draus geworden
hältst du dich für einen macher der für
den aufbruch der partei nützlich ist
dann geführt antwort ja danke siegbert
wenn ich richtig das verstehe bist jetzt
mitarbeiter der bundesgeschäftsstelle
sieghörtner
oder wie ist das jetzt
das ist ja irgendwie bemerkenswert dass
jetzt mitarbeiter der
bundesgeschäftsstelle hier fragen
stellen das finde ich schon sehr seltsam
in sachen fairness das muss ich mal
deutlich hier ansprechen ich habe zwei
jahre lang ich habe zwei jahre lang
silber siegbert das hast du ja selber
erlebt zwei jahre lang mit einigen
anderen zusammen die bundestagsfraktion
aufgebaut als parlamentarischer
geschäftsführer bernd baumann und andere
sie haben gemeinsam diesen laden
aufgebaut und er ist richtig gut
geworden und wir haben einiges geschafft
aber dass träume nicht wahr wurden und
zwar besondere zielvorstellungen die von
denen vor allen dingen auch andere
gesprochen haben die vorsitzende waren
zu dem zeitpunkt
newsroom usw das lag an bestimmten
gesetzlichen problemen und es lag
letztlich daran dass es dann die führung
irgendwann nicht mehr gewollt hat das
können alle bundestagsabgeordneten die
sich mit dem thema der fernseh und
rundfunk berichterstattung und der
zukunft der fraktion beschäftigt haben
bestätigen insofern ist deine angabe
falsch vielen dank herr braun sie sind
mit dank entlassen und als nächstes
dürfen wir dann den kandidaten matthias
vogler für seine vorstellung auf die
tribüne bitten
so der nächste kandidat matthias vogel
der für das amt des ersten beisitzers im
bund keine igs unvereinbarkeit mit einer
position im af die bundesvorstand nach
auf die bundessatzung nein
würde ein polizeiliches führungszeugnis
eintragungen enthalten keine
und ich darf sie bitten frühere partei
mitgliedschaften anzugeben die fdp ist
die einzige partei die es wert war
einzutreten alles klar dann haben sie
jetzt fünf minuten zeit um sich
vorzustellen ja liebe mitglieder schön
hier im wunderschönen riesa mein name
ist mathias vogler ich bin 40 jahre jung
komme aus nürnberg aber gebürtig bin ich
ein ossi in dem land wo wir jetzt
praktisch jetzt sind ich bin
ausgebildeter soldat achteinhalb jahre
war ich im dienst für das vaterland
unterwegs auch in afghanistan und den
bosnien afghanistan kann ich nur sagen
wir sehen ja alles hat nur geld gekostet
59 kameraden das leben gekostet und wir
haben da als deutsche nicht zu suchen
[Applaus]
wir haben nämlich unser land zu schützen
und unsere grenzen was komischerweise
jetzt gerade geht wenn die sieben in
ellmau in ein paar wochen stattfindet
kann die bundesregierung wieder die
grenzen schützen wenn es um krone geht
kann die bundesregierung die grenzen
schützen aber wenn es darum geht unser
land vor illegalen massenhaft
kriminellen einwandern zu überfluten
kannst das nicht und da frage ich mich
wieso
zu mir
ich bin in der haft in die afg 2016
eingetreten
weil die euro rettungspolitik und die
migrationspolitik für mich katastrophal
gescheitert waren
ich war gründungs vorstandsmitglied im
jr kreisverband in nürnberg fürth und
war zweieinhalb jahre kreisvorsitzender
in damals nürnbergs bayerns größten
kreisverband nürnberg schwabach
was ich jetzt die letzten tage auch ein
wochen gehört habe auch über die junge
alternative mit aberkennung und so
weiter und so fort kann ich einfach
nicht nachvollziehen weil woanders als
in der jungen alternative sollen wir
nachwuchs und wirkungen mitglieder
gewinnen als in dieser organisation aber
wenn landesverbände diese ausschließen
aus welchen gründen auch immer anstatt
mit denen zu reden und sie vielleicht
auch spur zu kriegen wenn sie dort
abdriften sollten was ich aber nicht
gesehen habe dann sind wir hier komplett
verkehrt
ich bin auch mitglied im konvent seit
über drei jahren wir hatten dort dieses
zentrum automobil auf der tagesordnung
waltons unternehmen was jetzt gott sei
dank ja auch heute wieder oder morgen
spätestens auch wieder drauf ist es kann
einfach nicht sein dass der
bundesvorstand zumindest der alte
eigenmächtig aus persönlichen interessen
solche vereinigungen lauf nimmt und
alle mitglieder damit diskreditiert
obwohl nur der vorstand dieser
vereinigung problematisch ist das muss
geändert werden
dessen sollten wir diesen auch morgen
wieder runternehmen
einen antrag hatte ich dazu eigentlich
gestellt dass der bundesvorstand nur die
unvereinbarkeit liste verändern kann
wenn der konvent dem zustimmt damit wir
nicht wieder diese problematik haben der
woofer entscheidet es geht medial durch
die presse der konvent nimmt runter kann
es aber nicht weil es dann wieder medial
durch die presse geht das müssen wir
verhindern aber ich glaube in dem
aktuell gewählt wo bis jetzt zumindest
wieder aussieht scheint dieses problem
in zukunft wohl nicht mehr zu geben
zu herrn leuten
habe ich leider doch noch ein zwei worte
zu sagen weil ich habe mich mit ihm
unterhalten
im konvent und sonstwo ich danke herrn
oyten ausdrücklich für seine
führungskraft
ausdrücklich weil er die hatte gebracht
spätestens bis kalkar aber dann stark
nachgelassen
machen sie es gut vermieten
ansonsten wenn ich mir angucke aktuell
wieder buch vor aussieht bin ich
deswegen auch angetreten in einer jahr
recht spontane entscheidung weil ich mir
sage mit dem solo ist jetzt der jüngste
gewählt worden ich bin dann der
zweitjüngste und ich bin kein
mandatsträger wo es bitteschön die basis
wo sind die normalen mitglieder in
dieser partei in diesem buch wo bis
jetzt vertreten ich risiken ich sehe
bundestagsabgeordnete
landtagsabgeordnete wir sind wieder da
wie vor zwei jahren wie wir vor vier
jahren waren überwiegend nur
mandatsträger nichts gegen die
qualitativ guten mandatsträger keine
frage aber in den beisitzer positionen
selbst wenn sie mich jetzt nicht wählen
sollten was ich mir aber wünschen würde
sollten sie auch das bedenken und dort
auch mal mitglieder wählen die nicht
mandat haben die aber mit herzblut
renner für diese partei die mit herzblut
brennen für dieses land die dieses land
bewahren wollen dieses land sichern
wollen und das beste für dieses land
erreichen wollen und zwar mit der
alternative für deutschland
ich will sich auch gar nicht länger auf
die folter spannen ich habe noch 30
sekunden aber die schenke ich ihnen weil
sie haben noch viele reden ich bedanke
mich auf alle fälle für ihre für ihre
ohren für ihre zeit freue mich auf einen
konstruktiven parteitag und hoffe dafür
morgen auch die satzung schaffen weil
die sind genauso wichtig vielen dank
vielen dank herr vogler
gibt es fragen an den kandidaten vogler
bisher nicht möchte noch jemand eine
frage anmelden
das kann ich nicht erkennen herr vogler
sie sind dann mit dank entlassen und
garantien bei der bewerberliste
das ist keine fragen an den kandidaten
gibt er hat halt kein mandat derzeit in
der afd er war mal mitarbeiter eines
bundestagsabgeordneten
in berlin und hatte mal ein bisschen
berühmtheit als einmal von der
besuchertribüne ein schild merkel muss
weg gehalten hatte das hat ihnen dann
ein wenig hausverbot damals gebracht das
hausverbot ist aber schon lange wieder
hinfällig
und er bemüht sich als kandidat aus der
basis herauskommen diesen posten
ausfüllen zu können
der nächste kandidat betritt die bühne
und wird sich für das amt bewerben mag
jungen ein wunschkandidat autokino in
bundesbern vereinbarkeit
zu einem
vorstandsamt immer auf die
bundesvorstand gemäss bundessatzung
besteht nein besteht nicht ich darf sie
dann als zweites fragen ob ein
polizeiliches führungszeugnis eintragung
enthielten keine eintragungen und
schließlich darf ich sie darum bitten
etwaige frühere partei mitgliedschaften
zu benennen nur afd keine früheren
mitgliedschaften herr dr jungen sie
haben jetzt fünf minuten zeit um sich
vorzustellen bitteschön
ja liebe parteifreunde
liebe bisher gewählte tino alice und
alle anderen ich möchte euch zunächst
herzlich zur wahl gratulieren das sieht
wirklich nach einem tollen team aus und
ich kann ja ein lied davon singen wie
wichtig harmonische vorstände sind ich
war seit 20 13 seit gründung unseres
landes verbands in baden württemberg in
verschiedenen landesvorständen vertreten
aktuell als stellvertretender sprecher
und programmkoordinator noch und ich
habe solche und solche vorstände erlebt
ein vorstand liebe freunde muss ein team
bilden man muss vertrauen zueinander
haben sonst lehnt man sich ungemein und
man verschleißt die kräfte gegenseitig
und wenn ich hier gewählt werden sollte
dann werde ich sicher auch mal anderer
meinung sein als die no oder alles
weiter und ich werde meine meinung dann
auch sagen aber ich kann ihnen eines
versprechen ich werde immer mit einer
konstruktiven haltung in dieser
diskussionen hineingehen denn am ende
liebe freunde geht es nicht ums recht
behalten es geht auch nicht um
irgendwelche flügelkämpfe sondern es
geht um das wohl unserer partei und
damit gleichbedeutend um das wohl
unserer heimat deutschland und da müssen
persönliche befindlichkeiten dann auch
zurückstehen
denn unsere heimat wir wissen es ist
gefährdet es ist mindestens fünf vor
zwölf seit vielen jahren arbeiten die
deutschen regierungen die per amtszeit
das wohl des deutschen volkes mehreren
so mehren sollen systematisch gegen das
eigene land und das eigene volk und die
lampe hat das noch intensiviert und zum
teil wissen diese leute ja gar nicht
mehr dass ein deutsches volk überhaupt
existiert oder sie schämen sich dafür
ich eher als kulturpolitischer sprecher
im kulturausschuss erlebe ich das immer
wieder sagt claudia roth
kulturstaatsministerin es ist es noch
schlimmer geworden wir wissen ja alle
aus youtube sie liebt die türkei aber
deutschland findet sie eher scheiße ja
so heißt das sie auf den transparenten
und jetzt soll die journalistin ferda
ataman
antidiskriminierungs beauftragte der
bundesregierung werden die deutsche
schon einmal öffentlich als kartoffeln
bezeichnet und die demnächst
wahrscheinlich allen deutschen
alltagsrassismus offiziell und aggressiv
unterstellen wird und wenn etwas
rassistisches liebe freunde dann die
aussprüche dieser dame und ich frage
mich wo sind wir als volk hin gekommen
dass wir uns das bieten und gefallen
lassen
aber ich frage das hier ja an der
falschen stelle denn hier sind ja
diejenigen versammelt und das darauf bin
ich auch stolz die gesagt haben wir
lassen uns das nicht gefallen wir wollen
nicht dass uns die heimat genommen wird
wir wollen nicht unsere souveränität an
ein post demokratisches imperium in
brüssel abgeben wir wollen nicht dass
unser geld immer weiter immer weniger
wert wird und das was wir noch haben
milliarden weise in den maroden
südstaaten versichert wir wollen nicht
dass unsere industrie ruiniert wird
durch eine vollkommen edel witzige
energiepolitik und wir wollen nicht dass
die deutsche kultur für die uns einmal
die halbe welt wenn er bewundert hat
land der dichter und denker dass diese
kultur verschwindet
zugunsten einer links-grünen politisch
korrekten einheitsbrei der buntheit der
toleranz und der hypo moralischen
selbstbezichtigung liebe freunde
und da ist immer zu recht heißt wir
sollen positiv sagen worum es uns geht
wofür wir stehen wir wollen ein
souveränes ein selbstbewusstes ein
blühendes deutschland das seine
interessen vertritt und das und das
seiner bürger in frieden mit der welt
aber eben nicht zu unter wenigen
diensten der ganzen welt und es liegt
allein an uns und das müssen wir uns
immer wieder bewusst machen allein an
der alternativen für deutschland diese
bessere zukunft vorbei zu führen und das
ruder noch herumzureißen und deshalb
liebe freunde dürfen wir uns doch nicht
selbst streiten und selbst zerfleischen
und leben damit betreiben wir das
geschäft unserer gegner denn die wollen
uns vernichten die deutschen
demokratischen parteien wie sie sich
nennen und indem sie grundgesetz und
demokratie mit füßen treten wir werden
sie werden aber keinen erfolg damit
haben wenn wir zusammenstehen wenn wir
wissen wo der feind steht denn wir haben
die wahrheit auf unserer seite und vor
allem die liebe zum eigenen land und die
haben nur die ideologie und den
kulturellen selbsthass ich möchte dazu
beitragen dass wir sie müssen zum
schluss kommen ndr jungs halten in
diesen schwierigen zeiten für unsere
partei ich bin sicher wir werden zur
großen und starken volkspartei dazu
würde ich gerne mit beitragen vielen
dank vielen dank
[Applaus]
gibt es fragen an herrn dr jungen
die erste frage stellt sandro schaer
das ist okay und dann gibt es eine
zweite frage das ist benjamin alte herr
im blauen saal mikrofon
ja lieber markt du bist in baden
württemberg dafür verantwortlich die
landes fachausschüsse zu koordinieren
das ist also thematische arbeit wir alle
hier im saal bolt einen ruck durch
deutschland wie wird es was machst du im
bundesvorstand damit dieser ruck beginnt
antwort
wie du sagst lieber sandro meine
bisherige arbeit war vor allem die
thematische die inhaltliche die
koordination der fachausschüsse ich
werde mich natürlich im bundesvorstand
auch dafür stark machen und werde
wahrscheinlich also dieses ressort
jedenfalls mich darum bemühen dass zu
erhalten und auch unsere
kampagnenfähigkeit glaube ich versuchen
zu stärken der ruck durch deutschland
der würde sofort gehen wenn unsere
botschaften ankommen würden wenn die
medien uns fair behandeln würden ich
sage gar nicht dass sie uns bevorzugen
müssen sie müssen uns nur fair über uns
berichten denn was wir
vertreten als stehe das ist doch dass
wenn man die umfragen hört was die
mehrheit der bürger eigentlich wollen
nur weil wir auf infame weise verteufelt
werden und in die diese rechtsextreme
ecke gestellt werden zu unrecht darum
kommt es nicht an beim bürger deswegen
haben ja auch so große angst vor uns die
altparteien deswegen machen sie diese
ausgrenzung und ich werde alles was in
meiner macht und meinen möglichkeiten so
steht steht versuchen diese brandmauer
die darum uns so riecht errichtet es zu
durchbrechen dann wird sich der realität
sind und die wahrheit von alleine bahn
brechen und dazu gehört natürlich auch
dass wir klare kante zeigen hart in der
sache aber doch verbindlich im ton
auftreten
und die zweite und letzte frage stellt
benjamin leute am roten saal mikrofon ja
herr dr jung kurzer weg das soll jetzt
weder eine gefälligkeit frage sein ob
das gegenteil sollen es interessiert
nicht einfach wirklich sie kommen ja aus
baden württemberg was sagen sie denn zu
dem unvereinbarkeitsausschuss mit
zentrum automobil
antwort
in baden württemberg haben wir hier eine
spezielle situation
die nicht in einer minute antwort zu
erklären ist deswegen werde ich mich
hier inhaltlich nicht weiter dazu
auslassen ich kann nur folgendes sagen
das ist meine
devise in allen landesvorständen in
allen gremien bisher gewesen ich
entscheide immer danach was ist zum wohl
unserer partei und was ist die richtige
entscheidung unserer partei für unsere
partei das werde ich auch weiterhin so
halten und ich bin sehr wohl der meinung
dass wir gewisse
grenzen auch ziehen müssen dass wir
nicht zu allen uns solidarisch erklären
müssen aber ich sehe natürlich auch dass
das immer ein gang auf messers schneide
ist dass man jedes mal sehr wohl
überlegen muss denn klar ist auch
vorfeldorganisationen braucht eine
politische partei und ohne diese werden
wir diese große wende die wir hier
vorhaben nicht schaffen deswegen immer
sehr wohl erwogen eine abwägung im
einzelfall
vielen dank herr doktor jungen sie sind
mit dank entlassen meine damen und
herren wir werden dann in zwei minuten
die erste position wählen dann werden
auch die türen geschlossen
ja so weit also mag jungen und die
vorstellung von ihm er ist mitglied des
deutschen bundestages vom landesverband
baden württemberg seit 2013 ist er in
der ard und hat erstaunlicherweise in
seiner
auch neben der deutschen die
niederländische und die italienische
staatsbürgerschaft das hängt mit seinen
eltern zusammen von denen er diese
staatsbürgerschaft geerbt hat aber
deutscher ist er logischerweise auch
weil er mitglied des deutschen
bundestages wird und ich wird sondern
ist und das kann man nur werden wenn man
die deutsche staatsbürgerschaft inne hat
so es gibt drei kandidaten für die wahl
des ersten beisitzers sie haben
vielleicht gesehen
ganz kurz im bild während der rede von
merklingen hat auch tino keller auf dem
podium kurz geklatscht es ist zu ende
einer rede ging und bei einer antwort
von ihm formation kam also es bleibt
abzuwarten ob der kandidat den
kinogruppe auf seiner team zukunfts
liste favorisiert hat es bei dieser wahl
schafft oder ob einer der beiden anderen
kandidaten jürgen braun oder matthias
vogler gewählt wird das ganze werden wir
in kurzer zeit erwarten und der
parteitag entscheidet in wenigen
augenblicken wenn wieder die berühmte
tür oder die türen zu sind
elektronisch über euro zu den favoriten
und dann schließen wir den türen in 54
10 die türen sind geschlossen ist wird
niemand mehr rein oder rausgelassen
meine damen und herren wir kommen zur
wahl des ersten
beisitzers sie haben folgende
abstimmungs möglichkeiten 1 jürgen braun
2 matthias vogler 3 d r mark jungen vier
nein zu allen fünf enthaltungen ich
öffne den wahlgang sie haben 40 sekunden
diese wahl ist die wahl des ersten
beisitzers insgesamt werden sechs
beisitzer gewählt wir haben es vorhin
gerade gehört von dem tagungs präsidiums
leiter der jetzt zur zeit das präsidium
und den parteitag in regie führt dass
sechs beisitzer noch gewählt werden dann
ist der komplette bundesvorstand gewählt
und man wird zu weiteren themen die noch
auf der tagesordnung sind unter anderem
eben ganz zum schluss auch über die
strukturreform innerhalb der partei die
ja mit dem leiter einer kommission
benannt werden soll beziehungsweise in
dem antrag zu dieser neuen kommission
zur partei strukturreform steht dass es
einen leiter geben soll den der neue
bundesvorstand er nennt und dieser
leiter ist dann in der lage zehn
personen aus dem
gesellschaftlich relevanten umfeld aus
verschiedenen gruppierungen zusammen zu
stellen um dann die strukturreform zu
erörtern und nah am bundesvorstand zehn
sekunden zur arbeit ins all das wird
aber später noch entschieden und beraten
jetzt geht's erst mal um die frage wer
gewinnt die wahl des ersten beisitzer
3210 der wahlgang ist geschlossen
[Applaus]
im ersten wahlgang knapp durchgesetzt
ich stelle
54,12 prozent für markierungen leicht
hat und ich darf er noch theologie war
als die geologen der afd bezeichnen
herr dr jungen
vor lauter glück wünschen nicht dazu die
wahrheit zu bestätigen das hat er jetzt
gemacht man hat das ja gehört
und damit
führt der parteitag fort in dem
wahlmarathon
wahrscheinlich sie werden es fast
erahnen mit der wahl des zweiten
beisitzers und den jeweiligen kandidaten
so
dann haben wir
nur noch fünf weitere beisitzer vor uns
und kommen jetzt zum insgesamt zweiten
beisitzer posten in diesem
bundesvorstand ich bitte um
entsprechende
vorschläge wer soll wer kann wer will da
kommt jemand
abholt ja bitte ja ich schlage martin
reichert vor herr martin reichert ist
vorgeschlagen
[Applaus]
gibt es dafür die erforderliche anzahl
an
unterstützern das ist offensichtlich der
fall vielen dank
dann gibt es weitere vorschläge ich sehe
im roten saal mikrofon ja bitte ich
schlage drk china baum vor frau doktor
baum ist vorgeschlagen
dann frage ich auch dazu ob es in einer
entsprechenden zahl von unterstützern
gibt ich sehe ja sehe ich auf anhieb das
ist der fall foto christina baum gibt es
weitere vorschläge
ist da jemand am blauen mikrofon nein
das ist nicht der fall aber am roten
dann bitte
andreas lienhart vor
andreas lienhart
gut wunderbar vielen dank dann frage ich
auch insoweit nach unterstützung aus dem
plenum wer unterstützt den die
kandidatur von herrn winhart
das sind auch die nötigen fünf vielen
dank
am blauen saal mikrofon sich aktuell
niemanden am roten
ebenfalls nicht
scheint da aktuell niemand unterwegs zu
sein da würde ich einmal die kandidatur
bereitschaft abfragen martin reichert
steht er zur verfügung
das ist der fall frau doktor baum
möchten sie kandidieren
entschuldigung habe sie nicht gesehen
jetzt nein
danke für die auskunft nein vdr baum
also bitte wieder streichen und herr
wien hat ich höre ein jahr
dann letztmalig abschließen frage gibt
es weitere kandidaten vorschläge
das doch da kommt noch jemand am roten
saal mikrofon
ich schlage martina böswald vor frau
böswald
dann brauche ich auch da einmal die
anzeige wert diese kandidatur
unterstützt sind das hinreichend viele
da hinten sehe ich etliche genau danke
dann auch an frau böswald die frage ob
sie überhaupt kandidieren möchte
wenn man mich so nett bittet ja das
nehmen wir einfach mal als ein jahr und
erneut der blick zum blauen mikrofon da
sehe ich niemanden
auch am roten
aktuell nicht dann scheint es mir als
könnten wir die kandidatenliste
schließen ich bitte wenn sie die
kandidatenliste für den zweisitzer
posten jetzt schließen möchten einmal um
das blaue käppi mittel für die
schliessung der kandidatenliste
jawoll vielen dank gibt es gegenstimmen
was logischerweise nur sinnvoll wäre
wenn sie auch noch einen
kandidatenvorschlag hätten sehe ich
nicht sehe keine gegenstimmen dann ist
die kandidaten liste
geschlossen
und wir und losen kurz eine reihenfolge
für die vorstellungen aus
drei kandidaten eine frau darunter auch
wieder ein favorit von tino propeller
martin reichert mitglied des deutschen
bundestages und gleichzeitig
landesvorsitzender von sachsen anhalt
martina böswald ist mitglied des
landtages in baden württemberg
und andreas lienhart ein
landtagsabgeordneter aus bayern 2 aus
den ländern einer aus dem berliner
bundestags geschäft
und gleichzeitig gilt er als vertrauter
der flügel strömung und ein
wunschkandidat
aus dem team europa lahm doch doch dort
geschaffen das
vermutlich wenn ich einen seite
zugreifen bekomme danach stellt sich
dann als erstes bitte vor gleichfalls
und als zweites herr reichert und dann
müsste noch ein dritter zettel da drin
sein genau als drittes dann bitte der
herr wien hat in dieser reihenfolge
dann bitte ich zunächst mal hobbys bald
für ihr kandidatenvorstellung
hier
zu uns nach oben
martina bis dann ausbaden
müssen inzwischen bekannten pflicht
fragen frau böswald bestehen
irgendwelche unvereinbarkeiten nach der
afg bundessatzung nein stehen keine
enthält ein aktuelles polizeiliches
führungszeugnis dass sie einholen
irgendwelche eintragungen hat es noch
nie nein
und waren sie schon mal eine andere
partei gewesen falls ja in welcher ja
ich war von
1994 bis 2006 mitglied der spd und bin
dort aufgrund der sozialpolitik 2006
ausgetreten das weiß glaube ich
inzwischen jeder dankeschön dann haben
sie wiederum fünf minuten zeit um sich
und ihr programm vorzustellen
bitte sehr wer das präsidium liebe
gewählte mitglieder hallo
liebe zuschauer liebe partei mitglieder
und freunde
ich habe mich über den vorschlag hierzu
kandidieren sehr gefreut und zwar
deshalb weil es mir zeigt
dass in dieser partei frauen und
kritische stimmen trotz aller
differenzen gehört gesehen und auch
geschätzt werden ich bin seit 2016 in
diese partei eingetreten weil mir die
silvester ereignisse ein fanal waren und
ich als emanzipierte und aufgeklärte
frau die zukunft meiner kinder nicht
mehr gesichert sei
daran hat sich
leider leider leider wirklich überhaupt
nichts geändert und wir sind als afd die
einzige oppositionspartei die dieses
land hat und wir sollten diese aufgabe
deswegen so gut so anständig und so
bewundernswert tapfer vollbringen wie
wir es unseren kindern schuldig sind ich
habe drei kinder ich bin seit 30 jahren
fast verheiratet und bin seit 24 jahren
selbstständige rechtsanwältin
insofern meine bewunderung an meine
kollegin frau marianne harder kühne ich
weiß was es bedeutet mutter von drei
kindern zu sein und trotzdem ein
abgeschlossenes jurastudium hingelegt zu
haben
ich habe es mit eigenen mitteln gemacht
dazu braucht man disziplin und
kampfgeist aber auch unterstützung von
freundlichen menschen die einem so das
eine oder andere mal netterweise
abnehmen ich bin seit
ich bin seit
2008 zehn kreisvorsitzende im breisgau
hochschwarzwald und ich weiß auch wie
hart das ist mit dem innerparteilichen
gegner so umzugehen dass unsere partei
dabei nicht beschädigt wird wir haben
uns in einem jahr schließlich drei mal
wählen lassen und einfach durch diese
herausforderung gezeigt dass man durch
eine gute arbeit und beständigkeit
tatsächlich dann doch so gewinnend sich
darstellen kann das ihr seit dem ja und
jetzt wechseln wir den blick vom saal
direkt für kurze zeit zum blick an unser
set und zu alexander keller
ja es kristallisiert sich immer mehr
heraus dass der nutzen dieser dieses
parteitages ein mann ist der heute gar
nicht zur wahl steht und das für eine
hecke der landesvorsitzende der afg in
thüringen der hocke sie müssten ja
eigentlich mit der wahl der neuen bundes
sprecher tino kubala und alles weitere
hoch zufrieden sein ja ich habe diese
waren unterstützt ich habe auch
unterstützen dass wir noch mal zu einer
zweier spitze
kommen obwohl ich grundsätzlich
befürworte da einer spitze bin aber ich
habe auch gesagt lassen wir uns auch
zwei jahre zeit das muss noch ein
bisschen was geklärt werden bevor wir
diesen schritt gehen und da bin ich froh
dass wir die spitze gewählt haben dazu
passt die doppel ich habe die frage
deswegen gestellt dann müssen sie jetzt
nicht mehr den satz wiederholen den sie
mal gesagt haben dass fast alle
bisherigen bundessprecher nicht die
charakterliche größe gezeigt haben die
das amt erfordert ja das ist ja
eigentlich ein verheerender befund für
die führungsfähigkeit der afg bisher die
ja schon fast zehn jahre existiert naja
es ist keine katastrophe aber von für
die führungsfähigkeit der auf dem
allgemein weil es gibt der
landesverbände die sehr gut
funktionieren will mit sich selbst auf
die schulter klopfen aber thüringens
exzellent aufgestellt macht eine sehr
gute arbeit als landesverband wir hatten
auf bundesebene probleme ja und meiner
diagnose ist dass es vor allen dingen an
den charaktereigenschaften des
führungspersonals dann auch lag das
heißt zu wenig willen zur kooperation zu
starkes konkurrenzdenken zu wenig will
auch die die institution der
bundesvorstand neutral zu führen und
nicht macht politisch zu missbrauchen
das muss jetzt besser werden sie haben
recht er sie haben den landesverband
thüringen fest im christ aber war es da
nicht pflicht vergessen von ihnen nicht
schon längst die hand zu heben und
bundessprecher zu werden wenn diese
führungsfähigkeiten der bundessprecher
sie haben gerade gesagt sie habe nicht
die charakterliche größe dieses amt
erfordert diese führungsfähigkeit nicht
da war warum sind sie nicht schon längst
in ring getreten und haben als
bundessprecher kandidiert weil ich
glaube dass
die wende in der deutschen politik hin
zu einer volks freundlichen politik in
görlitz in chemnitz dresden in altenburg
und in erfurt passieren und dass ich
deswegen in thüringen und im bereich
sachsen und sachsen anhalt wo ich
unterwegs bin sehr gut aufgehoben bin
und dafür die partei einen guten dienst
leisten kann mit auswirkungen mit
ausstrahlung auf die bundesebene
der verfassungsschutz beobachtet die
partei auf landes auf bundesebene führt
sie als rechtsextremisten sie da
eigentlich stolz darauf der
verfassungsschutz ist ein regierungschef
seine behörde die die aufgabe hat die
regierung vor der verfassung zu schützen
und deswegen ist der verfassungsschutz
der sogenannte verfassungsschutz auch
keine relevante größe für mich in einem
wirklichen demokratischen rechtsstaats
dürfte es einen verfassungsschutz ein
inlandsgeheimdienst nicht geben der der
opposition beobachtet unterwandert und
zersetzt sogenannter verfassung
geschützt da würde ich gerne noch mal
nachfragen sie waren ja beamter gewesen
dann müssten sie ja eigentlich wissen
dass eine behörde der verfassungsschutz
ist ja eine an recht und gesetz gebunden
ist und nicht einfach willkürlich hand
gehen kann genau wie oft es dann in den
letzten jahren recht und gesetz
gebrochen worden denken wir an die
politik der großen grenzöffnung von
angela merkel denken wir an die eu
rettungspolitik denken wir an den
atomausstieg usw vom
bundesverfassungsgericht sogar als
rechtsbruch markiert und in der
öffentlichkeit gestellt also wenn es
eine realistische partei getrennte seine
rechtsstaat eis dann gibt ist dass die
fdp die grenzen sind dann heimlich
geöffnet worden sondern hat sich
geschlossen das war der vorwurf denn es
gab ja auch offene grenzen jetzt haben
sie ja immer die möglichkeit gegen diese
beschlüsse des bundesamtes für
verfassungsschutz vorzugehen gerichtlich
machen sie ja auch gegen das urteil des
kölner verwaltungsgerichts dass sie
jetzt beobachtet werden dürfen diese
rechts möglichkeit haben sie ja fühlen
sie sich von der justiz tat beschützt
glaubt es ja die unabhängigkeit der
justiz die dann auch die interessen der
af deser vertritt ich denke dass es noch
unabhängige richter gibt ich denke
beispielsweise ein weimarer amtsrichter
der den mut hatte gegen die korona
maßnahme politik in schulen klar
stellung zu beziehen und das einzuordnen
erst dann mit hausdurchsuchungen
anschließend traktiert worden das
bedauere ich sehr ich sehe aber auch
dass wir eine tendenz haben gerade im
bundesverfassungsgericht letztlich nur
die regierungslinie zu exekutieren in
der urteilsbegründung ob das das
klimagesetz ist ob das die
urteilssprüche zur euro rettungspolitik
sind et cetera pp da gibt es eine
schlechte tendenz die die
gewaltenteilung letztlich auch
untergräbt also dass die das
bundesverfassungsgericht die
regierungslinie exekutiert davon konnte
letzte woche keine rede sein hat ja
regelrecht jubelschreie in der afg
ausgelöst angela merkel wurde kritisiert
dass sie ihrem amt als bundeskanzlerin
eingegriffen hat in die wahl von michael
kemmerich in thüringen zum
ministerpräsidenten also ist es dann
immer so immer wenn ein gericht
zugunsten der afg entscheidet ist es
unabhängig wenn es gegen die afg
entscheidet dann ist es werks werkzeug
des staatsapparates nein das möchte ich
so nicht an orten wie gesagt es gibt ja
auch gut arbeiten unabhängige richter
aber wissen beispielsweise das auf
staatsanwaltschaften druck ausgeübt wird
aus der regierung was sie was das urteil
gegen merkel angeht ja das begrüße ich
sehr aber der sachverhalt war so wenig
komplex war so einfach dass das urteil
eigentlich viel zu spät gekommen ist
dieses urteil hatte angela merkel noch
in ihrer kanzlerschaft ereilen müssen um
den entsprechenden konsequenzen haben
jetzt ist im ruhestand jetzt kann man
sie nicht mehr vielleicht ja gut es hat
eine rüge gegeben das hätte sie damals
aber auch nicht zum rücktritt gezwungen
wenn sie noch im amt wäre das ist das
problem der zeit dass die politische
elite auch wenn sie ein starkes 4
versagen leistet eben nicht mehr bereit
ist verantwortung zu übernehmen und
zurückzutreten
sie haben neulich auf dem marktplatz in
grimma in sachsen gesagt wörtlich wir
müssen unseren kopf aus dem hintern des
us amerikanischen hegemonie so als seien
wie eine amerikanische kolonie die
vorwürfe gegen spd gegen cdu ging eine
ganz andere richtung dass man viel zu
sehr eine nähe zu russland in den
letzten jahren gesucht hat wie kommen
sie zu diesem befund sie sind ja
geschichtslehrer gewesen genau ich habe
aber das zitat noch weitergeführt
beziehungsweise habe ich nur halb
zitiert dann wie gesagt wir müssen
unseren kopf aus dem hintern ist simon
usa heraus ziehen aber nicht um ihn dann
in den hintereinander des neuen hegemann
hineinzustecken sondern um eine
unabhängige position als deutschland und
in europa in einer multipolaren neuen
friedensordnung globalen frieden und
ordnung einzunehmen das ist meine meine
botschaft und ja ich habe schon das
gefühl dass wir immer noch in
fremdbestimmt das land sind sie haben
dann gesagt man müsse oder sie würden
dann wenn sie die
regierungsverantwortung übernommen haben
oder die macht ergriffen haben würden
die schutthalden der moderne beseitigen
also moderne ist ja eigentlich
rechtsstaat grund demokratische
rechtsstaat grundgesetz das heißt sie
braucht wollen den staatsstreich machen
sie wollen das grundgesetz beseitigen
nein das ist natürlich jetzt eine eine
suggestivfrage die modernen ist ganz
anders zu interpretieren moderne ist vor
allen dingen stadium in dem sie sich
immer noch befindet und ich bin einer
der eben nicht von der postmoderne redet
weil das ein definitorischen problem
darstellt ich bin jemand der sagt oder
der erkennt dass diese moderne im
fehlentwicklung beinhaltet die im
augenblick
augenfällig exekutiert werden ob das der
gender mainstreaming ansatz ist er
unsere sprache zerstört und auch unsere
geschlechtsidentität zerstört auch dass
der multikulturalismus ist der unsere
kulturelle identität zerstört oder auch
gedanken zum trans und post humanismus
alles das sind ansätze die tatsächlich
als ausfluss der dekadenz zu bezeichnen
sind und sie dann aus was der moderne
und dieser totalen die gilt es wirklich
zu beseitigen und über dekadenz kann man
natürlich lange diskutieren in zwei
jahren ist der nächste wahlparteitag der
afd dafür die bundesspitze dann wieder
neu gewählt sie haben vorhin schon
andeutungen gemacht dass es da noch ein
bündnissprecher gibt ist geplant von
ihnen dass sie sich die partei auch über
die parteistruktur kommission bis dahin
so zuschneiden werden das auf jeden fall
sie 2024 der alleinige bundessprecher
der afg sind als konservativer bin ich
grundsätzlich für eine einer spitze weil
ich denke führen in freiheit und
verantwortung auf zeit muss möglich sein
die strukturkommission hat die aufgabe
die partei institution und prozesse
effektiver und effizienter zu machen
also das ist ein dienst den ich der
partei gerne leisten will und am gremium
das dann besetzt werden muss das
bedeutet nicht dass ich ambitionen habe
auf die bundesposition oder
bundessprecher position in zwei jahren
ich bin natürlich sehr glücklich ich
will spitzenkandidat 2024 in diesem für
uns wichtigen landtagswahlkampf werden
ich will mit abstand stärkste kraft
werden und ich möchte die machtfrage in
thüringen stellen das ist mein ziel also
das heißt die nokia- und alles weitere
sind keine übergangs vorsitzenden noch
sehr viel länger im amt gleich gehe
davon aus dass sie sich bewähren und
dass sie jetzt einen vorstand auch eine
seite bekommen der kollegen
zusammenarbeitet und da bin ich guter
hoffnung dass wir aus den fehlern der
vergangenheit gelernt haben also die
röcke will in absehbarer zeit nicht
bundessprecher werden das nehmen wir
diese antwort bedanke mich für das
gespräch ist lang so und wir geben ab zu
doris müller es geht bei dem parteitag
genau es geht weiter mit dem parteitag
wir sind bei der wahl zum zweiten
beisitzer und es redet gerade der
wunschkandidat in der bewerbungsrede
martin reichert mitglied des deutschen
bundestages verlassen vielen vielen dank
[Applaus]
vielleicht treten wir dann bei den
fragen die an ihn gestellt werden noch
ein wenig an den inhalten von den
inhalten mit all ihrem gang vorhin in
der fünfminütigen bewerbungsrede
gehalten hat dann
wieder der eimer sein der
anfragen oder die frage stelle aus not
auslöst
und dann hören wir zu und gucken was für
inhalte er formuliert eine grün
schneider
dann und erste frage herr lied zurück
bitte einmal handzeichen wo ist aber
welches mikrofon links wunderbar dann
bitte ich um die frage ja wir stehen
hier alle in deutschland vor einem sehr
großen problemen dem walhai zudem
überall hört man das reiche deutschland
und zum anderen ist das größte risiko in
deutschland arm zu werden kinder zu
haben
ich hätte gerne gewusst welche
möglichkeiten du siehst dass man aus
unserem land wieder ein land macht in
dem kinder willkommen sind in dem mal
wieder gerne kinder hat und
welche politik man dafür betreiben muss
zunächst mal müssen familien in
deutschland wieder wertgeschätzt werden
jetzt hat auch die bundestagsfraktion
natürlich schon gearbeitet wir haben
programme aufgelegt und gefordert
familie leben die auf breiten auf
breiter front das image unserer familien
fördern sollen und natürlich ist es für
uns sehr wichtig und da sind auch die
programmkommission natürlich im bund und
im land gefragt da machen wir sehr gute
arbeit wir wollen natürlich alle
gemeinsam wir wollen baby willkommens
darlehen wir wollen ehe staat kredite
wir wollen alle diese punkte die auch in
anderen europäischen ländern hier zu
einer familienfreundlichkeit geführt
haben und ich denke dass wir das auch im
bundesvorstand in der form mit
einbringen dass wir kampagnen starten
und dass wir diese frohe botschaft an
unsere wähler herantragen dafür stehe
ich zur verfügung
jawohl
vielen dank die zweite frage stefan
brandner steht am roten mikrofon bitte
sehr wir haben hatte ich hab da noch mal
ein familienpolitik du bist ja einer der
wenigen zumal gestandenen mannsbilder im
deutschen bundestag die sich mit
familienpolitik beschäftigen das sind
dass uns überwiegend
politiker in den anderen geschlechts ist
es um gerade gesagt kampagnen im
bundesvorstand machen dass wir zu wenig
konkret wie würdest du familienpolitik
aus dem bundesvorstand in die breite
öffentlichkeit hinein tragen aus dazu
sagen wir machen kampagnen wir haben ja
zb einmal auch eine große kampagne
gestartet gegen die impfpflicht und all
diesen irrsinn wir haben große kampagnen
gestartet damals auch noch im verbund
mit der bundestagsfraktion gegen den
migrations packt und ich glaube zum
beispiel dass wir auch eine große
kampagne in der hinsicht starten können
gegen die sogenannten kinderrechte im
grundgesetz denn wir wollen nicht dass
der übermächtige all vater staat die
familien diktiert sondern wir wollen
hier eine kampagne und wir müssen eine
kampagne fahren dafür dass wir starke
familien haben und dass unsere familien
selbst bestimmt bleiben und dass nicht
die es einst gesagt wurde herr scholz
die lufthoheit über die kinderbetten
gewinnt
[Applaus]
dann kommt die dritte frage von frau
grün schneider am blauen mikrofon
ja lieber martin eine ganz kurze aber
auch wichtige frage wie stehst du zu
parteiausschlussverfahren
das eine schwierige frage aber eins muss
man ganz deutlich sagen es gibt
natürlich notwendigkeiten wo tatsächlich
ordnungsmaßnahmen bis hin zum phv
erforderlich sind aber ich will die
kurze frage auch kurz beantworten für
eins stehe ich nicht zur verfügung für
den missbrauch von
parteiordnungsverfahren im
innerparteilichen machtkampf da werde
ich mich gegen stellen ganz egal wen sie
treffen sollen und da werden wird man
mit mir im bundesvorstand immer eine
kritische stimme haben die hier zu
mäßigung und ruhe aufruft das kann ich
dazu sagen
jawohl vielen dank das waren drei fragen
soweit die inhaltlichen und bemerkungen
von martin reichert einem der kandidaten
für die wahl des zweiten beisitzers und
während
auf der bühne die wahl und die
kandidatenwahl weitergeht zeit für ein
fazit
am set mit alexander keller
und mit professor wolfgang schröder uni
kassel wissenschaftszentrum berlin der
schulter wenn man sich jetzt den
fortgang des heutigen tages ansieht wir
haben doch schon zwei mal besprochen wer
da jetzt was geworden ist wer sich bei
der wahl durchsetzt kann man sagen dass
dadurch gewählt wird dass auch diese
liste von timo grub aller wer darf mit
mir in den bundesvorstand eindrücken
relativ gut ab gewählt er ist nicht
abgewählt sondern berücksichtigt wird
und dass es so ein
bundesvorstand im sinne des ersten
bundes sprechers ist genau also die
problemanalyse der hier gefolgt wird ist
wir haben konflikte in der partei in der
vergangenheit gehabt weil ein bestimmter
teil der partei zu sehr sich kapriziert
hat auf die grenzlinie zum
rechtsextremismus die kontakte zum
verfassungsschutz und diese linie wollen
wir in dieser form nicht mehr haben weil
sie die partei spaltet und insofern ist
es nicht einfach so eine individuelle
charakter frage wie das von roeckl
verschiedentlich angedeutet worden ist
was die führungs problematik der afd
ausmacht sondern sind ganz knallharte
unterschiedliche interessen wie man die
partei entwickeln möchte und wenn man
die kandidatenliste jetzt für beisitzer
stellvertreter usw sich anschaut ist
eine ganz deutliche mehrheit aus dem
bereich des ehemaligen flügels aus dem
engeren und weiteren umfeld von röcke
und insofern
realisiert sich hier diese
choreografie einer lösung der spaltung
frage indem man die kräfte etwas verengt
etwas schließt und damit darauf hofft
dass man schneller und besser einheit
praktiziert weniger fraktionen hat
weniger konflikte und damit die außen
und innen ausstrahlung eine bessere in
zukunft werden wird es ist die strategie
von haacke die sie gerade skizziert habe
mir war ja gerade im interview bei uns
gewesen und hat ja auch gesagt also das
jetzt genau der bundesvorstand den er
unterstützt hat er da auch ganz offen
zugegeben dass er das wahrscheinlich
nicht nur vor sondern auch hinter der
bühne unterstützt hat ist das jetzt der
weg den er einschlägt ist das ganz klar
seine strategie also der stempel den er
diesen parteitag aufdrücken kann ist in
richtung einer mehr beschlossenen einer
mehr um seine ideen welt und seine
strategische ausrichtung probierte
vorstellung von der partei da ist
außerordentlich erfolgreich deshalb habe
ich ja auch schon verschiedentlich davon
gesprochen dass erhöhte festspiele haben
die zu einer typisierung der afd führen
könnten das darf man jetzt natürlich
nicht so versteht das jetzt propeller
weidl und all die anderen immer an der
leine von höcker hängen das berner idee
vorstellen wir haben durchaus ihre
handlungsspielräume die werden sie auch
nutzen sie werden auch versuchen eigene
akzente zu setzen das ändert aber nichts
an der grundausrichtung die
grundausrichtung vor der diese partei
doch immer wieder aufs neue steht ist
inwiefern sie sich ein stück weit öffnet
koalitionsfähig wird oder ob sie den
kurs des fundamental opposition weiter
geht und der kurs der fundamental
opposition ist eng verflochten mit dem
rechtsextremen umfeld und das ist nicht
immer im vordergrund zu sehen sondern es
sind auch viele hintergründige gruppen
kleingruppen strategie muster die da
einfließen und den hat höcker natürlich
die tür geöffnet und all die anderen die
hier auch mit an bord sind und
gleichzeitig versucht man nach vorne hin
so diese strategie der selbst
verharmlosung indem man sagt ja wir sind
doch die eigentliche bürgerlich liberale
konservative mitte dieser gesellschaft
wer mir bisher immer vermutet auch in
unseren gesprächen auf dem parteitag das
wirke die parteistrukturen sturmreif
schießen will in dieser struktur
kommission der jetzt vorsitzen will noch
ist sie nicht eingesetzt aber er hat
jetzt gerade gesagt will ja eigentlich
das gar nicht das amt des bundes
sprecher sind zwei jahren haben wenn sie
noch einen gibt weiterhin und propeller
seien alles andere als übergangs
vorsitzende er interessiert sich mehr
für das amt des ministerpräsidenten in
thüringen das wird ja spätestens im
herbst 2024 wenn ich das richtig im kopf
habe unmittelbar vor der neuwahl der
bundesspitze ja auch gewählt in
thüringen ist das tatsächlich seine
absicht oder hat er diesen posten des
bundes sprechers immer noch im auge ich
denke es ist ein weites feld und da tut
er gut daran sich da jetzt nicht
festzulegen so fern ist das durchaus
taktische klugheit in der kommunikation
die er praktiziert was am ende passiert
muss er genauso flexibel sein wie alle
anderen auch was man feststellen kann
die partei bewegt sich auf ihn zu und es
gab zeiten wo genau der gegenteilige
entwicklungszyklus die partei und das
verhältnis zu werke geprägt als gab
ausschlussverfahren gegen höcke die
angestrengt worden sondern alles weil
dabei die weser war frauke petry usw
alle zweifel und jetzt steht er auf
einmal in der mitte der partei also
diese parteien das kann man an der
person höcke sehr schön nachvollziehen
hat sich wieder einmal neu verändert und
diese neue veränderung ist natürlich
immer ein stück weit offen aber von der
programmatisch konzeptionellen anlage
läuft das auf fundamental opposition mit
einer ganz starken grenze in richtung
rechtsextrem hinaus kann man nicht was
die zukunft der afg angeht sagen im
westen und im osten top mann kann man
auch nicht sagen weil die
landratswahlen kommunalwahlen in sachsen
haben ja auch sehr deutlich gemacht dass
auch im osten die bäume nicht in den
himmel wachsen das auch doch die
bürgerinnen und bürger genau hinschauen
wenn es dann um die vergabe von ämtern
geht
dfds leer ausgegangen weil sie schon bei
verschiedenen wahlen doch die mehrheit
eingenommen hat also insofern ist in
beiden hemisphären so wohl wie im osten
wie im westen die position der afg alles
andere als gesichert und wenn wir uns
die entwicklung des parteien wettbewerbs
in den letzten monaten anschauen die ist
ja sehr zentriert auf die drei parteien
grüne spd und union da kann es durchaus
sein dass die afg weiter nach unten geht
weil sie nicht berücksichtigt wird und
dann hat sie natürlich auch sehr stark
darunter zu leiden dass die nichtwähler
die sich um stück weit an der afg
orientiert haben wieder ins lager der
nichtwähler zurückgegangen sind und
damit fehlt er natürlich auch eine
wesentliche dynamik die in den
vergangenen jahren ihre schlagkraft
ausgemachte soweit professor wolfgang
schröder der uns mit wissenschaftlich
politische expertise durch diesen afd
parteitag begleitet hat herzlichen dank
vielen dank auch von meiner seite und
hier geben zu doris müller zurück
dankeschön alexander keller wir sind
auch weiterhin mitten im wahlverfahren
in dem langen wahltag der afg die heute
diesem zweiten tag in riesa korrekt
andreas wien hat stellt sich zur wahl
für den zweiten beisitzer im
bundesvorstand er ist mitglied des
landtages in bayern und wird gerade
gefragt politik zu machen
danke schön ich denke der
parlamentarische geschäftsführer hat
schon aufgearbeitet dass er das team
zusammenhält und das alle vorkommen dass
alles sauber abgehandelt wird und das
habe ich meines wissens auch hier nach
besten wissen und gewissen bisher
gemacht und ich werde es auch weiterhin
zu machen egal aus welcher strömung so
ein antrag kommt da sind wir einfach den
bürgerinnen und bürgern verpflichtet
ansonsten versuche ich und die kollegen
aus den landesparlamenten kennen das
vielleicht ich versuche unsere anträge
deutschlandweit herum zu schicken dass
sich andere daran orientieren können
einfach hier eine plattform zu schaffen
dass
andere sich an bayerischen anträgen an
gesetzen dürfen hätte orientieren können
und das ist gelebte zusammenarbeit die
wir freunde profitieren alle davon und
da
müssen wir einfach noch viel mehr an
dass wir noch viel mehr zusammenwachsen
und muss das rad nicht jedes mal neu
erfinden
dankeschön
gehe ich recht in der annahme dass sich
am blauen seinem mikrofon herr stefan
schröder eingefunden hat dann bitte ich
um seine frage sehr geehrt kandidat sie
haben ja gerade die einheit der partei
angesprochen es ist ja aber auch fakt
dass sie maßgeblich in dem konflikt der
bayerischen landtagsfraktion über die
partei öffentlichkeit und die presse
diesem konflikt am leben gehalten haben
das ist doch genau das was wir in den
vergangenen wochen und monaten mit
einzelnen mitgliedern auch des
bundesvorstandes erlebt haben wie können
sie ausschließen oder wie können sie
überhaupt auf diese bühne gehen und
sagen sie stehen für die einheit wenn
sie den konflikt überhaupt seit monaten
und jahren am leben erhalten haben wie
können sie da vorne stehen
also kann hier sehr guten gewissens
stehen während der kollege und es ist
klar dass man es hier versucht ein
bisschen den eigenen kandidaten nach
vorne zu schieben ich kann ja sehr guten
gewissen stehen und es gibt genügend
belege wo man sieht das andreas wien hat
eine figur ist die eben integrieren kann
ich kann es im kreisverband ich kann
sind der fraktion es funktioniert für
alle gleich behandelt alle gleich und
ich werde es auch weiterhin so handhaben
und werde mich in der fall schließlich
stellen will sorry aber dann versucht
aber bessern bessere gelegenheit aus
ok und dann haben wir im roten saal
mikrofon herrn dierkes jahr danke sehr
geehrter herr wehner seit jahren fallen
sie in der landtagsfraktion und ihre
gruppe auch damit auf an die presse
durch zu stechen und die partei und die
fraktion vor bestätigen sie gelten sie
gelten als treuen anhänger und trotzdem
stehen sie hier und räten von einheit
und wollen vor dem bundesvorstand
kandidieren
was denken sie sich eigentlich dabei
also herr dirk es da sie erst sehr sehr
sehr sehr kurz in unserer partei sind
erkläre ich ihnen jetzt mal was 2018
habe mich erneuten vor großem publikum
und zwar bei anne will öffentlich
diffamiert ich war mit meinen leuten nie
einer meinung und wurde von leuten wie
ihnen einfach diesem lager zugeordnet
also das ist erst das zweite ist ich
wehre mich absolut dagegen und wird es
auch nochmal prüfen lassen aber
juristisch was machen kann wenn sie hier
behaupten ich würde was durchstechen das
kommt mir noch nicht mal in den sinn ja
ich möchte mal von ihnen wissen das kann
man dann bitte noch einmal beim kirchen
erklären was sie denn durch gestochen
haben sollte also eine unverschämtheit
von ihnen herr dirk ich sage ganz offen
ich ich steche nicht durch ich sorge für
einheit und
wir sehen uns mal geleert
unmöglich unmöglich
dankeschön das waren dann auch ihr drei
fragen und drei antworten und wir
bedanken uns bei herrn wien hat für die
vorstellung
damit haben wir die drei kandidaten
gehört ich starte jetzt die zwei minuten
die wir immer vorlauf geben vor einem
wahlgang ich bitte die technik den
wahlgang so weit schon mal vorzubereiten
in nicht mehr ganz zwei minuten machen
wir die türen zu und können dann den
wahlgang beginnen wer immer jetzt noch
vom rauchen ganz schnell wieder rein
muss der möge das jetzt tun
oder eben dann zumindest die nächsten
minuten auch draußen bleiben
während wird dann einen wahlgang machen
andreas wien hat mitglied des landtags
in bayern hatte sich als einer der
letzten kandidaten von drei zur
bewerbungsrede aufs podium begeben und
wurde dann mit fragen aus der
delegierten aus den delegierten reihen
befragt diese saal mikrofone sind bei
der afg immer teil des versuches
politischen einfluss zu nehmen und
politisch auch zu steuern design
mikrofone werden dann gesetzt von
sozusagen vertretern der eine oder der
andere
einflussnahme oder des versuchs der
einflussnahme und man versucht im sinne
des eigenen zieles in dieses dann auch
durchzusetzen oder zumindestens zu
produzieren so werden eben bestimmte
fragen gestellt oder eben auch nicht sie
konnten das heute bei der kandidatenwahl
zu den personal wahlen auch sehr gut
verfolgen andere wiener das wie gesagt
mitglied des landtags in bayern zusammen
mit martin reichert bewirbt er sich um
die wahl des zweiten beisitzers martin
reichert mitglied des bundestages und
gleichzeitig wunschkandidat vom
team gruber und martina böswald
mitglied des landesverbandes baden
württemberg
und während hier die wallonen
geschlossen werden und die wahl läuft
gebe ich noch mal zu alexander ja wir
wollen noch weitere neu gewählten
mitglieder des bundesvorstandes
kennenlernen und ein neu gewählter
beisitzer ist markierungen
stellvertretender landessprecher aus
baden württemberg man bezeichnet sich
auch öfter auch mal als chefideologen
der partei wenn das jetzt für sie nicht
ehrenrührig ist eher wenig das ist eher
die afg jetzt nach ihrem eindruck dass
die wahl angeht auch was die politischen
blöcke angeht die jetzt eingeschlagen
werden soll auf dem richtigen weg
also erstmal chefideologe ist natürlich
ein etikett das eine sache aufgeklebt
wird da kann man sich nicht dagegen
wehren also ich lege wirklich kein wert
auf der diesen titel ich glaube dass wir
hier schon die richtigen signale setzen
wir sind natürlich jetzt in einer
schwierigen phase unserer partei das
zeigt auch die berichterstattung die
themen die das geschehen bestimmt haben
in letzter zeit sprich corona und jetzt
keine krise das waren nicht die
klassischen steht dem und ich glaube
dass wir da auch sehr wichtige
positionen bezogen haben uns gegen die
korona maßnahmen gestellt haben jetzt
auch skeptisch waren gegenüber den
waffenlieferungen in die ukraine aber
das sind nicht so wie themen die in
unserer partei ist vollkommener konsens
sind auch wir hatten da durchaus
diskussionen und sie sind im moment
schwer zu vermitteln an die breite
bevölkerung aber ich denke das wird sich
auch in nächster zeit zeigen dass wir
auch damit recht behalten werden aber
man kann sich die themen ja auch nicht
aussuchen und wer volkspartei ist oder
werden will der muss natürlich auch auf
jedes thema der antwort wissen bei krone
hatte man das gefühl nicht nur das
gefühl sie haben sich mit der querdenker
szene verbunden es wird der afg immer
wieder unterstellt sei viel zu russland
nach viel zu putin freundlich wo sie da
noch eine andere
klarer machen wo sie eigentlich hin will
gerade auch wenn sie zum beispiel
politisch anschluss anschlussfähig sein
will
nein wir haben uns glaube ich in beiden
fällen auf einen mittelweg geeinigt und
wir haben eine eine vernünftige position
der mitte angenommen wir sind unsere
position ist nicht identisch mit der der
querdenker aber wenn sich da so eine
bürgerbewegung sammelt auf der straße
dann sind wir natürlich nicht dafür
verantworten wir haben das nicht
geschaffen und wir können uns auch nicht
tagtäglich davon distanzieren wir machen
uns wir gehen unseren weg wir haben
gesagt was wir für falsch halten an
diesen maßnahmen und wenn von querdenker
seite der einzelne positionen ebenso
klingen aber doch ins radikale
übersteigert das liegt dann nicht in
unserer kontrolle und genau so ähnlich
ist es auch in ukraine konflikt auch da
ist unsere position eigentlich sehr
ausgewogen und ja vielleicht könnten sie
auch mal
vertreter von uns öfters in eine
talkshow oder in einem interview der
gleichen einladen und dann hätten wir
etwas mehr gelegenheit unsere
differenzierte position auch da also
haben eine ganze reihe von führenden afd
gliedern eingeladen in diesem im
laufenden kalenderjahr aber wir haben
sie im auge und es gibt ja auch viele
dinge die gerade mit der afg auch gut zu
diskutieren sind gibt es in der afd
einen streben nach harmonie nach den
jahren der des zwists und der der
entzweiung wenn man das so sagen ich
glaube schon das sieht man auch hier wir
haben längst nicht mehr diese großen
kampfkandidaturen wie wir diese in den
anfangsjahren hatten natürlich gibt es
auch kandidaten gegeneinander antreten
aber das hält sich in einem in einem
vernünftigen rahmen wird in einer reifen
partei dann auch der fall sein sollte
und wir gehen diesen weg der reifung
dieses
wort vom jährigen haufen ist das ist
schon zu oft zitiert worden aber ich
denke man kann darauf verweisen uns
haben wir wir bewegen uns jetzt da
heraus und werden zu einer gereiften
partei da könnte allerdings der schritt
vom gierigen haufen zum langweiligen
haufen relativ kurz sein sehen sie da
die gefahr dass sie dann die afg das
verliert was sie bisher ausgemacht hat
nämlich eine gewisse streitlust und auch
versucht hat verschiedene positionen zu
verein selbst wenn das zum teil
chaotische zustände nach außen
vermittelt hat ich sehe den
medienvertretern kann man das nicht so
wirklich recht machen streiten wir zu
viel sind wir nicht regierungsfähig
streiten wir zu wenig dann sind wir
gleich langweilig nein das kann ja nicht
die alternative sein wir sind eine immer
noch sehr sehr junge partei und
seriös zu werden ja und das sind wir
auch unserer sicht schon weitestgehend
das muss unser ziel sein und natürlich
gehen wir diesen weg weiter langweilig
wird es in der politik garantiert nicht
dafür sorgen schon die themen und unsere
position ist immer noch die opposition
elste in sehr vielen fragen fast allen
fragen im deutschen parteienspektrum
wir müssen es nicht recht machen ich
habe trotzdem nach streit und harmonie
gefragt so weit mag jungen neu gewählter
frisch gewählte beisitzer im
bundesvorstand der fdp danke mich für
das gespräch ich danke ihnen und
hier geben zurück zu doris müller
genau und hier gehen sofort wieder ab in
den saal denn da gibt es gerade die
vorschläge zur wahl des dritten
beisitzers
und es war kein geringerer als der
frisch gewählte neue bundessprecher tino
keller der wiederum dann persönlich
einen namen in den ring geworfen hat für
die kandidatur zur wahl des dritten
beisitzers nämlich roman reusch er
selbst 2013 mitglied der afg ist und im
vorstand der kfd in brandenburg
tätig ist und ich sehe am blauen
mikrofon gibt es den nächsten vorschlag
ja ich schlage christina baum vor
erneut vorgeschlagen ist frau doktor
baum auch hier bitte einmal ganz kurz
das handzeichen wer von den anwesenden
stimmberechtigten delegierten das
unterstützt
dann sehen wir auch da die nötige anzahl
vielen dank und können zurückgehen zum
roten mikrofon mit einem weiteren
vorschlag ich schlage alexander wolf
herr alexander wolf ist vorgeschlagen
dann brauche ich auch insoweit einmal
kundgabe wo haben wir
es wird gemeldet dass das der fall ist
gut dann vermerken wir das so
die kameras zeigen mir momentan
lehre sowohl am blauen wie am roten saal
mikrofon
dann würde ich jetzt erst einmal die
kandidatur bereitschaft abfragen bevor
wir dann die liste schließen
so herr
roman reusch ich bräuchte einmal eine
bekundung dass sie bereit sind zu
kandidieren
wo ist er
er sagt ja wenn er das war vielen dank
martin renner wie gesagt hat schriftlich
mitgeteilte ist ja krankheitsbedingt
abwesend herr professor doktor hahn
kandidiert dankeschön frau der baum
könnte
forderte baum bitte noch einmal kurz uns
mitteilen
ob sie kandidieren möchte
ich höre aktuell nicht und dann herr
doktor wolf
ich höre ein jahr gut danke schön dann
haben wir vier
bewerber dann noch einmal der blick auf
die mikrofone nein da ist immer noch
niemand sichtbar der noch eine kenne
ich höre gerade von herrn doktor hahn
dass er ebenfalls in diesem wahlgang
nicht kandidieren möchte dann bitte ich
ihn auch zu streichen bitte herrn dr
hahn streichen
an den mikrofonen befindet sich niemand
weitere wahlvorschläge sollen also
offenbar nicht unterbreitet werden dann
bräuchte ich kurz die bestätigung der
versammlung dass wir die kandidaten ist
jetzt schließen wäre damit einverstanden
ist bitte einmal kurz die blaue karte
für die schließung der kandidatenliste
vielen dank gibt es gegenstimmen und
dann logischerweise auch noch weitere
vorschläge
das ist evident maßen nicht der fall
dann ist die kandidaten-liste hiermit
geschlossen und wir müssten eben die
reihenfolge der vorstellung bestimmen
eine sekunde bitte
roman reusch martin renner alexander
wolf der
auch derzeit noch im noch amtierenden
bundesvorstand ist er ist einer der
beisitzer und
kandidiert zur wahl des dritten
beisitzers auch für den neuen
bundesvorstand zusammen mit roman reusch
die anderen beiden kandidaten christian
bau mit ingo hahn haben sich
zurückgezogen und was und wie mit martin
renner der ja wie gesagt
krankheitsbedingt nicht anwesend ist
dann darf ich das müssen wir noch
abwarten was da mit dieser bewerbung
herum gegangen
und als zweites herr doktor alexander
wolf und als drittes würden wir dann
genau die vorstellung von martin renner
sehen und hören die bei der technik
stimmt wir uns ja abgelehnt geht ja gar
nicht
schön für die gedächtnis auffrischung
dann
die reihenfolge auf der folie können wir
noch ändern in die eben ausgeloste rösch
wolf renner und derweil mag sich bitte
gerne danke der kollege roman reusch
schon einmal bei uns einfinden erneut
heran
herzlich willkommen und ich beginne
erwartungsgemäß mit den pflicht fragen
bestehen irgendwelche unvereinbarkeiten
nach unserer bundessatzung nein
würde ein aktuelles polizeiliches
führungszeugnis eine eintragung
enthalten nein
gab es vor mitgliedschaft in anderen
parteien und falls ja in welchem in
meiner jugend war ich im jahre des
heilens 1973 bis 1988 mitglied der cdu
gut dann ist die uhr gestellt und wir
hören fünf minuten vorstellungsrede ab
jetzt bitte sie hallo zusammen wo zu
meiner person ich bin 68 jahre alt von
beruf jurist
ich war über 30 jahre lang staatsanwalt
in berlin
die letzten vier jahre meiner
berufstätigkeit habe ich im deutschen
bundestag zu gebracht als abgeordneter
unserer dortigen fraktionen mit ende der
legislaturperiode bin ich nur noch
ruheständler in der partei bin ich seit
sommer 2013 habe mich von der anfang an
mit programmarbeit beschäftigt dauert an
dann war ich beim landesschiedsgericht
dann bin ich vor einigen jahren in den
landesvorstand als beisitzer da sitze
ich auch heute noch
und nun stellt sich vielleicht jeder die
frage was will der ruheständler einzige
bundesvorstand gute frage
ein großes problem unserer partei das
heute vielfach angesprochen worden ist
dieser elende lagerkoller der uns
erwischt hat und da möchte ich gerne ein
wenig gegen arbeiten zumindest im
vorstand ich war nie irgend einem lager
zugehörig
nicht dem flügel als sie noch gab auch
nicht den flügeln als es die noch gab
ich habe wann immer ich mit mitglieder
zu tun hatte jeden so genommen wie er
war mir völlig egal auf welcher aus
welcher ecke der der partei der kommt
und ich könnte mir vorstellen ja also im
bundestag hatte ich die
erstaunliche erfahrungen gemacht bei der
zusammenhang mit den kollegen dass
diverse mitglieder der fraktion zu mir
ganz gute arbeits und sogar gute
persönliche beziehungen unterhielten
untereinander spinnefeind waren
das hat mich etwas überrascht gibt mir
aber die hoffnung dass ich sollte es bei
dieser mannschaft überhaupt nötig sein
vielleicht doch auch im bundesvorstand
ausgleichend und brückenbau und
wirken könnte was mich aber
bundesvorstand noch viel mehr reizt das
ist das zweite große schwarze loch das
auf uns wartet und das sind unter
verfassungsschutz prozesse ich habe
immer den eindruck die wenigsten
mitglieder wissen überhaupt was uns da
droht wenn wir diese prozesse verlieren
herrschaften dann reißen die uns den
allerwertesten bis zum stehkragen auf
dann erleiden wir das schicksal der
republikaner
und enden bei ein bis zwei prozent
ich sage das immer wieder und stelle
immer wieder fest dass sichert bei ein
rohr einmal wieder raus und hinterlässt
wenig spuren ich würde aber gerne daran
mitwirken
unsere partei hier aus dem feuer zu
holen
ich bin durchaus
[Applaus]
ich bin ein wenig im thema drin
ich war mitglied der arbeitsgruppe
verfassungsschutz ich betreue im
landesverband brandenburg diesem bereich
und begleitet dort unsere prozesse ich
war mit einer mündlichen verhandlung vom
verwaltungsgericht köln und ich kenne
auch unseren prozessvertreter dr konrad
mittlerweile ganz gut und ich würde
gerne diese arbeit fortsetzen
nun haben wir hier als delegierte die
interessante wahl zwischen doctor wolf
der das im alten vorstand betrieben hat
und einem neuen präsidenten
und ich bitte um ihre stimme und sehe
diesen gottesurteil gelassen entgegen
nun fragen
danke soweit wir klären eben das
vorhandensein von
fragen und see kopfschütteln es hat
niemand eine frage angemeldet ich lasse
einmal kurz den blick in die runde
schweifen ob ich jemanden sehe der
geschwinde schritt herbeigeeilt um noch
sein kärtchen irgendwo einzuwerfen
doch genau da ist der sprint
so
weitere herbeieilende prospektive
fragesteller sehe ich ehrlich gesagt
nicht
dann haben wir offenbar genau eine
nachfrage und dann bitte ich auch
das mikrofon das war nicht zu übersehen
dann bitte ich alle lose an dem roten
mikrofon seine frage auch zu
stellen ja danke sie haben sich dafür
ausgesprochen das dvs arbeitsgruppe
weitergehen soll und sie wollen den vs
von uns abwenden aber
sie möchten auch dass andreas kalbitz
wieder zurück die partei kommt wie passt
das zusammen
es ist kein geheimnis dass ich den
beschluss des früheren vorstands andreas
kalbitz aus der partei zu werfen für
rechtlich falsch und für politisch
falsch gehalten habe
[Applaus]
das auch öffentlich bei mehreren
gelegenheiten gesagt
ich bin heute immer noch dieser
auffassung dass das falsch war
ob man ihn wie den partei holen muss
dafür müsste er erst endgültig vor
gericht verloren haben
nach meiner persönlichen einschätzung
hat er nach wie vor ganz gute karten das
zu gewinnen also die frage stellt sich
erst mal nicht
und
ob man dann ob er dann ein
wiederaufnahmeantrag stellt und wie man
dann darüber zu befinden hätte tut mir
leid leute dass es spuken kicken wie man
im hohen norden sagt ja da kann viel
passieren es können neue erkenntnisse
aufkommen die bisher gewissheiten
umwerfen
in dem letzten urteil war die rede von
arglistiger täuschung was mich bisher
zum ende kommen danke was mich sehr
überrascht hat müsst ihr erst mal lesen
also ich gehe die frage stellt sich
derzeit nicht
okay das war dann die eine frage die
gestellt war wir bedanken uns bei herrn
rolf vorstellung
und
kommen zum
nächsten
bewerber der sich
auf den weg gemacht hat
alexander wolf der derzeit eben auch
noch weise zwar ist und alten wirklich
noch im amt seien dem bundesvorstand
nein
bestehen eintragungen im führungszeugnis
bestanden frühere mitgliedschaften in
anderen parteien verteilen welche ja
zwei einmal für wenige monate bei den
republikanern das war 1989 90 und
danach einige jahre bei der csu seither
parteifrei bis erste jahreshälfte 2014
afd dankeschön das waren die pflicht
fragen und die vorstellung folgt jetzt
fünf minuten
alexander wolf rechtsanwalt verheiratet
zwei kinder
liebe landsleute vor wenigen tagen wurde
beschlossen dass die
regenbogenfahne lage auf dem reichstag
gehisst wird für diversität und
transgender von den altparteien
und vor vielen rathäusern im ganzen land
haben wir dasselbe
regenbogen flaggen statt
schwarz-rot-gold
machen wir uns nichts vor
unser land ist bedroht unsere art zu
leben ist bedroht von einer links-grünen
walken schickeria die unser land zu
einer transgender republik umerziehen
will
liebe parteifreunde
ich will mich nicht umerziehen lassen
wir die afd sind die letzte bastion die
den mut hat gegen diese links grünen
woche schickeria aufzustehen und nein zu
sagen
lasst uns dabei zusammen stehen im
wissen dass wir dabei für die
schweigende mehrheit der deutschen
stehen
auch in der schule schreitet die
umerziehung voran in mathe so hörte ich
kürzlich müssen die kinder ausrechnen
wieviel erden sie mit ihren ferien
reisen
verbrauchen um so der neuen klima
religion auch in der zu würdigen und
freitag schulfrei vor für fridays for
future
um sich dann mit pattex an die straße zu
kleben und den autoverkehr zu behindern
schulkinder müssen sich ein doppel
sprech inzwischen zu legen eine
offizielle meinung die der lehrer hören
will und die private meinung die man
aber besser nicht in der schule
öffentlich sagt das erinnert mich an in
ganz
grauenhafter weise an die ddr früher
ich kann mich noch sehr gut erinnern an
die schulzeit in der ddr ich bin die
ersten zwölf jahre in leipzig
aufgewachsen bevor übersiedelten das
wollte und das möchte ich nie wieder
erleben lasst uns gemeinsam nein sagen
zu diesem linken kultur kampf gegen
deutschland
[Applaus]
ich komme zu einem ernsten thema ein
thema was eben auch schon mein vorredner
ansprach die abwehr des
verfassungsschutzes
keineswegs auf die leichte schulter zu
nehmen sondern existenziell
das ist aus meiner sicht eine
überlebensfrage für unsere partei denn
worum geht es da es geht darum uns mit
hilfe des vs stempels an den pranger zu
stellen der verfassungsschutz ist heute
das was im mittelalter
der hölzerne pranger auf dem marktplatz
war mit dem der zwingend den leuten
sagte das sind die ganoven mit denen
redet nicht ich sage ihnen das können
und dürfen wir nicht hinnehmen wir
müssen uns mit allen legalen mitteln
dagegen wehren das sind wir unseren
mitgliedern schuldig vor allem den
beamten und angestellten in großen
unternehmen aber auch unserer
gesamtpartei
wir haben einiges erreicht in diesem
kampf
die lokale hat es schon erwähnt dass wir
vor den bundestagswahlen im letzten jahr
nicht als verdachtsfall vom vs
bezeichnet werden durften und nicht als
solche geprüft werden durften so konnten
wir unbeschwert in diesen
bundestagswahlkampf in soweit gehen und
vielleicht hat auch das mit beigetragen
dass wir ein zweistelliges ergebnis
wieder erringen konnten
ich will aber auch nicht verhehlen es
gab auch niederlagen am achten märz in
köln vor dem verwaltungsgericht eine
höchst fragwürdige
entscheidungen die nicht rechtskräftig
ist ich habe im bundesvorstand intensiv
dafür geworben dass wir in berufung
gehen und wir haben das dann auch
einstimmig beschlossen berufung ist
eingelegt es ist mir ein anliegen und
deswegen bitte ich um ihr vertrauen mich
auch in diesen neuen bundesvorstand zu
wählen dieses verfahren weiter zu
betreuen und hoffentlich zu einem
erfolgreichen ende zu bringen
meine damen und herren eine große
deutsche tageszeitung schrieb über mich
einmal der ist kein chorknabe
das ist richtig ich bin kein chorknabe
aber ich singe gerne und das wissen auch
die meisten von ihnen
und ich bin ein kämpfer ich will und
werde es nicht kampflos hinnehmen dass
unser land zu einer regenbogen republik
umerzogen wird ein staat der regenbogen
flaggen auf zieht ist nicht mehr neutral
ich sage dazu frei nach helmut schmidt
wer die regenbogenflagge aufzieht sollte
zum arzt gehen ich möchte auch in
zukunft in einem land leben in dem wir
stolz schwarz rot und gold flaggen
vielen dank
[Applaus]
alexander wolf vom landesverband hamburg
schön er ist stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender in der
bürgerschaft für die a-elf
vorliegen das ist der fall
dann gehen wir die einmal abholen
ja auch an ihnen werden fragen gestellt
die jetzt
sozusagen mehr als drei bedeuten immer
dann muss gelost werden
herwig und das hören wir uns jetzt dass
weiteres herrn stefan schröder und
als drittes noch herrn wolfgang wille
so dann sehe ich
herbig hat sich bereits eingefunden am
roten saal mikrofon dann bitte ich um
seine frage sie haben ja gerade
festgestellt dass die kinder
berechnen sollten wie viel werden sie
verbrauchen auf ihrer flugreise jetzt
kann ich ihnen sagen dass die kinder
wenn die grünen und roten fertig sind
das gar nicht mehr berechnen können
meine frage ist daher konnte ich ihnen
jetzt diese angst nehmen
vielen dank für diese frage das kommt
natürlich dazu dass und das haben wir in
hamburg ganz besonders ich bin selber
schulpolitiker schulpolitischer sprecher
unserer bürgerschaftsfraktion die zu
starke orientierung an kompetenzen und
das vernachlässigen von wissen von
basiswissen rechnen schreiben
geschichtskunde das ist mir ein dorn im
auge ich setze mich selbstverständlich
dafür ein dass wir auch da wieder zu
einem soliden klassischen auch
klassischen frontalunterricht wo es
richtig ist zurückkehren es gibt manche
pflänzchen wo wir das unterstützen
können in jedem fall werden wir uns
gegen diese ideologisierung gegen diese
um erziehung der kinder durch einen
geist der die meinungsfreiheit verengt
und einengt zu wehr setzen in diesem
sinne hatte ich auch übrigens vor
mehreren jahren schon das portal
neutrale schule hamburg
was viele derartige fälle aufgedeckt hat
und bundesweit aufsehen erregte
dankeschön
dann kommen wir zur nächsten frage am
blauen mikrofon steht herr schröder
bitte sehr
toto wolff sie haben vor einigen wochen
eine pressekonferenz mit dem ehemaligen
vorstandsmitglied auch johanna katar
gegeben deren ziel ist hatte den
bundessprecher herrn tino keller zu
beschädigen jetzt stehen sie ja vorne
wollen in den gleichen vorstand woher
gruppe a la vida vorsitzender ist ich
verstehe dass du dich auf der einen
seite die ganze schuld kinogruppe und
jetzt wollen sie genau an diesen
vorstand wieder rein wie wollen sie das
glaubhaft machen wie wollen sie uns
delegierte das vermitteln wie können sie
da überhaupt wieder antreten außerdem
können wir davon aus dass sie eines
solchen pressekonferenz nicht noch mal
wieder schön sprecher anzugreifen
dankeschön das war die frage
vielen dank für diese frage das gibt mir
nämlich die möglichkeit etwas richtig zu
stellen was offenbar wenig bekannt ist
ich habe in einer pressekonferenz an
einer pressekonferenz teilgenommen ich
habe dort mit keinem wort tino kubala
angegriffen ich habe sachlich geäußert
dass ich dass es mir wichtig ist dass
ich in brennender sorge nach den
wahlniederlagen in schleswig holstein
und nrw um die zukunft unserer partei
bin und dass es mir darum geht den
freiheitlich konservativen markenkern
wieder zur geltung zu bringen ich habe
in einer pressemitteilung
war ich mit beteiligt wo ich die ukraine
politik kritisiert habe da wurde tino
kubala auch mit angesprochen ich habe
ihm gegenüber und dafür augen erklärt
dass sich das bedaure und für einen
fehler hielt und ich habe das auch in
der landesvorsitzenden telco
angesprochen das fällt nicht leicht
etwas als fehler zuzugeben in jedem fall
bin ich nach aussprache mit tino keller
überzeugt dass wir in einem guten team
werden zusammenarbeiten können
ok dann kommen wir zur tritt frage amrod
mikrofon herr wille bitte herr dr wolff
sie haben sich vorgestellt als hamburger
mit vergangenheit aus dem osten
aufgewachsen bis zum nächst mehr richtig
gemerkt habe bis zum zwölften lebensjahr
naja
was würden sie denn mit ihrem
hintergrund der westlb die sagen was
kann die west afd von der ostalb sie
lernen
interessante frage die der
hauptunterschied ist die bürger der
ehemaligen ddr sind gott sei dank nicht
so durch angepasst wie es viele
westdeutsche leider sind die jahrzehnte
von umerziehung durchlaufen haben die
ehemaligen ddr bürger haben eine
kritische distanz zu dem was ihnen von
den regierenden und von den medien
gesagt wird ich habe das auch wenn ich
damals erst zwölf jahre alt war noch
erlebt wie man in der zeitung zwischen
den zeilen
diesen hat weil man diese skepsis hatte
weil man wusste die belügen uns doch das
ist ein pfund mit dem wir wuchern können
das ist eine botschaft eine erkenntnis
die wir auch stärker in den westlichen
teil unseres vaterlandes tragen müssen
damit die
westdeutschen ein stück weit davon
profitieren von den ostdeutschen etwas
mitnehmen und gegenüber
regierungsamtlicher diffamierender
propaganda wie durch den
verfassungsschutz nicht sich so leicht
ins bockshorn jagen lassen und dann nix
für ein u vormachen müssen
vom osten lernen heißt insofern siegen
lernen
dankeschön
dieses war die antwort auch die dritte
frage dann bedanken wir uns bei lothar
wolf für die vorstellung und erschien
und ich darf
zu dem dritten bewerber in diesem
wahlgang herrn martin renner noch
mitteilen dass er ebenfalls schriftlich
die 3 pflichtangaben hier hinterlegt hat
und mitteilt dass keine
unvereinbarkeiten nach der bundessatzung
vorliegen dass keine eintragung im
polizeilichen führungszeugnis vorliegen
und das an vor mitgliedschaften die cdu
zu erwähnen wäre so dass dazu dann
können wir wiederum die zwei minuten
sozusagen vor frist in gang setzen
damit jeder der
von diesem fortgang der verhandlungen
jetzt gerade überrascht wurde noch die
möglichkeit hat herr bald zu heilen
egal wo er sich gerade befindet
der dritte kandidat nicht wie gesagt der
aus krankheitsgründen nicht anwesend ist
aber sich dennoch zur wahl stellt hat
den nachteil dass er natürlich jetzt
keine inhaltlichen begründungen geben
kann warum er dieses amt inne haben
möchte warum er sich zur wahl stellt und
mit welchen inhalten er versucht ddg
delegierten nein für seine wahl zu
überzeugen rückfragen gibt es natürlich
logischerweise aus diesem kreis der
delegierten heute bei diesem parteitag
auch nicht vielleicht ist dieser fall
für die
verfahrens- crowe und für die
parteitagsregie eine aufforderung auch
intern solche fälle vielleicht künftig
dann geschmeidiger zu lösen für viele
delegierte weil logischerweise das jetzt
an technischen voraussetzungen fehlt um
diesen
elektronisch einzufügen aber er ist
kandidat der kann sich mit aufstellen
lassen und wird an der wahl genauso
teilnehmen wie die beiden kandidaten
alexander wolf und roman reusch dessen
kandidatur von bundessprecherin okpala
selbst vorgeschlagen wurde er hatte
selber das mikrofon ergriffen und diesen
kandidaten
vorgestellt und dann wird man sehen
welche der drei kandidaten das rennen
macht zurzeit läuft wieder die uhr
runter für das schließen der türen sie
kennen das prozedere für diejenigen die
da jetzt schon länger am
live stream oder am
digitalen fernsehen oder linearen
fernsehen live die berichterstattung von
uns von phoenix verfolgen über den
wahltag
bei der afg in riesa
und dann läuft jetzt die abstimmung für
diese drei kandidaten
und dann wird man sehen welcher der drei
kandidaten
den vorzug von den delegierten erhält
sodann sind das jetzt noch zehn sekunden
und für diejenigen die sich jetzt
einschalten so sind jetzt dies ist oder
eine elektronische abstimmung beendet
und wird an zeugen per screen
eingeschaltet ohne 3g ergebnis sieht aus
wie sie es sehen
danach hat
keiner der kandidaten die erforderliche
einfache mehrheit erreicht dh wir treten
bald in eine stichwahl ein allerdings
wie zuvor bereits gehandhabt damit wir
der einheitlich bleiben geben wir die
zwei minuten während der mb die tür
also die türen sind wieder offen und die
zwei minuten laufen wer da jetzt zu
dieser stichwahl zu den nächsten
wahlgang
hereinkommt komme herein
der parteitag hat den ganzen tag gewählt
es werden nach dieser wahl zum dritten
beisitzer noch drei weitere beisitzer
gewählt in einer einzelwahl dann ist der
bundesvorstand der neue komplett und wir
haben gerade schon in einer
experteneinschätzung die alexander
kähler mit professor schroeder
gehalten hat von professor schröder als
fazit und analyse gehört dass es ganz im
sinne von der liste von tino keller
läuft jedenfalls bis zum zweiten
beisitzer viele kandidaten die er gerne
hätte sind gewählt worden und das ganze
auf der grundlage von absprachen aus den
landesvorständen und aus dem land landet
landtagen
wir haben gehört dass in dem interview
dass alexander keller mit piano geführt
hat auch wenn hacker sich als vater
dieser liste empfindet und
dann bleibt abzuwarten
ob die anderen drei wunschkandidaten so
sie es denn gibt und so sie kandidieren
auch für die restlichen drei
beisitzerposten zur verfügung stehen das
wird man sehen und dann ist nach der
wahl der sechs beisitzer der
bundesvorstand komplett und die wahlen
geschlossen danach wird es noch reden
der beiden neuen bundessprecher geben
bzw ein bisheriger wurde ja
wiedergewählt in europa ali seidel ist
neu aber jetzt gucken wir erstmal wie
die wahl zum dritten beisitzer die
stichwahl
verläuft erschließen die technik den
wahlgang
entsprechend freizuschalten
sie erreichen unter der 1 wahlgang läuft
sie erreichen unter der 1 wo man rasch
unter 2 doktor alexander wolf unter 3
nein zu allen und unter vier
enthaltungen bitte um stimmenabgabe
jetzt
die abgegebenen stimmen zahl erhöht sich
nach wie vor wir sind schon hoch in den
400 bereichen heute morgen hatte
julian fleig der versammlungsleiter
531 stimmen gezählt und delegierte auch
hier sind noch über 500 abgegebene
stimmen
bei dieser wahl zu erwarten und genau
die stimmen jetzt gleich ab und werden
das ergebnis präsentieren und gucken ob
es für die mehrheit für die einfache
mehrheit des jeweiligen einen oder
anderen kandidaten gereicht hat
21 und die wahl ist vorbei ich bitte das
ergebnis einzublenden
da wird sich tino kubala freuen sein
kandidat hat in der stirn als er hörte
hausen sondern ergeben sich ein prozent
der bewerber roman roche die
erforderliche einfache 30 erhalten sowie
den alexander war ich gucke einmal zu
ihm rüber und bitte mal eben um ein
lautstarkes jahr
das war ein lautstarkes ja er hat die
wahl angenommen vielen dank und wenn wir
den gratulations parcours
zivil halten können wir also nicht
ausarten lassen können wir über gehen
zur eröffnung der kandidatenliste für
die nächste beisitzer position die
insgesamt vierte von sechs
da steht jemand am rednerpult und möchte
vermutlich einen vorschlag machen dann
lass hören die vermutung ist korrekt ich
schlage maximilian krah vor herr christ
vorgeschlagen dann schreiben wir ihn
zunächst mal auf
und dann sehe ich bitte ob es die
erforderliche zahl von unterstützern
gibt die diesen wahlvorschlag mit
zeichnen möchten jawohl das ist der fall
vielen dank dann bitte herrn doktor krah
auf die liste schreiben
maximilian stellvertretender
vorsitzender der afg in sachsen und seit
2009 10 mitglied des
europaparlaments auch er hat einen
prominenten
gefunden aus dem neuen bundesvorstand
nämlich stefan brandner der ihnen
vorgeschlagen hat
wenn sie noch einen wahlvorschlag machen
möchten
dann
wäre es angezeigt sich jetzt zügig zu
dem nächstgelegenen mikrofon zu begeben
da zeigt sich allerdings
niemand so maximilian graf 45 jahre und
seit 2000 und 16 mitglied der asd
zunächst normal da ich das noch nicht
getan habe herr doktor kaviza und möchte
er kundtun ob er kandidieren möchte
war das ein jahr okay das kann man dann
ist das der fall dann
da ich immer noch niemanden sehe er
einen weiteren vorschlag machen möchte
brauche ich einmal bitte die blaue karte
für das schließen der vorschlagsliste
verdi jetzt schließen möchte einmal
bitte blau kurz das sind zahlreiche
dankeschön gibt es gegenstimmen
das ist nicht der fall dann ist die
kandidaten liste geschlossen und wir
können zur vorstellung des kandidaten
übergehen
der auch heuer viertel war gibt es jetzt
keine kampfkandidatur sondern es gibt
nur einen vorschlag für den vierter
beisitzer
maximieren caro dann folgen jetzt
zunächst einmal die üblichen pflicht
fragen liegen unvereinbarkeit nach der
bundessatzung vor es liegen keine
unvereinbarkeiten vor
liegen eintragungen im führungszeugnis
vor es liegen keinerlei eintragung vor
nicht mal nicht nur eine volksverhetzung
und
gibt es vor mitgliedschaften falls ja
welche es gibt eine cdu vergangenheit
ach dann starte ich die zeit und bitte
um ihre vorstellung vielen dank liebe
freunde ich freue mich euch hier in
riesa zu sehen kurz vor dresden wo wir
mit unserem kreisverband
einhellig ja und damit verlassen wir an
dieser stelle erst mal die bühne auf dem
parteitag und geben ab ans set
ja wir sind dafür heute schon alle auf
der zielgerade aber nach dem viel
passiert ist heute auf dem parteitag
wollen wir natürlich noch mit den beiden
mit der kollegin mit dem kollegen aus
dem hauptstadtkorrespondenten chor
sprechen mit ann kathrin müller vom
spiegel und mit alexander kissler oder
neuen zürcher zeitung
was lehrt uns der heutige tag wohin
driftet wohin segel wohin galoppiert die
afg das schon was sagen ich würde sagen
die fes endlich ehrlich mit sich selbst
und wählt den bundesvorstand der partei
passt denn tatsächlich machen hier die
leute von tino copala und teilweise auch
von höcker eben einen durch durchmarsch
und zeigen eben dass die parteien
inzwischen so weit rechts steht dass
jetzt der bundesvorstand auch dazu passt
und eben nicht ein feigenblatt mit ihrer
beute davor steht was bedeutet das jetzt
für die das innere parteileben in der
afg bisher hat man da viel streit gehört
viel trinken viel verärgerung wird jetzt
aus dem jährigen haufen ein langweiliger
haufen und er die partei ist schon ein
wenig biederer geworden hier also auch
so die anarchische lust ist noch etwas
geschwunden wir reden ja zurzeit viel
von verschiedenen arten von frieden es
soll kein diktat frieden geben kein
unterwerfung frieden hier sehen wir
allerdings es gibt auch so was wie einen
erschöpfungs frieden also gewisse
bürgerlich-liberale teil haben sich
gewissermaßen die innere emigration
zurück gezogen man sie zu treten nicht
einmal mehr an also der zweite durchgang
schon bei denen es keine gegenkandidaten
gibt man sagt okay ihr habt gewonnen
tosics alter das ist euer bundesvorstand
jetzt jetzt bitte sorgt man dafür dass
wir auch gute ergebnisse bekommen also
man ist die straßen seiner schwäche
bewusst geworden und zieht sich nur in
die beobachterposition zurück aber im
hintergrund schwelt das natürlich weiter
müller strukturell wird werden die wird
die fdp möglicherweise eine normale
partei aber von normalität kann ich
eigentlich keine rede sein ist nicht
anschlussfähig sie steht am rande des
politischen spektrums ja und sie zeigt
das ja auch immer wieder mit ihren
wortbeiträgen sie will gegen alles sein
eben dieses wenn die anderen was gegen
und haben machen wir alles richtig also
das ist ja keine partei die mit anderen
irgendwie wirklich zusammenarbeit könnte
weil sie eben außen stehen will und sich
in dieser rolle auch gefällt es ist eher
das was ich gerade tod
versucht sie einfach zwar sich jetzt neu
aufzustellen aber im prinzip das was ich
schon immer getan hat nämlich einfach
nicht anschlussfähig zu werden am rande
zu stehen die schwierigkeit ist eben der
kommunikation nicht umsonst
kommunikation eines der hauptkriterien
vieler beiträge man hat eine
kommunikation nach innen und die
kommunikation nach innen ja wir machen
ihnen schon alles richtig wir haben
schon immer die richtigen antwort gehabt
jeder zweite beitrag sagte auch die
mehrheit der deutschen will eigentlich
das was wir wollen sie wissen es nicht
wir müssen besser kommunizieren und es
dann hätten wir ein zwei positionen
fällt die kommunikation nach außen und
das eben die wirklich das haben wir ganz
klar gesehen nach außen nach innen will
man die reihen schließen als
gewissermaßen diskurs innerhalb der
blase jawohl wir machen das richtig kurs
halten weiter segeln müsste man sagen
herr opa hat gesagt er will die
strömungen zu einem strom vereinen nach
außen allerdings stößt dieses
zusammenfügen an grenzen weil man dort
eben dann eher als destruktive kraft
wahrgenommen wird also die partei ist
bisher natürlich weder erwachsen
geworden noch indem sie eine normal wie
sie es behauptet aber ich würde sie auch
noch nicht komplett abschreiben sie hat
nach wie vor einen markt wirtschaftlich
gesehen ein gewisses potenzial auf dem
wählermarkt muss man abwarten
zu sagen dass man
für alle deutschen die politik machen
sie müssten nur noch nicht dass sich die
einzelnen parteien seien die das können
uns natürlich mit kommunikation zu tun
das ist schon eine sehr weitgehende
zwischenbilanz wir wollen das morgen
noch einmal weiterführen weil mit ann
kathrin müller mit alexander kissler ja
die zuschauer wir gehen jetzt weg aus
dem parteitag der afg liefern ihnen
alles das was hier noch stattfindet
morgen wahrscheinlich ab 10 uhr nach die
beiden parteivorsitzenden
bundessprecher bundessprecherin genannt
wollen ja auch noch mal reden und dann
werden wir morgen den dritten und
letzten tag über tragen da geht es um
wichtige inhaltliche antrags debatten zb
um die haltung der afg zu europa oder
wie hält es die partei mit
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine das
könnte möglicherweise ziemlich spannend
werden das war's für heute aus riesa
gegeben zurück nach bonn in die programm
zentrale